von meinem Kollegen Erhard Schäfer der
sich jetzt mit Gästen aus dem Foyer des
Bundestages meldet
in der tatransvena fitkau wir melden uns
aus der westlobby im Reichstagsgebäude
und exakt wenige Tage vor einem Jahr und
es war ein Sonntag erstmals an einem
Sonntag dass der Bundestag beraten hat
gab es die mehrfach zitierte Rede des
Bundeskanzlers und spätestens seitdem
während draußen tausende friedlich für
die Ukraine demonstriert haben
spätestens seitdem war hier auch ein
PolitikerInnen klar dass alte Maßstäbe
und alte Gewissheiten nicht mehr zählen
zumindest was die Außen
sicherheitsunverteidigungspolitik angeht
sie haben Hans Werner und ich rede
erwähnt und einen großen Teil ihrer
Inhalte auch aber die große Frage ist
was ist denn tatsächlich passiert
seitdem die Kritik ist gerade in den
vergangenen Tagen wieder etwas lauter
geworden insbesondere was das ähm die
Ausgaben über das Sondervermögen das für
die Bundeswehr angeht und deswegen
wollen wir heute Rede schon mal schauen
die Bilanz des Bundeskanzlers gleich die
Bilanz Zwischenbilanz mit zwei
Parlamentariern jetzt schon mal Michael
rotes bei uns der Vorsitzende im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss für jedes
Bundestag und ich freue mich dass Sie
auch Johann wadeful da ist
stellvertretender Vorsitzender der
Unionsfraktion und zuständig für die
Bereiche außen und auswärtiges und
Verteidigung guten Morgen ihnen beiden
Herr Roth das Wort Zeitenwende ist ein
bisschen abgenutzt finde ich ist es
zumindest extrem hell häufig verwendet
worden obwohl das Wort des Jahres 22
geworden ist haben Sie einen anderen
Begriff für das was da passiert ist oder
eingeleitet worden ist im vor gut einem
Jahr
ich finde den Begriff gut und ich
verwende ihn auch gerne weil er
inzwischen auch eingängig ist und auch
deutlich macht was für eine historische
Zäsur wir erleben und erlebt haben werde
das für möglich gehalten dass wir noch
mal in Mitten Europas mit einem so
furchtbaren grauenhaften Angriffskrieg
zu tun haben mit vielen vielen Opfern
dass ein Land ein freies souveränes Land
angegriffen wurde wir haben aber auch
lernen müssen dass eine liberale
Demokratie eine offene Gesellschaft sich
verteidigen sich schützen muss ebenso
ihre Partnerin und Partner und darüber
reden wir ja gerade auch was heißt das
nicht nur finanziell was heißt das
politisch und da müssen wir die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger mitnehmen
deswegen ist es auch gut dass der
Bundestag immer wieder auch hier im
Bundestag der Bundeskanzler immer wieder
im Bundestag spricht und eben nicht nur
in Talkshows er war voll das Wort
zeitenwände wir werden gleich auch noch
jede Menge inhaltliche argumentieren
aber dies war Zeiten wenn du was Lust
hast für Bilder aus was für ein
Assoziation
ich finde der den Begriff schon sehr
treffend und das war eine große Rede des
Bundeskanzlers in der er die ganze
Nation eingestimmt hat auf den
epochenumbruch den wir halt erleben
durch diesen russischen Aggressionskrieg
das zu verinnerlichen das zu verstehen
ich glaube daran arbeiten wir alle
miteinander noch und das ist in einer
freien und offenen Gesellschaft
natürlich ein bisschen schwieriger als
wenn sie in einer Diktatur leben da wird
das von oben befohlen und dann geht das
so aber wir sind ja glücklich dass wir
in einer anderen Situation leben aber
wir müssen an dem Begriff noch Arbeiten
an dem Verständnis was das bedeutet
können wir gleich noch auf jeden Fall
drauf vor knapp einem Jahr gab es
stehende Ovationen auch aus der
Unionsfraktion für den Bundeskanzler ich
vermute mal damit können wir heute nicht
so richtig rechnen oder ja ich glaube
der Bundeskanzler hat von der cducs so
Fraktion vielleicht sogar mehr Applaus
erhalten aus insgesamt aus den Rhein der
Koalition aber das war ein ehrlich
gemeinter aus der gilt auch heute noch
das war eine große Rede das bleibt er
ist ein bleibendes Verdienst dieses
Bundes Kanzlers die Umsetzung ist aus
unserer Sicht nicht ausreichend das muss
man klar sagen sie haben das vorhin
schon angedeutet bei der Bundeswehr ist
noch viel zu wenig Geld angekommen wir
müssen insgesamt noch in dieser
Gesellschaft viel mehr verstehen was das
bedeutet und da ist auch kommunikativ
auch durch den Bundeskanzler noch sehr
viel mehr zu leisten als wir bisher
gehört haben ich habe eben schon gesagt
die Zwischenbilanz des Bundeskanzler
sehen wir und hören wir gleich ich
bestelle eine Frage sehr sehr offen und
ich weiß dass es gefährlich aber ich bin
sicher dass sie sie kompakt beantworten
können was ist erreicht worden Herr rot
seit einem Jahr
wir haben es ja wirklich mit einem
historischen Einschnitt zu tun der viel
mit diesem furchtbaren Krieg zu tun hat
aber wir sind inzwischen das Land in
Europa das so stark und so engagiert wie
kein zweites die Ukraine nicht nur
politisch finanziell humanitär sondern
vor allem auch militärisch unterstützt
wir haben mal mit 5000 Helmen begonnen
und sind jetzt bei modernen Kampfpanzern
und damals ein bisschen peinlich gewirkt
hat ja es ist das das war der Versuch
das war der Versuch
das zu tun was notwendig war wenn es
nach mir gegangen wäre hätten wir da
vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen mehr
Tempo reingebracht aber am Ende des
Tages Stimmen Worte und Handeln in
Deutschland über ein und wir haben das
getan was wir angekündigt und
versprochen haben und das den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern immer wieder zu
erklären das ist unsere originäre
Aufgabe deswegen bin ich auch der
cdu/csu-fraktion außerordentlich dankbar
dass die Koalition in diesen schwierigen
Zeiten in diesen Fragen bei allem Streit
und bei aller Kritik nicht alleine lässt
weil ich glaube die Menschen machen sich
wahnsinnige sorgen und da tut es gut
wenn wir im Bundestag eine breite
parlamentarische Mehrheit haben und das
fällt ja auch den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen nicht immer ganz leicht weil
Opposition heißt erstmal Alternativen
aufzeigen und nicht der Regierung
zustimmen
parlamentarische Unterstützung sagen sie
auf der anderen Seite haben wir gerade
Montag und Dienstag Herr Wade
folienpartei und Fraktionsvorsitzenden
gehört der
heftige Kritik doch geübt hat an der
Bundesregierung und an dem Bundeskanzler
und unter anderem gesagt hat irgendwie
diese zeitenwände sei offenbar bei der
Bundesregierung noch gar nicht
angekommen und sie habe die Zensur noch
nicht verstanden die sich da ereignet
hat können Sie das mal ein bisschen
ausführen weil ich wenn man sich anguckt
was in den vergangenen vergangenen Jahr
entschieden worden ist deckt sich das ja
nicht so ganz
naja ich habe ein grundzeugen hier neben
mir stehen der Kollege Roth hat schon im
vergangenen Sommer glaube ich sogar
Frühsommer schon vorgeschlagen dass wir
in ganz Europa einen Pool von Leopard
Panzer Nationen bilden die sich dann
entschließen entsprechend Kampfpanzer in
die Ukraine zu liefern und dort zur
Verfügung zu stellen das hätte wenn man
ihm gefolgt wäre das hätte viel Blut
gespart und das hätte uns die
Unterstützung für die Ukraine sehr sehr
viel deutlicher ausgefallen es hat über
ein halbes Jahr gebraucht bis der
Bundeskanzler den Vorschlag seines
Parteifreundes verstanden hat und dann
auch wirklich umgesetzt hat also das
zeigt schon dass das Verständnis nicht
ganz ausgeprägt ist wir noch nicht eine
Milliarde von den 100 Milliarden
ausgegeben wir wurden gedrängt möglichst
schnell der Verfassungsänderung zu
machen wir haben es gemacht noch nicht
eine Milliarde von 100 Milliarden ist
ausgegeben da kann man nicht von uns
erwarten dass wir anerkennen dass die
zeitenwände umgesetzt ist sondern hier
gibt's ganz klar umsetzungsdefiziert
Defizite es gibt definitiv
Orientierung dieser zeitenwände und
insofern haben wir als Opposition auch
manches anzumahnen ganz kurze Zitat der
vom Bundeskanzler selbst dazu der bei
Maybrit Illner gesagt hat was ich mir
ganz vorher fest vorgenommen habe ist
dass ich in dieser Zeit das Richtige tue
dass ich mich nicht drängen lasse dass
ich keine falschen überstürzen
Entscheidungen treffe dass ich keine
Dinge tue die hinterher alle Bedauern
sondern dass ich dafür sorge dass unser
Land diese schwierige Zeit gut übersteht
was ist falsch daran also daran ist gar
nichts falsch aber am Ende des Tages hat
er richtigerweise das getan was Michael
rot und wir ja auch vorgeschlagen haben
nämlich schwere Waffen das heißt auch
Kampfpanzer zu liefern das hat er nicht
überstürzt getan sondern das hat er
verzögert getan das hätte er mindestens
mindestens ein halbes Jahr vorher machen
können und das hätte die Ukrainer in
eine bessere militärische Lage versetzt
darf fallen jeden Tag und Schuldige
Menschen ich will die Opfer auf
russischer Seite gar nicht ähm geringer
schätzen Putin treibt ja sein eigenes
Volk in einem schrecklichen Krieg hinein
aber wir hätten der Ukraine sehr viel
schneller sehr viel wirkungsvoller
helfen können hätte er
also am Ende des Tages ist es dem
Bundeskanzler gelungen auch die
Vereinigten Staaten davon zu überzeugen
dass auch sie Kampfpanzer liefern das
war für ihn eine ganz zentrale
Weichenstellung und wenn ich mir jetzt
anschaue wie zögerlich einige Partner in
Europa sind die noch vor Monaten
angekündigt haben dass sie eher heute
als morgen bereit wären auch Leopard zu
liefern muss ich anerkennen der Kanzler
hat das so falsch nicht gemacht er hat
eben gesagt ich brauche ein breites
Bündnis und jetzt muss das verstetigt
werden und da mache ich mir nach wie vor
große Sorgen wenn ich an die Munition
denke die die Ukraine dringend braucht
also ich glaube wir müssen jetzt auch
unsere Bevölkerung darauf einstellen das
sind alles keine alltagsfliegen die
militärische Unterstützung muss
konsequent fortgesetzt werden das
schaffen wir aber nicht alleine in
Deutschland dafür brauchen wir die
Partner und dafür brauchen wir vor allem
auch weiterhin die USA aber was ist denn
jetzt anders irgendwie im Blick auf die
Lage denn Johann Wade hat ja richtig
gesagt Sie haben gemeinsam auch mit Frau
Zimmermann auch mit Anton Hofreiter sehr
gedrängt vor mehr als einem halben Jahr
das alles schneller geht und das
schneller geliefert werden muss warum
ist jetzt richtig was damals falsch war
wir haben immer gesagt dass wir die
Unterstützung die militärische
Unterstützung der Ukraine auch dem
Kriegsverlauf Anpassen der Bundeskanzler
bezieht immer stark in sein Handeln ein
auch die Sorgen und die Skepsis unserer
eigenen Bevölkerung ich bekomme jeden
Tag furchtbare Post ich sei der
schlimmste Kriegstreiber und ich gehöre
sofort aus diesem Bundestag
herausgeschmissen vielleicht geht's dem
Kollegen warte voll ähnlich
insofern weiß ich dass meiner Haltung
auch auf massive Kritik stößt aber
natürlich auch auf Zustimmung und jeder
muss am Ende verantwortungsbewusst damit
umgehen und der Kanzler hat es zu
entscheiden und der Kanzler hat es auch
zu verantworten das war die Begründung
trotzdem noch mal die meine Frage was
ist jetzt richtig was im letzten Sommer
falsch war
noch einmal jetzt ist deutlich geworden
jetzt ist deutlich geworden dass
Russland diesen Krieg brutalst möglich
fortsetzt dass Russland kein Interesse
hat an einer Lösung am Verhandlungstisch
die wollen weiter die Ukraine vernichten
bislang hat es in der Ukraine ganz gut
funktioniert mit den ähm Waffensystemen
auch mit den Kampfpanzern aus alter
sowjetischer Produktion die sind aber
demnächst aufgebraucht auch die Munition
und deshalb ist es jetzt so so wichtig
und so richtig dass auch moderne
westliche Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine
kommen und da bin ich natürlich
enttäuscht dass wir es bislang erst
schaffen ein Bataillon also 31 moderne
Leopards in die Ukraine zu entsenden
aber die kommen maßgeblich aus
Deutschland aus Schweden und aus
Portugal gucken wir noch mal fix ein
Punkt den ich anfangs auch schon mal
angesprochen habe Umsetzung sogenannte
Sondervermögen eigentlich sonderschulden
für die Bundeswehr weil ich betrachtet
kritisiert insbesondere die Union dass
er noch kleine Mittel geflossen sind im
Jahr 22 es gibt offenbar Verträge aber
das Beschaffungswesen Bedarf bei der
Bundeswehr einer dringenden Reform aber
das Gesetz zur Reform des
Beschaffungswesen bei der Bundeswehr hat
auch die Union im vergangenen Jahr mit
dem hat auch mit zugestimmt waren sie da
nicht weitgehend genug in ihren
Überlegungen und in dem in der Arbeit an
diesem Gesetz alle miteinander nein nein
wir hatten weitergehende Überlegungen
aber die Koalition war nicht bereit mehr
zu machen und dann haben wir gesagt wir
machen zumindestens das wozu die
Koalition jetzt bereit ist wer ja albern
gewesen dagegen
Entwurf heute ich glaube dass wir ganz
grundsätzlich das Beschaffungsamt
umstrukturieren müssen das eine
mammutbehörde die viel zu groß geworden
ist ich glaube auch nicht dass wir sie
allein staatlich erledigen können die
beschaffungsfrage ich glaube dass wir ja
auch darüber nachdenken müssen die
anderen Nationen das lange machen dass
wir Agenturen haben die auch privat
organisiert sind die das
Beschaffungswesen effektiver herleiten
können da gibt es immer noch Kräfte die
das verhindern wollen
wir haben eine große Behörde in Koblenz
in Rheinland-Pfalz und die
sozialdemokratische Ministerpräsidentin
gehört nicht zu den ersten Verfechtern
einer Reform das verstehe ich mit bei
all der Bindung an Gewerkschaften an
Arbeitsplätze wir müssen aber einfach
schneller werden ich meine es kann nicht
angehen dass wir Jahre brauchen um die
nächsten Kampfpanzer Leopard zu
beschaffen die wir längst eingeführt
haben und nach derzeitigen Stand der
Dinge ist es so und wie gesagt es ist
eine Milliarde erst von 100 Milliarden
ausgegeben das ist deutlich zu wenig zum
Schluss noch ein rot was tut die
Koalition in dieser Sache
also erstmal hat ja sogar der CDU
verteilungsminister add dem ist jetzt
zugegeben dass mit dem Beschaffungswesen
so wie er es organisier das hat nicht
funktioniert wir müssen mit einem
starken tatkräftigen
Bundesverteidigungsminister endlich auch
dafür sorgen dass das Geld auch
investiert wird in die Systeme die wir
dringend brauchen und ich meine dringend
an eine europäisch koordinierte
Aktion denn es kann nicht angehen dass
wir in Konkurrenz stehen zu unseren
europäischen Partnern wir müssen die
Waffensysteme standardisieren auch bei
der Munition damit wir noch enger
zusammenarbeiten können und das spart am
Ende auch Kosten und wir werden das
weiter diskutieren müssen für heute sind
wir leider am Ende unserer Zeit
angekommen erholt vielen Dank dass Sie
heute morgen bei uns gewesen sind auch
ihnen erwartet vielen Dank oder anderen
Mehrwert für sicherlich in der Debatte
zumindest sehen aber wahrscheinlich auch
hören vielen Dank für den Moment danke
sehr und wir meine Damen und Herren
schauen schon mal in den Plenarsaal
hinein der sich recht gut gefühlt hat
schon denn es geht ja auch in Kürze los
wir haben im Hintergrund den Gong gehört
das bedeutet die Bundestagspräsidentin
ist auf dem Weg zu ihrem Platz und
deswegen gebe ich jetzt rein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Gäste auf der Besuchertribüne die
Sitzung ist hier mit eröffnet ich heiße
Sie recht herzlich willkommen
guten Morgen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir beginnen die heutige Sitzung mit
einer traurigen Mitteilung
die Abgeordnete Corinna miaska ist
gestorben
ihr Leben endete viel zu früh
sie wurde nur 39 Jahre alt
Corinna miaska wuchs in Oldenburg auf
und sie zog zum Studium nach Bayern dass
ihre zweite Heimat wurde
2017 zog sie erstmals in den Deutschen
Bundestag ein sie engagierte sich
zuletzt als stellvertretende Vorsitzende
ihrer Fraktion und als Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Angelegenheiten der
Europäischen Union
Corinna miaska hat lange gegen ihre
Krankheit gekämpft an der immer noch
viel zu viele Frauen sterben
sie hatte den Mut sie hatte die Stärke
ihre Krankheit öffentlich zu machen
zwischenzeitlich glaubte Corinna miaska
an Ihre Genesung und deshalb trat sie
auch im Jahr 2021 ein weiteres Mal zur
Bundestagswahl an
am vergangenen Samstag ist Corinna
miaska ihrer Krankheit erlegen
in Gedanken sind wir bei ihrer Familie
ich bitte Sie sich für eine
Schweigeminute von ihren Plätzen zu
erheben
vielen Dank
wir haben nun die Aufgabe in den
parlamentarischen Betrieb für den
heutigen Tag einzusteigen und ich rufe
nun auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 6 die
Abgabe einer Regierungserklärung durch
den Bundeskanzler mit dem Titel ein Jahr
Zeitenwende Deutschlands Sicherheit und
Bündnisse stärken die Ukraine weiter
unterstützen für die Aussprache ist im
Anschluss an die Regierungserklärung
eine Dauer von 90 Minuten vereinbart
das Wort zur Abgabe einer
Regierungserklärung hat nun der
Bundeskanzler Herr Olaf Scholz ich
eröffne die Aussprache Herr
Bundeskanzler sie haben das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
heute vor einem Jahr am 7 Tag des
russischen Angriffskrieges gegen die
Ukraine notierte die ukrainische Autorin
efgennjabellebuch
draußen höre ich wieder eine Explosion
in solchen Minuten überfällt mich die
Angst und ich überlege wie ich mich
selbst und die Menschen die ich liebe
aus dieser Situation retten kann
und weiter schrieb sie
jetzt ist die Zeit tapfer zu handeln und
gegen den agresser starke wirksame
Mittel zu finden
in meiner Fantasie spielen sich jetzt
schon hundert Varianten ab wie das alles
aufhören kann wie der Krieg endet in
diesem konkreten Moment
ich habe dieses Zitat ausgewählt weil
ich es wichtig finde dass wir
ukrainische Stimmen hören wenn wir über
Russlands Krieg in der Ukraine
diskutieren
ich meine
zentrale Gedanken zum Ausdruck erstens
die Ukraine will dass dieser Krieg endet
vom ersten Kriegstag an jede Ukrainerin
jeder Ukrainer sehnt sich nach Frieden
mehr als irgendwer sonst
und zweitens der Weg hin zu diesem
Frieden erfordert tapferes handeln
Frieden schaffen das bedeutet eben auch
sich Aggression und Unrecht klar
entgegenzusetzen
so wie es mehr als 40 Millionen
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer seit mehr als
einem Jahr tun um endlich wieder in
Frieden und Freiheit zu leben so wie wir
es tun indem wir die Ukraine
unterstützen solange wie das nötig ist
ich weiß in diesem Haus findet dieser
Kurs Breite und Zustimmung über die
Fraktionen der Regierungsparteien hinaus
dafür Säge der März bin ich ihnen und
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
cdu/csu-fraktion
auch die Mehrzahl der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger wünscht sich das unser Land der
Ukraine weiterhin beisteht und zwar so
wie wir es seit Beginn des Krieges tun
entschlossen
abgewogen eng abgestimmt mit unseren
Freunden und Partnern und ich sage dabei
bleibt es
und zugleich wenn ich mich heute an
diejenigen in unserem Land die sich vor
einer Eskalation des Krieges fürchten
in den vergangenen Tagen haben wir viele
Kundgebungen gesehen die einen haben
ihre Solidarität mit der Ukraine
ausgedrückt und weitere Unterstützung
gefordert andere haben gegen Waffen die
von demonstriert und sofortige
Friedensverhandlungen mit Russland
verlangt
vor dem Hintergrund so unterschiedlicher
Haltung
wie also kommt die Ukraine dem Ziel
eines gerechten Friedens näher
und ich sage bewusst die Ukraine
denn sie wurde angegriffen ihren Bürgern
und Bürgern drohen Gewalt und
Unterdrückung sie kämpfen um ihre
Freiheit und die Existenz ihres Landes
darum kann und wird es keinen
Friedensschluss über die Köpfe der
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine
man schafft auch keinen Frieden wenn man
hier in Berlin nie wieder Krieg ruft und
zugleich fordert alle Waffenlieferungen
an die Ukraine einzustellen denn wir
wissen welches Schicksal den Ukrainern
und Ukrainern unter russischer Besatzung
blüht
dafür stehen Ortsnamen wie Botschaft und
kammert ist jung und Mario Polen wo
Putin Soldaten ukrainischen Zivilisten
unfassbares Leid angetan und
furchtbarste Kriegsverbrechen begangen
haben
Friedens liebe heißt nicht Unterwerfung
unter ein größeren Nachbarn würde die
Ukraine aufhören sich zu verteidigen
dann wäre das kein Frieden sondern das
Ende der Ukraine
ein diktatfrieden gegen den Willen der
Opfer verbietet sich aber nicht nur aus
moralische Gründen sondern auch wenn wir
das Wohl unseres eigenen Landes und die
Sicherheit Europas und der Welt im Auge
haben
was für eine fatale Ermutigung des
Angreifers wäre es wenn der Bruch des
Völkerrechts und der europäischen
Friedensordnung belohnt wird
ein gerechter dauerhafter Frieden
erfordert die Wiederherstellung
internationalen Rechts die Achtung
unsere Friedensordnung
schließlich hat die Weltgemeinschaft
doch eine fundamentare leere aus den
Verheerungen der beiden Weltkriege
gezogen
Angriffskriege ein für alle Mal zu
echten
Putin für diese Regel und damit die
Kater der Vereinten Nationen
auch die Fundamente europäische
Sicherheit reist Putin ein sein
Kriegsziel spricht der offen aus sich
weite Teile der Ukraine einzuverleiben
die Ukraine als Nationen zu zerstören
damit legt er die Axt an die vielleicht
wichtigste Errungenschaft der
Entspannungspolitik von Willy Brandt und
Helmut Schmidt das gemeinsame Bekenntnis
in der Schlussakte von Helsinki Grenzen
in Europa nicht gewaltsam zu verschieben
ja und nach dem Fall des Eisernen
Vorhangs haben sich die Staaten
Nordamerikas und Europas auch Russland
in der Karte von Paris zu Demokratie
Pluralismus Rechtsstaatlichkeit und zur
freien bündniswahl bekannt
im eigenen Land hat Putins Regime schon
längst mit diesen Prinzipien gebrochen
auch nach innen setzt es auch brutalste
Repressionen gegen die eigene
Bevölkerung
umso mehr muss für uns klar sein
unsere europäische Friedensordnung ist
Wert
unser nie wieder bedeutet dass der
Angriffskrieg niemals zurückkehrt als
Mittel der Politik unser nie wieder
bedeutet dass sich Putins Imperialismus
nicht durchsetzen darf
nur dann werden die zivilisatorischen
Errungenschaften Bestand haben auf die
auch unsere Friede baut und die wir in
der Kater der Vereinten Nationen der
Schlussakte von sehr hellsinki und der
Kater von Paris festgeschrieben haben
bleibt die Frage ist Putin überhaupt
bereit über die Rückkehr zu diesen
Grundsätzen und einen gerechten Frieden
zu verhandeln
im Moment spricht nichts dafür
viel mehr selbst Putin auf Drohgebärden
wie zuletzt die Aussetzung des
newsstart-vertrags mit den USA
vom Grundsatz ausgewogener
Gegenseitigkeit hat Helmut Schmidt mit
Blick auf den helsinki-prozess der
1970er Jahre gesprochen
davon kann aber keine Rede sein solange
Putin die Ukraine in ihrer Existenz und
damit zugleich die Grundfesten der
europäischen Friedensordnung bedroht
mit der Waffe an der Schläfe lässt sich
nicht verhandeln außer über die eigene
unterwerfen
umso bemerkenswerter ist dass Präsident
selenski zum G20-Gipfel im November
Vorschläge für einen dauerhaften
gerechten Frieden vorgelegt hat
für die Bundesregierung ist klar
wir werden der Ukraine helfen das ist zu
einem solchen Frieden kommt
deshalb sprechen wir mit Kirche und
anderen Partnern auch über künftige
sicherheitszusagen für die Ukraine
solche Sicherheits zu sagen setzen aber
zwingend voraus dass sich die Ukraine in
diesem Krieg erfolgreich verteidigt
auch gegenüber Partnern in Asien Afrika
und im Süden Amerikas flankieren wir das
Werben der Ukraine für einen gerechten
Frieden mit Erfolg wie die Abstimmung in
der UN-Generalversammlung vergangenen
Donnerstag gezeigt hat ich bin
Außenministerin beerbock sehr dankbar
für ihr intensives werben im Vorfeld
dieser Sitzung
das Ergebnis ist eine klare Botschaft
der Weltgemeinschaft an Putin
ziehen sie ihre Truppen zurück dann ist
dieser Krieg augenblicklich vorbei
es ist wichtig dass Putin diese
Botschaft von Ländern weltweit hört das
habe ich in meinen Gesprächen mit dem
brasilianischen Präsidenten und zuletzt
mit dem indischen Premierminister betont
das ist seit Kriegsbeginn auch unsere
Botschaft gegenüber China
bei meinem Besuch in Peking und
anschließend beim G20-Gipfel hat sich
auch Staatspräsident
unmissverständlich gegen jede Drohung
mit Atomwaffen oder gar deren Einsatz im
Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine
und es ist gut das China die klare
Botschaft gegen den Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen jüngst in seinem zwölf
Punkteplan wiederholt hat und sich auch
eindeutig gegen den Einsatz biologischer
und chemischer Waffen
Massenvernichtungswaffen stellt
aber
man kann zu Recht von China erwarten
dass es seine Ideen mit den
Hauptbetroffenen bespricht mit den
Ukrainern und Präsident selenski
enttäuschend ist ist China beim jüngsten
Treffen der G20 Finanzminister nicht
mehr bereit war zu bekräftigen was noch
beim Gipfel in Bali Konsens war eine
klare Verurteilung des russischen
Angriffs
meine Botschaft an Peking ist klar
nutzen sie ihren Einfluss in Moskau um
auf den Rückzug russische Truppen zu
drängen und liefern sie keine Waffen an
den ergressor Ausland
setzt nach wie vor auf einen
militärischen Sieg
doch diesen Sieg wird es nicht geben
auch weil wir und unsere Partner die
Ukraine weiter unterstützen
Putin verkalkuliert sich wenn er glaubt
dass die Zeit für ihn spielt
je früher er begreift dass er seine
imperialistischen Ziele nicht erreicht
und dass die internationale Gemeinschaft
seinen Völkerrechtsbruch nicht duldet
desto größer ist die Chance auf ein Ende
dieses Krieges deshalb stehen wir so
fest an der Seite der Ukraine bei der
Verteidigung ihrer Souveränität und
ihrer territorialen Integrität
deshalb leisten wir humanitäre
wirtschaftliche und militärische Hilfe
für die Ukraine für ihre Bürgerinnen und
Bürger mehr als 14 Milliarden Euro und
den zurückliegenden zwölf Monaten ein
großer und unserem Land angemessener
Betrag
unsere Waffen die von stets eng
abgestimmt mit unserem Verbündeten
helfen der Ukraine sich zu verteidigen
und durchzuhalten
dafür stehen die Artillerie und
luftverteidigungssysteme die bereits
seit Monaten hochwirksam im Einsatz sind
und wir bauen unsere Unterstützung
weiter aus allein seit Jahresbeginn mit
dem Patriot Luftabwehrsystem dem
Schützenpanzer Marder und den dem
Kampfpanzer Leopard 1 und 2
alle die zu dieser gemeinsamen
kraftanstellung beigetragen können
sollten das tun und dafür bin ich an der
Linda berok Boris Pistorius und sehr
gezielt sehr dankbar dass sich dass sie
zusammen mit mir gezielt bei unseren
Verbündeten dafür werben übrigens mit
Erfolg
die Leopard 2 liefern wir in enger
Zusammenarbeit mit Polen Schweden
Norwegen Spanien Kanada und Portugal
die Leopard eins mit Dänemark und den
Niederlanden die Panzerhaubitzen mit
Italien und den Niederlanden die
patrick-systeme mit den USA und den
Niederlanden und die mehrfach
Raketenwerfer mit Großbritannien und den
USA
darüber hinaus haben wir unsere Partner
einen Beschaffung für die Ukraine
gemeinsam mit uns durchzuführen etwa
Artillerie Munition Panzerabwehrwaffen
und
er Gebhard und ein zusätzliches
Luftverteidigungssystem ihres Team
bringen wir in den kommenden Wochen auf
den Weg sie werden Ukraine und Ukraine
vor russischen Luftangriffen schützen
parallel arbeiten wir mit der Industrie
an verlässlichem Nachschub für Munition
und Ersatz teil
und insgesamt über 3000 Soldaten und
Soldaten aus der Ukraine hat die
Bundeswehr seit Kriegsbeginn ausgebildet
für mehr als 1000 Soldaten steht der
Ausbildungsbeginn in Deutschland
unmittelbar bevor
eng koordiniert mit den
ausbildungsinitiativen der USA und
Großbritannien ist unser Land damit der
Zentrale Ausbildungsort für ukrainische
Soldaten in Europa
ich habe mir diese Ausbildung selbst
angesehen die Bundeswehr leistet hier
geradezu meisterliches
allen unseren Soldaten und Soldaten auch
den zivilen Mitarbeitern und
Mitarbeitern der Bundeswehr die das
möglich machen sage ich herzlichen Dank
ich weiß
diese Art der Unterstützung unsere
Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine das ist
ungewohnt in unserem Land
darum verstehe ich alle Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die darüber nicht Hurra schreien
ihnen versichere ich
die von mir geführte Regierung macht
sich Entscheidungen über Waffen die von
niemals leicht
ja wir unterstützen die Ukraine auch um
die europäische Friedensordnung zu
verteidigen
und zugleich achten wir bei jeder
unserer Entscheidung darauf dass die
NATO nicht zur Kriegspartei wird
darin bin ich mir mit dem amerikanischen
Präsidenten einig
um unsere enge Abstimmung vorzuführen
weil sich heute zu Gesprächen mit Joe
Biden nach washing ein Jahr Zeitenwende
heißt auch ein Jahr transatlantische
Partnerschaft enger und vertrauensvoller
denn je
auch die Europäische Union und die NATO
sind zwölf Monate nach Kriegsbeginn so
geeinigt wie selten zuvor
erst in der vergangenen Woche haben wir
in Brüssel unser mittlerweile zehntes
Paket von Sanktionen gegen Russland
verabschiedet
gemeinsam mit unseren internationalen
Partnern haben wir hier in Berlin den
Grundstein für den Wiederaufbau der
Ukraine gelegt
wir haben Klarheit darüber geschaffen
dass die Zukunft der westbalkanstaat die
Zukunft der Ukraine moldas und
perspektivisch auch Georgiens in der
Europäischen Union liegt
schon jetzt gibt das den Reformen in den
Kandidatenländern zusätzlichen
Rückenwind zum Beispiel im solange
festgefahrenen Konflikt zwischen Serbien
und Kosovo
ich bin froh dass ich beide Seiten
Präsident bucic und Premierminister
Kurti Anfang dieser Woche klar zum
deutsch-französischen Vorschlag für eine
Grundlagenvereinbarung bekannt haben wir
werden diesen Prozess mit Nachdruck
weiter verfolgen
auch bei der engen Verzahnung der
Verteidigungsindustrie in Europa kommen
wir voran dafür stehen gemeinsame
Projekte wie FAS das künftige
luftkampfsystem mit Frankreich und
Spanien und die von Deutschland
initiierte European Sky Shield zur
Stärkung von Europas Luftverteidigung im
Rahmen der NATO
gerade erst haben sich mit Schweden und
Dänemark zwei weitere enge Freunde
diesem Vorhaben angeschlossen
und schließlich haben wir Europäer uns
im Zeitraffer aus der Abhängigkeit von
Öl Gas und Kohle aus Russland gelöst und
zugleich beim Aufbau einer
klimaneutralen europäischen Industrie
den Turbo gezündet
[Applaus]
der Industrieförderung für den Cleantech
vereinfachte Beihilfe Regeln mehr
Investitionen in klimafreundlichen und
digitalen Wandel eine batterieallianz
den Chips Act all das haben wir in
kürzester Zeit aufs Gleis gesetzt all
das sind zugleich Schritte zu einem
geopolitischen Europa zu Europa das
international wettbewerbsfähig ist und
auch durch neue Freihandelsabkommen und
Rohstoff Partnerschaften das
unterstreicht zu einem Europa das sich
auch in der multipolaren Welt des 21
jahrhunderts behauptet und Standard
auch Deutschland ist im Licht der Zeiten
Wende widerstandsfähiger geworden
am deutlichsten wird das wenn man auf
die Bundeswehr blickt wir machen Schluss
wir machen muss Schluss mit der
Vernachlässigung unserer Streitkräfte
dafür steht das Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr und ich bin dankbar für die
breite Unterstützung dafür auch seitens
der größten Oppositionsparteien
dafür steht aber auch der Aufwuchs des
Verteidigungshaushalts insgesamt damit
wir dauerhaft das 2% Ziel der NATO
erreichen
diese Zusage die hier am 27 Februar
vergangenen Jahres gegeben habe gilt
wichtige Beschaffungsverfahren haben wir
eingeleitet etwa den F35 Kampfjet ein
Großteil der für das Sondervermögen
vorgesehenen Projekte soll noch in
diesem Jahr unter Vertrag sein das sind
zumeist langfristige Vorhaben für die
Aufgaben aus dem Sondervermögen
entsprechend geleistet werden
auch die Nachbeschaffung etwa von
Panzerhaubitzen Munition und anderen
Gütern die wir aus Beständen der
Bundeswehr an die Ukraine geliefert
haben wird in den kommenden Monaten
unter Dach und Fach gebracht
wir tun all das auch mit Blick auf
unsere gewachsene Verantwortung und die
gestiegenen Erwartungen die unsere
Bündnispartner zurecht an Deutschland
als bevölkerungsreiches und
wirtschaftsstärkstes Land Europas
richten
letztes Jahr am 27 Februar habe ich hier
im Bundestag gesagt
wir stehen ohne wenn und aber zu unserer
Beistandspflicht in der NATO
und auch diesen Worten lassen wir taten
folgen
mit einer eigens designierten Brigade
zum Schutz Litauens mit der
Unterstützung Polens und der Slowakei
bei der Flugabwehr mit unserem Marine
und Bundespolizei die sich zusammen mit
Norwegen und anderen um den
schutzkritischer Infrastruktur in Nord-
und Ostsee kümmern
indem wir in diesem Jahr die
nato-schützen führen und dafür 17.000
Soldaten und Soldaten in hoher
Bereitschaft halten und indem wir ab
2025 zunächst 30.000 Soldaten und
Soldaten für die künftige nato-
Industrie über einen echten Spurwechsel
hin zu einer schnellen planbaren und
leistungsfähigen Beschaffung von
Rüstungsgüter für die Bundeswehr und
andere europäische Armee
wir brauchen eine laufende Produktion
von wichtigen Waffen Geräten und
Munition das erfordert langfristige
Verträge und Anzahlung um
Fertigungskapazitäten aufzubauen
so schaffen wir hier in Deutschland eine
industrielle Basis die ein Beitrag
leistet zur Sicherung von Frieden und
Freiheit in Europa auch das ist eine
Erkenntnis der Zeitenwende
wenn wir Sicherheitsfragen im Licht der
Zeitenwende neu denken dann geht es
nicht nur um militärische Fähigkeiten
wir haben den vergangenen zwölf Monaten
Desinformationskampagnen erlebt
sabotageakter an kritischer
Infrastruktur auch Cyberangriffe
auch dagegen wappnen wir uns
denn freie offene Gesellschaften wie
unsere müssen auch im Inneren stark und
widerstandsfähig sein
wie stark und widerstandsfähig wir sein
können das haben wir gezeigt als
Russland uns mit dem Stopp von
Energielieferungen unter Druck gesetzt
hat denn wir sind gut durch diesen
Winter gekommen auch ohne russische
Gaslieferung
von kalten Wohnungen war die Rede von
der Zwangsabschaltung ganzer
Industriezweige vom
Produktionsstillstand von einem heißen
Herbst und wutwinter
nichts davon ist eingetreten weil wir
entschlossen gehandelt haben weil wir
zusammen geblieben sind und hinter
diesem Bier steht unser ganzes Land
und Länder gemeinsam haben wuchtige
entlastungspakete geschnürt dadurch sind
die Großhandelspreise gefallen das kommt
nun auch bei den Verbrauchern und
Verbrauchern an wir haben die
gastspeicher so gefüllt dass sie heute
noch zu mehr als 70% voll sind dass es
ein gutes Polster um sicher auch durch
den nächsten Winter zu kommen
eine enorme Hilfe dabei ist dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger weiter Energie
sparen viele bauen sich zu Hause neue
Wärmepumpen und Solaranlagen ein andere
haben das vor
Unternehmen haben ihre Energieversorgung
umgerüstet und investierenden
klimafreundliche Produktion und
schließlich haben wir im Rekordtempo
neue lng-terminals und Leitungen in
Betrieb genommen
es waren die vielen hervorragend
ausgebildeten Ingenieuren und Ingenieure
in unserem Land unsere tüchtigen
FacharbeiterInnen und Facharbeiter
unsere Handwerker und Handwerkerinnen
und noch ganz viele andere die das alles
möglich gemacht haben ihnen allen sagen
wir heute herzlichen Dank
von der neuen Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit habe ich gesprochen ich
wünsche mir dass wir die wir diese
Deutschland Geschwindigkeit beibehalten
als Fortschritt den unser Land aus der
Zeiten Wende mitnimmt
besonders wichtig ist das mit Blick auf
die industrielle Transformation und den
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
2022 waren die Erneuerbaren bereits für
fast die Hälfte der Stromproduktion
verantwortlich Tendenz deutlich steigend
weil wir bürokratische Hürden für den
Ausbau beseitigt haben weil wir uns mit
den Ländern auf klare Flächen Ziele
verständigt haben weil der Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren nun als überragendes
öffentliches Interesse gesetzlich
festgeschrieben wird
mit den bereits beschlossenen Gesetzen
verdreifachen wir den Ausbau zu Wasser
zu Land und auf dem Dach immer mit dem
Ziel bis 2030 80 Prozent unseres Stroms
aus erneuerbaren Energien zu produzieren
all das war schon vor der Zeitenwende
richtig jetzt aber sind diese Aufgaben
noch wichtiger noch dringendiger und mit
dieser Dringlichkeit gehen wir Sie auch
an
Russlands Angriffskrieg der Bruch des
Völkerrechts und der europäischen
Friedensordnung diese Zeitenwende hat
uns allen viel abverlangt in den
vergangenen zwölf Monaten
am meisten natürlich den Ukrainerinnen
und Ukrainern die um ihr Leben kämpfen
und zugleich haben wir mehr erreicht als
viele uns zugetraut haben
die Ukraine behauptet ihre Freiheit und
Unabhängigkeit gegen Russlands
Aggression auch mit unserem
Unterstützung
die Einigkeit von Europäischer Union G7
und NATO ist gewahrt gerade in dieser
Krise haben wir sie weiter gestärkt
und wir haben den Winter gut überstanden
auch ohne Gas aus Russland
und wir investieren in die Sicherheit
unseres Landes und unsere Bundeswehr in
unsere Energieinfrastruktur in die
Zukunft unserer Wirtschaft und
Energieversorgung
am Ende ihres eingangs zitierten
Tagebucheintrags vom 2 März 2022
schreibt die Ukrainerinnen
als die Ukraine die man verteidigen muss
es gibt Situationen in den Widerstand
die Rettung bedeutet
schönen Dank
die Regierungserklärung des
Bundeskanzlers gut ein Jahr nach seiner
sogenannten Zeitenwende Rede wir haben
eben gesehen den ukrainischen
Botschafter natürlich auf der
Ehrentribüne im Deutschen Bundestag eine
Rede die Gemeinsamkeiten betont hat auf
vielerlei Ebenen und in der der
Bundeskanzlerin natürlich hat man fast
sagen auch das betont was seiner Meinung
nach erreicht worden ist im vergangenen
Jahr gibt viel Applaus aber keinen
stehenden Applaus es gab zwischendrin
noch ein paar Lacher aus den Opposition
rein als es etwa um das Sondervermögen
ging und ähm applaudierenden wir dürfen
recht herzlich bei uns begrüßen den
Botschafter der Ukraine Alex
herzlich willkommen
aber die Begrüßung von olexemakew durch
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin ja von
Gemeinsamkeiten die der Bundeskanzler
betont hat habe ich eben schon
gesprochen international auf der einen
Seite in Richtung NATO G7 EU natürlich
auch Richtung der USA hat die
Kooperation bei Waffenlieferung betont
aber auch wiederholt Annalena baerburg
gelobt die bundesaußenministerin des
Verhältnis galt ja zuletzt als etwas
angespannt zwischen ihr und dem
Bundeskanzler und hat schließlich noch
gesagt wir unser ganzes Land habe einen
hätten eine Bewährungsprobe bestanden
jetzt der Oppositionsführer in der
vergangenen Woche lehrte sich der Beginn
des russischen Angriffs-
zum ersten Mal
seit einem Jahr begleiten uns die
schrecklichen Bilder
dieses Krieges
und jenseits aller militärischen Fragen
denken wir auch heute vor allem an die
Menschen in der Ukraine und an den hohen
Preis den sie für die Verteidigung ihrer
Freiheit zahlen
an die Männer und Frauen die ihr Leben
gelassen haben an die zerrissenen
Familien
und wir denken auch noch einmal
an den
Holocaust Überlebenden
Boris romanschenko der hier schon öfter
genannt wurde der den Nazi-Terror und
vier Konzentrationslager
überlebt hat der aber dann im Alter von
96 Jahren bei einem russischen
Raketenangriff auf das Wohngebiet in
chakif da wo er gewohnt und gelebt hat
getötet worden ist
und mittlerweile meine Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen haben wir
Anlass mehr denn je
auch an viele Kinder zu denken die jeden
Tag in den von Russland besetzten
Gebieten von russischen Soldaten aus den
Familien gerissen
und die nach Russland deportiert werden
und dort zu Russinnen und Russen
umerzogen zu werden all das passiert nur
drei Flugstunden von hier
nur wenige Minuten von hier entfernt hat
am Wochenende eine Demonstration gegen
diesen Krieg stattgefunden
damit kein Missverständnis entsteht
genau das zeichnet unsere Freiheit ja
auch aus
das bei uns nämlich jeder gegen alles
und auch für alles demonstrieren kann
und für den Frieden einzutreten und für
den Frieden zu demonstrieren das ist nun
wirklich aller Ehren wert
aber wenn am Wochenende von maßgeblichen
Vertreterinnen und Vertretern von ganz
links und ganz rechts auch vom
Abgeordneten aus ihrer Fraktion und
ihrer Fraktion in einer geradezu
bizarren Gemeinsamkeit
Täter und Opfer verwechselt werden nicht
mal so zuvor nicht mal so zufällig
sondern geradezu vorsätzlich und wenn er
dann noch eine der VertreterInnen aus
ihrer Fraktion so Axel zuckend im Saat
deutschen Fernsehen sagt naja
Vergewaltigungen die gibt's halt so in
jedem Krieg und dann auch noch auf
beiden Seiten und dann noch auf beiden
Seiten meine Damen und Herren dann ist
das zynisch menschenverachtend
dann ist das
dann ist das einfach nur
niederträchtig und dann ist das
beschämend für unser ganzes Land und
wenn sie dann hier Zwischenrufe machen
dann möchte ich Ihnen sagen es wäre doch
ganz schön wenn diese Kollegin hier
heute morgen an dieser Debatte mal
teilnehmen würde statt in Deutschland
sind jedes durch jede Fernsehsendung zu
gehen und den und den Beifall von der
Seite den Beifall von der Seite dann
auch noch einzuholen gegen diesen
Zynismus meine Damen und Herren müssen
wir aus der Mitte dieses Parlamentes
heraus der Bevölkerung in Deutschland
immer wieder sagen dies ist und bleibt
ein völkerrechtswidriger Angriffskrieg
Russlands es gibt nur einen der ganz
allein für diesen Krieg verantwortlich
ist und der Mann heißt Vladimir Putin
nur eine meine Damen und Herren
und der Aufruf
und der Aufruf sich die der Aufruf
diesen Krieg zu beenden kann sich nur
und allein gegen Putin und sein Regime
in Russland wenden nur gegen einen
lassen nämlich mit einem ganz einfachen
Satz sagen denn Russland heute die
Waffen schweigen lässt dann ist morgen
der Krieg zu Ende wenn die Ukraine heute
die Waffen niederlegt dann ist morgen
das ukrainische Volk und die Ukraine als
Staat am Ende das ist der Unterschied
meine Damen und Herren den Tee und den
sie auch hier irgendwann einmal
akzeptieren soll
meine Damen und Herren wir müssen diesen
Krieg aber auch bitte richtig einordnen
dies ist nicht allein ein Krieg des
größten Landes in Europa gegen das
zweitgrößte Land in Europa das wäre für
sich genommen schon schrecklich genug es
ist ein Krieg der stellvertreten steht
für die Absicht zahlreicher
autokratischer Staaten auf dieser Welt
die Welt in Einflusssphären neu
einzuteilen und politische Dominanz mit
militärischer Gewalt in ihrer jeweiligen
Region durchzusetzen
und vielleicht bringt es die Neue
Zürcher Zeitung vor einigen Tagen genau
auf den richtigen Punkt es ist so
schreibt der Autor der erste große Krieg
der unter den Bedingungen der
Globalisierung ausgetragen wird gekämpft
wird nicht allein an Don und Nico zur
Disposition steht die globale
Machtverteilung
meine Damen und Herren wir haben diesen
Krieg heute hier im Deutschen Bundestag
erneut zu besprechen sie ja
Bundeskanzler haben ihn vor einem Jahr
vollkommen zurecht als eine Zeitenwende
beschrieben aber was folgt nun aus
dieser Beschreibung und diesem Wort ja
sie haben ohne Zweifel zu Recht erneut
darauf hingewiesen Europäer in der in
der in der EU und die Verbündeten in der
NATO sind nicht auseinandergefallen
sondern sie sind zusammengeblieben und
haben der Ukraine in vielerlei Hinsicht
geholfen
humanitär finanziell und eben Gott sei
Dank auch militärisch
zum ganzen Bild gehört aber leider auch
dazu ohne die Hilfe der Amerikaner wäre
die Hauptstadt Kiew und damit das ganze
Land heute längst in russischer Hand die
Europäer allein wären zu schwach und sie
wären zusammen auch nicht willens genug
der Ukraine in dem Umfang zu helfen wie
es bisher geschehen ist
und selbst diese Hilfe
Herr Bundeskanzler haben sie vor allem
in Bezug auf Schützenpanzer und
Kampfpanzer bis zum Schluss von den
Amerikanern abhängig gemacht
sie haben dann zwar oft gesagt dass sie
das so wollen aber sie haben uns bis
heute die Antwort nicht darauf gegeben
warum sie das eigentlich so wollten
und vielleicht hat der
Sicherheitsberater des amerikanischen
Präsidenten vor wenigen Tagen
im amerikanischen Fernsehen die Antwort
gegeben
er hat gesagt wörtlich im Interesse des
Bündnisses und um sicherzustellen dass
die Ukraine bekommt was sie haben möchte
obwohl die Abrams nicht das Werkzeug
sind dass sie braucht sagte der
Präsident okay ich werde der Führer der
freien Welt sein ich werde Abrams
liefern wenn ihr jetzt Leopards liefert
Ende dieses Interviews diese Leopards
diese Leopards werden jetzt geliefert
Ende dieses Zitats aus dem Interview von
lexale warum geht der wenige Tage bevor
Sie erneut nach Washington fahren mit
einem solchen Wort
in die Öffentlichkeit ich kann dem nur
aus zwei Gründen einen Sinn abgewinnen
erstens er will uns deutlich klar sagen
es sind nicht die Abrams es sind die
Leopard-Panzer die notwendig sind und es
war der Widerstand des deutschen
Bundeskanzlers der überwunden werden
musste mit einem Wort des amerikanischen
Präsidenten aber es gibt eine zweite
Begründung für diese es gibt eine zweite
Begründung dafür dass der
Sicherheitsberater des amerikanischen
Präsidenten mit einem solchen Interview
in die Öffentlichkeit geht die zweite
Begründung ist das machen wir einmal
aber kein zweites Mal
und Herr Bundeskanzler
Herr Bundeskanzler wenn Sie heute erneut
in die USA reisen dann hätten sie doch
diese Regierungserklärung zum Anlass
nehmen können einmal zu begründen was
ist eigentlich der Sinn und Zweck dieser
erneuten Reise sie ist weder vorbereitet
mit dem was sie uns hier heute gesagt
haben noch nehmen Sie Journalisten mit
noch haben sie dort einen
abschlusskommuniki vorbereitet was ist
der Sinn ihrer Reise heute nach
Washington warum reisen sie dorthin sie
hätten das heute eigentlich hier
erklären können
sie haben drei Tage nach dem Beginn
dieses Krieges
in der sie wissen es offensichtlich auch
nicht anders kann ich mir die Unruhe in
ihren rein nicht erklären
sie haben am 27 Februar 2022 in ihrer
Regierungserklärung mit unserer
Zustimmung
ein Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr in
100 in Höhe von 100 Milliarden Euro
vorgeschlagen dass wir dann auch
gemeinsam beschlossen und in das
Grundgesetz aufgenommen haben und sie
haben erklärt dass von nun an und sofort
mehr als zwei Prozent des BIP für die
Ausrüstung der Bundeswehr zur Verfügung
stehen
der Bundeskanzler ein Jahr später müssen
wir feststellen der Verteidigungsetat im
Jahr 2023 ist gegenüber dem
Verteidigungsetat des Jahres 2022 um 300
Millionen Euro gesunken wir entfernen
uns von diesem Ziel der zwei Prozent wir
nähern uns ihm nicht und 100 Milliarden
Euro für die Bundeswehr
davon sind nach Stand von heute wenn der
Deutsche Bundestag richtig informiert
worden ist 600 Millionen Euro ausgegeben
und weitere Bestellungen lassen auf sich
warten sie haben völlig zu Recht hier
die Zusammenarbeit in der Industrie auch
mit den europäischen Partnern
angesprochen aber warum sind denn diese
Bestellungen warum sind denn diese
Entscheidungen nicht alle schon längst
im letzten Jahr getroffen worden sie
haben uns hier unter großen Zeitdruck
gesetzt die Grundgesetzänderung musste
innerhalb von wenigen Wochen beschlossen
werden Anfang Juni ist sie getroffen
worden was ist eigentlich im zweiten
Halbjahr 2022 geschehen dass diese
Zusagen die sie gegeben haben auch
umgesetzt werden
und vielleicht müssen Sie immer noch die
Widerstände in ihren eigenen Reihen für
diese aus- und Aufrüstung der Bundeswehr
überwinden ich will es mit einem Satz
sagen die die
Ministerpräsidentin des Landes Estland
vor einigen Tagen gesagt hat und dieser
Satz ist den Stein gemeißelt der wird
für die nächsten Jahre vielleicht
Jahrzehnte gelten sie hat gesagt die
Freiheit muss immer besser bewaffnet
sein als die Turnerei und genau das ist
die richtige Antwort auf diese
Aggression Putins wir werden Jahre wenn
nicht Jahrzehnte Sicherheit in Europa
nicht mehr mit Russland sondern
Sicherheit in Europa gegen Russland
organisieren müssen und dazu Herr
Bundeskanzler müssen Entscheidungen
getroffen werden und nicht nur
Regierungserklärungen abgegeben werden
sie haben
interessanterweise in ihrer
Regierungserklärung heute Morgen wenn
ich es nicht überhört habe kein Wort
mehr zu ihrer nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie gesagt Sie haben
diese nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
angekündigt für das Ende des letzten
Jahres dann ist die verzögert worden
verspätet sollte sie zur Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz vorgetragen worden
sein jetzt soll sie Ende des Monats März
veröffentlicht werden das einzige was
wir bisher wissen von dem was die
nationale Sicherheitsstrategie nennen
ist ein langandauernder Kompetenzstreit
zwischen Verteidigungsministerium
Außenministerium und Bundeskanzler wo
denn diese nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie in Zukunft
lokalisiert sein soll aber der Inhalt
dieser nationalen Sicherheitsstrategie
Herr Bundeskanzler lässt weiter auf sich
warten sie streiten in dieser Koalition
über Zuständigkeiten statt in den
strategischen Fragen die jetzt
beantwortet werden müssen wirklich
Antworten zu geben und nicht zu zögern
und zu zaubern und wieder einmal zu spät
zu kommen
und dann
haben sie völlig zu Recht China
angesprochen das wird neben diesem Krieg
vermutlich die nächste große
Herausforderung sein vor der wir alle
stehen das Verhältnis zu China ist
klärungsbedürftig lassen Sie mich nur
auf einen Punkt eingehen den Sie uns
hier immer zu Recht wie ich finde auch
vorhalten wir haben zu lange am Nord
Stream zwei festgehalten
aber das was Russland mit Nord Stream 2
gemacht hat das was Russland mit Nord
Stream 2 gemacht hat macht die
Volksrepublik China seit Jahren mit
ihrer sogenannten neuen Seidenstraße das
ist ein genauso
imperiales Projekt
um wirtschaftlichen Einfluss und
politische Macht in einer viel größeren
Region zu gewinnen als Russland in der
Lage war mit Nord Stream 2 zu erreichen
wir sollten auch mit diesem Projekt den
Fehler den wir alle gemacht haben mit
Nord Stream 2 nicht noch einmal
wiederholen wir müssen dieses Projekt
strategisch richtig einordnen es ist ein
imperiales Projekt der Volksrepublik
China und nicht etwa ein altruistisches
oder wirtschaftliches Projekt so wie wir
einmal Nord Stream 2 bezeichnet haben
lassen Sie mich
abschließend noch zu den
wirtschaftspolitischen Folgen dieses
Krieges etwas sagen ja wir haben uns
hier gemeinsam darum bemüht Antworten zu
geben wir haben lange gerungen auch
gestritten um die gasumlage und dann um
die preisbremsen einige davon treten und
gerade heute in Kraft wir sind gut durch
den Winter gekommen wobei die Kassandra
Hofe die schrecklich das alles wird die
kam nicht von uns die kam auch nicht nah
in die kamen nicht von uns die kam noch
nicht aus der Industrie die kam zum ganz
großen Teil aus ihrer Regierung und von
ihrem Bundeswirtschaftsminister aber
wenn wir aber wenn wir jetzt heute
feststellen können dass das einigermaßen
gut gegangen ist dann hat das Ursachen
die zum Beispiel in den privaten
Haushalten liegen die gespart haben die
milden Winter liegen und die natürlich
auch bei der Industrie liegen aber die
Industrie meine Damen und Herren hat
nicht gespart sondern die Industrie hat
Produktionen stillgelegt
und deswegen will ich einen kurzen Blick
auf die wirtschaftliche Lage des Jahres
2022 werfen wir haben im Jahr 2022 das
erste Mal in Deutschland eine
Industrieproduktion gehabt die unter 20
Prozent unserer Wertschöpfung liegt das
ist das erste Mal dass wir unter 20
Prozent liegen in einem Industrieland
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und die
Industrievertreter die regelmäßig mit
ihrer Regierung sprechen kommen
mittlerweile zu uns und sagen wörtlich
ich zitiere wir sind wir sind diese Lava
runden leid wenn jede Woche neue
Vorschläge gemacht werden wie die
Industrie die Arbeitsplätze die
Wirtschaft in Deutschland belastet
werden und nicht etwa wie sie entlastet
werden und wie sie eine Möglichkeit
haben in Deutschland auch zu produzieren
und Arbeitsplätze zu erhalten das ist
die Wahrheit
ihrer
Wirtschaft der Bundeskanzlerin
noch gar nicht ersparen sie sitzen einer
tief zerstrittenen Koalition vor aus der
Herr regelmäßig heraus jede Woche neue
Vorschläge kommen was man den verbieten
könnte und was man noch weiter
regulieren könnte und bevor diese
Vorschläge einzelner Kabinettsmitglieder
von uns hier das Deutsche Bund in
deutschen Bundestag erreicht haben steht
schon der Generalsekretär der FDP im
Fernsehen und erklärt das sei alles mit
der FDP nicht zu machen das ist die
Arbeitsmethode ihrer Regierung zu
arbeiten sie
vielen dank
vielen Dank für den Beifall aus den
Reihen der FDP ich nehme an sie gehören
trotzdem noch dieser Koalition an meine
Damen und Herren wir wollen Sie Herr
Bundeskanzler wir wollen Sie bei Ihren
Bemühungen diesem Krieg gemeinsam mit
den Partnern in der EU und in der NATO
einzudämmen zurückzudrängen weiter
unterstützen wir tun das aus tiefer
innerer Überzeugung wir bleiben aber
auch dabei zu sagen sie bleiben heute
ein Jahr nach dem Beginn des Krieges mit
den entscheidenden Weichenstellungen
ihrer Regierung weit hinter den
selbstgesetzten Ansprüchen ihrer Zeiten
Wende zurück das muss in den nächsten
Wochen und Monaten besser werden sonst
wird es nicht gelingen
Friedrich Merz CDU CSU
Fraktionsvorsitzender und natürlich auch
cdu-parteivorsitzender zu Beginn mit
einer für seine Verhältnisse wie ich
finde ungewohnt emotionalen Rede die
insbesondere verwiesen hat auf die Opfer
dieses Krieges in der Ukraine dann ist
er heftig ins Gericht gegangen mit denen
die eine seiner Meinung nach Täter Opfer
Umkehr betreiben nie der trächtig und
beschämend sei das unter die ist
erwartete er die Protagonisten auch im
Bundestag und nicht nur in Talkshows
Präsidentin Britta Hasselmann für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
kommt
an diesem Tag nicht darauf ankommt zu
klären welche Journalisten der Kanzler
mit in die Staaten nimmt für mich geht
es auch nicht darum daran rumzumäkeln
dass die Bundesregierung sich aufgemacht
hat eine nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
entwickeln denn zu entwickeln denn diese
Bundesregierung tut es wenigstens sie
waren 16 Jahre im Amt
meine Damen und Herren
und es geht
es geht auch nicht darum
nicht darüber zu reden welche Fehler in
Zeiten der großen Koalition gemacht
wurden im Hinblick auf völlig verfehlte
geostrategische und energiepolitische
Entscheidung bei nostream 2 auch die
haben sie zu verantworten
genauso wie die SPD in der großen
Koalition und die Situation die wir hier
vorgefunden haben was die Frage der
Energiesicherheit der
Versorgungssicherheit angeht leere
Gasspeicher und eine Abhängigkeit von
fossilen Energien
die haben auch sie zu verantworten Herr
Merz und deshalb glaube ich ist es
unklughaltungsnoten in Richtung des
Wirtschaftsministeriums zu verteilen ich
bin froh dass Robert Habeck und die
Leute
Wirtschaftsministerium gemeinsam in der
Bundesregierung dafür gesorgt haben dass
wir so gut über den Winter gekommen sind
und daraus sollten Sie kein
kleinteiliges
parteipolitisches
irgendwelche Industrie
Wirtschaftsverbände und Unternehmen
würden dieser Bundesregierung nichts
zutrauen ich rate dazu dass sie nicht
mit ihren eigenen Wirtschaftsverbänden
reden sondern mal reinhorchen in
Industrie in Wirtschaft in Handwerk denn
die wissen ganz genau was in dieser
Krisensituation
bewältigt wurde was auf den Weg gebracht
wurde
meine Damen und Herren wo standen wir
vor einem Jahr Entsetzen über den Krieg
in Europa entsetzten und Befürchtung um
die Ukraine
der Tatsache dass angesichts der
russischen Übermacht die Ukraine
vielleicht in wenigen Tagen überrannt
sein könnten die Botschaft in dieser
schrecklichen Lage ist ein Jahr später
heute die Ukraine lebt und die Ukraine
wehrt sich
Herr Botschafter
ich freue mich dass Sie heute da sind
und ich möchte Ihnen an dieser Stelle
meinen Respekt meine Hochachtung für den
Mut und den Willen der Ukraine ihr Land
ihre Freiheit und unsere gemeinsamen
Werte zu verteidigen
aussprechen danke dass Sie heute hier
sind und danke
dass wir unsere Gedanken unsere
Solidarität mit den Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainern mit ihnen allen Teilen können
aber welche sinnlosen
welche Kosten dieser sinnlose brutale
völkerrechtswidrige Angriffskrieg
fordert sehen wir jeden Tag und wir
müssen nur genau hinsehen das Tun nicht
alle hier im Haus man kann darüber
eigentlich nicht hinwegsehen
Flucht Vertreibung Tod Leid
Vergewaltigung von Frauen als
Kriegswaffe systematisch eingesetzt die
Verschleppung von Kindern
viele Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer sind
erschöpft vom Krieg vom Alltag vom
Stromausfall vom ständigen Alarm
jede und jeder hat irgendwen zu
betrauern bei Tod oder Flucht
zu ihrem Leben gehört und gleichzeitig
ist da so viel Hoffnung und das
bewundere ich zutiefst
mehr als
Zustand für die vielen Kinder
deren Alltag nicht das Kind sein das
unbekümmert sein in sich trägt sondern
die warn-app der Schutzkeller die
Entbehrung die Gefahren und das große
Thema Verlust und das ist furchtbar für
diejenigen die geblieben sind sie
erleben das jeden Tag und gleichzeitig
diese Entschlossenheit nicht aufzugeben
und für ihr Land für Freiheit und
Selbstbestimmung zu kämpfen was können
wir tun wir geben Unterstützung und
damit hoffentlich ein bisschen Kraft und
ein bisschen Rückhalt und wir stehen
fest an ihrer Seite und den Menschen in
der Ukraine
putin ist es der der Aggressor ist und
Putin kann diesen Krieg sofort beenden
und ich kann es nicht mehr hören die
Gegensatz der insbesondere von ihnen
konstruiert wird
Diplomatie oder Waffen nein liebe linke
darum geht es nicht die Ukraine braucht
die Unterstützung und zwar humanitär
wirtschaftlich und mit Waffen sonst
könnte sie sich nicht selbst verteidigen
und sie hat alles Recht der Welt dazu
das zu tun und
ich kann ich nehmen die Sorgen und
Ängste der Menschen im Land sehr Ernst
wer von uns wünscht sich keinen Frieden
wer hat Angst vor Krieg natürlich ist
das eine ganz ganz große Sorge viele
viele Menschen und die müssen wir ernst
nehmen diese Besorgnis aber so zu tun
und den Menschen weiß zu machen als
ginge es um Diplomatie oder Waffen ist
falsch und sie wissen was sie tun damit
und welche
geisterführung rufen meine Damen und
Herren und wer sich am
Wochenende
Wissen
gemein macht mit den Rechten mit den
Rechten hier im Haus und mit den Rechten
im Land das war ein durchschaubares
billiges Spiel und ich finde das
unverantwortlich meine Damen und Herren
und deshalb Putin kann diesen Krieg
sofort beenden denn meine Damen und
Herren hört Putin auch zu kämpfen Ende
dieser Krieg und zwar sofort hört die
Ukraine aufzukämpfen endet die Ukraine
und das weiß jede und jeder und deshalb
müssen wir verantwortlich handeln auch
wenn es schwer fällt auch wenn man
hadert auch wenn man sich jeden Tag
fragt ob es genug ist was man tut aber
wir müssen entschlossen handeln und zwar
humanitär wirtschaftlich und mit Waffen
und selbstverständlich auch mit
Diplomatie nichts anderes ist letzte
Woche bei der unfallversammlung passiert
141 Staaten haben
diesen Krieg sofort zu beenden die
Waffen zu stoppen warum bringen sie es
eigentlich nicht fertig das zu tun meine
Damen und Herren warum
deshalb gehört die Diplomatie genauso
dazu wie alle andere Unterstützung und
die Kraftanstrengung die die zeitenwände
hier bedeutet hat seit einem Jahr das
Sondervermögen die Frage von innerer
Sicherheit
cybersicherheit die Frage von Stärkung
des Zivilschutzes und des
Bevölkerungsschutzes eine Politik die
die Energiesicherheit und
Versorgungssicherheit stabilisiert denn
da hatten sie keine Vorsorge getroffen
genauso notwendig wie auch die Frage was
machen wir mit der einen Welt wie können
wir die humanitäre Hilfe die
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit und die
ganzen Krisen und konfliktpräventionen
Stärken auch darum geht es und darum
bemüht sich diese Regierung seit einem
Jahr mit Unterstützung von uns im
Parlament und ich bin froh dass unsere
Handlungsmaxime die ist
Verantwortungsübernahme in dieser
schwierigen Zeit denn es geht um
Freiheit es geht um Selbstbestimmung es
geht um Demokratie und Menschenrechte
und da sind wir gefordert Verantwortung
zu zeigen und das tun wir an dieser
Stelle vielen Dank
Britta Hasselmann Vorsitzende der
Fraktion Bündnissen 90 die Grünen hat
hier mal betont dass sie die Sorgen der
Menschen vor einem Krieg auch hier in
Deutschland sehr ernst nehme also die
Sorgen der Menschen hier aber sie
kritisiert auch noch einmal heftig
diverse reden von einer Demonstration am
vergangenen Wochenende hier in Berlin
Kino für die afd-fraktion Frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren liebe Landsleute
von nunmehr einem Jahr vielen in der
Ukraine die ersten Schüsse und russische
Truppen marschierten ins Land seit
nunmehr ein Jahr haben wir wieder Krieg
in Europa Menschen aus der Ukraine und
Russland sterben Takt täglich und Mütter
stehen wieder vor Soldatengräber wie
alle hier hofften sowas niemals erleben
zu müssen und genau deshalb
irritiert es umso mehr dass ich das
gemeinsame Ziel nach Frieden und das war
es nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg so
verschoben hat waren wir uns alle damals
einig dass die Waffen schweigen müssen
wird heute wieder über kriegsgewinner
gesprochen und Herr märz und auch
rasenmann ihre kriegsritoring die sie
hier heute wieder an den Tag gelegt
haben ist gefährlich für Deutschland und
auch für Europa
da hört man dann Sätze die Ukraine müsse
gewinnen und Russland müsse verlieren so
die Sprachrohre von ihnen und auch der
Rüstungsindustrie und der ehemaligen
Besatzer aus Amerika und ich sage es
hier wieder ganz deutlich aus diesem
Krieg geht die Ukraine genauso als
Verlierer hervor wie Russland
es gibt nur einen Gewinner und dieser
Gewinner der heißt USA
wie oft drohte diesem Land in den
letzten Jahren die Zahlungsunfähigkeit
und wie reagieren wir hier in Europa wir
finanzieren einerseits den
US-amerikanischen landlied aus den
Steuergeldern unserer Bürger und
befeuern damit andererseits den Krieg
auf unserem eigenen Kontinent
und zusätzlich und zusätzlich liefert
die deutsche Bundesregierung erst
Ausrüstung jetzt noch schwerer Waffen in
einen Krieg in dem wir uns besser eben
nicht einmischen sollten denn es ist
nicht unser Krieg
und auch die beschworenen
Bündnisverpflichtungen aus dem Kalten
Krieg haben nicht das Ziel Frieden
wiederherzustellen sondern sie wollen
das größte Land der Welt eine
atommacht-politische schlagen das ist
einfach nur größenwahnsinnig und nein
ich befürworte nicht die russische
Kriegsstrategie aber beide Seiten
weiten die russische und die ukrainische
müssen sich schnellstmöglich
en Wege ein Ende dieses Konflikt
konzentrieren das muss das Ziel sein
Diplomatie muss immer die erste Formel
sein in diesen Krieg
die Bundesregierung betreibt die Politik
eine simplen Freund für ein Thema sie
und ihre Minister sprechen und brechen
stabile Brücken in Politik Wirtschaft
Wissenschaft und Kultur einfach ab sie
vernichten damit die Arbeit von
Jahrzehnten von Generationen die in
einen friedlichen Kontinenten Europa
gearbeitet haben und sie wollen uns
wirklich hier erzählen dass unsere
engsten Vertrauten die auf dem
nordamerikanischen Kontinent leben dass
das jetzt unsere neue einseitige Karte
sein soll Herr Bundeskanzler im Fall von
Russland haben sie es doch auch
verstanden Staaten haben keine Freunde
Staaten haben Interesse und Präsident
beiden Präsidenten weiß diese für sein
Land zu vertreten Ihnen und Ihrer
Bundesregierung scheint allerdings unser
Land mittlerweile immer gleichgültiger
zu werden
mittlerweile planen deutsche und
europäische Firmen mittlerweile plant
Deutsch und europäische Firmen in der
Uni in die USA abzuwandern weil dort
wirtschaftsfreundliche Bedingungen
vorher herrschen und weil man mit
Subventionen lockt machen das gute
Freunde gerade jetzt in dieser
wirtschaftlichen Situation nochmal es
geht um Interessen und das ist auch
völlig legitim und darum frage ich Sie
wann und warum haben sie die
Partnerschaft auf Augenhöhe verlassen
herr Schulz warum richten wir uns
politisch einseitig transatlantisch aus
um den nutzt es vor allem Deutschland
jedenfalls nicht
verlieren nicht nur die beiden
Kriegsparteien sondern auch der
europäische Kontinent und Deutschland
meine Damen und Herren seit einem Jahr
sehen wir aber auch wie andere Länder
auf die politische Umgestaltung der Welt
reagieren Indien Brasilien oder China
scheinen in ihrer Identität
selbstbewusster zu sein sie verstecken
sich nicht hinter einer wertige
leitenden Politik wo sehen Sie die
Ursachen dafür Frau bärburg und wie
möchten Sie darauf reagieren wieder mit
wirtschaftlichen Sanktionen damit
treffen sie wieder muss die Bürger in
den Ländern und natürlich die
Bevölkerung im eigenen Land in
Deutschland
zu gut erhalten muss man ihnen Herr
Bundeskanzler dass sie die Zeitenwende
jedenfalls nicht angestoßen haben
allerdings machen sie sich im Prozess
dieser Transformation zum Spielball
Dritter damit folgen Sie der Desert
Drüsen CDU markepolitik der letzten
knapp zwei Jahrzehnte selbst den
Politikstil kopiert diese
Bundesregierung kopflos und vernünftig
und kurzsichtig denken Sie dabei nur an
die bewusste der Montage der Bundeswehr
damit wurde in Kauf genommen nicht
verteidigungsbereit zu sein oder den
über alten Ausstieg aus der Kernenergie
wir haben bis heute keine Grund- und
dauerlastträge Energieversorgung in
diesem Land aber beerdingen zuerst die
Kernkraft gefolgt von der Gasversorgung
die als Übergangs Technologie propagiert
wurde und bis heute ist es ihnen
offensichtlich auch vollkommen egal wer
den Anschlag auf nordstream und die
damit unsere kritische Infrastruktur
verübt hat und deshalb fragen Sie in
Washington nachher Schulz ich glaube das
ist der richtige Ort um nachzufragen
und wissen Sie eigentlich was die
höchsten Energiepreise der Welt für
Betriebe des deutschen Mittelstandes
bedeuten die Produktion droht immer
unwirtschaftlicher zu werden kombiniert
mit der steuernabgabenlast dem
übergroßen Verwaltungsaufwand und den
hohen Arbeitskosten verlieren
Deutschland und deutsche Produkte mehr
und mehr die Konkurrenzfähigkeit auf dem
europäischen aber auch auf dem Weltmarkt
kurz sie betreiben eine Politik die
Deutschland immer weiter die
industrialisieren wird und das kann
nicht ihr Plan sein Herr Bundeskanzler
sie fahren wie ihre Vorgängerregierung
die wirtschaftsmaschine Deutschland
permanent auf Verschleiß das betrifft
auch den personellen Bereich die
Grundversorgung gerade im ländlichen
Bereich wird immer schlechter von Tag zu
Tag von Monat zu Monat wir haben keine
Ärzte auch keine Bäcker keine Dachdecker
keine Heizungsbauer keine Lehrer keine
Polizisten aber seit 2015 seit 2015
bekommen wir hier das Versprechen der
Einwanderer die diese Lücke schließen
soll wie viele zugewanderte Zahlen heute
eigentlich in die Sozialsysteme ein aus
denen sie und die dazugehörigen Familien
Leistungen beziehen und wie viel Prozent
der eingewanderten sind straffällig
geworden die Antworten kennen sie alle
hier aber sie leugnen sie und sie wollen
sich nicht wahrhaben ihre Politik
schafft keine Anreize für wirkliche
Fachkräfte die wir sicherlich auch
brauchen und schauen sich doch die Welt
an die wirkliche Fachkraft egal wo sie
auf der Welt lebt warum sollten Sie
ausgerechnet nach Deutschland kommen
warum und es kümmert sich auch überhaupt
nicht dass immer mehr deutsche
Jugendliche ohne Schul- oder
Berufsabschluss da stehen und bereits
jetzt haben wir in Deutschland auch
Verteilungskämpfe vor denen wir immer
wieder auch gewarnt haben Beispiel
Lörrach 40 Mieter aus Wohnung geworfen
Berlin Wedding eine Altenpflegeheim wird
zur flüchtlingswohnheim umfunktioniert
weil das Land für Flüchtlinge mehrzüge
zahlt als für Senioren das
ist ungeheuerlich und das ist
und deshalb kümmern sie sich erstmal um
die Probleme im eigenen Land bevor Sie
versuchen die ganze Welt mit ihren guten
Ratschlägen zu retten aber das scheint
ihnen ja mittlerweile zu gefallen
arrogant und überheblich tragen Sie hier
heute auch wieder ihre ideologischen
Wertevorstellungen vor sich her sie
glauben anscheinend der Staat sollte bei
den Bürgern ideologisch nachhelfen oder
soll sie sich sagen nachdenken helfen
ihre Versuche ist betreuten Denkens
haben bereits gefährliche Züge
eingenommen die hypermoralisieren und
legen ein schwarz-weiß denken
mittlerweile an den Tag was unerträglich
geworden ist und wer ihnen nicht
zustimmt wird mittlerweile abgestempelt
und ausgegrenzt hier die aktuelle
Debatte um den Krieg in der Ukraine mir
scheint
sie machen alle unliebsamen mundtot weil
sie sich dem demokratischen Diskurs
nicht aussetzen wollen woran liegt das
warum versuchen sie im gleichen Moment
andere Länder zu belehren dass diese
mindestens undemokratische mit ihrer Art
von Politik machen sich zum Totengräber
unseres Grundgesetzes was das Recht auf
freie Meinungsäußerung genauso
garantiert wie die von ihnen so viel
beschworene Vielfalt die Wahrheit ist
sie setzen alles daran die Gesellschaft
weiterhin zu spalten frei nach dem Motto
wäre nicht für mich ist ist gegen mich
monatelang wurden die Kritiker der
corona-politik der vergangenen Regierung
aber auch dieser Regierung diffamiert
und beschimpft heute zeigen sich in den
Impfschäden oder auch in dem
psychosozialen Erkrankungen der Kinder
die Auswirkungen ihrer Maßnahme unter
lauter ihre Staubmaske die fehlt ja
heute das sieht man doch und so lassen
sich
die treiben eine Transformation voran
die nicht Weiterentwicklung sondern
eingängung bedeutet sie machen Politik
gegen die Bürger und vor allem für deren
Lasten noch vor zwei Jahren wurden
Prämien dafür gezahlt das alte Ölheizung
durch moderne Gasheizung ersetzt werden
und die Bürger haben investiert und
darauf vertraut für die nächsten
Jahrzehnte sicher und günstig mit
Energie versorgt zu werden
das war genauso und ist genauso ein
Schwachsinn wie damals die gasumlage her
habe das ist ihre desaströse
Wirtschaftspolitik und wie reagieren Sie
wenn die Bürger das nicht mitmachen
wollen ganz einfach mit einem Verbot
nichts anderes kann diese
Bundesregierung und vor allen Dingen die
grüne Politik mit Verboten sie machen
sich
sie machen sich den gesamten politischen
Betrieb für die Bürger immer
unberechenbarer und unglaubwürdiger
meine Damen und Herren weder das tilgen
von Straßennamen noch eine feministische
Außenpolitik sind Lösungen oder das was
unsere Bürger oder Deutschland brauchen
wir brauchen eine Bundesregierung die im
Interesse aller bürgerhandel die
tagtäglich zur Wertschöpfung beitragen
oder beigetragen haben sie haben ein
Recht auf eine Politik die für den
Erhalt der Heimat und der eigenen
Identität einsteht die aktuelle
transformationspolitik oder wie Sie es
nennen zeitenwände dieser
Bundesregierung führt allerdings in eine
Zukunft ohne Frieden und ohne
wirtschaftliche Sicherheit vielen Dank
kinoprophaler Vorsitzende der
afd-fraktion kritisiert die ich zitiere
russische Kriegsstrategie allerdings
kritisiert er nicht den Krieg Russlands
gegen die Ukraine
Russland gegen die Ukraine an sich die
Verantwortung liegt dabei Deutschland
und den USA Christian dürft für die
FDP-Fraktion
deswegen ich hatte Anfang diesen Monats
die Gelegenheit mit Kollegen aus meiner
Fraktion die panzertruppenschule in
niedersächsischen Munster zu besuchen
fast ein Jahr nach Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges auf die Ukraine konnte
ich mich mit denjenigen austauschen die
im Zentrum der zeitenwände stehen an der
panzertruppenschule in Münster werden
ukrainische Streitkräfte werden
ukrainische Soldaten und Soldaten am
Schützenpanzer Mara am Leopard von
deutschen Soldaten ausgebildet am
westlichen Gerät werden ukrainische
Soldaten von ihren deutschen Kameraden
und Kameraden ausgebildet um
verteidigungsfähig zu sein in diesem
fürchterlichen Angriffskrieg meine Damen
und Herren Putin
hat die Ukraine
Europa
die unterschätzt wir sind stärker als
diese Adresse das zeigt insbesondere die
Bundeswehr und unsere Soldaten und
Soldaten liebe Freunde
er hat das Gegenteil dessen erreicht was
er wollte er wollte die NATO Spalten er
wollte das westliche Bündnis Spalten die
Wahrheit ist wir werden zwei neue
Mitglieder im Kreis der NATO begrüßen
können in den kommenden Zeit und ich
will zudem etwas sagen wie auch die
deutsche Debatte darüber verläuft
angesichts der Rede meines Vorredners
und auch der Demonstration die in den
letzten Tagen nicht weit von hier am
Brandenburger Tor stattgefunden habe an
der
Demonstrationen an der
Solidaritätsdemonstration für die
Ukraine durfte ich selbst mit vielen
Kollegen aus diesem Haus teilnehmen die
andere Demonstration muss ja auch
erwähnt werden liebe Kollegen Kollegen
es ist vollkommen zulässig in einer
demokratieentscheidung von Regierung und
politische Meinung von Fraktionen in
diesem Hause zu kritisieren es ist
zulässig natürlich darüber zu
diskutieren wie wir innerhalb des
westlichen Bündnisses die Ukraine
unterstützen aber eines ist nicht
zulässig Täter und Opfer bewusst zu
verwechseln liebe Kolleginnen nicht
zulässig
und ich sage das in der Deutlichkeit
weil ich glaube dass die demokratischen
Fraktion genau das nicht zulassen dürfen
und das sage ich in Richtung der
Kollegen und Kollegen der Linkspartei
ich unterstelle nicht dass Ihre gesamte
Partei und Fraktion so denken die Frau
Wagenknecht aber wenn das so ist wenn
Sie nicht alle so denken wie diejenigen
die an dieser fürchterlichen Demut
teilgenommen haben wenn das nicht so ist
wenn dass sie so denken wie diese Rechte
Fraktion da müssen sie sich von diesen
Kräften in ihrer Partei trennen liebe
Kollegen und Kollegen sie müssen sich
von denen das finanzieren und lossagen
denn die märchenerzählung ist ginge
ausschließlich um militärische Maßnahmen
die ist schlicht falsch und der
Bundeskanzler hat es vorhin erwähnt die
finanzielle Unterstützung der Ukraine
die der Bundesfinanzminister im
g7-format als wir die Präsidentschaft
hatten organisiert hatten hat
sichergestellt dass die Ukraine auch in
ihrer staatlichen Integrität in ihrer
staatlichen Funktionalität in diesem
Angriffskrieg erhalten bleibt oder die
Unterstützung im Justizbereich ist
werden heute diese Kriegsverbrechen
dokumentiert das Ziel muss sein liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen dass diese
Kriegsverbrechen Russlands am Ende auch
geahndet werden das ist die Antwort auf
diesen Krieg das ist die Antwort der
westlichen liberalen Demokratie liebe
Kollegen
und ich will auf drei Punkte eingehen in
meiner Rede die Sicherheitspolitik die
wir gehabt haben in den letzten Jahren
war ganz entscheidend natürlich von der
Unterstützung der USA und wir haben hier
eine Abhängigkeit gehabt die uns jetzt
gefährlich geworden ist und das ist ja
auch richtig hier gesagt worden unsere
Energiepolitik war abhängig vom billigen
russischen Erdgas auch das sind
allgemein festgestellt worden das hat
nicht funktioniert und unsere
Wirtschaftspolitik war in der
Vergangenheit zu sehr fokussiert auf
autokratische Regime und nicht auf die
liberalen Demokratien ich will deswegen
zuerst etwas zur Sicherheitspolitik
sagen ich bin der cdu/csu-fraktion
dankbar dass sie das Sondervermögen für
die Bundeswehr unterstützt hat ich
verstehe jede Ungeduld ich sehe auch
dass der neue
Bundesverteidigungsminister das zum
obersten Ziel erklärt hat nämlich die
Truppe so auszustatten insbesondere weil
wir jetzt Material an die Ukraine
liefern dass das bei den Soldaten und
Soldaten ankommt Herr Merz sie haben in
ihrer Rede vor einem Jahr gesagt in
Wahrheit stehen wir spätestens mit
dieser Woche das war wenige Tage nach
dem Ausbruch des Krieges in Wahrheit
stehen wir spätestens mit dieser Woche
vor einem Scherbenhaufen der deutschen
europäischen außen und
Sicherheitspolitik der jetzt letzten
Jahrzehnte wie wahr wir standen vor
allem Scherbenhaufen und diese
Bundesregierung hat den Hebel umgelegt
es ist richtig dass wir unsere
Verteidigungsfähigkeit stärken müssen
und es ist jetzt richtig dass wir
unseren Verpflichtungen die
Vorgängerregierung nicht nachgekommen
ist sind im nato-bündnis endlich erfüllt
dafür steht diese Bundesregierung kein
Zweifel daran liebe Kollegen mit
Kollegen
und ich will einen zweiten Punkt der
Zeitenwende ansprechen nämlich auch die
wirtschaftspolitischen und
energiepolitischen Forderungen
Herausforderungen die wir in Deutschland
haben ich habe vorhin davon gesprochen
dass unsere Energiepolitik aus zwei
Pfeilern in Wahrheit Bestand hat auf
einer auf der einen Seite der Ausbau der
neuen Energien und auf der anderen Seite
das billige russische Erdgas diese
Energiepolitik war auf Schocks nicht
vorbereitet diese Energiepolitik war
falsch und zur Wahrheit gehört dass wir
jetzt Dinge tun müssen auch aus
klimapolitischer Sicht die wir uns nicht
gewünscht hätten in Deutschland fahren
jeden Tag das hat diese Bundesregierung
wegen der Fehler der Vergangenheit
entscheiden müssen in Deutschland fahren
jeden Tag 30.000 Tonnen Kohle zu den
Kohlekraftwerken das ist notwendig
geworden weil in der Vergangenheit
Fehler gemacht worden sind zur Wahrheit
gehört dass wir es geschafft haben seit
September
2022 auch dadurch unabhängig zu werden
vom russischen Erd aber Teil dieser
zeitenwände ist auch das was wir in den
letzten Monaten realen Betrieb genommen
haben wir haben denn viele in diesem
Haus darüber gelächelt als meine
Fraktion schon zu meiner Zeit in
niedersächsischen Landtag im übrigen als
meine Partei gesagt hat wir müssen auch
auf lng-terminals an der
niedersächsischen an der deutschen Küste
setzen in Wilhelmshaven haben wir es im
Betrieb genommen in Lubmin läuft es
jetzt weitere werden folgen wie richtig
ist doch diese Politik der Umsteuerung
im energiepolitischen Bereich liebe
Kollegen Kollegen wer hätte das noch vor
14 Monaten gedacht dass Deutschland dazu
in der Lage ist und wir haben weitere
Entscheidungen getroffen in den letzten
Tagen wenn ich beispielsweise daran
denke dass wir die Stromnetze jetzt
endlich schnell ausbauen wenn ich
beispielsweise auch daran denken und das
will ich zum Schluss in Richtung der CSU
insbesondere sagen bin ich
beispielsweise daran denke dass diese
Koalition geräuschlos am Dienstag
entschieden hat dass wir gerade im
Verkehrssektor nicht eindimensional
fahren werden sondern beispielsweise in
Deutschland endlich klimaneutrale
Kraftstoff in Form von if you zulassen
ja ja sie mögen jetzt sagen das haben
wir in den letzten Monaten ja auch immer
gefordert als CDU und CSU die Wahrheit
ist der größte unintelligible Feind des
Verbrennungsmotors und man kann
unterschiedlicher Meinung in der Sache
sein die Haltung meiner Partei und
Fraktion ist klar der größte Feind der
größte Kritiker des Verbrennungsmotors
in den letzten Jahren war Markus Söder
der dauernd ein ausgefordert hat
ausgefordert hat für den Verbrenner
Technologie auch mal ist das Gebot der
Stunde und genau genau dem wird der März
diese Bundesregierung gerecht liebe
Kollegen Kollegen
Zeitenwende heißt
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu stärken Zeiten
wenn der heißt mit den liberalen
Demokratien der Welt jetzt auch in Form
von Freihandel zusammenzuarbeiten und
deswegen will ich sagen Herr
Bundeskanzler ich bin Ihnen dankbar dass
sie heute Abend in Richtung Washington
abheben ich bin Ihnen dankbar dass sie
mit asiatischen Ländern reden und auch
mit den südamerikanischen Ländern die
Zukunft Deutschlands und insbesondere
die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und die wir
hier gleichermaßen in der Demokratischen
Mitte besorgt sind die Zukunft
Deutschland liegt im Handel und in der
Kooperation mit den liberalen
Demokratien der Welt das ist zeitenwände
ich danke Ihnen
Christian dürfte Vorsitzende der
FDP-Fraktion war das ja verteidigt und
betont noch mal die Haltung der
Koalition und der Bundesregierung zu den
Beschlüssen der vergangenen Monaten z.B
die militärische Hilfe für die Ukraine
aber auch die Maßnahmen zur
energiesicherung
[Musik]
in Russland einen seinen brutalen und
unerträglichen Feldzug gegen die Ukraine
seit mehr als einem Jahr wird in der
Ukraine gemordet seit mehr in einem Jahr
seit einem Jahr wird das Völkerrecht
gebrochen russische Soldaten foltern die
verschleppen
Infrastruktur wird gezielt zerstört mehr
als 300 Tote deshalb es muss alles alles
dafür getan werden das Russland seinen
Krieg endlich beendet und da gibt es
keine Relativierung meiner Fraktion und
das ist die Position einer Fraktion aber
lieber Herr Merz wenn Sie hier mit einer
ziemlich großen Klappe agieren will ich
ihren Stellvertreter Herr
kretschmerzitieren der vom Einfrieren
des Konfliktes im November gesprochen
hat damit wir schnell wieder Öl aus
Russland bekommen kümmern sie sich um
ihre Fraktion und zur Demo nur so viel
der hat genau bei den ersten
unterzeichnen im übrigen viele höchst
sehr geehrte Persönlichkeiten da hat
genau ein Mitglied der LINKEN
unterschrieben mehrere unionsmitglieder
im übrigen zehn Mitglieder der SPD und
hier tun sie
so an mehr unionsmitglieder hatten
unterzeichnet bei dieser Demonstration
das ist die Wahrheit und nicht die
einseitige schuldvorlage und zehn
Sozialdemokraten auch das gehört zu
Wahrheit nur einen Mitglied der LINKEN
das ist die Wahrheit und meine Damen und
Herren wer den Krieg beenden will wer
den Krieg beenden will der ist kein
friedensschwurbler der ist auch kein
putinversteher wer friedensverhandlung
fordert will das Sterben der will das
Leid in der Ukraine beenden und er will
die Möglichkeit der nuklearen Eskalation
verhindern es muss Schluss damit sein
dass diejenigen diffamiert werden und
angegangen werden die auch nur eine
Kritik am Kurs der Bundesregierung
äußern das kann doch nicht wahr sein
mich erinnert das an eine Diskussion
Kultur wie bei Corona wie war denn das
da wer gegen Kita Schließung war wer
gegen Impfpflicht war der wurde als
alu-hut diskreditiert das ist doch die
Wahrheit und es ist so wie heute gegen
kampfpanzerlieferung ist und die Blume
die einfordert der wird aus einer
riesigen Allianz aus der Politik aus
Medien als naiv und Russland freundlich
bezeichnet und das ist eine
unsägliche eine unsägliche Verengung des
meinungskorridors und das schadet der
Demokratie in unserem Land meine Damen
und Herren Jürgen Habermas Jürgen
Habermas hat in der Süddeutschen Zeitung
zu Recht und ich zitiere ihn von einem
polizistischen Tenor einer geballten
veröffentlichen Meinung gewarnt in der
die Hälfte der deutschen Bevölkerung
nicht mehr zu Wort kommt meine Damen und
Herren wie absurd ist es da wenn die
hier heute hochgelobte Außenministerin
Annalena Werbung sagt und ich zitiere
Sie unsere Waffen helfen Menschenleben
zu retten nochmal unsere Waffen helfen
Menschen leben zu retten nein nein nein
nein nein nein nein auch da hat aber
erst
im übrigen überhaupt nicht gegen
Waffenlieferung aber er sagt wer
Waffenlieferung und ich zitieren wieder
hat eine moralische Mitverantwortung für
Opfer und Zerstörung ich empfehle uns
allen hier etwas mehr Nachdenklichkeit
und liebe Britta Hasselmann diese
unfassbare Selbstsicherheit
ist wirklich höchst problematisch da
lobe ich mir die Nachdenklichkeit
unseres Bundeskanzlers und hier wird
permanent unterstellt was wir so alles
tun und machen das einfach die unehrheit
im Moment erleben wir das Gegenteil von
Nachdenklichkeit Diskussionen über
panzerkoalition Forderungen nach mehr
Milliarden für die Bundeswehr 100
Milliarden sind zu wenig die zwei
Prozent müssen überbütende wenn man
findet wenn man findet in
leopard-klamotten
irgendwo hinzugehen das überhaupt nicht
lustig es ist überhaupt nicht lustig das
sind gefährliche Kriegswaffen wird
zärtlich von Leos spricht nein das ist
die völlig falsch Herangehensweise und
angesichts der Herausforderung vor der
wir alle stehen da sind wir uns
vielleicht sogar einig von Armut bis
Klimawandel müssen doch diese Mittel
nicht für Wettrüsten sondern für andere
Dinge ausgegeben werden da sind wir uns
hoffentlich eigentlich meine Damen und
Herren im Januar hat der Bundeskanzler
gesagt Deutschland hat der Bundeskanzler
den Bundeskanzler wurde vorgeworfen so
dass wir das Deutschland isoliert wenn
es keine Leopard 2 Lieferung an die
Ukraine gibt das bewusster Eindruck
erweckt worden jedes Land was über
Leopard verfügt würde Waffen in den
Krieg schicken und Deutschland bremst
das nur aus das war glatte glatte
panzerpropaganda richtigerweise liefern
die allermeisten Länder heute in
überhaupt keine Kampfpanzer in die
Ukraine Panzer Frankreich zum Beispiel
keinen einzigen ist macron Putin
verstehe oder in friedensschwobbler über
Türkei und Griechenland will ich
überhaupt nicht reden die die meisten
Leopards haben und nicht einen einzigen
liefern ich hätte mir gewünscht dass da
der Kurs gehalten wird denn eins ist
doch klar diese Diskussion wird doch
dazu führen dass noch mal einer
draufgelegt wird und wenn Herr Melnik
jetzt sagt dass er wettet dass
Deutschland in diesem auch bald
Kampfjets liefern wird ich möchte diese
Wette halten und auch sagen Deutschland
wird Kampfpanzer Kampfjets liefern ich
wünsche mir nur lieber Herr
Bundeskanzler dass ich diese Wette
verliere es wäre nur so gut und deswegen
nur zum Schluss meine Damen und Herren
natürlich
über die Köpfe der Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine verhandelt werden das doch
völlig unstrittig aber auch noch mal
Jürgen haberma spricht vom vorbeugenden
charakterechtzeitiger Verhandlung die
verhindern dass der Westen nach einem
abnutzungskrieg nur noch vor der Wahl
steht entweder selbst einzugreifen oder
der Ukraine ihrem Schicksal zu übergeben
dieses Szenario muss verhindert werden
deshalb wir brauchen eine europäische
Frieden jetzt Entschuldigung
danke schön
Vorsitzende der Linksfraktion spricht
von einem unerträglichen Feldzug der
gegen die Ukraine des Völkerrecht sei
gebrochen worden er kritisiert dass die
militärische Komponente zu sehr und die
diplomatische zu wenig betont werde sagt
aber nicht dass der Kreml gerade vor
wenigen Tagen Verhandlungen und ein
Kriegsende ausgeschlossen hat Rolf Mütze
nicht Kollegen ich bin froh dass der
Bundeskanzler diese
Regierungserklärung für die Regierung
aber auch für die drei
koalitionsfraktion
getan hat und ich will betonen ich ging
davon aus dass diese Debatte versucht
auch vor dem Hintergrund der Aggression
Russlands über eine Neuvermessung der
internationalen Ordnung ein bisschen
heute nachzudenken und Rechenschaft
abzulegen
deswegen möchte meine erste Bemerkung
sein dass es überhaupt gar kein Zweifel
darin bestehen kann dass der Überfall
russischer Streitkräfte auf die Ukraine
ein tiefer Einschnitt in die europäische
sicherheitsordnung ist es ist der größte
Landkrieg nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg und
dieser Krieg ist errichtet worden auf
Demagogie auf Lügen auf Toten auf
verletzten auf Vertreibungen und eben
letztlich auch auf eine Katastrophe der
die Ukraine gegenüber steht und deswegen
war es richtig gewesen dass der
Bundeskanzler vor einem Jahr diesen
Einschnitt in die europäische
sicherheitsordnung eine Zeitenwende
genannt hat und damit wird auch dieser
Begriff in Zukunft das fassen was unsere
Aufgabe ist meine Damen und Herren und
umso mehr will ich aber auch sagen der
Begriff muss über den 24 Februar
hinausgehen nach meinem Dafürhalten ist
Begriff Zeitenwende zu gehaltvoll zu
notwendig auch für die gesamten anderen
Herausforderungen nehmen sich die
Bundesregierung den sich unser Land
Europa aber auch die Welt
gegenübersteht zeitenwände ist auch die
nationale und internationale Entwicklung
ist aber letztlich eben auch das was wir
in unserem Land tun nämlich in den
nächsten 20 Jahren den Umbau einer
Industriegesellschaft auch eben genau
wegen des Klimas aber damit auch
Deutschland stark bleibt sozusagen als
Zeitenwende zu verstehen ja und die
Zeitenwende findet auch in der
internationalen Ordnung statt meine
Damen und Herren neue gestaltungsmächte
beanspruchen die internationale Ordnung
mitzuprägen auch das ist eine
Zeitenwende deswegen glaube ich wir
befinden uns in Zeiten wenden in der
Zeitenwende die durch Russland
hervorgerufen worden ist und das ist
eine große Aufgabe und ich finde darüber
müssen wir heute aber auch in Zukunft
Rechenschaft ablegen deswegen bin ich
froh dass die Koalition Verantwortung in
dieser Zeit übernommen hat dass diese
Koalition unser Land durch diese Krisen
führen will und was wurde nicht alles
vorhergesagt in den letzten Monaten
Energieknappheit Betriebsschließungen
einige hatten gesagt es ist gar kein
Problem mal den Schalter von 1 auf Null
zu legen nein das war ein Problem und
das haben wir erkannt und deswegen haben
wir auch dagegen gesteuert und
gleichzeitig auch noch neue soziale
Rechte hier im Deutschen Bundestag
verabschiedet für Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer und das war wichtig gewesen
auch das ist eine Zeitenwende meine
Damen und Herren
einige meinen und deswegen möchte ich
diese Debatte auch zum Anlass nehmen
über das ein oder andere zu reflektieren
was vielleicht manchmal auch etwas
leichtfertig in den öffentlichen Raum
geworfen wird einige meinen mit dem
Überfall Russlands auf die Ukraine Seite
der Kalte Krieg zurückgekehrt und es ist
ja eine Mode mittlerweile geworden dann
dem neue Begrifflichkeiten zu widmen
nämlich ein kalter Krieg 2.0 das ist
unzutreffend ich glaube der Kalte Krieg
und wir können froh sein dass wir ihn
überwunden haben meine Damen und Herren
war gezeichnet von Bipolarität und von
einem einzigen macht und
ideologiekonflikt und heute meine Damen
und Herren ist die Situation eine andere
deswegen empfehle ich wirklich sehr gut
auf die Debatte zu achten die wir auch
hier in Deutschland führen weil der
Kalte Krieg wird woanders ganz anders
wahrgenommen früher ist der kalte Krieg
auf dem Rücken anderer Länder
ausgetragen worden deswegen dürfen wir
nicht mit der Hybris des Kalten Krieges
sozusagen versuchen die internationale
Ordnung neu zu gestalten wir müssen
darauf aufpassen dass sich andere Länder
nicht ausgegrenzt fühlen in der
internationalen Politik schon gar nicht
durch uns die Gestalt der Welt ist zu
kompliziert als dass man sie einfach auf
ein neumodisches Wort zurückführt
deswegen ich bevorzuge das was der
deutsche Friedensforscher eine Gestalt
der internationalen Ordnung genannt hat
nämlich Dieter sengers schon vor einiger
Zeit er hat von einer zerklüfteten Welt
gesprochen diese Welt besteht darin dass
16 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung in der
OECD Welt leben in unserer Welt die mag
gut vernetzt die mag manchmal auch sehr
bequem sein aber das ist nicht die Welt
die da draußen ist die andere Welt
besteht aus 37 Prozent der
Weltbevölkerung 130 Staaten die sich
versuchen leidlich zu entwickeln oder
unintelligible Abkippen genauso wie die
Staaten die schon längst zerbrochen sind
und die repräsentieren dann auch noch
mal zehn Prozent der Weltbevölkerung und
dann und das ist das Novum meine Damen
und Herren für die internationale
Ordnung allein in zwei Großstaaten Leben
weitere 37 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung
und ich finde wir müssen uns mit dieser
Gestalt genauso auseinandersetzen wie
die Situation die durch Russland
hervorgerufen worden ist aber wenn ich
betone
wenn ich betone das ist nicht der Kalte
Krieg dann wunder ich mich manchmal
schon welche Sprachmuster aus dem Kalten
Krieg in unsere deutsche Diskussion
wieder Eingang finden da gibt es
Expertinnen und Experten die uns glauben
machen ein nuklearer Krieg sei
beherrschbar da gibt es Wissenschaftler
die Begriffe von kriegsfähigkeit und
letztlich Pazifismus Weltmeister in die
Debatte bringen
Sweatshirts mit leopardenmustern werden
als öffentliche Manifestation getragen
oder Leoparden Witze machen die Runde
das ist nicht angemessen vor dem
Hintergrund der Zeitenwende meine Damen
und Herren wir brauchen nicht ständig
einen permanenten Ausnahmezustand in der
Diskussion sondern wir brauchen Klarheit
und Vernunft und ja ich bedaure sehr
dass wenn es mal denkt an Stöße gibt wie
den von Jürgen Habermas
dann wird der Übergang dann wird er zur
Seite gelegt abgeheftet oder er wird
sogar mit Geschrei und übler Nachrede
verfolgt ich glaube Deutschland ist
erwachsener genug sich mit diesen auch
manchmal sehr komplizierten Fragen
auseinanderzusetzen und dann auch hier
der Deutsche Bundestag deswegen habe ich
versucht im letzten Jahr den Gestalt der
Welt vielleicht zu versuchen vor dem
Hintergrund des Abstimmungsergebnisses
in der Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen zu zeichnen mit einer Weltkarte
ja die Mehrheit von 141 Staaten hat
diesen Angriffskrieg verurteilt genauso
auch wieder wie vor zwei Wochen und es
war gut dass die Bundesregierung die
Außenministerin der Bundeskanzler Länder
überzeugt hat weiterhin in dieser großen
Koalition dann letztlich auch der Länder
zu stehen aber auf der anderen Seite
müssen wir uns eben auch mit der
Situation befassen dass der andere Teil
der weniger Länder sind trotzdem der
größere Teil wenn man ihn an diese Welt
an an der Weltbevölkerung ist und am
Bruttosozialprodukt und vielen anderen
Dingen auch deswegen ist es gut dass der
Bundeskanzler auch gegen manchen
vielleicht gut gemeinten Hinweis
trotzdem gereist ist nach Südafrika nach
China vor wenigen Tagen nach Indien man
muss mit diesen Ländern darüber reden
wie sie diese Welt sehen und ob Sie an
unserer Seite sind um diesen Krieg
endlich zu beenden und ich kann nur
sagen Herr Bundeskanzler ist alle Mühen
wert ich weiß
und merke auch wie anstrengend dass ist
aber ich will nur sagen es ist auch im
Interesse Deutschlands und dafür ganz
herzlichen Dank
19 37 schrieb Antonio gramschi die alte
Welt liegt im Sterben die neue ist noch
nicht geboren es ist die Zeit der
Monster wie aktuell ist dieses Zitat und
was hat damals Antonio gramchi
vorausgesehen deswegen sollten wir uns
vielleicht auch an dieses Zitat halten
weil in diesem Zitat eines klar wird ja
wir müssen den Monstern entgegentreten
deswegen ist das
Selbstverteidigungsrecht der Ukraine so
lange meine Damen und Herren der
Sicherheitsrat eben nicht bereit ist
Verantwortung zu übernehmen
gerechtfertigt und deswegen unterstützen
wir auch die Ukraine mit militärischen
mit wirtschaftlicher hilf mit
humanitärer Hilfe und das ist auch
völkerrechtlich verankert und trotzdem
hat natürlich auch Selbstverteidigung
haben auch wir müssen wir darauf achten
dass das humanitäre Kriegsvölkerrecht
nicht verletzt wird deswegen war die
Reaktion der Bundesregierung damals
richtig gewesen als Streumunition
angefragt worden war
mögen wir gar nicht darüber aber wir
müssen das in der internationalen
Debatte mit einbringen und ich will auch
sehr deutlich nochmal sagen ja wir
müssen dem Monster Putin entgegentreten
aber wir müssen genauso versuchen eben
auch mit dem Möglichkeiten des
Völkerrechts entgegenzutreten deswegen
bin ich der bundesaußenministerin
dankbar dass sie in Den Haag beim
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
versucht hat auch eine Plattform zu
finden in dieser Richtung ein Monster
aus dieser Realität zu verbannen meine
Damen und Herren
zum anderen wenn wir neue Monster
aufhalten wollen müssen wir natürlich
auch Rechenschaft über das Ablegen was
in der Vergangenheit war das tue ich
auch und ich will hier sehr freimütig
sagen ja ich habe damals den Artikel von
Putin ich glaube in der Zeitschrift
Osteuropa gelesen
vielleicht habe ihn nicht richtig
verstanden oder vielleicht habe ich es
unterschätzt das gebe ich zu aber ich
will mal sagen auch in deutschen
Zeitungen ist über diesen Artikel im
Förderturm berichtet worden und nicht in
der großen Ausgabe vorne wenn es um
Nachrichten geht deswegen bin ich
manchmal etwas verwundert in Deutschland
über diejenigen die immer angeblich
alles gewusst haben ich habe nicht alles
gewusst und ich finde diese Demut diese
Demut sollten auch alle anderen haben
die in den letzten Wochen und Monaten
immer meinten alles richtig zu machen
zum Schluss heftige Reaktion hat es
gegeben auch gegenüber mir Bilder das
Bekennen wenn ich den Begriff der
Diplomatie in den Mund genommen hat ich
habe ihn deswegen erwähnt weil der
genauso wie das Selbstverteidigungsrecht
der Ukraine Bestandteil der Kater der
Vereinten Nationen ist Diplomatie muss
gleichrangig auch mit den anderen
Mitteln behandelt werden anders ist
Problem Aspekt des Völkerrechts
internationale Politik nicht möglich
aber warum habe ich Diplomatie gesagt
doch nicht um mit Putin zu verhandeln
sondern das zu unterstützen was der
Bundeskanzler getan hat er will dem
russischen Präsidenten
eskalationsmöglichkeiten nehmen die
eskalationsdominanz zu verringern und
deswegen war es gut dass China sich
angeschlossen hat zu sagen dass nukleare
Tabu muss erhalten bleiben weil das hat
uns erst die Möglichkeit gegeben so zu
handeln wie wir es getan haben
und deswegen meine Damen und Herren
schafft kluge Diplomatie auch neue Räume
für entsprechende Möglichkeiten und ich
finde das ist auch Aufgabe die wir von
allen anderen Regierungen verlangen
können insbesondere die die im
Sicherheitsrat der Vereinten Nationen
sind deswegen Herr Kollege Merz ich
mache mir gar keine Gedanken darüber
warum der Bundeskanzler
nicht mit Journalisten reist ich finde
das nicht falsch mit Journalisten zu
reisen aber wenn er ein Arbeitsbesuch
bei Präsident beiden macht was spricht
denn dagegen mit dem wichtigsten Partner
in der transatlantischen Allianz in den
nächsten Stunden auch diese Gespräche zu
führen das ist sozusagen eine
existenzversicherung für Deutschland
dass diese Gespräche geführt werden und
es ist gut
[Applaus]
dass sie das tun umso wichtiger ist dass
auch sonderverantwortung übernimmt ja
ich bin enttäuscht über diesen Plan aber
im Gegensatz zu vor einem Jahr steht
China nicht mehr am Rande und wir dürfen
es auch nicht mehr loslassen in dieser
Situation immer wieder neu zu fordern
wir dürfen die Welt nicht in ein
schwarz-weiß aufspalten wir müssen jeden
Tag nach Gemeinsamkeiten suchen und mehr
miteinander teilen meine Damen und
Herren auch noch südpolitik gehört dazu
sonst werden sich noch mehr Monster
unsere Welt bemächtigen vielen Dank
Rolf Mütze nicht Vorsitzender der
SPD-Fraktion mit Dankern Kanzlerin und
Außenministerin aber auch mit
Selbstkritik was die eigene Einschätzung
der Lage vor einem Jahr angeht aber auch
mit deutlicher Kritik an
leichtfertigem Umgang mit nuklearen
Bedrohungspotenzial allzu begeisterter
kriegsrätorik und zu wenig Gehör für
kritische Stimmen und Diplomatie
Alexander Dobrindt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Bundeskanzler sie haben in ihrer Rede
heute sich bei der cdu/csu-fraktion für
die Unterstützung ihrer zeitenwände Rede
bedankt diese Unterstützung haben sie
auch nach wie vor aber zugegebenermaßen
dem ersten Aufbruch ist leider viel
Ernüchterung gefolgt es waren große
Worte vor einem Jahr aber es kam keine
Wende sie haben einen höheren Wehretat
versprochen sie haben einen niedrigeren
verita beschlossen sie haben die
Vollausstattung der Bundeswehr
angekündigt sie haben keine einzige
Patrone bestellt sie haben das zwei
Prozent NATO Ziel in Aussicht gestellt
aber
1,5%
erreicht sehr geehrter der Bundeskanzler
das was sie heute über ihre Zeitenwende
uns erzählt haben das deckt sich in
keinster Weise mit dem was international
über die Zeitenwende gedacht wird der
Economist der schreibt beispielsweise
von einem verlorenen Jahr für Reformen
das Wall street-journal schreibt dass
der Kanzler der die zeitenwände
verkündet hat keine vollzogen hat sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler richtig ist
allerdings auch dass die zeitenwände das
Wort des Jahres
2022 ist aber Herr Bundeskanzler die
Zeitenwende hätte nicht das Wort des
Jahres sondern die Tat des Jahres werden
müssen und das haben sie versäumt
sie haben ihre Rede vorhin gesagt dass
sie das zwei Prozent nato-ziel einhalten
wollen diese Zusage gilt das waren ihre
Worte nein sie gilt eben nicht und warum
sie nicht gilt darüber kann man
spekulieren möglicherweise liegt es an
ihrer eigenen Fraktion der neue
Verteidigungsminister der hat deutlich
gemacht dass das zwei Prozent Ziel sich
daran annähern zu wollen dass das nicht
ausreichen wird und erfordert 10
Milliarden zusätzlich für den
Verteidigungsetat jedes Jahr im gleichen
Moment sagt ihre Parteivorsitzende Frau
esken sie ist dass sie das öffentlich in
Frage stellt dass dieses Geld gebraucht
wird der Kollege Klingbeil meint er
könnte es unterstützen der Kollege Mütze
nicht sagt historius sollte sich
vielleicht mehr um Ihnen und
Sozialpolitik kümmern jeder beide SPD
scheint genau zu wissen wo er bei der
zeitenwände hin will aber eine
gemeinsame Kurs den haben sie nicht
sie haben das 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen heute angesprochen sie
haben dabei über die F35 gesprochen sie
haben nicht darüber gesprochen dass sie
im letzten Jahr keinen einzigen Euro
davon ausgegeben haben die zugesagte
Beschaffung von 10 Milliarden Munition
die haben sie nicht erwähnt es ist auch
überhaupt keine Beschaffung daraus
erfolgt die ersten Mittel die jetzt in
diesem Jahr wahrscheinlich ausgegeben
werden die werden verausgabt für
Bestellungen die schon in der letzten
Wahlperiode vorgenommen worden sind
deswegen kann ich Ihnen nur raten nehmen
Sie Ihren Auftrag an dieser Stelle war
den wir ihn mit den 100 Milliarden mit
auf den Weg gegeben haben und der heißt
nicht zaudern zögern oder zerreden
sondern beschaffen beschleunigen und
beschützen das muss das Motto sein für
die 100 Milliarden
ihre Verteidigungspolitik mangelt es
übrigens nicht nur an den
panzerbestellungen sondern auch an einem
Plan im letzten Jahr hätte die nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie vorgestellt werden
soll sollen man kann interessanterweise
auf der Internetseite des
Verteidigungsministerium nachlesen da
steht die nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
formuliert eine Orientierung was die
Zeitenwende für Deutschland bedeutet ja
wo bleibt ein Jahr nach Kriegsbeginn
diese Orientierung Auswärtiges Amt
Kanzleramt Finanzministerium können sich
offenbar nicht darauf verständigen man
darf aber von einer Bundesregierung
erwarten dass sie zumindestens bei
Fragen der nationalen Sicherheit an
einem Strang ziehen sie schaffen es
nicht meine Damen und Herren
zu Beginn dieser Woche hat
Putins Stellvertreter mitje
damit gedroht dass die Ukraine von der
Weltkarte verschwinden wird
wer so spricht der fühlt sich nicht
bedroht sondern der plant ein Verbrechen
der plant einen Völkermarkt wir haben in
dieser Woche mit der Journalistin
Kathrin Eigendorf in der
cdu/csu-fraktion die Chance gehabt zu
sprechen und sie hat uns bedrückend
beschrieben dass diese Angriffskrieg
alle Elemente eines Völkermordes zeigt
die Kultur wird zerstört die Elite wird
zerstört die Kinder werden entführt und
umerzogen und wer angesichts dieser
Situation unsere Waffenlieferung zu
Unterstützung der Ukraine zum
eigentlichen Problem erklärt der
verweigert sich offen dieser brutal
Realität meine Damen und Herren
und wer sich dieser brutalen Realität
verweigert der schafft auch keinen
Frieden sondern der blickt auf die
Zerstörung der Ukraine und da kann aus
einem Manifest für Friedens schnell auch
ein Manifest für Zerstörung werden ich
rate allerdings ausdrücklich jedem auch
darauf zu achten wer bei einer
Demonstration neben einem steht was sich
hier öffentlich versammelt das ist doch
schon längst diejenigen die im Geiste
sich einig sind das hofeisen schließt
sich und Sarah Wagenknecht führt genau
dieses Feuer darüber müssen sie sich im
Klaren sein meine Damen und Herren
dem Zusammenhang
darf man auch den Hinweis geben ich bin
da auch ehrlich empörter darüber Kollege
koopalla dass Sie hier den besten
vorwerfen er würde die Zerschlagung
Russlands wollen dass es schlichtweg
putinpropaganda aber dass sie jetzt auch
noch im Jahr 2023 hier im Deutschen
Bundestag sich trauen die Befreier des
deutschen Volkes die Vereinigten Staaten
von Amerika als die Besatzer
Deutschlands zu bezeichnen das ist ein
Geschichtsvergessenheit nicht zu
übergeben
ich würde Ihnen auch liebe Frau
hasselfeld an der Stelle einfach mal
raten
sie haben sie haben genau eine Minute
gebraucht
sie haben genau eine Minute gebraucht
und ihrer Rede auf 16 Jahre zu kommen
ich würde dringend empfehlen weniger
über 16 Jahre nachzudenken als über die
vergangenen 16 Monate in diesen 16
Monaten haben sie Deutschland in Europa
isoliert sie haben und auch
unternehmensabwandungen nicht reagiert
sie haben die Inflation
ignoriert sie haben Rekord Schulden
angehäuft und ich sage Ihnen wir werfen
ihnen nicht die Kriegsschluss wir werfen
ihnen nicht die Krisen vor aber wir
werfen ihnen ihr katastrophal des
Krisenmanagement vor das ist die einzige
Wahrheit und die dir geht
gerade hasselfeld mit Hasselmann
wechselt in Rede von Herrn
ist für bundeseben
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ja
das war wohl eben lieber Kollege
Dobrindt das was man ein freudchen
Versprecher sagte und offenbarte so ein
bisschen mit wem sie im Streit liegen in
den eigenen Reihen
und ein Punkt will ich Ihnen dann gerne
mal auch kann ich Ihnen wirklich nicht
ersparen es stimmt wir müssen
investieren wir müssen die Bundeswehr
besser ausrüsten
aber vor dem Hintergrund müssen wir eben
auch darüber sprechen dass wir eine
Bundeswehr vorgefunden haben nach 16
Jahren schwarzer Verteidigungsministerin
und Verteidigungsminister die zum Teil
die Qualität hatte der Doktorarbeit
ihres einzigen staatsende
[Applaus]
Zeitenwende ist keine Rolle rückwärts
wir haben diese Investitionen ins
Militär zu machen aber in der
multipolaren Welt von heute beruht
Stärke auf Bündnissen Stärke beruht auf
integrierter Sicherheit wir müssen
unsere Stärke finden indem wir wehrhaft
resilient und nachhaltig Sicherheit
schaffen so geht moderne
Sicherheitspolitik in dieser Welt
und das geht erheblich über die Debatte
hinaus was wir an zusätzlichen Mitteln
ins Militär in die Stärkung der Ukraine
eingeben müssen
wir müssten angesichts des Angriffs
schon Putin auf die Ukraine dort
Budgethilfe leisten wir waren es die mit
700.000 Generatoren dafür gesorgt haben
dass seit 14 Tagen in Kiew keine
Blackouts mehr sind nach dem Putin die
Stromversorgung und die
wärmeversorgungsamt hat
und ja wir wissen dass kostet Geld und
deswegen wird es auch einer Zeitenwende
in der Haushaltspolitik bedürfen auch da
gilt der Satz des Bundeskanzlers dass
die Zeiten heute nicht mehr so sein
werden wie davor nun ganz aktuelles
Beispiel wir werden nächstes Wochenende
500 Millionen eine halbe Milliarde
zusätzlich in die europäische
friedensversität einbringen müssen das
ist Geld was wir brauchen um Munition
dringend benötigt für die Ukraine zu
beschaffen aber wir werden daneben
weiter mehr humanitäre Hilfe leisten
müssen wir werden investieren müssen in
Diplomatie um jene Koalition
zusammenzuhalten der 141 Staaten die den
Rückzug der Russlands aus der Ukraine
gefordert haben und meine Damen und
Herren ja
die umkerei auch aus der Union was alles
passieren wird wenn Putin uns mit Gas
erpresst sie ist nicht eingetreten weil
wir eine handlungsfähige Regierung
hatten
aber das reicht nicht wir werden auch
und dafür sorgen müssen dass wir unseren
Gasverbrauch unseren Ölverbrauch zu
reduzieren haben und deswegen ist es
richtig wie sich die Ampel miteinander
verabredet hat schrittweise fossile
Heizung in den Kellern zu ersetzen und
deswegen ist es falsch zu glauben man
könne einem Laufzeitverlängerung für
verbrennerautos machen
der nächste Redner ist für die
FDP-Fraktion klein
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen schon seit über
einem Jahr dauert jetzt der
verbrecherische völkerrechtswidrige
Angriffskrieg den Vladimir Putin über
die Ukraine gebracht hat an und wir
Freien Demokraten und ich denke die
spreche für die große Mehrheit in diesem
Haus verurten urteilen diesen
verbrecherischen Krieg auf schärfste
diese russische Invasion hat sehr viel
Leid über die ukrainische Bevölkerung
gebracht leid das resultiert aus Angst
Verlust Tod schlimmsten Menschenrechts
und Kriegsverbrechen die dort geschehen
aber diese Invasion hat auch den Blick
geschärft unseren Blick geschärft auf
unsere Verteidigungsfähigkeit auf die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit unseres
Bündnisses und wir haben mit dem
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr mit 100
Milliarden Euro ein Instrument zur
Verfügung gestellt um diese
Verteidigungsfähigkeit wieder
herzustellen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
aber noch wichtiger wir haben dieses
Instrument nicht nur wir haben nicht nur
diese Mittel 100 Milliarden Euro zur
Verfügung gestellt sondern liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union die
Ampel hat dieses Instrument auch mit
Leben gefüllt wir haben Projekte auf den
Weg gebracht in diesem Parlament in
diesem Haus aber ich möchte an dieser
Stelle auch mal dem frisch gebackenen
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius
und natürlich den Finanzminister
Christian Lindner danken dass auf der
Regierungsseite auch schnell gehandelt
worden ist wichtige Projekte für die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit wie die F35
Nachfolge des Tornados für die nukleare
Teilhabe oder die persönliche
Schutzausrüstung für unsere Soldatinnen
und Soldaten zu Wahrheit gehört dazu
dass heute schon über 30 Milliarden Euro
die Sondervermögens gebunden sind für
diese Projekte fast ein Drittel und
deshalb will ich an dieser Stelle auch
die Bundesregierung auffordern halten
Sie bei der Beschleunigung des Tempos
nicht an sondern setzen Sie es vor wir
brauchen mehr Projekte in Parlament
diesen mehr Projekte beschließen die bei
den Soldatinnen und Soldaten ankommen
denn unser Ziel muss es sein dass wir
mindestens 50 Prozent des
Sondervermögens am Ende dieses Jahres
für solche Projekte gebunden haben liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen unsere
Nato-Partner unserer europäischen
Partner die haben diese Sondervermögen
begrüßt und sie haben es begrüßt weil
wir in diesem Parlament und in der
Bundesregierung weil die Ampel in dieser
historischen Situation auch eine
historische Entscheidung für unsere
äußere Sicherheit für unsere Sicherheit
getroffen hat zum ersten Mal in der
Geschichte seit vielen Jahren ist es
gelungen dass wir nicht nur mehr Mittel
für die unsere Sicherheit in 2023 so zur
Verfügung gestellt haben im übrigen 11
Milliarden Euro mehr als die CDU CSU
geführte Regierung geplant hat sondern
wir haben auch dafür gesorgt dass es
eine Planungssicherheit für große
wichtige zentrale
Investitionsprojekte Rüstungsprojekte
bei der Bundeswehr geben wird und geben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
deshalb bin ich an der Stelle nochmal
betonen wir alle wollen mit diesen
Mitteln uns in Frieden und unsere
Freiheit verteidigen viele Projekte die
wir hier oft diskutieren sind nur
möglich wenn wir verteidigungsfähig wenn
wir ein abschreckungspotenzial haben und
deshalb glaube ich ist es gehört es auch
zur Wahrheit dass wir in den nächsten
Monaten auch über die Verteilung
innerhalb des Haushaltes reden dass
diese Erkenntnis sich auch in der
Schwerpunktsetzung des Haushalts
abbildet und da will ich zum Schluss nur
noch mal daran erinnern momentan hat die
Verteidigungsausgaben ca 10% des
Bundeshaushalts 1990 waren es 20 Prozent
und das beschreibt die Aufgabenstellung
die vor uns liegt vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
das Wort hat der Abgeordnete Johannes
Huber
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Mitbürger
Georgien 2008 Krim 2014 und Ukraine 2022
haben eines gemeinsam die jeweilige
Krise in den Zustimmungswerten des
russischen Präsidenten als Folge einer
Rapid der schlechter werdenden
gesellschaftlichen Stimmung zu sehen am
russischen Finanzmarkt auch die im
November 2021 geschlossene strategische
Partnerschaft zwischen den USA und der
Ukraine
waldkampfansage an dornetz und auch der
Krim für den Frieden in Europa nicht
hilfreich es bleibt aber Putin der im
dezember 2021 die NATO ultimativ
aufgefordert hat
entgegen der Selbstbestimmung der Völker
aus allen 14 Ländern in Osteuropa zu
verschwinden das offenbart ist ein
strategisches Ziel sein verlorenes
Imperium wiederherzustellen ich stimme
also jenen zu die auch Deutschland als
strategisches Kriegsziel sehen bereits
die Sprengung von Nordstemmen hat
gezeigt dass Deutschland aufgrund der
eigenen Schwäche als Spielball anderen
Großmächten ausgeliefert ist Deutschland
wird aber nicht weniger Kriegsziel wenn
wir uns vorauseilen von Neo heroisch
empfindsamen Schlafwandeln am Rande des
Abgrundes auf das Schlachtfeld führen
lassen dass in einer Auseinandersetzung
zwischen NATO und Russland immer in
Deutschland sein wird die führenden
westlichen Militärs sagen dass eine Krim
Rückeroberung nicht sehr wahrscheinlich
ist ein dortiger Angriff mit Beteiligung
von deutschen Kampfpanzern erzeugt aber
die general Mobilisierung von einer
Million weiteren Russen erhöht gemäß der
russischen Militär Doktrin die
Wahrscheinlichkeit für den Einsatz von
ABC-Waffen und bringt Deutschland
endgültig in das Fadenkreuz
die einzige realpolitische Chance für
uns alle und für alle Seiten ist es also
in wenigen Monaten in Istanbul Budapest
oder meinetwegen auch Jerusalem die
Verhandlungen wieder aufzunehmen und
nicht weiter am besten nichts Neues zu
spielen mögliche
gebietgewinne wären verboten dabei
höchstens ein wenig gesichtswahl in der
Pyros Sieg die Ukraine wird aber weiter
existieren und verteidigungsfähig sein
genau damit sollte Deutschland endlich
anfangen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
das Wort hat Dr Nils Schmidt für die
SPD-Fraktion
Ion frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren ja dieser
Überfall Russlands auf die Ukraine
stellt eine Zeitenwende da aber ich will
in dieser Debatte daran erinnern zu
förderst für die Ukraine selbst und
natürlich auch mit dramatischen
Auswirkungen auf den Aggressor und auf
das Land Russland
für die reine eine historische
Katastrophe sie ist erneut Opfer
geworden von übermächtigen Nachbarn und
für Russland mit noch nicht absehbaren
dramatischen Folgen ja auch eine
Tragödie für die russische Gesellschaft
die
erneut als ergressor auftritt
und wenn wir auf die Ukraine schauen und
den heldenhaften Widerstand der Ukraine
betrachten dann ist das nicht nur
militärisches agieren sondern dieser
Widerstand baut auf auf einer
Zivilgesellschaft auf einer
selbstständigen Nation die seit der
Unabhängigkeit von mehr als 30 Jahren
sich als Staatsbürger Nation entwickelt
hat
eigenständig über sprachliche und
mögliche ethnischen Grenzen hinweg und
egal ob man russisch oder Ukrainisch
spricht diese Menschen in Ukraine haben
vor 30 Jahren entschieden als
unabhängige Nation ein eigenständigen
Weg zu gehen
und dass dieser Widerstand zu
erfolgreich ist hat viel damit zu tun
und straft auch all jenen Lügen in
Deutschland und anderswo die Ukraine nur
als ein Wurmfortsatz Russlands
betrachten und eben nicht als
eigenständiger Reaktion sehen und das
ist auch eine Lehre aus dieser
Zeitenwende dass wir nie mehr Ukraine
oder andere selbständige Nationen im
Osten Europas als quasi Anhängsel von
Russland betrachten dürfen
ja und diese starke Zivilgesellschaft
ist kreativ im Widerstand gegen den
Besatzer und ergressor und diese
Zivilgesellschaft diese ukrainischen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger kämpfen nicht nur
sondern sie verteidigen Demokratie und
Rechtsstaatlichkeit selbst im Krieg es
sind unabhängige NGOs und Medien die
Korruption aufdecken und eine Regierung
die auch im Krieg entschlossen dagegen
vorgeht und damit ist auch klar dass die
Ukraine für europäische für
demokratische Werte kämpft und deshalb
unsere Unterstützung gerade auch in
dieser Zeit verdient
und diese Ukraine ist verbunden
historisch geschichtlich und menschlich
mit Russland 11 Millionen und
reinerinnen und Rheine haben nahe
Angehörige in Russland aber seit der
krimination und erst recht seit diesem
furchtbaren Krieg ist natürlich die
Kluft zwischen Ländern größer und fast
unüberwindbar geworden und das hat viel
mit den Zuständen in Russland zu tun und
nicht nur mit der Aggression sondern
auch mit der gesellschaftlichen
politischen Grundlage den Nährboden für
russischen Imperialismus der bis heute
angeht und wenn wir in das Russland nach
der Zeiten wenn Sie schauen dann sehen
wir ein Staat eine Gesellschaft die
zurückgeworfen ist in düstere Zeiten mit
Tausenden in Gefängnissen
Oppositionen und Zivilgesellschaft
vermeiden
und überhaupt kein Blick in weiten
Teilen der Gesellschaft für die
Verantwortung Russlands der
Kriegsverbrechen aktuellen der Ukraine
aber auch wenn man in die Geschichte
zurückschaut wenig
Anerkennung und wenig Auseinandersetzung
mit den Taten und den Tätern der
Unterdrückung der Gesellschaft zu zeigen
der Sowjetunion ja man hat
Denkmale für die Opfer der Sowjetunion
und ist Journalismus erinnert errichtet
aber die Täter wurden nicht verfolgt und
deshalb zeigt gerade dieser Krieg
Russlands in der Ukraine das keine
Zukunft
ohne Gerechtigkeit möglich ist und
deshalb treten wir zusammen mit unseren
ukrainischen Freunden dafür ein dass
auch diese Kriegsverbrechen die aktuell
begangen werden nicht straflos bleiben
das Gerechtigkeit für die Ukraine
möglich wird und das auch Russland die
Chance bekommt Gerechtigkeit walten zu
lassen um selber als Gerechter Staat in
die Zukunft starten zu können auch an
dieses will ich heute aus anlässlich des
Jahrestages erinnern herzlichen Dank für
Ihre aufmerksam
das Wort hat der Kollege Robin wagenau
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen vor fast genau einem Jahr
wachten Millionen Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer vom Donner von Explosionen im
ganzen Land auf bis zuletzt hatten
unsere Außenministerin und der
Bundeskanzler alles diplomatische
versucht um diesen Einmarsch zu
verhindern und es war allein das
verbrecherische Regime im Kremmel dass
ich ihn alleiniger Verantwortung dafür
entschieden hat die Grenzen zu Ukraine
mit den Truppen zu überschreiten und
alle diplomatischen Versuche für den
Frieden in den Wind zu schlagen und wer
das nicht klar auf dem Schirm hat der
ist moralisch bankrot und da hilft einem
auch keine mit zehn zu eins liegen
andere vielleicht auch falsch
Distanzierung oder was immer das weiß
ehrlich gesagt gerade nicht verstanden
wenige Tage nach dem Überfall Sprache
ich mit Alina janschenko eine
Abgeordneten der Radar meine Kollegin in
der ukraine-deutschen Parlamentarier
Gruppe sagte sie mir übersetzt heute
lebe ich ich weiß nicht was morgen ist
in zwei so kurzen Sätzen die Realität
dieses Angriffskrieges so gut
zusammengefasst
aber sie sagte mir auch hab keine Angst
denn Angst ist Putins mafia-methode und
genau wie Präsident selensky blieb Alina
jantschenko genau mit der Mehrheit der
Abgeordneten der Radar in Kiew während
russische Truppen schon in den Vororten
waren während klar war dass die
russischen Invasionstruppen Todeslisten
dabei hatten auf denen auch viele
Abgeordnete standen im Laufe des Jahres
kam die Radar 46 mal im Plenum zusammen
und verabschiedete 384 Gesetze ein
Ausdruck der zentralen Rolle des
Parlaments in der Demokratischen Ukraine
selbst in Kriegszeiten und es kommen
auch immer wieder
und es kommen auch immer wieder
Abgeordnete in diplomatischer Mission
hier nach Berlin darunter innersdorf zum
Beispiel im vergangenen Herbst
berichtete sie mir wie sie in der
u-bahn-schutz suchte und während
russische Raketen in der Hauptstadt
einschlugen fragt ihr zehnjähriger Sohn
sie Mama war die Explosion gerade eine
normale Bombe oder eine Atombombe
ein Jahr nach dem russischen Überfall
verneige ich mich vor dem Mut und der
Entschlossenheit unserer ukrainischen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im Parlament
aber in der ganzen Gesellschaft auch in
der Ukraine
der russische Überfall hat vielen in
Deutschland den Schleier von den Augen
gerissen von großen je sochumi über
Aleppo bis nach mariopol der Bogen
russischer Verbrechen des lang als
deutsche müssen wir die richtigen Lehren
daraus ziehen und unsere Politik
gegenüber Russland aber auch unsere
Politik in der Partnerschaft mit unseren
Freundinnen und Freunden Mittel und
Osteuropa ändern zeitenwände bedeutet
den Anfang davon den haben wir gemacht
und die weiteren Schritte müssen wir
zusammen gehen
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland steht
fest und unverbrechlich an der Seite
unserer ukrainischen Freundinnen und
Freunde wir teilen die Werte der
Demokratie Freiheit und des Friedens
diese Werte und die Menschen die dafür
einstehen werden wir niemals aufgeben
das haben wir am 27 Februar des letzten
Jahres beschlossen es geht heute am 372
Tag des Angriffskrieges und es bleibt
dabei wir stehen fest an der Seite der
Ukraine bis die letzten Invasionstruppen
das Land verlassen haben bis unsere
Freundinnen und Freunde ihr Land in
Frieden und Freiheit wieder aufbauen
können bis Europa Abgeordnete aus der
Ukraine unseren Kontinent gemeinsam
mitgestalten hier könnt ihr euch auch
uns verlassen
Ukraine vielen Dank
das Wort hat die Kollegin Sena ab die
für die Fraktion für die SPD-Fraktion
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen schon vor einem Jahr stand
ich genau hier und habe im Anschluss an
die 4 zitierte Rede unseres
Bundeskanzlers über die Auswirkungen des
russischen Angriffskrieges gesprochen
und noch immer herrscht dieser
schreckliche Krieg viele der sorgen die
wir uns damals gemacht haben sind
eingetroffen bedauerlicherweise vieles
konnten wir auch erfolgreich abwenden so
kamen wir in Deutschland trotz aller
Befürchtungen dank einer klugen
Energiepolitik gut durch den letzten
Winter und während sich derzeit die
politische Debatte viel um die
Waffenlieferungen zu Selbstverteidigung
der Ukraine dreht beschäftigt sich die
Entwicklungspolitik mit der Frage wie
die Menschen in der Ukraine hier im Hier
und Jetzt sowie zukünftig ihren Alltag
bewältigen können die deutsche
Entwicklungspolitik leistet in der
Ukraine mit ihrer Vielfalt an
Instrumenten ein enorm eine enorm
wertvolle Unterstützung seit
Kriegsbeginn unterstützen wir die
Ukraine mit rund
52 Millionen Euro und im Zentrum der
Zusammenarbeit stehen die akuten
Bedürfnisse der Menschen sowie die
langfrist der langfristige und
strukturelle Wiederaufbau des Landes
[Applaus]
wir unterstützen bei der Etablierung des
Stromnetzes der Wasserversorgung des
Bildungs- und gesundheitssystemes und
wir schaffen Wohnraum für geflüchtete
und ermöglicht wird die wertvolle
entwicklungspolitische Arbeit durch
staatliche Akteure wie die GEZ die KfW
zahlreiche NGOs unsere Partner vor Ort
die über 120 Deutsch ukrainischen
kommunalen Städtepartnerschaften und
durch eine Bundes-
wir müssen Krisen wir müssen die Krisen
unserer Zeit aktiv angehen bevor sie
eskalieren eine gut durchdachte
Zeitenwende stellt die
Entwicklungspolitik daher zwangsläufig
in ihren Mittelpunkt oder wie es schon
Willy Brandt sagte Entwicklungspolitik
von heute ist Friedenspolitik von morgen
konkret
konkret bedeutet das für die
Entwicklungspolitik in der zeitenwände
wir brauchen eine den globalen
Herausforderungen angemessene und
beständige Finanzierung das 0,7 Prozent
oder Ziel und die eins zu eins Regel des
Koalitionsvertrages müssen dabei
handlungsweisend sein
Zusammenarbeit auf Augenhöhe darf keine
leere Floskel sein wir müssen diesen
Ansatz mit konkreten Inhalten umsetzen
und dies gelingt durch fair
ausgestaltete Handels- und
rohstoffabkommen durch eine stärkere
miteinbindung von Entwicklungsländern
internationalen Formaten wie im
klimaklub oder zuletzt bei der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz und durch eine
Reform der Weltbank zugunsten
wirtschaftlich schwacher Staaten
und zuletzt die großen Probleme unserer
Zeit wie die Klimakrise Hungersnöte und
Flucht Bewältigung benötigt bewältigen
wir niemals allein mit einer
militärischen Denkweise als
vorausschauende und Struktur schaffende
Friedenspolitik ist die
Entwicklungspolitik ein wesentlicher
Bestandteil der zeitenwände wir
benötigen die Entwicklungspolitik für
eine internationale Politik die
zukunftsfähig krisenfest und
sozialgerechtes sie schafft Vertrauen
sie baut langfristige Partnerschaften
auf und in diese Partnerschaften müssen
wir investieren vielen Dank
[Applaus]
das Wort hat der Abgeordnete robert-
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren ihre zeitenwände
bedeutet dass sie Deutschland mit der
falschen parole Frieden schaffen durch
Waffen in den durch silensky angeführten
us-stellvertreterkrieg immer tiefer
gegen Russland hineinziehen wollen
die neuen sanktionspakete gegen Russland
haben unsere eigene Wirtschaft in die
Knie gezwungen aber eben nicht die
russische Wirtschaft und bieten den USA
jetzt die Möglichkeit große Teile
unseres Mittelstandes und der Industrie
abzuwerden und den Konkurrenten
Deutschland
auszuschalten die wirtschaftliche Zeit
die wirkliche Zeitenwende begann am 26
September 22 als in der Nacht die Nord
Stream Pipelines durch die USA und
Norwegen in den Meeresgrund
hineingesprengt wurden so wurde die
Basis unserer Energie Stromversorgung
Industrie und unseres Wohlstandes
angegriffen nach China fordert jetzt
auch Ungarn die Untersuchung der
Vereinten Nationen zu dem Angriff auf
die nordsee-pipelines Ergebnis dieses
terroristischen Anschlags ist die totale
Abhängigkeit unseres Landes von den USA
dieser Terroranschlag müsste eigentlich
die nato-bündnisfall auslösen was aber
nicht geht weil die Hauptmacht des
Bündnisses eben der Terrorist USA selbst
ist sie Herr Scholz machen Deutschland
zum versal der USA würden uns die Lasten
des Ukraine Krieges auf den die USA seit
acht Jahren mit Tier vorbereitet haben
um Russland zu schwächen und den
nächsten Krieg und die
Auseinandersetzung mit China
vorzubereiten
liebe Damen und Herren sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren liebe Leute ich sage
euch aus tiefster Sorge für die
gegenwärtige Lage wir stehen am Rande
einer nuklearen Katastrophe auch wenn
klugschschwester das Gegenteil behaupten
wir brauchen einen Waffenstillstand
diplomatische Verhandlungen und den
Ausschluss weiter kriegerische
Handlungen damit tausende Menschen
sterben die Menschen sollen Leben und
das morgen muss aufhören
[Applaus]
der nächste Redner in dieser Debatte ist
Wolfgang Helmig für die SPD-Fraktion
Ion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegin ich muss
erstmal mit der schlechten Luft hier
zurechtkommen
[Applaus]
aber Herr Botschafter lassen sich nicht
von solchen reden oder von anderen reden
hier irritieren weil dieser Bundestag
und diese Bundesregierung wir werden
gemeinsam hinter der Ukraine stehen und
ihnen alles geben solange sie es
notwendig haben solange wir im Volk
geholfen werden muss und solange der
Krieg auch nicht beendet wird weil das
werden wir an Unterstützung für Sie
leisten andere Stimmen hier vergessen
die die spielen da keine Rolle
es ist Putins Angriffskrieg der die
abschreckungsverteidigungspolitik in
Zentrum der Sicherheitspolitik rückt ob
wir wollten oder nicht es ist die
Realität und in dieser Realität sind wir
angekommen die Einigkeit von EU und NATO
der gemeinsame Wille die demokratische
Ordnung zu verteidigen erfordert das was
wir gerade in diesen Bündnissen tun
Bündnis Solidarität erfordert auch mehr
militärische Fähigkeiten und Mittel um
eine wirksame Wehrhaftigkeit unserer
demokratischen Ordnung auch organisieren
und Abschrecken gegenüber Putin auch
deutlich machen zu können die Bundeswehr
steht im Fokus
sich wo steht den Fokus der
bundesverteidigung unsere Bündnispartner
schauen sehr genau da drauf was wir tun
um was wir entscheiden die
Herausforderungen sind groß wir müssen
Lücken schließen wir müssen
materialabgabenmunition ersetzen und wir
müssen unsere Bündnis sozusagen mit voll
ausgestatterter der Division mit
Schiffen und Flugzeugen für die NATO bis
2025 auch erfüllen das haben wir
zugesagt das müssen wir auch tun
und viel ist schon geschehen entgegen
dem was hier von der Opposition
verkündet wird und erzählt wird die
Entscheidung zu F35 sind genannt worden
die persönliche Schutzausrüstung und die
Ausrüstung des angekommen der Aufwuchs
des Haushaltes mehr als 50 Milliarden
Beschleunigung der Beschaffung und nicht
zuletzt das 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen
wir haben in Europa Führung übernommen
mit der europäischen
verteidigungsinitiative für die
bodengebundene Luftverteidigung um den
gegen aller Kritik ist dieses alles
wirksam und unsere Bündnispartner folgen
uns auch und es stimmt eben nicht dass
das 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen in
diesem Jahr irgendwie wirkungslos
gewesen wäre der Kollege Kleinert schon
darauf hingewiesen 30 Milliarden davon
30% sind in Verträgen gebunden und
werden realisiert werden erwarten in
diesem Jahr 60 Prozent und alle auch die
die in öffentlich kritisiert haben da
wäre ja noch nichts angekommen die alle
wissen ganz genau abgesehen davon
bestimmt nicht sie alle wissen ganz
genau das Rüstungsproduktion nicht von
heute auf morgen geschehen kann und
deshalb danke ich den Soldaten
die nehme ich mit großer Geduld in
vielen Einsätzen dort wo sie für die
NATO an den Grenzen des bündnisgebietes
ihren Dienst tun sei es im Baltikum sei
es im Süden sei es in der Ausbildung der
ukrainischen Soldaten Soldaten die ihren
dienstlungen dieses auch ertragen und
sie wissen es
sie wissen dass es Zeit braucht und sie
setzen darauf dass wir unsere Zusagen
einhalten mit höchstem tempoort
anzuarbeiten diese Lücken zu schließen
ihn das Material in Jahren zu gehen dass
sie für ihren Dienst auch brauchen
zum Abschluss zum Abschluss dieser
dieser Debatte ja freiheit ist nicht
umsonst
Freiheit wird uns etwas kosten an dieser
Stelle sind keine Haushaltsdebatten zu
fühlen sondern der Stelle ist klar zu
machen dass wir zu dem Zusagen wir
getroffen haben dass wir zu unseren
Soldaten Soldaten stehen
vielen Dank dass Sie mir zugehört haben
ich gehe jetzt in den Maschinenraum wo
offensichtlich der Minister schon ist um
an dem Rad zu drehen dass alle unsere
Zusagen umgesetzt werden das Prozesse
beschleunigt werden und dass die
Soldaten Soldaten das bekommen was Sie
für Ihre Arbeit brauchen schönen Dank
ich schließe die Aussprache
ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 7
Beratung der Beschlussempfehlung des
Ausschusses für Inneres und Heimat zu
dem Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu mit
dem Titel
migrationspolitischen Sonderweg in
Europa sofort beenden für die Aussprache
wurde eine Dauer von 68 Minuten
vereinbart
ich bitte zügig Platz zu nehmen
ich eröffne die Aussprache das Wort hat
der Kollege Hakan Demir für die SPD
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren vor zwei drei Wochen
war ich mit einer Gruppe oben auf der
Tribüne die Gruppe hatte Personen mit
dabei die aus Syrien aus Afghanistan und
aus der Ukraine kam alle hatten
unterschiedliche Aufenthaltstitel
und ehrlich gesagt konnte ich ihnen das
auch gar nicht so richtig erklären warum
die eine Person Paragraph 24
Aufenthaltsgesetz bekommen hat und die
anderen in einem Asylverfahren sind wo
der Prozess noch nicht klar ist aber es
gab natürlich auch dort Menschen die
ganz normal als gefürchtete anerkannt
worden sind
eine Person aus der Gruppe meinte ich
hätte nie gedacht dass ich hier im
Reichstagsgebäude mal sein darf und kann
hier im Bundestag und für mich aber war
in dem Moment klar natürlich sie leben
hier sind hier hingekommen sind ein Teil
dieser Gesellschaft ich habe keinen
Unterschied zwischen denen gemacht und
wir sollten auch keinen machen
der Antrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion macht aber einen
Unterschied ich finde es gut dass sie
sagen dass sie solidarisch sind mit den
geflüchteten aus der Ukraine da steht
meine Fraktion 100% dahinter ich finde
es aber schade dass sie es nicht in
einem Satz oder in den folgenden Sätzen
schaffen zu sagen wir sind auch
solidarisch mit allen anderen
geflüchteten die in dieses Land kommen
und am Ende zu 70 Prozent als
geflüchtete anerkannt werden auch das
müssen sie schaffen und das schaffen Sie
mit diesem Antrag leider wieder nicht
und ich finde es unsolidarisch
[Applaus]
zum
solidaritätsmechanismus auf der EU-Ebene
unsere Innenministerin nennt sie Feser
hat sich dafür eingesetzt dass wir einen
solidaritätsmechanismus haben und es
wird manchmal behauptet dass wir da
isoliert sein auf EU-Ebene dann frage
ich mich aber warum
19/20 EU-Länder da mitmachen bei diesen
solidaritätsmechanismus es ist ein
historischer Schritt den müssen wir
weiter voranbringen und das macht auch
unsere Innenministerin das macht auch
unsere Bundesregierung und das ist ein
guter Weg
Griechenland Stichpunkt ihrer gelehre
Migration das war auch Thema gestern im
Innenausschuss
die Unionsfraktion beschwert sich
darüber dass Menschen die beispielsweise
in Griechenland als geflüchtete
anerkannt worden sind dann vielleicht
über verschiedene Umwege nach
Deutschland kommen
und da will ich auch einmal ganz offen
sagen das weiß auch die Unionsfraktion
das Problem mit den Menschen in
Griechenland ist auch wenn Sie eine
Anerkennung dort bekommen als
geflüchtete dann ist nicht gewährleistet
dass sie Brot Bett und Seife haben
unsere Gerichte lehnen ist deshalb immer
wieder ab Menschen die in Griechenland
anerkannt worden sind hier aus
Deutschland wieder zurückzuführen weil
wir sagen einen menschenwürdiges Leben
ist in diesem Land einfach nicht möglich
und das müssen sie auch erstmal
akzeptieren fakt ist aber auch wir
müssen natürlich stärker mit
Griechenland darüber sprechen wie man es
schaffen kann wenn Menschen
anerkannt sind als geflüchtete natürlich
dann auch Leistungen dort in diesem Land
bekommen und da weiß ich auch dass wir
intensive Diskussionen und Gespräche mit
Griechenland führen ich glaube das ist
der eine richtige Weg
ein weiterer Punkt den ich in ihrem
Antrag vermisse der aber in den letzten
Tagen auch noch mal wichtig geworden ist
wir haben in Süditalien an der Küste
wieder Menschen über 60 auch darunter
Kinder und Frauen die ertrunken sind
sie wurden nicht gerettet da würde ich
mich natürlich auch mal freuen wenn die
CDU CSU-Fraktion mal auch sagt ja
vielleicht kann es sein dass wir auch
mal eine europäische Rettungsmission
starten müssen dass wir die
seenotrettungsorganisation Stärken
müssen damit sie einfach diese Menschen
auch stärker retten können das wäre auch
mal etwas was aus ihrer Fraktion kommen
könnte aus unserer Fraktion aus der
Ampel kommt das wir haben
Koalitionsvertrag ganz klar und darauf
verständigt dass wir auch eine EU
Rettungsmission brauchen wir brauchen
eine europäische staatliche
seenotrettungsorganisation oder
Seenotrettung weil wir genau wissen dass
wir diese Menschen auch retten müssen
dass es einfach recht staatlich korrekt
ist es moralisch korrekt und diesen Weg
müssen wir auch weitergehen
[Applaus]
der weitere Punkt flüchtlingsgipfel das
ist ja auch nochmal ein Thema weil ja
viele Sachen die sie in ihrem Antrag
haben ja teilweise obsolet sind wir
haben jetzt mit Joachim stamp eine
Person die auch migrationsabkommen
vereinbaren wird und ein Punkt auch weil
das in der Presse ein bisschen
rumgegangen ist
es ist ja klar dass wir schon letztes
Jahr etwas gemacht haben wir haben die
Länder unterstützt und dieses Jahr ist
es ja auch so dass etwa 3 Milliarden
Euro noch mal für die Länder zur
Verfügung stehen ich frage mich aber
manchmal wenn ich mir Bayern angucke und
sage dass da die Kapazitäten sagen wir
bis zu 90% ausgelastet sind und dann
andere Länder gucke angucke wie Hessen
60%, dann frage ich mich dass da
offenbar auch innerhalb der Länder und
zwischen den Ländern die Verteilung
nicht gut funktioniert und da müssen wir
auch weiterhin gucken deshalb gibt's die
vier Arbeitsgruppen die vier
Arbeitsstrukturen wo Bund Länder und
Kommunen zusammenkommen und darüber noch
mal intensiv sprechen und rund um Ostern
wird es auch Ergebnisse dazu geben
ich hatte am Anfang meiner Rede gesagt
dass ich da oben mit Menschen aus Syrien
Ukraine und Afghanistan stand und ich
darf für meine Fraktion sagen dass wir
solidarisch sind mit diesen Menschen
wenn sie vor Krieg Gewalt und Tod
geflohen sind wir machen da keinen
Unterschied egal aus welchem Land sie
kommen und diesen Weg gehen wir auch
weiter und lehnen deshalb ihren Antrag
ab dankeschön
[Applaus]
hat nun der Kollege Thorsten frei das
Wort
[Applaus]
verehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
im vergangenen Jahr sind
1,1 Millionen Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer
nach Deutschland gekommen zusätzlich hat
es etwa 250.000 Asylanträge gegeben es
bedeutet im Klartext das im letzten Jahr
mehr Menschen nach Deutschlands Schutz
suchend gekommen sind als in den Jahren
2015 und 16 zusammen
dass die Städte und Gemeinden und auch
die Landkreise in Deutschland das bisher
so hervorragend hingekriegt haben ist
eine gigantische Leistung die nicht hoch
genug eingeschätzt werden kann und wenn
ich jetzt Bürgermeister
Oberbürgermeister oder Landrat wäre
verehrter Herr Demir dann würde ich mich
durch ihre Rede veräppelt vorkommen das
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
wir wollen solidarisch sein und offen
gegenüber denen die vor Krieg Tod
Vertreibung fliehen aber das setzt
voraus dass wir uns auch genau auf diese
Menschen konzentrieren dass wir zwischen
illegaler und illegaler Migration
unterscheiden dass diejenigen die kein
Bleiberecht in Deutschland haben auch
wieder zurückgeführt werden das setzt
voraus dass wir in der Lage sind denen
zu helfen denen wirklich geholfen werden
muss warum weil unser Land auch
vorbereitet sein muss auf diesen Zuzug
was fehlt was fehlt in den Kommunen es
geht doch nicht nur um Unterbringung und
Verpflegung es fehlen Kitaplätze es
fehlen Schulen es fehlen Ärztinnen und
Ärzte es fehlen Wohnungen in Deutschland
700.000 Wohnungen und vor diesem
Hintergrund muss man sagen Ressourcen
sind endlich wir müssen uns auf
diejenigen konzentrieren die wirklich
unserer Hilfe bedürfen
und vor diesem Hintergrund wäre es
wichtig gewesen einen flüchtlingsgipfel
mit den Kommunen auch im
Bundeskanzleramt zu machen warum weil es
um alle Ressorts dieser Bundesregierung
geht weil damit auch ein Signal hätte
ausgesendet werden können dass es hier
eine nationale Kraftanstrengung braucht
um diese Herausforderungen zu bewältigen
und wenn man sich dann anguckt was dabei
rausgekommen ist dann muss man sagen
zwei Dinge sind mehr aufgefallen dass
wir neue Arbeitskreise gebildet werden
sollen und dass man sich irgendwann in
Zukunft um die weiteren Fragen der
Finanzierung kümmern muss da muss man
sagen außer Banalitäten außer
vertagungen außer sprachlichen Girlanden
ist da gar nichts rausgekommen bei
diesem flüchtlingsgipfel und
liebe Frau bundesinnenministerin es
reicht natürlich auch nicht zu sagen das
sind ein paar die da im Wege der
illegalen Migration zu uns kommen im
Wesentlichen geht es doch um die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer ich kann als
bundesinnenministerin da gar nichts tun
natürlich sie haben als zuständiges
Kabinettsmitglied alle Instrumente in
der Hand und die Maßnahmen zu ergreifen
die notwendig sind um Migration zu
ordnen und zu steuern und auch zu
begrenzen und sie tun es nicht und ich
will mal auf zwei Dinge den Blick werfen
zunächst einmal auf das Ende der des
Verfahrens ihre Haltung ist dass sie
einen Vorschlag einer schwedischen
Sozialdemokratin wie man
ausreisepflichten besser durchsetzen
kann einfach vom Tisch wissen was haben
Sie in den letzten Wochen hier gemacht
sie haben ein Gesetz gemacht dass auch
ausreisepflichtigen die über ihre
Identität getäuscht haben und Täuschen
ein Aufenthaltsrecht in Deutschland
ermöglichen und was planen Sie in den
nächsten Wochen dass man zukünftig auch
durch eidesstattliche Versicherung die
Identität feststellen kann das ist das
Gegenteil einer Politik die notwendig
wäre das ist eine Politik der offenen
Türen das ist eine Politik die deutlich
macht der ist einmal nach Deutschland
geschafft hat der kann auch hier bleiben
und das bedeutet Migrationsdruck wird
wachsen die Probleme werden größer
werden insbesondere für die Kommunen und
nicht kleiner und damit lösen sie
überhaupt gar nichts und
wenn das schon so schwierig ist dann
will ich noch auf eine zweite Punkt
Hinweisen Kollege frei ich habe die Uhr
angehalten gestatten Sie eine Frage oder
Bemerkung des Kollegen die mir
vielen Dank dass Sie die Frage zulassen
wir haben ja in der großen Koalition
auch einige Sachen
lösen können zum einen die erwähnten
geduldeten Menschen sie haben das ja so
definiert was ja auch richtig ist sind
meistens Menschen die Ausreise die wo
die aus die Ausreise ausgesetzt ist
jetzt haben wir eine Ausbildungs- und
eine beschäftigungsduldung in der großen
Koalition zusammen gemacht für diese
Menschen jetzt gehen wir in der
Ampelkoalition diesen Weg eigentlich
weiter für Menschen die seit fünf Jahren
schon hier in diesem Land sind also
eigentlich machen wir nichts anderes als
was wir in der großen Koalition zusammen
gemacht haben wo wir gesagt haben wenn
Menschen hier sind die hier leben und
eine Ausbildung bekommen können oder
eine Beschäftigung dann am Ende haben
dann ermöglichen wir diesen Menschen
hier zu bleiben warum sind sie jetzt
gegen diesen weiteren Schritt von uns
obwohl es eine ähnliche Gruppe betrifft
sehr geehrter Herr Kollege die mir eines
betrifft eben eine ganz andere Gruppe
ich war bei den Verhandlungen damals
2019 mit dabei und sie haben vollkommen
recht dass wir gemeinsam Maßnahmen
ergriffen haben damit wir die Situation
für diejenigen die hier sind leichter
machen
welche Gruppe war damals nicht umfasst
und genau um die geht es jetzt es geht
um Menschen die ausreisepflichtig sind
und die über ihre Identität getäuscht
haben und immer noch täuschen wer nach
Deutschland kommt um hier Schutz zu
suchen und nicht in der Lage ist zu
sagen woher er kommt der hat diesen
Schutz dann ganz offensichtlich auch
nicht verdient und deswegen ist für uns
auch vollkommen klar dass es für diese
Menschen nicht auch noch als Belohnung
eine Arbeitsmöglichkeit plus
Aufenthaltsrecht geben kann wir reden
über zwei völlig verschiedene Gruppen
und deswegen ist klar warum wir im einen
Fall dafür waren und hier auch nur
dagegen sein können
ich war frau Präsidentin stehen
geblieben beim Ende des beim Anfang des
Verfahrens denn es ist vollkommen
richtig dass wir auch dafür sorgen
müssen dass Menschen die ganz
offensichtlich gar keine Aussicht auf
eine Bleibeperspektive haben in
Deutschland nicht auch noch auf den
gefährlichen Weg geschickt werden durch
Wüsten übers Meer sie haben das
angesprochen in ihrer Rede und es
probate Mittel dass wir dafür im
nationalen Recht haben das ist die Liste
der sicheren Herkunftsstaaten und Frau
Bundesministerin diesen Punkt könnte man
aufgreifen SPD CDU und CSU haben mit der
letzten Wahlperiode ein Gesetz
verabschiedet wonach wir die Liste der
sicheren Herkunftsstaaten für Marokko
Algerien Tunesien und Georgien erweitern
möchten dieses Gesetz liegt immer noch
im Bundesrat als die Grünen verhindert
haben und schauen Sie mal was das für
Auswirkungen hätte letztes Jahr sind
10.000
hier nach Deutschland gekommen mit einer
schutzquote von 0,4 Prozent das ist
etwas wo man handeln kann aber es ist
mir klar dass die Grünen das ja
überhaupt nicht wollen weil im Grunde
genommen wollen sie ja das Gegenteil
erreichen sie wollen auch
Integrationskurse für diejenigen die aus
sicheren Herkunftsstaaten kommen das ist
die völlige Aufgabe von Ordnung und
Steuerung von Migration und deshalb
werden sie mit dieser Politik die Lösung
nicht herbeiführen können herzlichen
Dank
Thorsten frei war das noch mal mit einer
Erläuterung zum Antrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion zur europäischen
Migrationspolitik der Bundesregierung
die der Unionsfraktion nicht gefällt in
vielerleifers hätten nächste Rednerin in
dieser debatistischer Hina Gambi aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
mindestens 62 Menschen sind am
vergangenen Wochenende im Mittelmeer
ertrunken darunter viele Kinder dutzende
Leichen wurden durch italienische
Rettungskräfte geborgen erst Mitte
Februar wurden 18 Tote Menschen in einem
Laster in Bulgarien entdeckt und
parallel tauchen immer mehr Leichen im
polnischen im polnisch Bella russischen
Grenzgebiet auf erfroren erstickt oder
ertrunken das ist die Realität für
Menschen auf der Flucht jeden Tag
und parallel greift Russland die Ukraine
unvermindert brutal an die Kommunen
leisten unvorstellbares bei der
aufnahmeukrainischer Frauen Männer und
Kinder die vor dem Krieg fliehen
das Deutschland eben keinen Sonderweg
geht haben wir gesehen als Putin sein
hinterhältigen Angriffskrieg begonnen
hat und hunderttausende in die EU
fliehen mussten die Bundesregierung hat
die sogenannte massenzustrom Richtlinie
auf den Weg gebracht die ist uns
ermöglicht schnell und unbürokratisch
ukrainische Menschen Schutz zu gewähren
gemeinsam mit europäischen Partnern
haben wir besonders betroffene Staaten
wie Moldawien humanitär und finanziell
bei der Unterbringung und Versorgung
geflüchteter aus der Ukraine unterstützt
ich bin unsere Außenministerin Anna-Lena
berborg besonders dankbar dass sie
damals schnell reagiert hat und
gemeinsam mit Innenministerin Nancy
fazer ein gut koordiniertes europäisches
Handeln ermöglicht hat
viele tausende haben deshalb auch ein
Zuhause in Deutschland gefunden nun
arbeiten wir mit Hochdruck im Austausch
mit Kommunen und Ländern daran wie wir
die Kommunen besser bei der
Unterbringung und Versorgung
geflüchteter unterstützen können
und da frage ich mich doch worin die
Union einen Sonderweg erkennen möchte
ich sehe Humanität und Solidarität
gegenüber Flüchtenden und unseren
europäischen Partnern was mir aber
tatsächlich sorge bereitet ist der
Sonderweg des Manfred Weber der
Vorsitzende der EVP Fraktion pendelt
gerade recht zwischen Rom und Brüssel
und hofierte Rechte Kandidatin im
italienischen Wahlkampf ob in Thüringen
oder Rom die Brandmauer nach rechts
scheint in der Union nur noch ein
kleines Feuerchen zu sein
doch um EU-Politik scheint es doch gar
nicht zu gehen blicken wir den Antrag so
meint die Union mit einer vermeintlichen
europäischen Sonderweg die
gesetzespakete mit dem wir in der
Koalition gerade auf den Weg bringen
argumentiert wird hier einmal mehr mit
fantasietheorien aus den 60er Jahren es
ist keine Überraschung dass die Partei
die ukrainischen kriegsgeflüchteten als
asyltouristen und deutsche als kleine
Paschas beleidigt und mit der längst
überholten poolfaktoren Theorie
aufwartet die von uns geplanten
Verbesserung der Gesetzeslage
identifiziert die Union fleißig als
Anreiz für Migranten nach Deutschland
ganz im Thema von Herr Merz der in aller
Öffentlichkeit darüber fantasiert ob
unsere Sozialsysteme Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine dazu verleitet zu fliehen diese
wage Theorie des Anreize sogenannte
prüfaktoren Menschen zu Flucht verleiten
geisterzeit
Jahrzehnten in der migrationspolitischen
Diskurs diese er dachte Theorie gilt in
der Migrationsforschung als längst
überholt
das deutsche Zentrum das deutsche
Zentrum für Integration und
Migrationsforschung sagt dass die
Realität viel komplexer ist als in
diesen Modellen von Push und
pull-faktoren zulässt doch Komplexität
passt nicht in das politische Konzept
der Union wenn wir dafür sorgen dass
flüchtende hier angemessen und würdevoll
untergebracht und versorgt sind dann
heißt es nichts anderes dass wir die
Würde der Menschen respektieren das ist
eben kein Anreiz in der Ukraine in
Syrien oder Afghanistan nach Deutschland
zu fliehen ich komme zum Ende nein Sie
müssen nicht zum Ende kommen ich habe
gerade die Uhr angehalten mit der Frage
ob sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung aus der
Unionsfraktion zulassen nein danke ich
hoffe sehr dass sie in der Union sich
einmal ernsthaft mit der aktuellen
Forschung in dem Bereich
auseinandersetzen das würde uns nicht
nur einen niveauvollere debat te
ermöglichen frei von rassistischen
Interesse sondern Betroffenen helfen die
unter ihrer die Vermehrung leiden müssen
vielen Dank
der Bundestag diskutierte über die
deutsche Migrationspolitik aufgrund
eines Antrags in die cdu/csu-fraktion
hier vorgelegt hat und die Grünen
beispielsweise lassen hier Menschen
reden mit Zuwanderungsgeschichte Sarina
Gambia die wir eben gesehen und gehört
haben ist in Kabul geboren hat er hier
Abitur dann aber hier in Deutschland
gemacht und zwar in Stadthagen Bernd
Baumann der erste parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer der afd-fraktion Istan
über 100 alte Menschen verlieren
plötzlich ihre Wohnung die Kirche
ausgerechnet die Kirche lässt ein
Seniorenstift Räumen die Presse meldet
ist flossen Tränen die Alten waren
völlig überrascht
Reporter beobachteten einige Bewohner
hing noch an ihren Atemgeräten und Möbel
landeten auf den Müll
Grund für den Rauswurf die Kirche will
Platz schaffen für Migranten meine Damen
und Herren das ist ein neuer Tiefpunkt
an Menschenverachtung in Deutschland das
kann so nicht gehen
die kirchlichen Träger des
Seniorenheimes auch das wurde deutlich
verdienen heute durch Vermietung an
Migranten mehr Geld wie kann das sein
die Antwort lautet unser Staat gibt für
Migranten mehr Geld aus als für unsere
eigenen Senioren diese
regenbogen-regierung zieht damit
Migranten all jenen Menschen vor die
durch harte Arbeit unseren Wohlstand
erst geschaffen haben wie undankbar
wie undankbar wie ungerecht wie
unmenschlich unsere Senioren haben weit
Besseres verdient meine Damen und Herren
denn das ganze ist ja kein Einzelfall
kurz zuvor wurden in Lörrach Mieter aus
ihren Wohnungen geworfen ebenfalls und
Platz zu schaffen für Migranten in
Lörrach traf es sozial Schwache und die
SPD hat das auch noch unterstützt es
wird wohl bald weitere Fälle geben
aufgrund der ungebremsten
Masseneinwanderung insgesamt
wuchsiebevölkerung in Deutschland seit
2015 um fast 4 Millionen vier Millionen
das sind so viele wie die Einwohner von
ganz Frankfurt
plus Köln
plus München
plus Dresden die allermeisten Migranten
kamen aus Orient und Afrika von da
strömen auch jetzt noch jeden Monat
30.000 völlig unkontrolliert hier zu uns
allein für diese müssten jeden Monat
eine neue Mittel einen mittelgroße Stadt
aus dem Boden gestampft werden deshalb
fehlt es ein Wohnungen an Schulen an
Krankenhäusern
es fehlt an alle unsere Kommunen
schreien auf der Städte und Gemeindebund
Streit auf aber niemand hört auf Sie
diese Politik ist irrsinnig meine Damen
und Herren
und die Bundesregierung geht ja sogar
noch weiter statt den gigantischen
Migrationsdruck durch eine kluge Politik
einzudämmen macht sie das Gegenteil
vergangene Woche fliegen gleich zwei
Bundesminister Hubertus Heil und Svenja
Schulze mit großen Presse aufgebaut nach
Ghana
sie werden vor Ort man kann es ja kaum
glauben aktiv um noch mehr Einwanderung
aus Schwarzafrika nach Deutschland in
der offiziellen Presseerklärung der
beiden Minister heißt es wörtlich
Menschen die aus Ghana auswandern wollen
sollen auf legalen wegen nach
Deutschland kommen auf diese Weise
wörtlich in der Presseerklärung der
Minister soll die demografische Lücke in
Deutschland geschlossen werden und auch
der Fachkräftemangel mit Hilfe
Schwarzafrikas behoben werden und alle
TV-Sender vor Ort melden das bis ins
letzte Dorf meine Damen und Herren schon
als die CDU regierte weil die
Migrationspolitik eine Katastrophe
jetzt wird sie vollends absurd sie wird
apokalyptisch meine Damen und Herren und
nicht ohne Grund nicht ohne Grund haben
die Deutschen Angst vor solcher Politik
sie sieht mit großer Mehrheit dagegen
und das hat jetzt auch die CDU
verstanden jetzt will die CDU von dieser
Stimmung profitieren sie legt heute
einen Antrag vor um Einwanderung zu
begrenzen sie hat dafür bis in Details
abgeschrieben von der AFD hören Sie sich
das an die CDU will jetzt auf einmal
eine abschiebe offensive sie will
effektive Grenzkontrollen sie will die
illegale Migration begrenzen all das
fordern wir von der AFD seit Jahren und
was hat die CDU sie lehnte alle unsere
Anträge ab jetzt übernimmt sie sie
komplett bis in Details unserer
Forderung bis in Details das ist schon
eine große Frechheit meine Damen und
Herren sie von der CDU waren ja die
ganze Zeit an der Regierung da haben sie
16 Jahre lang genau das Gegenteil von
dem gemacht was sie jetzt fordern sie
haben Millionen aus Orient und Afrika
unkontrolliert hereingelassen das war
das Ergebnis
und sie haben damit unzähligen deutschen
unzähligen deutschen ihr Heimatgefühl
genommen in Berlin-Neukölln in Duisburg
in Mannheim in Dortmund in Bochum in
Essen und ich könnte noch weitermachen
und heute tun sie so heute tun Sie so
als stünden sie auf deren Seite nein sie
stehen nicht auf deren Seite sie haben
diese Leute verraten jahrelang verraten
und das wissen wir auch
schlimmer noch unsere ja identischen
Forderung nach Grenzkontrollen nach
Abschiebung nach Begrenzung der
Migration haben sie jahrelang verteufelt
sie haben sie als ausländerfeindlich als
rassistisch als rechtsradikal
gebrandmarkt und nun fordern Sie all das
selber was für eine Heuchelei meine
Damen und Herren das zeigt doch wie
niederträchtig das zeigt doch wie
niederträchtig zu Vorgehen bis zu
Instrumentalisierung des
Verfassungsschutzes meine Damen und es
geht genau die gleiche Richtung
es ist ja so durchschaubar vor Wahlen
blinkt die CDU immer rechts und tut dann
genau das Gegenteil wie kürzlich bei der
Landtagswahl in Berlin ganz Deutschland
war der noch geschockt von den
silvesterkrawallen alle hatten noch die
brutalen Fernsehbilder im Kopf ein
größtenteils aus Migranten bestehender
Mob lockt Polizisten Feuerwehrleute und
Sanitäter in Hinterhalte greift sie mit
Raketen an die Berliner CDU witterte im
Wahlkampf sofort ihre Chance öffentlich
forderte sie den Senat auf die Vornamen
aller Täter zu benennen damit deutlich
werden sollte die Täter heißen eben
nicht Andreas oder Karl-heinz sondern
vorwiegend alle und Musterverfahren mit
solchen Aktionen mit solchen Aktionen
erschleicht sich die CDU das Vertrauen
der Wähler über 10%
über zehn Prozent legte die CDU am
Wahlabend zu und dann und dann auf
höchster Ebene hier im Innenausschuss
des Bundestages wollte die CDU plötzlich
nichts mehr davon wissen sie
distanzierte sich von der Berliner
Wahlkampfstrategen das zeigt doch wie
heuchlerisch wie unehrlich wie
charakterlos die CDU mittlerweile ist
ihr ist das Land egal meine Damen und
Herren
was Deutschland stattdessen braucht
Deutschland stattdessen braucht
ist aber genau dies deutschland braucht
mehr Ehrlichkeit mehr Verlässlichkeit
mehr Charakter
mehr AFD meine Damen und Herren
Baumann war das der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
afd-fraktion im Deutschen Bundestag der
über einen Antrag der Unionsfraktion
debattiert zum zur Migrationspolitik der
Bundesregierung da so heißt es in dem
Antrag gehe die Bundesregierung einen
Sonderweg in Europa
ist parlamentarischer Geschäftsführer in
der FDP-Fraktion der Antrag der Union
den wir heute beraten stammt vom Oktober
2022 das merkt man im logischerweise
auch an vielen Stellen an denn in der
Zwischenzeit hat sich manches getan im
Bereich der mediationspolitik denn der
Sonderweg den Sie hier beklagen das ist
der Regierung Merkel den wir mit unserer
beenden werden meine Damen und Herren
gerade jetzt im Februar habe ich einige
Dinge geändert zum Beispiel der
europäische migrationsgipfel am 9 und 10
Februar bei dem auch Änderungen beim
außengrenzschutz beschlossen worden sind
bei denen die kommissionspräsidentin
Ursula von der Leyen vor der CDU nicht
gerade Vorreiterin gewesen ist meine
Damen und Herren oder es gab jetzt am
eine Woche danach am 16 Februar den
migrationsgipfel von Bund Ländern und
Kommunen eine neues Format das oft
schlecht geredet worden ist aber dazu
führte dass wir neue ständige
Arbeitsstrukturen bilden etwas was es
noch nicht gibt bislang und das ist eine
echte Verbesserung finden wie ich finde
und seit
dem ersten Februar ist auch der neue
sonderbevollmächte der Bundesregierung
für migrationsabkommen im Amt dr Joachim
Stamm dessen Aufgabe sein wird
migrationsabkommen auch zu handeln die
auch Rücknahme Verpflichtungen enthalten
und weil immer gesagt wird dass der Bund
die Kommunen im Stich lassen im letzten
Jahr hatte Bund im in 3,5 Milliarden
Euro für flüchtlingsunterbringung zur
Verfügung gestellt mit in diesem Jahr
noch einmal 2,75 Milliarden dafür zur
Verfügung stellen macht in Summe 6,25
Milliarden Euro man kann nicht sagen
dass der Bund die Kommunen ganz und gar
im Stich lassen meine Damen und Herren
wir wollen mit einem Paradigmenwechsel
den Sonderweg der Regierung Merkel
beenden wir wollen mehr reguläre
Migration in den Arbeitsmarkt in unserem
Land wir wollen weniger irreguläre durch
die Wüste und über das Meer und da will
ich ein paar Punkte ansprechen die
wirklich unter den Nägeln brennen was am
meisten oder Nägeln brennt und die
Menschen besorgt ist dass es uns in der
Vergangenheit nicht hinreichend gelungen
ist Straftäter und Gefährder auch
abzuben das der Bundesminister ein
Vorschlag unterbreitet wie durch einen
besseren Daten austauscht
Abschiebung besser gelingen können vor
allem aber will ich auf die
migrationsabkommen hinweisen die wir
aushandeln wollen mit Rücknahme
Vereinbarungen da muss man sich etwas
Geduld haben das wird nicht über Nacht
geschehen können wir nicht über Nacht
all das aufarbeiten können was in den
letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten liegen
geblieben ist aber kaum ist der neue
sonderbevollmächtige Tochter stammt im
Amt er hat noch nicht einmal wirklich
mit Arbeiter im Amt hat er schon erste
Gespräche geführt und das zeigt dass er
wirklich sein Amt sehr ernst nimmt und
damit hohe Geschwindigkeit lose Dinge
die Vergangenheit der Kollegen geblieben
sind es werden alle
und Länder und Kommunen weiter leisten
müssen kann man nicht nur auf einen
zeigen wir haben was das Thema
ausweisige Wahrsagen betrifft die
Möglichkeit geschaffen den Gewahrsam auf
78 Tage zu verlängern aber zu Wahrheit
gehört auch dass sie Länder bislang nur
gewahrsamsplätze bereithalten auch die
Länder müssen einen Beitrag dazu leisten
dass auch ab Aussage Gewahrsam besser
gelingen kann und es gehört eben auch
zur Wahrheit auch wenn sie Kommunen
vielleicht nicht gern hören wollen dass
auch die Ausländerbehörden oft im Stich
gelassen worden sind sie sind oft
Personal unterbesetzt sie haben mit
schweren Fällen zu tun stehen oft in der
öffentlichen Kritik aus der Gesellschaft
auch aus den Kirchen kommt oft der
Vorwurf das Abschiebungen in human sein
ja mit einem komplizierten Rechtsgebiet
zu tun wir brauchen die
Ausländerbehörden die eine schwierige
Aufgabe haben die aber auch ein Teil
unseres Asylsystems ist indem sie doch
mehr wert Schätzung aber nur echte
Unterstützung in der schweren Arbeit
unterstützen es genügt nicht dass man
immer nur auf den Bund zeigt alle Ebenen
Hund Länder und Kommunen müssen ihren
Beitrag leisten das Abschiebungen auch
gelingen und wir Schutz und Hilfe den
wir werden können die Sie wirklich
benötigen meine Damen und Herren
ich will in der kurzen wieder
verbleibenden Zeit noch auf einen Punkt
zu sprechen kommen der in ihrem Antrag
enthalten ist auf die falschen Anreize
damit meinen Sie wie ich annehme den
chancenaufenthalt den wir im letzten
Jahr beschlossen haben aber gerade um zu
verhindern dass wir die Zukunft falsche
Anreise gesetzt werden haben wir die
Chancen Aufenthalt mit einem Stichtag
versehen denn was ist denn die Situation
die wir vorgefunden haben
300.000 ausweispflichtige Menschen haben
wir als Erbe von der Vorgängerregierung
übernommen die zum Teil acht Jahre sich
von Duldung zu Duldung schleppen das ist
doch irgendeinmal sinnvoll zu sagen wenn
es in acht Jahren nicht gelungen ist
jemanden abzuschieben dann ist es
sinnvoller die Energie darauf zu wenden
wie wir Menschen integrieren und bei uns
in Arbeitsmarkt bringen als weiter zu
versuchen Sie abzuschieben auch das ist
ein Teil der Wahrheit das ist unsere
Sonderweg der Regierung Merkel beenden
wollen vielen Dank
Stefan thomeyerischer Geschäftsführer
der FDP-Fraktion
es geht weiterhin die europäische
Migrationspolitik der Bundesregierung
und da ist die nächste Rednerin klarer
aus der Linksfraktion sie ist Sprecherin
für fluchtpolitik
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir debattieren
heute erneut den Antrag der Union indem
sie fordern die Rechte von geflüchteten
weiter einzuschränken und das mit
Zustimmung der AFD dass es wirklich sehr
schauderhaft
wir Timing könnte kaum schlimmer sein
ein Jahr nach dem Beginn des Krieges in
der Ukraine fast einen Monat nach dem
schweren Erdbeben in der Türkei und in
Syrien und nur wenige Tage nach dem
mindestens 66 Menschen auf der Flucht
nach Europa gestorben sind fordern die
christlichen Parteien eine Politik die
mehr Leid und mehr Tote zur Folge haben
wird das hat doch mit christlichen
Werten nicht zu tun
heute können Sie in allen Tageszeitungen
lesen dass die Angriffe auf geflüchtete
massiv gestiegen sind und sie betreiben
wir dennoch Hetze auf dem Rücken der
Menschen die hier Schutz suchen schämen
sie sich dafür
und wir kennen doch alle die Bilder von
Rostock Lichtenhagen und wir müssen
endlich alles dafür tun dass Angriffe
auf geflüchtete gestoppt werden wir
müssen nicht nur alarmiert sein sondern
wir müssen auch endlich handeln das sage
ich auch in Richtung der Ministerin die
Toten vor der Küste von Italien haben
noch mal deutlich gemacht wie dringend
wir sichere Fluchtwege brauchen es kann
nicht sein dass frontex-beamte in
pushbacks involviert sind statt zu
retten wir brauchen Aufnahmeprogramme
damit Menschen gar nicht erst in Boote
steigen müssen statt die Festung
europaweite auszubauen braucht es ein
funktionierendes seenotrettungsprogramm
damit niemand auf der Flucht sterben
muss
doch auch im Umgang mit den Menschen die
es nach Deutschland geschafft haben
verkennt der Antrag die Realität statt
anzuerkennen dass wir aus der Behandlung
von ukrainischen geflüchteten im
vergangenen Jahr lernen und ein
menschliches und würdiges ankommen für
alle ermöglichen könnten werden
ukraineerinnen gegen andere geflüchtete
ausgespielt als ob es im Krieg einen
Unterschied machen würde welchen Pass
man besitzt
dabei ist sich die Union nicht zu schade
die reale not manche Kommunen für ihre
populistische Politik auszunutzen die
Antwort auf Engpässe bei der Versorgung
und Unterbringung kann nicht sein den
Weg nach Deutschland noch tödlicher zu
machen
und das alte Märchen vom pulfaktor auch
wieder herauszukramen es wurde ja schon
gesagt da gibt es keine
wissenschaftlichen Studien dazu und
niemand kommt nach Deutschland um in
Containern und Zelten ein abgeschiedenen
Orten zu leben niemand riskiert sein
Leben auf der Flucht um für
Sozialleistungen unter dem
Existenzminimum hier in Deutschland zu
leben dass wir überhaupt in dieser
Situation sind hat doch die Union zu
großen Teilen selbst zu verantworten
denn sie haben immer mehr Kapazitäten
reduziert statt dezentrales Wohnen zu
ermöglichen Kommunen brauchen jetzt
unsere Unterstützung um diese Fehler zu
beheben die private ja die private
Unterbringung bei Verwandten oder
Bekannten kann dabei helfen die Aufnahme
der über eine Million Ukrainerin hat das
auch gezeigt diese Option muss auch für
andere Asylsuchende geöffnet werden die
lagerpflicht muss endlich enden und das
Land Berlin ist mit katja Kipping als
inatorin damit guten Beispiel
vorangegangen Liebe Ampel schaffen Sie
die lagerpflicht endlich ab und ich
finde es sehr begrüßenswert dass die
Innenministerin gestern zugesichert hat
dass sie sich mit dieser Idee
auseinandersetzen wird
auch Angebote von Kommunen die bereit
sind mehr Menschen aufzunehmen müssen
angenommen und unterstützt werden damit
alle geflüchteten
menschenwürdig unterkommen können muss
aber noch viel mehr passieren wir
brauchen dringend massive Investitionen
im bezahlbaren Wohnraum damit
benachteiligte Gruppen und das das sind
nicht nur geflüchtete und ich finde es
unsäglich dass die AFD ihre Politik auf
dem Rücken von armen Menschen in
Deutschland macht es geht dabei
natürlich nicht nur im geflüchtete
Menschen sondern es geht auch um
Menschen mit deutscher
Staatsangehörigkeit die Sozialleistungen
erhalten auch die brauchen Unterstützung
und deshalb brauchen wir massive
Investitionen in bezahlbaren Wohnraum
damit diese Gruppen nicht gegeneinander
ausgespielt werden sondern gemeinsam
unterstützt werden vielen Dank
das Wort hat der Kollege für die SPD
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wenn in einem Moment wo gerade
ein Boot mit 150-180 Personen zerborsten
zerschellt ist wobei mindestens dutzende
ums Leben gekommen sind wenn in einem
solchen Moment zunehmend viele auch in
diesem Hohen Hause eine das Boot ist
voll Rhetorik bedienen dann finde ich
das ein erheblichen Ausdruck von
Pietätlosigkeit und Geschmacklosigkeit
um das mal so ganz deutlich zu sagen
aber
auch diese
sonderwegsthese die hat ja System und
Kalkül und eine Absicht steckt gezielt
dahinter eine anscheinend
erweckungspolitik ganz bewusst wird
betrieben und getäuscht und diese
anscheinend erweckungspolitik die sie da
betreiben die muss zerlegt werden so wie
man auch diesen Antrag es tut mir leid
sie ziehen muss erstens mal ist der
Antrag weitesten komplett out of Dad das
heißt weitestgehend schon abgearbeitet
ein
sonderbevollmächtigter für
migrationsabkommen übrigens sondern
bevollmächtiger für migrationsabkommen
nicht
rückführungsbeauftragter einfach meinen
Koalitionsvertrag gucken ist eingesetzt
in Bezug auf Serbien auch die
bundesinnenministerin hatte sich da
vehement und erfolgreich eingesetzt ist
die Frage dieser Pflicht entsprechend
geklärt all das ist abgearbeitet all
diese Punkte sind längst bearbeitet ihre
Antrag in weiten Dingen überholt das ist
das eine das andere ist aber die
sonderwegsthese und dieser Sonderweg ist
eine Fata Morgana und nicht nur das wenn
Sie von diesem Sonderweg sprechen ist
das zum einen fahrlässig es ist zum
anderen unsinnig und unwahr und es ist
zum dritten gefährlich warum ist es
fahrlässig
sie wissen genau
um die Begriffsgeschichte des Wortes
Sonderweg Hans-Ulrich Wehler einschlägig
auch in der Union gewiss bekannt
Sonderweg beschrieb da den Weg den
angenommenen Sonderweg Deutschlands mal
aufgrund mangelnder Modernisierung
hingehen in den Nationalsozialismus ich
finde es historisch wirklich vergessen
und absolut unsensibel ausgerechnet den
Begriff Sonderweg in diesem Zusammenhang
zu verwenden
zum zweiten
unwahr und unsinnig
es ist wenn wir uns die Zahl der
Asylanträge gucken überhaupt nicht so
dass Deutschland einen Sonderweg geht
schauen Sie sich Österreich an
ÖVP regiert ÖVP Innenminister ÖVP
Bundeskanzler wenn man die Anzahl von
Anträgen auf Personen ist liegt
Österreich Deutschland deutlich vor
Deutschland trotz der demonstrativen
österreichischen Balkanroute zu Politik
erstaunlich nicht wahr auch bei der
anerkennungsbote Nachbarländer Schweiz
aber auch Österreich in den bereinigten
Zahlen vor Deutschland oder auch Dritter
Bereich auch da sonderwegs diese
eindeutig widerlegt durch die Zahlen
Abschiebung Frankreich Italien Spanien
alle mit viel niedrigeren Pfoten also
ihre Sonderweg These ist eine Täuschung
ist schlicht anscheinend Erweckungen
Politik und das ist unanständig in
diesem Zusammenhang
und was besonders unanständig ist
dass sie den Eindruck erwecken das
aufgrund nicht abgeschobener geduldet
hat oder aufgrund jetzt kommender
Menschen aus Syrien und Afghanistan die
Kommunen unter der Belastung stünden wir
haben über eine Million richtigerweise
Ukraine Ukraine aufgenommen dieses nicht
unerhebliche Detail sollten Sie erwähnen
und keine abschiebungsoffensive würde
jemals an diesem Umstand etwas ändern
diese Tatsache sprechen sie aber gerade
nicht aus und das ist vehemente
Täuschung und das ist zutiefst unredig
was sie da betreiben das heißt
wenn sie wirklich
Fluchtursachen und die Ursachen für die
jetzige Krisensituation die aber trotz
allem immer noch hervorragend gemeistert
wird von vielen Kommunen auch
unterstützt vom Bund unterstützt von der
Bundesinnenminister und von einer
großartigen Zivilgesellschaft dann
sollen sie mal auf die echten flussur
Sachen gucken und wie heißt Putin und
Putin Regime und die heißt Taliban in
Afghanistan und die heißt Regime das
muss endlich mal ausgesprochen werden
ich halte es für unerträglich wenn sie
den Eindruck erwecken wir würden die
kommunale Lage substanziell verbessern
wenn wir weniger Menschen bleiben Recht
geben würden oder massiv abschieben
würden schlichtun war und außerdem ist
dass sie behaupten es wäre ein Versagen
der Bundesregierung nicht abzuschieben
haben Sie mal was von der Länder
Zuständigkeit für Abschiebung gehört
also wenn sich an ihre
Länder die gar nicht wie dieser Vorwurf
an den Bund an sie selbst zurückgeht wer
hat denn die Bundesinnenminister
gestellt in den letzten Jahrzehnten Herr
de maizia Herr Seehofer und und warum
waren sie dann nicht erfolgreich in
ihrem Sinne weil es auch gar nicht
möglich war weil viele Länder
geflüchtete nicht zurücknehmen weil es
schlicht nicht machbar ist 300.000
400.000 Menschen abzuschieben und
übrigens auch nicht sinnvoll bei
Menschen Stichwort Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht die viele Jahre ihr
Leben diese Täuschung muss man hier im
Hause klar benannt werden es ist eine
grobe Lüge zu behaupten es wäre ein
politisches Versagen durch nicht
reinreichen Grenzkontrollen und nicht
hinreichend abschieben für die
gegenwärtige Situation gesagt haben das
ist schlicht unwahr entscheidend ist die
Situation die Kriegssituation und auch
entscheidend
Aufnahmeprogramm für in Afghan wollen
sie aber jetzt sagen dass wir Menschen
auf Afghanistan für die wir auch
Verantwortung tragen die gegen dieses
barbarische Regime eintreten darunter
viele Frauen die höchst gefährdet sind
dass wir die nicht aufnehmen sollten
deshalb rate ich Ihnen auch nicht
Ausdrücke wie Aufnahmeprogramm von
Migranten zu verwenden sondern
Aufnahmeprogramm von schutzbedürftigen
zu sagen das ist die Wahrheit und ich
empfehle Ihnen auch nicht den Begriff
Asyl Zuwanderung zu verwenden und jetzt
noch ein letztes in diesem Hause haben
sie ja damals groß applaudiert als ich
damals ich erinnere mich noch genau die
Opposition kritisiert habe weil sie sehr
kritisch war gegenüber Abschiebung und
gleichzeitig unter ihre Beteiligung
Abschiebung in Ländern stattgefunden
haben
wenn sie das aber kritisieren was ist
dann mit Ihnen die NRW-Landesregierung
hat mit vorgriffsregelung mit erlassen
mit diversen Maßnahmen unter einem CDU
Ministerpräsidenten bereits in den
letzten Jahren Schritte genau hin zu
einem Chancen Aufenthalt eingeleitet hat
es im Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten
ihre eigenen Leute im größten Bundesland
in dem Land mit den meisten geflüchteten
vertreten eine Politik die wir umsetzen
was sie hier betreiben ist unredig und
es ist doppelmoralisch das ist zu
benennen und ich wette das nicht wenige
aus ihren rein das genauso sehen wie wir
das haben wir ja auch an diversen
prominenten Enthaltung im Zusammenhang
mit dem Chance auf das Gesetz also
täuschen sie nicht weiter benennen sie
Tatsachen umbenennen sie die
Verantwortung da wo sie ist ich mache
und wir machen Ihre anscheinend
erwerbungspolitik nicht mehr mit vielen
Dank
ja sagt hey gelind hier für die
SPD-Fraktion und jetzt hat die
Unionsfraktion direkt die Gelegenheit
darauf zu reagieren mit ihrer nächsten
Rednerin das wird Andrea Lindholz sein
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir die
unionsfraktionen appelliert seit Monaten
wie auch zahlreiche Kommunen in unserem
Land an die Bundesregierung endlich die
Kommunen in der migrationskrise zu
entlasten und die irreguläre Migration
zu begrenzen Politik beginnt mit dem
Betrachten der Wirklichkeit letzte Woche
schilderte der grüne Landrat aus meinem
nachbarwahlkreis Markus Scherf genau die
Wirklichkeit vor Ort ich darf Ihnen
auszugsweise zitieren wir haben 50
dezentrale Flüchtlingsunterkünfte im
Landkreis die sind voll die Bereitschaft
in den Gemeinden weitere geflüchtete
aufzunehmen nimmt rapide ab wir gehen in
jede Gemeinderatssitzung wo uns dann
gesagt wird dass wir nicht nur kein
Wohnraum haben dass die Kindergärten
voll sind und die Schulen auch wir
können die Menschen die zu uns kommen
einfach nicht mehr neuen Zitat Ende wenn
sie uns schon nicht glauben dann glauben
Sie doch wenigstens den
Kommunalpolitikern aus ihren eigenen
Reihen sie
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen sind
aktuell mitverantwortlich dafür dass es
in vielen Teilen Deutschlands auch in
meinem Wahlkreis in der Gemeinde
Großostheim aber auch in Lörrach in
Berlin oder in Upahl zu massiven
sozialen und gesellschaftlichen
Spannungen kommt weil sie die Kommunen
seit Monaten mit ihren Problemen alleine
lassen sie lassen sie auf den Kosten
sitzen und sie lassen die irreguläre
Migration einfach laufen im letzten Jahr
kamen über eine Million
Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der Ukraine zu uns
und natürlich müssen wir denen helfen
und natürlich haben wir Ihnen auch
geholfen und werden wir Ihnen auch
weiterhelfen aber das Problem ist dazu
kam weitere 217.000 Asyl Erstanträge aus
dem Bereich der irregulären Migration
und im Januar diesen Jahres waren es
bereits 29.000 rechnen Sie das mal hoch
was das für die nächsten 12 Monate
bedeuten würde die Hälfte dieser Fälle
in der Hälfte dieser Fälle besteht kein
Schutzanspruch in meiner Heimatzeitung
mein Echo können Sie heute morgen
nachlesen unter der Überschrift Sorge
vor Integration da geht es um die
Aufnahme von Menschen in der Gemeinde
Großostheim dass die Regierung von
Unterfranken mitgeteilt hat das aktuell
nach Bayern 75 bis 80 Prozent der
ankommenden Menschen
Alleinreisende junge Männer aus Syrien
und Afghanistan sind und es sind genau
nicht die Familien von denen Sie hier
heute morgen wieder gesprochen haben und
das ist die Realität in Deutschland
Kollegin Lindholz bestatten sie eine
Frage oder Bemerkung der Kolleginnen
nein der Kanzler schweigt eisig und
deshalb Monaten die Innenministerin hat
noch hier im November folgendes gesagt
meine Damen und Herren wir haben keine
große migrationskrise ja liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wie viel
Realitätsverweigerung geht eigentlich
noch
was sie hier machen mit den Kommunen mit
den Bürgermeister mit den Gemeinderäten
mit den Landräten mit allen
Kommunalparlamenten das ist kein
Krisenmanagement das ist schlicht und
ergreifend realitäts- und
Arbeitsverweigerung unser Antrag ist
vier Monate alt aber in unserem Antrag
ist alles noch aktuell weil in diesen
vier Monaten haben sie
nicht und eines
rückführungsbeauftragten ist noch lange
keine Rückführung
bundesimmobilien können die Probleme
nicht lösen das wissen wir der Bund hat
nicht ausreichend Kommunen hat nicht
ausreichend Immobilien was wir also
brauchen ist endlich eine Begrenzung der
irregulären und illegalen Migration und
dafür gibt es natürlich Maßnahmen es ist
ein Bündel es sind viele Maßnahmen
rückführungsoffensive umsetzen Druck auf
die Länder machen die nicht abschieben
bin grenzenlage angepasst kontrollieren
freiwillige Aufnahmeprogramme zum
Beispiel für Afghanistan aussetzen
sichere Herkunftsländer endlich
beschließen nur vier Maßnahmen was
machen Sie sie setzen neue Fehlanreize
in die Welt die zu weiterer Ehre
Migration führt und das ist ein Fehler
Deutschland ist stark Deutschland ist
hilfsbereit aber die Kommunen zeigen uns
ganz klar unsere Aufnahmekapazitäten
sind begrenzt natürlich sind sie im
Übrigen in Europa vollkommen isoliert
dass sie das selber noch nicht gemerkt
haben ist die genau die gleiche
Realitätsverweigerung gute Möglichkeit
wäre um auf Herkunftsstaaten Einfluss zu
nehmen die ihre Bürger nicht
zurücknehmen der Visa Hebel was erleben
wir da jirat in Stockholm im Januar Frau
Feser lehnt den Visa Hebel ab da Kanzler
im Rat in Brüssel im Februar
offensichtlich auf Druck seiner Kollegen
stimmt in dieser Hebel zu ich bin
gespannt was sie jetzt machen ich kann
Ihnen nur empfehlen sich an dem Visa
Hebel zu beteiligen um Druck auf die
Länder auszuüben auf die er
offensichtlich auch zumindestens die
fdp-druck ausüben will
was ist also entscheidend in der
migrationskrise entscheidend ist dass
wir uns endlich den Sorgen der Kommunen
annehmen entscheidend ist dass der
Kanzler dieses Thema zur Chefsache macht
weil eins haben wir gesehen die
bundesinnenministerin kann es
offensichtlich nicht und deswegen
empfehle ich auch unserem Antrag heute
zuzustimmen
sagt Andrea Lindholz hier für die CDU
CSU-Fraktion ja die Rückführungsabkommen
das ist in den Augen aller eigentlich
ein zentraler Punkt die Bundesregierung
hat ja den früheren
nordrhein-westfälischen
iterationsminister Joachim Stamm von der
FDP als sonderbevollmächtigten für
migrationsabkommen im
Bundesinnenministerium eingesetzt er
soll sich ja auch beispielsweise kümmern
um Vereinbarung über Visa Erleichterung
und so weiter nächster Rednerin Fillys
Polat für die Grünen
Damen und Herren gestanden sie mir diese
persönliche Vorbemerkung auch mir fällt
es schwer wenige Tage nachdem in
Kalabrien vor unserer europäischen Küste
wieder viele mehr als 60 geflüchtete ums
Leben gekommen sind über einen Antrag zu
debattieren der sich mit einem
vermeintlichen Herr gelind hat gesagt
migrationspolitischen Sonderweg
beschäftigt meine Damen und Herren wie
selbstbezogen liest sich dieser Antrag
angesichts des wöchentlichen Sterbens
von Menschen im Mittelmeer
oder auf anderen gefährlichen
Fluchtrouten und Frau Lindholz sie
müssen wirklich mal aufklären was sie
mit illegal meinen die
hauptherkunftsländer die uns erreichen
sind Syrer Afghanen Iraner in politisch
Verfolgte Kurden aus der Türkei
jesident und das sind bei ihnen
illegalisierte 90 Prozent aller
illegalen Grenzübertritte die von der
Bundespolizei Statistik so erfasst
werden werden eingestellt weil die
Menschen ein Asylantrag stellen und wie
die Statistik zeigt wir haben den nach
wie vor eine sehr hohe schutzquote über
all diese Personenkreise
wieder einmal in simulieren Union
implizit an dass Deutschland isoliert
ist schlimmer noch sie unterstellen
dieser Regierung sie Locke
menschengerade zu an sich zu uns
aufzumachen und wie so oft macht auch
diese Antrag nicht halt vor Einstufung
hier die Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine die
unsere volle Solidarität verdienen da
die asylmigration jene die illegal nach
Deutschland zu uns gelangen versuchen
meine Damen und Herren diese Aufteilung
in geflüchteter erster und zweiter
Klasse ist und bleibt zynisch sie
relativiert das Leid und die Bedrohung
von Millionen Menschen die Verfolgter
und Tod fliehen
so etwas spaltet unsere Gesellschaft
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union sie reden von humanitärer
Verpflichtung auch meinen aber in
Wahrheit nur Abschottung
oder auch mal ganz konkret was heißt es
denn wenn sie fordern die gegenwärtige
Lage nicht durch zusätzliche
Aufnahmeprogramme von Migranten weiter
zu verschärfen soll das heißen sie
stellen auch in Frage dass Deutschland
von Verfolgung und Tod bedrohte Menschen
aus Afghanistan Sicherheit gewährt sie
sollten die jüngsten Worte von
UN-Generalsekretär
ätherisch beherzigen wir brauchen
sichere legale Routen für Migranten und
Flüchtlinge und nichts anderes macht
diese Bundesregierung meine Damen und
Herren
und meine Damen und Herren was Europa
und vor allem die EU ausmacht sind
Demokratie und das Eintreten für die
universellen Grundrechte das heißt für
uns gerade nach dem Erfahrungen von zwei
Weltkriegen und das sollten wir in
diesem Jahr nicht vergessen die Aufnahme
und Versorgung von geflüchteten ist
unsere humanitäre Verpflichtung und eine
gesamtstaatliche und gesellschaftliche
Verantwortung sie ergibt sich schlicht
aus der UN grundrechte-
in ihrem übrigen
arg veralteten Antrag so will ich das
tatsächlich auch sehen taucht zwar das
märz zur Unwort vom sozialtourismus
nicht auf das hindert sie aber nicht
daran Botschaften der Abschottung
auszusenden wieder besseren Wissens
weiter ihre mehr vom Sonderweg zu
verbreiten auf den sich diese Regierung
vermeintlich befinde interessant ist sie
legen einen Antrag zur Migrationspolitik
vor und bringen es fertig das auf knapp
drei Seiten nicht ein einziges Mal das
Wort Integration vorkommt das muss man
erstmal fertig bringen meine Damen und
Herren
setzen Sie doch mal ihre Fantasie ein
was ließe sich bewirken wenn die
Millionen Summen die auf EU Ebene in
immer neue grenz- und Kontrollsysteme in
Zäune und mäuern Mauern fließen im
übrigen mit deutschen Steuergeld
stattdessen in die Aufnahme und
Versorgung von geflüchteten investiert
würde in ein funktionierendes Asylsystem
in faire und zügige Verfahren
rechtsstaatlich meine Damen und Herren
und deshalb ist es gut richtig und
wichtig dass das Spitzentreffen zur
Flüchtlingspolitik auf Einladung unserer
Bundes Innenministerin stattgefunden hat
herzlichen Dank nochmal Frau Ministerin
fesan wir sind dankbar dafür dass sie
bundländer unkommunen an einen Tisch
gebracht haben erstmalig und und das
haben sie auch gestern im Innenausschuss
betont das zum ersten Mal und eigentlich
sollte selbstverständlich sein die für
Integration zuständigen Minister in an
der Sitzung teilnehmen konnten denn um
das geht es doch wenn wir von Flucht und
Migration sprechen müssen wir
gleichzeitig natürlich über die
Integration dieser Menschen reden wir
sorgen wir sorgen dafür dass Menschen so
schnell wie möglich Zugang zu uns
bekommen Zugang zu Sprachkursen und zum
Arbeitsmarkt und die Union will
stattdessen an arbeitsverboten
festhalten wie absurd ist das denn meine
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir reden
hier von einer gesamtstaatlichen Aufgabe
und ja wir reden auch über Geld oder
besser ich würde sagen Investitionen
Investitionen in Bildungsinfrastruktur
und in den sozialen Wohnungsbau und ich
rufe dazu in Erinnerung auch ihre
Regierung der Bund hat sich im Jahr 2016
mit 8 Milliarden Euro an den
flüchtlingsbezogenen Kosten beteiligt
das ist der Maßstab an dem wir uns
orientieren meine Damen und Herren es
ist gut und richtig dass wir heute und
regelmäßig über das Thema Migration und
Ihre Herausforderungen debattieren ja
natürlich auch kontrovers aber bitte die
Auseinandersetzung über Verteilung und
Finanzierung dürfen nicht auf dem Rücken
von geflüchteten ausgetragen werden das
führt nämlich zu Situationen wie in opal
Frau Lindholz und sie vergessen dass in
opal eine große völkische Siedlung ist
und rechtsextreme diese BürgerInnen
unterwandert haben und das müssen sie
zur weiterzusagen das ist
höchstgefährlich und ihre Antwort darauf
ist das Flüchtlinge nicht mehr nach
Deutschland kommen dürfen da dienen sie
nur und sind der Nährboden für solche
Kollegen meine Damen und Herren
ich habe meine Riesenhütte zum Schluss
ich komme zum Schluss frau Präsidentin
ich habe meine Rede mit der Erinnerung
an die Tragödie für Kalabrien
eingeleitet und schon vor gut zehn
Jahren fragte die Bürgermeisterin der
unweit gelegenen Inselgemeinde Lampedusa
Frau Nicolini wie groß muss der Friedhof
auf meiner Insel noch werden die Frage
ist bis heute noch nicht beantwortet
worden und sie beschämt uns bis heute
wir werden Ihren Antrag ablehnen
Polat in Richtung der cdu/csu-fraktion
denn deren Antrag ist ja Grundlage
dieser Aussprache dieser Debatte nächste
Rednerin Johanna Kota die bis vor kurzem
noch Mitglied der afd-fraktion war jetzt
als fraktionslose Abgeordnete im
Bundestag sitzt
Junioren fördern die dem Antrag den
deutschen Sonderweg bei der Migration zu
beenden die Einwanderung zu begrenzen
und unsere Grenzen zu schützen nochmal
CDU CSU fordern die Masseneinwanderung
zu stoppen das ist eine kognitive
Dissonanz die ihresgleichen sucht genau
die beiden Parteien die uns die asylt
diese 2015 eingebrockt haben deren
Chefin Tor und Tür aufgemacht haben und
sie alle die das kritisiert haben in die
Nazi-Ecke gesteckt haben genau die
Parteien fordern jetzt die Grenzen zu
kontrollieren absurder geht es nicht
mehr meine Damen und Herren und damit
sind wir beim Kernproblem der Politik in
Deutschland angekommen sie ist nämlich
vollkommen unglaubwürdig geworden nicht
nur bei der Union die so tun als ob sie
16 Jahre lang nicht regiert hätte nein
die FDP verteidigt das Netz die
Wirtschaft an die Wand und sorgt dafür
dass Leistungsträger in diesem Land noch
mehr bezahlen müssen die SPD hat ihr
Klientel längst vergessen die Arbeiter
die nicht mehr wissen wie sie ihre
Nahrung bezahlen sollen und sie ich weiß
nicht warum die Menschen sich immer mehr
von der Politik abwenden warum das Lager
denn Nichtwähler immer größer wird
zuletzt bei fast 50 Prozent den NRW
genau deswegen weil sie Werte Kollegen
alles dafür tun um man da Macht zu
bleiben und dabei den echten Menschen da
draußen vergessen in sogar für dumpf zu
verkaufen und wer es wagt die Politik zu
kritisieren der wird sofort in eine
radikale Ecke gesteckt und notfalls
verkaufen sie für eine Ministerposten
auch ihre Seele das mag ihnen Geld aufs
Konto bringen aber die Bürger die wenden
sich an geekelt ab der Gesellschaft
fehlt das Vertrauen die Werte und den
Zusammenhalt auch weil sie ihnen das
alles nicht mehr Vorleben meine Damen
und Herren es wird höchste Zeit das ist
die Politik wieder ehrlicher Wert den
Menschen da draußen zuhört Politiker
wieder einmal sagen ich stehe zu meinem
Wort ich habe Fehler gemacht Liebe CDU
ich entschuldige mich ich trete zurück
ich mache lieber keine als schlechte
Politik dann vielleicht kann Vertrauen
wieder wachsen und dann kann man solche
Anträge auch wieder ernst nehmen vielen
Dank
das Wort hat Dr an miroschka Jurisch für
die FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen Kollegen
sehr verehrte Damen und Herren
deutschland solle sein
migrationspolitischen Sonderweg beenden
was wollte und was will uns die Union
mit ihrem Antrag sagen wovon redet die
Union
ja von dem migrationspolitischen
Niemandsland das uns Horst Seehofer
hinterlassen hat das ist in den letzten
Jahren seit der großen Migrationswelle
2015 der Union wieder gelungen ist die
von der Union so beklagte irreguläre
Migration zu verringern noch die
dringend erforderliche reguläre
Migration in unseren Arbeitsmarkt
wirklich zu steigern
wir werden diese Situation nun Schritt
für Schritt verbessern wir haben im
Dezember das chancenaufenthaltsgesetz
verabschiedet im Paket mit einer
deutlichen Verschärfung des
Asylverfahrens und asylgerichtsgesetzes
mit Joachim Stamm hat nun der
sonderbeauf Bevollmächtigte der
Bundesregierung für migrationsabkommen
seine Arbeit aufgenommen wir werden als
nächstes dafür sorgen dass das
migrationspolitische Niemandsland dass
die Union bei der erwerbsmigration
hinterlassen hat aufzubauen wir wollen
die besten Köpfe und fleißigsten Hände
in unser Land holen
unsere Mission ist mehr Einwanderung in
unseren Arbeitsmarkt und weniger
irreguläre Migration beim Antrag der
Union haben wir es dagegen mit einer
Scheindebatte zu tun denn zur
Ehrlichkeit in der Migrationsfrage
gehört rund um das Thema Flucht und
Migration gibt es keine einfachen und
schnellen Lösungen und das wissen sie
auch wer was anderes behauptet dessen
Lösungen werden spätestens an der
Realität scheitern fakt ist dass wir in
viele Länder derzeit nicht abschieben
können daran hat im letzten Jahrzehnt
die Union übrigens nichts geändert fakt
ist dass Migration nicht aufhören wird
wir müssen deshalb irreguläre Migration
begrenzen und dafür mehr gezielte
Einwanderung in unseren Arbeitsmarkt
ermöglichen
vor allem fakt ist dass wir Probleme der
irregulären Migration nur europäisch
lösen können und wie sehen solche
europäischen Lösungen aus erstens wir
müssen wir müssen zu einer besseren
Verteilung von geflüchteten innerhalb
Europas kommen dazu müssen
migrationspolitische Entscheidungen
innerhalb der EU künftig mit
qualifizierter Mehrheit gefasst werden
können meine Damen und Herren nur so
kommen wir zu einem gerechten
verteilmechanismus in Europa und ich bin
unserer Innenministerin sehr dankbar
dass sie intensiv auch Gespräche auf
europäischer Ebene führt bis dahin muss
dringend der freiwillige
Verteilungsmechanismus den Frankreich im
letzten Jahr ja angestoßen hat
reaktiviert und ausgebaut werden auch
Kommunen in Deutschland müssen endlich
darüber entlastet werden
zweitens europa muss sein humanitären
und völkerrechtlichen Verpflichtungen an
den Grenzen selbstverständlich und aus
tiefster Überzeugung nachkommt dazu
gehört aber auch Menschen davon
abzuhalten lebensgefährliche Wege in
Richtung Europa zu beschreiten und es
müssen Ihnen Alternativen dazu
aufgezeigt werden und deshalb und
drittens auch auf europäischer Ebene
müssen wir mehr Wege eröffnen regulär in
die EU kommen zu können nämlich als
Einwanderer auch in unseren Arbeitsmarkt
und in Deutschland werden wir es mit
einem Punktesystem nach kanadischen
Vorbild endlich attraktiv machen in
unseren Arbeitsmarkt einzuwandern
meine Damen und Herren der vermeintliche
migrationspolitische Sonderweg ist wenn
ich ein Produkt der Union so doch
zumindest eine Chimäre als Koalition
werden wir unseren Weg Schritt für
Schritt weitergehen mehr Einwanderung in
unseren Arbeitsmarkt ermöglichen ihre
reguläre Migration reduzieren und das
insbesondere auch durch bestmögliche
Kooperation auf europäischer Ebene
vielen herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
das Wort hat der Kollege Alexander Thom
für die cdu/csu-f
Raktion
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Frau Kollegin
Dr Jurisch und mutig sich da
hinzustellen und auf die letzten Jahre
zu verweisen wenn man selbst im Jahr
2022 die höchste Zahl irreguläre
Migration nach Deutschland mit zu
verantworten hat mit über
230.000 Menschen das ist nicht richtig
wenn Sie hier auf die vergangenen Jahre
hinweisen dass die höchste Zahl seit
2016 und ich weiß nicht
ob sie sich erinnern dass ich mich bei
der ersten Lesung dieses Antrags dazu
bekannt habe dass ich erstmals ein Tweet
der Frau Ministerin gelegt habe es war
aber seither auch das einzige Mal sie
hat nämlich getwittert im Oktober wir
sind in der Verantwortung illegale
Einreisen zu stoppen und da hat sie
Recht und insofern war das auch ein
guter Tweet als Vorbereitung auf die
hessische Landtagswahl nur getan hat
sich nichts weil sich nämlich die Zahlen
um 60% seit 2021 erhöht haben und
deswegen nichts getan nur geht wieder
dort und das können wir nicht
akzeptieren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und erste
Politiker in der SPD erkennen ja auch
dass wir hier einen irreweg haben
vermisse den Kollegen castellucci als
Ihnen als migrationspolitischen Sprecher
der SPD heute der Jan fünf Punkte Plan
Papier vorgelegt wo er unter anderem
fordert das der
eu-solidaritätsmechanismus ausgesetzt
werden soll das da hat Recht in der
Sache das haben wir auch gefordert
das Problem ist nur das soll ja das
große Meisterstück der Frau
Innenministerin gewesen sei dieser
solidaritätsmechanismus ein historischer
Durchbruch tatsächlich sind 255 Menschen
verteilt worden davon 2005 von
Deutschland 85 % und das zeigt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Ampel das
Deutschland mit seinen Versuchen auf
europäischer Ebene tatsächlich isoliert
ist und deswegen in der Tat ja ein
migrationspolitischer Sonderweg auf
europäische Ebene seitens der
Ampelkoalition begangen wird liebe
Kollegen
ich kann ihnen auch belegen
alle anderen europäischen Staaten außer
Deutschland und vielleicht noch
Luxemburg begrenzen mit nationalen
Maßnahmen zu weit das möglich ist
illegale Migration die anderen Staaten
haben vor dem EU-Rat darauf gedrängt
dass wir einen visahebel machen dass wir
Infrastruktur an der Grenze
mitfinanzieren seitens der EU und das
sichere Herkunftsstaaten auf
europäischer Ebene noch mehr
ausgeweitet werden alles Punkte von dem
die Bundesregierung nichts wissen will
insbesondere die Grünen jetzt hat der
Bundeskanzler in einer Nachtaktion
dazugestimmt unter Druck der anderen
europäischen Staaten wir werden bei
ihnen einfordern dass sie die Beschlüsse
des EU-Rat vom 9.2 auch tatsächlich hier
mittragen und auch europäischer Ebene
unterstützen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ich will noch
ich will noch mit der neuen großen
Erzählung der Linken aufräumen es gäbe
keine wissenschaftliche Belege für gull-
oder
push-faktore nicht nur der Linken nein
das sagen ja auch der Kollege Demir von
der SPD von den Grünen habe ich es auch
schon gehört Herr Kollege Hauptmann sie
brauchen sich nicht nur auf die
Linkspartei umschauen das ist auch bei
ihnen in der Partei entsprechende
Programmatik ich verweise auf den
Bericht der Vorgängerorganisation der
europäischen asylagentur aus dem Jahr
2016 der Push & Co factors Office im
related Migration das ist eine Lektüre
die ich allen Kollegen und Kollegen der
Ampel Koalition dringend und der Linken
natürlich dringend zur Lektüre an dem
Fehler dann werden Sie sehen dass sie
mit ihrer Politik eines
paradigmenwechselt den sie neue
derartige Anreize setzen Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht ist genannt und vieles
andere mehr dass sie da ganz genau dafür
sorgen dass wir zusätzlich
Migrationsströme ja auch gefährliche
Frau Kolle ginoland damit nach Europa
und insbesondere nach Deutschland
ansehen herzlichen Dank
Alexander drum war das für die
CDU-Fraktion
hier in dieser Aussprache
und jetzt kommt wieder ein
fraktionsloser Abgeordnete das ist
Matthias Helferich mittlerweile ja hier
im Bundestag sechs fraktionslose
Abgeordnete frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren im vergangenen
Jahr diskutierten wir über die
Flutkatastrophe in NRW und
Rheinland-Pfalz da ich es gewagt hatte
anzumerken dass rund 90 Prozent der
Tatverdächtigen Plünderer die das Leid
der Flutopfer für die liebeswerk
missbrauchten Ausländer waren wurde ich
mit einem Ordnungsruf gemäß regelt der
SPD-Kollege Hartmann beschimpfte mich
als unverantwortlichen Hetzer und
Spalter CSU innenpolitikerin Wittmann
schämte sich für mich da ich die
Wahrheit ausgesprochen hatte fassen wir
einmal kurz zusammen was über die
mehrheitlich nicht deutschen Plünderer
Wissen 632 Eigentumsdelikte trafen die
Opfer der Flut 275 am Mitte der
Tatverdächtige
196 davon fremde Ausländer immerhin kam
es zu 48 Verurteilung aber
selbstverständlich keine einzigen
Abschiebung und in ihrem heutigen Antrag
ist es wie mit der Aussage ihres
CDU-Vize aus NRW Golland der vollmundig
und schneidig im Fokus forderte wer so
handelt gehört hart bestraft und hat
sein Gastrecht verwirrt das was sie
liebe cdu/csu betreiben ist konservative
Mimikry sie gebärden sich in ihrem
aktuellen migrationspolitischen Antrag
geheilt und tragen doch weiterhin die
migrationssucht in sich denn überall wo
sie regieren tragen Sie die suizidale
massenmigrationspolitik der anderen
linken Parteien mit und so wird mir
Angst und Bange wenn sie fordern dass
die migrationslage in der
Bundesregierung endlich Chefsache werden
müssen uns allen graut noch vor der Zeit
als die Migrationspolitik unter der CDU
Chefinnen Sache war wenn sie es ihr mit
ihrem Antrag ernst meinen Schweißen sie
erstmal in NRW wo sie in Verantwortung
sind die migrantischen Langfinger raus
die die Flut Opfer beklauten dann
starten Sie unter ihrem
Ministerpräsidenten Hendrik wüst eine
rückführungs Offensive für die rund 200
islamistischen gefährdern NRW dann
beginnen sie endlich die Massenmigration
nach Deutschland nicht äußere mystisch
als liberal zu verharmlosen sondern
bezeichnen sie die Massen Migration als
das was sie ist selbstmörderisch und
immer wieder häufiger tödlich vielen
Dank
Zwischenruf geht weiterhin
wir fahren in der Zwischenrufe gab es
hier während der Rede die kann man
tatsächlich hier auch innerhalb des
plenars als auch bzw hier in der
Sprecherkabine sehr schlecht verstehen
aber der nächste Redner dem gilt jetzt
hier die Aufmerksamkeit ist mehr mit Ali
für die SPD
wissen Sie ich bin ja Sozialpolitiker
und ich habe immer so gedacht
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus der
Union die Sozialpolitiker aus der Union
die haben Langeweile aber wenn ich mir
den Antrag zur der Innenpolitiker der
Union lese die haben ordentlich
Langeweile meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren die Union waren vor einem
vermeintlichen ihr Weg der
Bundesregierung in Sachen Einwanderung
wirklich ist hierbei das durchhaltende
Rechtsabbiegen sie haben offenkundig den
Kompass verloren für sie geht es seit
einer Weile schon nur noch nach rechts
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie
machen den Menschen Angst mit wild
durcheinander gewürfelten pull-effekten
einem Ansatz der übrigens in der
Migrationsforschung längst überholt ist
das wissen Sie auch über die
rückführungsoffensive haben auch schon
ein paar meiner Vorrednerin und
Vorredner gesprochen und sie wissen ganz
genau dass die logistischen Hürden und
auch die rechtlichen Hirten hier sehr
sehr schwierig sind
und wenn man sich das dann noch mal
alles genauer vergegenwärtigen lässt
kann ich mir durchaus auch vorstellen
wie so ein
Abend bei der Union zu Hause aussieht da
sitzt man vor der Tagesschau guckt um
die um die Wände herum und denkt sich
naja welche Probleme können wir denn
heute mal ansprechen und wenn uns keine
Probleme einfallen wenn nichts mehr geht
gegen Migranten geht es immer das ist
das Motto inzwischen bei der Uni und
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
in meinem Wahlkreis sprechen ihre Leute
schon ganz alle AFD von Einwanderung in
die Sozialsysteme mit solchen
populistischen Unsinn heißen sie die
Debatten fahrlässig an sie erhöhen
bewusst den medialen Druck auf die
ohnehin überlasteten Kommunen zu deren
Anwälten sie sich plötzlich erklären
damit nehmen sie Hetze und Anfeindung
gegen kommunale Mandatsträgerinnen und
Politikern billigend in Kauf
wohin das führt und was das mit dieser
Gesellschaft macht muss ich in den
letzten zwei Wochen in meinem eigenen
Wahlkreis erleben lieber Thomas ja nicht
unweit von deinem Wahlkreis entfernt in
Lörrach nur wenige Schritte von meinem
Wahlkreisbüro entfernt steht ein alter
Wohnblock
vor wenigen Wochen haben die rund 40
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner der
Wohnanlage ein Angebot der städtischen
Wohnbaugesellschaft erhalten zum
ähnlichen und gleichen Mietpreisen in
den städtischen Neubau einzuziehen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren lassen
Sie einfach meinen Wahlkreis in dieser
Angelegenheit in Ruhe es werden hier
Desinformationskampagnen aus seitens
rechts und auf seitens der Union medial
aber auch vor Ort Betrieben fakt ist
dass die städtische Wohnbaugesellschaft
nicht anderes gemacht hat als leider
einen Kommunikationsfehler
herbeizuführen dass nicht alle
Informationen beinhaltet keine der
Mieterinnen und Mieter wird gezwungen
werden umzuziehen es wird Ihnen Angebote
gemacht dass sie in bessere Neubauten
reinkommen können in barrierefreie
Wohnbauten reinkommen können und die AFD
macht nichts anderes als letztes
Wochenende am Samstag natürlich zu
mobilisieren was passiert vor Ort der
Kollege Thomas Seitz und der
Kreisverband der AFD in lör einfach
meinen dann eine Kundgebung in Lörrach
auf dieserselben Straße durchzuführen
mit lediglich 30 40 Leuten die man aus
der gesamten Bundesrepublik mobilisieren
muss weil man ja sonst keine
Unterstützung vor Ort erfährt meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
letztendlich muss man auch sagen dass
auch nicht nur die Mieterinnen und
Mieter dieses nachgeschmeckte erfahren
mussten was es bedeutet wenn Rechte vor
der Tür sich anhäufen sondern auch die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus dem
Kreisverband Lörrach der Grünen vor
ihrem Büro wo haben vermummte identitäre
ein Protest abgehalten mit den Satz wir
haben Platz aber nicht für deutsche das
Büro wurde auch noch angegriffen das ist
respektlos dafür muss man sich schämen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren und
sie was sie machen ist einzig allein
Rechtspopulismus das ist der
Rechtsradikalismus pur und ich frage
mich warum immer identitäre da sind wo
sie vorher eine Kundgebung gemacht haben
die Verbindung ist hier eindeutig und
ganz klar meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren und noch und noch zum Schluss
möchte ich noch eindeutig was loswerden
es gibt den Künstler nur Phönix er hat
das Lied Baba darin ich zitiere ich hole
das Cash für Mama und kaufe einen Benz
für Papa jetzt könnte man sagen
das ist Ghetto Musik aber wissen Sie was
das ist migrationspolitisch dieser Satz
so wichtig
darin beschreibt er nichts anderes als
die Generation nämlich meine Generation
das geschafft hat was wir uns schon
lange gewünscht haben dass unsere Eltern
hier in Deutschland angekommen sind dass
wir auch und uns um unsere Eltern
kümmern möchten und das auch so weit
sind und auch einen deutschen Bands
fahren können das ist der Aufstieg
meiner Generation damit beweisen wir das
und ich sage auch in Richtung Thomas dir
ich lade Dich gerne dein Wahlkreis ist
ja nicht so weit weg von mir nach
Mülheim an wir gehen mal zusammen ins
Team und auch mal gemeinsam eine Shisha
und essen dabei eine Baklava und dann
reden wir über Migrationspolitik vielen
Dank
ja das Angebot hier von Taxis mehr mit
Ali
in Richtung jetzt Fraktion
und deshalb letzte Wort hier hat noch
mal ein Redner der Unionsfraktion der
hier auch diese Debatte beantragt haben
Detlef wird das sein
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine Damen und Herren
im vergangenen Jahr sind über eine
Millionen Ukrainer zu uns gekommen den
wir Schutz gewähren zusätzlich über
200.000 weitere Drittstaatsangehörige
die einen Asylantrag oder Antrag auf
internationalen Schutz stellen
seit November letzten Jahres rund 30.000
Personen die ein Asylantrag stellen
hochgerechnet würde das bedeuten rund
360.000 in diesem Jahr
das überfordert unser Land und ich
wundere mich in der Debatte niemand von
ihnen hat das Wort Überforderung
Belastung
Hilferufe aus den Kommunen auch nur im
Ansatz in den Wort genommen ist
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar meine
Damen und Herren
und was ich ihnen nicht vorwerfe ist
dieser hohe Migrationsdruck in der Welt
der sich natürlich bei uns bemerkbar
macht was ich Ihnen aber vorwerfe ist
dass sie in dieser Situation die
falschen Weichen stellen und ich sage an
dieser Stelle auch Sie haben eine
falsche und für unser Land sehr
gefährliche Grundeinstellung
Rebecca Harms eine von den Grünen die
eine Neuausrichtung in der Asylpolitik
verlangen bringt es auf den Punkt wenn
sie davon spricht dass es bei Ihnen
einen Unwillen gibt sich zur Kontrolle
der Zuwanderung auch nur im Ansatz zu
bekennen wir brauchen Schutz
internationalen Schutz auf der einen
Seite aber auch Kontrolle
Sicherheitssteuerung und Ordnung das
gehört zusammen
und sie betreiben eine Politik der
offenen Türe und dem keine Rücksicht auf
deutsche Sicherheitsinteressen bei der
Zuwanderung der Menschen aus der Ukraine
hat die Union von Anfang an gefordert
ich kann mich erinnern wir haben immer
wieder nachgefragt wie sieht das aus mit
der Verteilung das muss doch gerecht
sein innerhalb der Europäischen Union es
kann doch nicht sein dass Menschen die
in einem anderen Mitgliedstaat schon
Schutz erhalten haben zu uns kommen und
hier wieder aufgenommen werden das war
überhaupt kein Thema aber ich glaube die
Innenministerin erkennt das langsam und
hat sich dieses Problems angenommen
die ampelregierung hat eine Koalition
der aufnahmewilligen auf den Weg
gebracht wir haben schon drüber
gesprochen wir sollen wieder die
Hauptlasten tragen sie geben
identitätsdeutschland durch das Chancen
Aufenthaltsgesetz ein Aufenthaltsrecht
sie wollen ermöglichen dass
Asylantragsteller alleine durch ihre
eidesstattliche Versicherung ihre
Identität belegen können sie haben keine
Personaldokumente dabei sie nehmen in
der aktuellen schwierigen Situation in
Kauf Das tausend Afghanen pro Monat
insgesamt 40.000 im Rahmen eines
aufnahmeprogramms zu uns kommen und die
Krux und die Krönung der Sache ist es
werden wieder neue ortskräfte
eingestellt der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland in Afghanistan erklären sie
das mal irgendwie jemand anders
gestatten Sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung
der Kolleginnen ich habe die Uhr
angehalten ja wie letztes mal gerne
Herr Kollege sagt weil sie hier davon
sprechen dass die Menschen irregulär
einreisen aus Afghanistan oder anderen
Ländern was sagen sie eigentlich dazu
dass die Anerkennungsquote also die
schutzquote die bereinigte schutzquoten
von Menschen die nach Deutschland kommen
und Schutz suchen bei über 70% liegt ich
frage sie wie können sie ständig von
illegaler Migration sprechen wenn die
überwiegende Mehrheit hier in
Deutschland einen Schutzanspruch
bekommen
also ich werde meine Rede noch mal
durchlesen aber ich meine den Begriff
habe ich jetzt bei dieser Rede nicht
verwendet aber
70 Prozent verrechnen kann ich nehme
jetzt ihre Zahl 30 Prozent haben keinen
Schutzanspruch 30 Prozent von über
200.000 Menschen Macht über 60.000
Menschen pro Jahr und wir haben eine
Migrationspolitik die ist gerade zu
gestattet und erlaubt durch pull-effekte
hier hinzukommen und ich will ihn an
dieser Stelle eins sagen weil das auch
vorhin mitgeteilt wurde die toten
Menschen Mittelmeer wo ist denn
eigentlich die Ursache die Ursache ist
doch dass es Schlepper Organisationen
gibt das ist NGOs gibt dass man Aussicht
hat in die Europäische Union zu kommen
was wir brauchen ist eine Organisation
der Seenotrettung und sichere Häfen im
Bereich Nordafrika wir wissen bei Libyen
gibt es Problem e wenn Sie das Problem
reingehen wollen hier wird illegal
irregulär gegen Völkerrecht werden die
Menschen aufgenommen sie müssen den
nächsten sicheren Hafen anlaufen und die
müssen wir einrichten und dann werden
wir auch dieses sterben was uns alle
betroffen macht vermeiden können in der
Zukunft
so und ich habe nur ein paar Punkte
aufgelistet aber sie wollen den bei den
subsidiär schutzberechtigten demnächst
wollen sie auch den Familiennachzug
unbegrenzter öffnen wir werden es
wahrscheinlich auch hier mit einer
dreistelligen Zahl im Tausender Bereich
zu tun haben
sie wollen ein sogenanntes
fachkräftezuwanderungsgesetz auf den Weg
bringen das aber wir haben es studiert
nur geringe Anforderungen auch
tatsächlich an die Arbeitswelt stellt
und an die Kenntnisse und Fähigkeiten
und sie verwechseln Migration
Zuwanderung im Rahmen des Asyls und
Fachkräfte Zuwanderung und auch da liegt
ein großer Fehler das Politik Magazin
Cicero hat den Fall Mohammad gehen
aufgedeckt hier hat das Auswärtige Amt
die Auslandsvertretung trotz eines
nachweislich gefälschten Passes
angewiesen ein Visum zu erteilen welcher
Fall sollen noch deutlicher vor Augen
führen dass für die Ampel
Sicherheitsinteressen unseres Landes
zweitrangig sind sie haben ein falsches
mindset und meine Damen und Herren wir
schaffen das nicht es sei denn
sie ändern radikal ihre Ansätze in der
Migrationspolitik vielen Dank
Detlef Seif war das für die CDU Ziel zu
Fraktion hier der diese Debatte
sozusagen jetzt zugemacht hat der letzte
Redner und auch bei seinem Redebeitrag
ist nochmal deutlich geworden also hier
sind die Meinungen im Haus die gehen
doch sehr weit auseinander die Union hat
ihre Vorstellung noch mal in einem
Antrag formuliert und darüber wird jetzt
abgestimmt empfiehlt in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache
5599 den Antrag der Fraktionen der
cdu/csu auf Drucksache
3933 abzunehmen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen
[Musik]
danke wer enthält sich die
Beschlussempfehlung des mit den Stimmen
der
Koalitionsfraktionen und der Fraktion
DIE LINKE gegen die Stimmen der
cdu/csu-fraktion und der afd-fraktion
angenommen so das heißt dann im
Umkehrschluss dass der Antrag abgelehnt
wurde das hat sich ja in der Debatte
schon angedeutet also hier die
ampelfraktion auch die linke Fraktion
hat diesem Antrag der Union nicht
zugestimmt wir kommen zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt und der knüpft noch
mal an an den heutigen Vormittag hier im
Bundestag da gab es ja eine
Regierungserklärung von Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz zu einem Jahr Zeiten wenn
die in seiner Regierungserklärung hat
der Bundeskanzler noch mal deutsche
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
verteidigt und Forderungen nach einem
schnellen Friedensverhandlungen einer
Absage erteilt mit der Waffe an der
Schläfe ließe sich nicht verhandeln so
hat der Bundeskanzler heute morgen
gesagt außer über die eigene
Unterwerfung und er sagte weiter es
könnte keinen Friedensschluss über die
Köpfe der Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine
hinweggeben in diesem Tagesordnungspunkt
jetzt der auf Antrag der Linksfraktion
hier aufgesetzt wird fordert DIE LINKE
an sofortigen Waffenstillstand und eine
diplomatische Initiative für
anschließende friedensverhandlung es
spricht als erster gregorie
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen über ein Jahr
müssen wir nun den völkerrechtsspiegel
in Krieg der Russischen Föderation gegen
die Ukraine miterleben
bei dem völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg der
NATO gegen Serbien und bei der
völkerrechtsführerin Lostrennung des
Kosovo habe ich im Gespräch mit
damaligen Regierungsmitgliedern gewarnt
dass dies Schule machen können was
leider eingetreten ist ich weiß dass vor
diesem Krieg vom Westen vieles falsch
gemacht wurde und die Ukraine mindest
zwei Verletzte das don' was Gebiet wurde
nicht autonom innerhalb der Ukraine
außerdem war das damalige Verbot der
russischen Sprache ebenso falsch
all dies rechtfertigt aber niemals einen
völkerrechtsverjährigen Angriffskrieg
wir erleben Kriegsverbrecher
insbesondere von russischer Seite Folter
Tötung von Zivilisten
Vergewaltigung es muss ein
völkerrechtlicher Weg gefunden werden
Schuldige bei allen Kriegen zur
Verantwortung zu ziehen
unsere Solidarität gehört der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung
im Unterschied zu anderen hier war ich
nicht zu einer Stippvisite in der
Ukraine sondern zusammen mit Professor
Trabert dort mehrere Tage wir haben
medizinische Geräte und Spenden
übergeben der Bürgermeister eines
Vorortes von Kiew für die Zerstörungen
beseitigen und bat um einen kleinen Bus
ein Traktor und eine betonmaschine
Mischmaschine meine entsprechende Bitte
an dem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck wurde
Geld verpennt per Panzer ja für eine
Betonmischmaschine nein mit Hilfe des
sächsischen
CDU-Ministerpräsidenten Kretschmann ist
es gelungen mit einer
Städtepartnerschaft die bitten zu
realisieren das Verhalten der
Bundesregierung finde ich in diskutabel
die Frage wie dieser Krieg das Grauen
beendet werden kann treibt unsere ganze
Bevölkerung um
es gibt in Kern zwei unterschiedliche
Antworten wenn wir eine tiefe Spaltung
unserer Gesellschaft verhindern wollen
sollten wir respektieren dass die einen
wie die anderen
Frieden zwischen Russland und der
Ukraine wollen
die einen glauben mittels
Waffenlieferungen das
Selbstverteidigungsrecht der Ukraine zu
stärken und einen gerechteren Frieden zu
erreichen wir die das anders sehen
dürfen sie nicht als Kriegstreiber oder
ähnliches sehen und beleidigen
diejenigen die wie wir
unverzüglich ein Waffenstillstand wollen
möchten das Töten verletzen die
Zerstörungen sofort beenden deshalb ist
es ebenso falsch uns als Putin Knechte
zu bezahlen
wir haben inzwischen einstellungskrieg
der BND-Präsident wie es daraufhin das
Russland noch bis zu einer Million
Soldaten rekrutieren können die Ukraine
hat eine solche weitgehende Möglichkeit
nicht
Jürgen habermaß erklärte dass die NATO
bisher ihr Ziel nicht definiert habe er
schrieb weiter das ist ein Unterschied
gebe ob ein Land Siegen müsse oder ob es
nicht verlieren dürfen interessant
mir wird entgegnet das Putin zu einem
Waffenstillstand nicht bereit sein was
halten sie von folgender Idee mit
Einverständnis der ukrainischen Führung
könnte die NATO doch erklären dass sie
jetzt keine einzige Waffe mehr an die
Ukraine lieferte wenn die russische
Führung einem Waffenstillstand zustimmte
das setzte sie beachtlich unter Druck
das Ergebnis dann von
Friedensverhandlungen muss eine auch vom
Besten gesicherte Ukraine sein wir
müssen einen Weg finden wie wir zu
Deeskalation Abrüstung
Interessenausgleich viel mehr Diplomatie
und strikter Wahrung des Völkerrechts
durch alle Seiten zurückkehren können
die Regierung muss aufhören wegen der
Kosten im Zusammenhang mit dem Krieg und
den Flüchtlingen Sozialleistungen in
Frage zu stellen eine solche Aufrechnung
für Nachteil gerade der ärmeren Teile
unserer Bevölkerung ist durch
zurechtfertigen die Inflation die
Teuerung der Lebensmittel liegen die
unerträglichen Preise für Heizung und
Strom müssen wirksam bekämpft werden
letztlich wenn gleich fertig es gibt
auch die völkerrechtswürdigen Kriege des
nato-mitglieds Türkei gegen Syrien und
Irak speziell gegen die kodeln und
Kurden die uns alle im Kampf gegen den
islamischen Staat unterstützt hat es
gibt seit Jahren ein furchtbaren Krieg
im Jemen mit unvorstellbaren Leid
dahinter stehen der Iran und
Saudi-Arabien wenn wir glaubwürdig sein
wollen müssen wir diese kriegen
ebenfalls scharf verurteilen
ich hoffe dass unsere
öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien endlich
einmal Bilder von diesen Kriegen zeigen
damit sich humane solidarische Gefühle
in unserer Bevölkerung entwickeln können
das ist das Beste für die Ukraine mehr
Waffen zur Gegenwehr und die Fortführung
des Kriegs oder ein Stopp der
Waffenlieferung aus dem Westen und
Verhandlungen mit Russland für beide
Wege gab es beispielsweise am
vergangenen Wochenende Demonstration
eine große Demonstration am Samstag zur
Unterstützung der Ukraine am
Freitagabend und am Samstag die Gegner
weiterer Waffenlieferungen unter anderem
ja initiiert von der Linken Politikerin
Sarah Wagenknecht von der Linken Spitze
gab es davorwürfe Sahra Wagenknecht
Grenze sich nicht nach rechts ab also
die Debatte innerhalb der Linken wie man
sich positioniert ist durchaus teilweise
sehr scharf geführt in nächster Redner
jetzt für die SPD Ralf steht ne richtig
entscheidend und mehr noch der
Unterschied zwischen Wort und Tat
zwischen der schlussversion Ihres
Antrags und im öffentlichen Auftritt des
Demo dahinten nicht schwarzer ist gerade
zu Erschreckens
seit über einem Jahr suchen wir nach
wegen ihrer endlich Frieden in Europa
kriegen können Leid und Tod zerstören
russische kriegsverbrechende kokaine den
ungebrochen weiter trotzdem zwischen
100.000 Tote ist noch immer kein Ende in
Sicht das entsetzlich und jeder neue
Kriegstag bedrücken gerade deshalb fehlt
mir wirklich jedes Verständnis mit
welcher Kälte ihre Fraktionskollegen
waren nicht im Fernsehen das
unglaubliche Leitung
und Vergewaltigung durch russische
Soldaten kommentiert
die glatte politrhetorik zum Krieg vor
unserer Haustür und die pr-getriebene
Selbstverliebtheit der Demoleitung
beschädigen maximal die glaubwürdigung
von friedenspapellen hier im Bundestag
das ist keine linke Friedenspolitik
meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Antrag fordert Diplomatie statt Panzer
das ist mir wirklich nicht unsympathisch
auch gegen eine verhandlungsinitiative
zu Beendigung des Krieges kann man wenig
einwenden solange Putins versucht die
Grenzen mit Gewalt zu verschieben nicht
belohnt wird ich freue mich über uns
auch darüber wenn Menschen für Frieden
demonstrieren hat er selbst oft genug
getan halt auch nichts von der
pauschalen Diffamierung von
Demonstranten intellektuellen und
Unterstützern diverse Aufrufe auch wenn
ich die Auffassung nicht Teile und
manche Formulierung überhaupt nicht
Teile was aber gar nicht geht ist hier
Anträge für Friedensverhandlungen zu
stellen und gleichzeitig gemeinsam mit
Rechtsextremisten auf die Straße zu
gehen ohne
dass sie distanziert ich habe bei der
Debatte zu dem scheinheiligen aktiv
friedensantrag hier betont dass sie den
rechten Knie und Frieden sondern immer
um die Unterstützung des russischen
Diktators geht meine lieben Kollegen sie
müssen sich schon entscheiden wer sich
nicht klar von Rechtsextremisten an
diese mieten und reichsbürgern hat keins
und jede und ich meine wirklich jede
Form der Zusammenarbeit verweigert der
steht nicht glaube Frieden und er steht
auch nicht links und die Erklärung von
Sahra Wagenknecht ihr Mann der nun
wirklich keinen Politik Neuling ist man
machen keine Gesinnungsprüfung bei dem
was ist eine intellektuelle Beleidigung
eine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren mit
Rechten demokratiefein macht man niemals
nirgendwon aus keinem anders gemeinsam
und da muss man sich schon fragen warum
der Neonazi Björn höcke ihre damalige
Fraktionsvorsitzende zum einen in seiner
afd-truppe auffordert was wollen sie
sich eigentlich noch alles gefallen
lassen wollen sie warten bis eine Liste
Wagenknecht rechts auf noch Stimmenfang
geht ich diskutiere gerne mit Ihnen über
progressive außenfriedenspolitik die die
europäische Friedensordnung wieder
herstellt wir brauchen keine
Konjunkturprogramme für
Rüstungsindustrie wir brauchen noch
keine Kriegswirtschaft da sind wir uns
einig was sie aber brauchen ist eine
moderne und gut ausgestattete
parlamentserfahrung Armee die fähig ist
ihre Bündnisverpflichtung Aufgaben der
Landesverteidigung zu erfüllen deshalb
und nicht
ausrüstungsgründen haben wir den
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr von
100 Milliarden Euro zugestimmt wir
werden ihrem Antrag nicht zustimmen weil
manches fehlt und anders einfach falsch
ist der Vorwürfe würden ausschließlich
auf militärische Mittel setzen und die
Fortsetzung des Krieges stabilisieren
mögen Sie bitte an die richten die sich
in der Öffentlichkeit mit denen setze
ich mich auch auseinanderbringen für den
Bundeskanzler für die Bundesregierung
für die sozialdemokratische
Bundestagsfraktion geht das Gegenteil
die Bürger und Bürger können sich darauf
verlassen wir unterstützen die Ukraine
über ihre Selbstverteidigung politisch
ökonomisch humanitär und auch
militärischer lange es notwendig ist und
wir werden mit Deutschland und der NATO
definitiv keine Kriegsteilnehmer und wir
handeln stets gemeinsam mit unserem
Verbündeten in Washington und Paris wir
unterstützen jede seriöse diplomatische
Anstrengung für Frieden ihre
Aufforderung an die Bundesregierung
Bedarf ist wirklich nicht
zusammengefasst ihre Worte höre ich wohl
allein mir fehlt der Glaube dass die
gesamte Linke bereit ist diesen Krieg
als das zu beschreiben was er ist ein
illegaler verbrecherischer und
imperialistischer Raubzug Russland gegen
Ukraine lassen Sie das
anti-amerikanische Geraune das ist von
rechts genauso unsympathisch wie von
links es gibt genau einen der für den
Krieg Verantwortlichen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
bringen
ihre rechte Flanke lassen Sie uns gerne
weiter konstruktiv über modernen Dinge
Friedenspolitik streiten das ist aber
nicht wenn man auch von Täter
durcheinander bringt das ist nicht wenn
man Menschen verweigert sich zu werden
das ist schon gar nicht wenn man kein
Mitgefühl hat für die die dann auch dazu
leiden haben und das ist der Teil der
uns bewegen muss dafür zu sorgen dafür
zu sorgen dass wir dahin kommen und sie
wissen sehr genau dass sie mich mit den
kritisch auseinandersetzen nur die
militärische Dimension sehen
international herstellen das geht aber
nur wenn man sich ehrlich macht wenn man
nicht mit zwei Maßstäben lässt und schon
gleich gar nicht wenn man mit Demokratie
verändern irgendwas zusammen machen
war das für die SPD und wenn wir in die
Reihen der Linken schauen da sitzen der
Fraktionsvorsitzende Bartsch und die
Parteichefin Janine Wissler Sahra
Wagenknecht die wahrscheinlich immer
wieder auch Gegenstand in dieser Debatte
sein wird mit ihrer Demonstration am
Samstag die ist nicht hier im Plenarsaal
zur Regierungserklärung des
Bundeskanzlers heute hat schon gezeigt
dass die Fraktion in der Mitte dieses
Hauses eng zusammenstehen in ihrer
Solidarität an der Seite des
ukrainischen Volkes und ich kenne mich
den Worten des Kollegen Stegner nur
anschließen und auch dem was der
Bundeskanzler man Fraktionsvorsitz heute
morgen gesagt haben das ist ein
verbrecherischer Krieg den Präsident
Putin
angezettelt hat den er allein zu
verantworten hat und Herr Kollege Gisi
was an ihrer Unterscheidung an und oder
an ihrem daneben stellen der zwei von
Ihnen definierten Gruppen hier in
Deutschland so Fleisch ist dass sie
nämlich so tun als sei das sozusagen
gleichberechtigt in seinem moralischen
Anspruch hier gibt es eine Seite die hat
angegriffen und hier gibt es eine andere
Seite und das ist die ukrainische Seite
und die hat jedes moralische übrigens
auch völkerrechtliche Argument sich zu
verteidigen und das ist die Seite an die
wir als Deutsche gehören und glaube es
ist von entscheidender Bedeutung
dass wir hier Unterschiede nicht
verwischen dass wir Verantwortlichkeiten
benennen und dass wir Maßstäbe einhalten
die wir dann in der Tat auch anderswo
auf der Welt anwenden und das was sie im
Ergebnis hier machen ist dass sie das
narrativ Putins bedienen und in der Tat
ist ja auffällig gewesen dass der
Beifall von der afd-fraktion für ihre
Rede mindestens genauso groß gewesen ist
wieder Beifall den sie aus den eigenen
Reihen bekommen haben darüber sollten
Sie Nachdenken darüber sollten Sie
nachdenken wenn ich glaube wir haben
eine
gemeinsame wir haben eine gemeinsame
Verantwortung
hier die demokratische Mitte und
übrigens die parlamentarische Mitte und
den Parlamentarismus aufrecht zu
erhalten und ich will das jetzt an
dieser Stelle mal sagen die Art und
Weise wie die Kollegin Wagenknecht
dieses Parlament den sie angehört und
für die Zugehörigkeit ja Diäten bezieht
missachtet indem sie in keinem Ausschuss
Mitglied ist
reihenweise an Abstimmungen auch
namentlichen Abstimmung nicht teilnimmt
und auch heute an diesem parlamentstag
es nicht für nötig hält auch nur eine
Sekunde in diesem Haus zu verbringen ist
eine Missachtung des Parlamentarismus
ist eine Missachtung des
Parlamentarismus der nicht akzeptabel
ist liebe Kolleginnen
und
da hat ein kluger Journalist in den
letzten Tagen einen Kommentar
geschrieben der deutlich gemacht hat
dass das am Kern Demokratie
Feindlichkeit ist was Frau Wagenknecht
zum Ausdruck bringt und ich schließe
mich dem an
weil völlig abgesehen von den
antisemitischen Einsprengungen die
außerordentlich unappetitlich sind die
das zusätzlich hat und deswegen ich bin
mache mich nicht wieder Kollege
stinkender sozusagen hier zu formulieren
was gute linke Politik ist da wäre ich
mit Sicherheit der falsche
an der Stelle wäre vielleicht sogar der
Kollege Stegner der richtige aber ich
muss schon sagen wir müssen und ich
glaube wir haben eine gemeinsame
Verantwortung in diesem Hause darauf
aufmerksam zu sein das nicht Dinge
wieder passieren die in diesem Land zu
unseligen Zeiten die Grundlage dafür
gelegt haben dass Nationalsozialisten in
diesem Land die Macht übernommen haben
und das heißt dass wir den ich würde
gerne fortführen frau Präsidentin das
heißt dass wir den
Kern des dessen aber bei allen
parteipolitischen Streit was sachlicher
Auseinandersetzung aber was auch Achtung
von Institutionen was Achtung von
grundlegenden Regeln unseres
demokratischen Gemeinwesens angeht dass
wir das gemeinsam einhalten und das
stelle ich fest hier verwischen die
Grenzen und dabei ist schon weniger noch
die Gefahr dass hier ein
Hufeisen sich
sondern insgesamt
dass hier eine Gruppe von Politikern von
ganz links und von ganz rechts Einfluss
gewinnt auf eine leidersteigende Zahl
von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern in unserem
Land die von unserem demokratischen
Gemeinwesen sich wegbewegen und dem
müssen wir uns alle entschlossen
entgegenstellen entgegenstellen
[Applaus]
wollen und habe ja noch ein paar
Präsidentin lassen wollen
abschließend einfach folgendes sagen es
kommt ja in dem Aufruf auch zum Ausdruck
da wird er die Behauptung aufgestellt
Russland sei atomar bewacht und man
könnte einen Krieg deswegen nicht
verantwortungsvoll gewinnen oder
weiterführen erstens ist das falsch weil
die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika und
vietnamen und die frühere so wird Union
in Afghanistan eine andere Erfahrung
gemacht haben aber meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren das perverse an dieser
Überlegung ist und ich finde das dürfen
wir nicht vergessen auch für die Zukunft
die Ukraine
die eigenen Atomwaffen dem Land dass sie
jetzt überfällt in dem Vertrauen in die
Hand gegeben dass die Souveränität
gewahrt wird und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wenn wir nicht wollen
dass der Iran und das Nordkorea daraus
die falschen Schlüsse ziehen dann müssen
wir gerade gegenüber Russland an der
Stelle eine besondere Härte und nicht
gerade eine besondere Weichheit
zum Ausdruck bringen denn die Verletzung
dieser besonderen souveränitätsgarantie
die die Ukraine empfangen hat um den
Preis der Abgabe von Atomwaffen darf
nicht dazu führen dass die Souveränität
gerade verletzt wird sondern dass sie
extra beschützt wird und deswegen
verpflichtet uns das in besonderem Maße
der Ukraine zur Seite zu stehen vielen
Dank
ja während der rede hier von Johann war
voll für die Union gab es auch
verschiedenste Handzeichen Antrag auf
Zwischenfragen jetzt hören wir mal die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin
habe selber dran Herrn Vahle lasse ich
zu und weise Sie darauf hin dass
Kurzintervention eine besondere
Begrenzung unterliegen was die Zeit des
zeitlicher Ausmaß angeht mit Robert
Vahle als fraktionsloser darf jetzt also
eine Kurzintervention machen Präsidentin
nur ganz kurz erstens die Kritik was die
Arbeit im Parlament anbelangt dass man
hier nicht kommt
das ist das was ich auch für richtig
finde wenn ich in der Öffentlichkeit für
die Friedenspolitik eintrete dann muss
ich auch den Respekt vor dem Parlament
mitbringen hier zu erscheinen und mit zu
diskutieren das teile ich aber ich hätte
gerne gefragt den Kollegen der gerade
gesprochen hat ob er das gut findet wenn
man den Respekt vor dem Parlament hat
wie ist der Lenski mit seiner Opposition
in der Ukraine
umgegangen ist alle verboten hat
zum Teil hat verfolgen lassen und sogar
die Presse in der Ukraine vollständig
gleichgeschaltet ist das hat doch mit
demokratischen Parlamentarismus
0,nichts zu tun danke
möchten sie darauf antworten bitte sehr
Meldung nicht allzu viel Aufmerksamkeit
zukommen lassen wollen aber eines
festhalten das was sie hier zur Politik
in der Ukraine und zur Politik des
ukrainischen Präsidenten gesagt haben
ist schlichtweg falsch
[Applaus]
jetzt wieder regulär auf der Rednerliste
Jürgen Trittin für die Grünen als
Mitglied im Auswärtigen Ausschuss meine
Damen und Herren das war jetzt der
Versuch der Linkspartei hier im Hause
Einigkeit zu demonstrieren dazu schicken
sie dich lieber Gregor hier hin weil
alle über dich positiv annehmen du bist
ein verständlich diskutierender
reflektierter Mensch
und das was Du hier aber abgelaufen hast
war an Verlogenheit nicht zu überbieten
ich will mal ganz deutlich sagen sich
hier hinzustellen und zu sagen die
Bundesregierung gebe Geld für Panzer
aber habe nicht mal Geld für einen
kleinen Trecker um der Ukraine zu helfen
das kann man schon nicht mal mehr als
Unwahrheit bezeichnen
ich will mal darauf hinweisen dass diese
Bundesregierung über das Ministerium für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit 650 Milli
Millionen in die Ukraine gegeben hat
dass sie über das BMI 500 Millionen in
die Ukraine gibt dass sie über das AA
fast 800 Millionen unter anderem
700.000 Stromgeneratoren geliefert hat
und dass diese Bundesregierung über das
Finanzministerium
6,24 Milliarden ausgegeben hat rein
Zivil zum großen teilbudget-hilfe für
die Ukraine die Behauptung wir würden
hier niemanden Zivil unterstützen lieber
Gregor wie sie ist eine Lüge
und dann wird er versucht sozusagen die
eigene Spaltung die die Linkspartei über
die krisenkrieg hat zu bemänteln auf der
einen Seite Sahra Wagenknecht mit
Porsche Klaus mit
Gregor Gysi der auch aufgerufen hat
dorthin zu gehen er ist nicht neutral
und Seven daddelem und auf der anderen
Seite Mitglieder Mitglieder wie Klaus
Lederer oder Bodo Ramelow und dazwischen
steht die Parteiführung von Janine
Wissler und weiß nicht was passiert der
Kollege möchten Sie eine Zwischenfrage
von Herrn Gysi zulassen nein ich mache
jetzt essen
der Abgeordnete Gregor Gysi hat die
Möglichkeit zu einer Zwischenfrage an
den Abgeordneten Jürgen bitte schön
Herr Kollege Trittin abgesehen davon
dass auch grün und Sozialdemokraten das
Manifest unser zeichnet haben möchte ich
Sie folgendes Fragen ich habe einen
Brief der parlamentarischen
Staatssekretärin aus dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium erhalten wo
drinsteht dass für den Traktor den Bus
und den Beton Mischmaschine keine
Strukturen und kein Geld vorhanden ist
dann hat sich ein Journalist der
Süddeutschen Zeitung damit beschäftigt
hat recherchiert und wurde gesagt
eigentlich sei ja das
Entwicklungsministerium zuständig
daraufhin hat er gefragt warum haben Sie
denn diese nicht geantwortet er soll
sich
Entwicklungsministerium wenden dafür
haben sie gesagt weil wir uns erkundigt
haben die haben dafür auch kein Geld und
keine Strukturen es war nicht möglich
diesen Traktor diesen Bus und die Beton
Mischmaschine für den Vorort von KFZ zu
realisieren über den CDU
Ministerpräsidenten Sachsens ist es
gelogen deshalb war das keine Lüge
sondern absolut wahr und belegbar was
ich gesagt habe
lieber Kollege
easy
wenn man schon im Loch sitzt sollte man
vermeiden auch noch weiter was
zuzuschütten meine Aussage hat ganz
einfach gelautet wer hier den Eindruck
erweckt die Bundesregierung würde
ausschließlich Panzer liefern und mit
einem solchen Beispiel versucht zu
illustrieren das Deutschland keine
zivile Hilfe gibt der sagt bewusst die
Unwahrheit und ich fühle mich eines
hinzu ich hätte mir ja deswegen habe ich
mehr gefreut die wäre Zwischenmeldung
aber wie jemand mit einer aufrechten
linken Haltung zu einer Demo aufrufen
kann
wo auf zusätzlich ein Jürgen Elsässer
ankündigt dort mit nationalen fahren zu
demonstrieren ich finde lieber Kollege
Gregor Gysi sie haben den politischen
Kompass in dieser Situation vollständig
verloren
ich will an der Stelle dann aber nein
zweite Bemerkung machen man muss ja auch
nicht die eigene Naivität irgendwie so
demonstrieren
haben Sie eigentlich nichts zur Kenntnis
genommen was Herr Peskow dass der
Sprecher des Kreml auf die Forderung der
Verbündeten Chinesen doch bitte ein
Waffenstillstand zu machen sagen das ist
derzeit gibt es dafür keine Grundlage
die Wahrheit ist es ist nicht die
Bundesregierung es ist nicht
Europa es ist nicht die Ukraine es ist
Russland das einen Waffenstillstand den
Sie hier verlangen nicht will und die
Frage muss man sich doch stellen wie
kommt man in einer solchen Situation zu
Verhandlungen ich habe mir mal die Mühe
gemacht in der Geschichte ein Beispiel
zu suchen was vielleicht der Linken
hilft
wie ist es zugekommen das Lido und Henry
Kissinger
angefangen haben über Frieden zu reden
obwohl die USA Richard nichts mehr
versprochen hat Vietnam in die Steinzeit
zurückzubauen
dafür waren zwei Dinge von zentraler
Bedeutung das eine waren die
Waffenlieferung Chinas und der
Sowjetunion an den Wert kommen die
verhindert haben dass sie Vietnamesen
von der Übermacht der Amerikaner
überhand wurden und das andere das war
der Aufstand einer ganzen Generation auf
diesem Globus gegen diesen Krieg der die
USA wenn eine politische Isolierung
geführt hat die in der zu gezwungen hat
sich auch Verhandlungen einzulassen und
genau das ist es was wir als
Bundesregierung mit diesem Krieg
versuchen wir wollen verhindern dass die
Ukraine überrannt wird dafür liefern wir
Waffen und wir setzen auf Diplomatie
diplomatie ist nicht schön dass wir mal
drüber gesprochen haben diplomatie ist
dafür zu sorgen dass in den Vereinten
Nationen 141 Staaten gemeinsam den
Rückzug Russlands aus der Ukraine
fordern Diplomatie
diplomatie ist es auch wenn wir dahin
gehen die Finanzierung dieses Krieges
durch Putin zu beschenken schneiden
deswegen inzwischen das zehnte
Sanktionspaket deswegen bezieht Europa
heute keine Kohle kein Öl kein Gas mehr
aus Russland weil wir der Auffassung
sind wir küssen Russland daran hindern
diesen Krieg vorzusetzen auch das ist
die plomativ ich würde mir übrigens bei
der Gelegenheit im elften
sanktions-paket wünschen dass wir die
Liste der nicht mehr importierten
energetischen Ressourcen künftig in
Europa auch auf Uran erweitern dass wir
ein echter Vorschlag für das elfte
Sanktionsrecht
und das ist genau der Punkt wo wir uns
unterscheiden
wir frönen nicht der Naivität des bloßen
Forderns sondern wir wollen Russland
dazu bringen diesen Krieg zu beenden und
dafür in Verhandlung zu treten und
deswegen gibt es keine Alternative zu
einem Weg der sagt auf der einen Seite
sicherstellen dass es nicht überrannt
wird und auf der anderen Seite alles
dafür tun dass dieser Politik von Putin
diese verbrecherische Strategie ein
anderes Land zu überfallen dabei auf
eine
Kriegsstrategie der Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit zu setzen das ist Vorsatz
und gemacht gibt es keine Alternative
will man diese Verbrechen beenden dann
muss man diesen Weg gehen man muss so
ausrüsten und man muss politischen Druck
entwickeln damit endlich verhandelt wird
um diese Verbrechen zu beenden
jugendreutin war das hier am Rednerpult
teilweise in sozusagen im Dialog mit
Gregor Gysi wer sich übrigens selbst ein
Bild davon machen möchte was Deutschland
an Unterstützungsleistung bisher
geleistet hat militärisch aber auch
darüber hinaus es gibt auf der Seite der
Bundesregierung eine Liste die auch
aktualisiert wird auch auf der Seite des
Entwicklungshilfe Ministeriums
beispielsweise sind 270 Stromgeneratoren
geliefert worden um auch die
Infrastruktur aufrecht zu erhalten bzw
wieder die Stromversorgung zu
gewährleisten
weil ihre Fraktion hat vier Minuten
Redezeit das können wir jetzt nicht hier
miteinander dienen so klappt das nicht
sie haben das Wort Peter Bistum für die
AFD steht vorne
Kollegen Liebe Kollege sie haben hier
bewundernswert versucht jetzt gerade
einen einen äh zu treiben sogar zwischen
die Linken aber auch zwischen die Linken
und und die rechte Seite des Parlaments
und Herr Dr raten
das ist das ist nein das ist
symptomatisch für die für die ganze
Diskussion der letzten Zeit ja
das ist das sind das sind Denkmuster aus
den 19 Jahrhundert dieses dieses
ja im 20 hat es noch vorgesehen aber wir
leben im 21 Jahrhundert ja und dieses
Links rechtsspektrum ist längst überholt
wo wir was wo reden wir leben wo wären
Leben ist nein wir haben hier die
Menschen die auf die Straße gehen und es
ist den völlig egal ob das Sarah Wagen
nicht oder Jürgen Elsässer oder Peter
Bistro in München dazu aufrufen die
demonstrieren für Frieden und gegen den
Krieg was wir hier haben ist eine
horizontale Teilung des politischen
Spektrums das sind die Menschen da unten
und die globalen Eliten da oben und das
erleben Sie jeden Tag wenn sie das nicht
verstehen dann verfolgen sie das noch
ein paar Tage dann wird sie die Realität
einholen
haben Sie denn nicht darüber nachgedacht
warum wir hier immer auf Antrag der
Opposition
diskutieren warum sich Deutschland nicht
an diesen Krieg beteiligen soll warum
wir keine Waffen liefern sollen und
stattdessen Frieden schaffen sollen
weil die Bundesregierung eben aus
Parteien besteht die ihre Wahl
Versprechen gebrochen haben die lieber
Krieg führen als Frieden zu schaffen und
weil sie die Grundsätze der Außenpolitik
der Nachkriegszeit komplett über den
Bord geworfen haben
[Applaus]
sie betreiben hier genau die Spaltung
der Gesellschaft wie die anderen
Kollegen sie haben hier auch noch
angesprochen hier wissen sie was sie
machen jeder der sie als unfähige Person
kritisiert das sagen sie ja das ist eine
Delegitimierung der Institution nein sie
dele geht die mehren diese Institution
durch ihr Verhalten und durch ihre
Unfähigkeit
[Applaus]
noch mal
sie alle haben ihre Wähler belogen und
betrogen und sie alle regieren jeden Tag
über die Köpfe der Menschen hinweg die
Menschen demonstrieren zu zigtausenden
für den Frieden gegen den Krieg und was
machen sie sie
liefern Waffen und die Familien die
Demonstranten das ist doch ihre Taktik
das haben sie hier gerade in dieser
Diskussion gezeigt sie die Familie die
Menschen dafür dass sie für den für den
Frieden demonstrieren
FDP sie kaufen Waffen für die Ukraine
aus Steuergeldern von Menschen die das
nicht wollen warum richten Sie nicht
eine Freiwilligen vor dann können Sie
Slava Ukraine nennen und lassen sie da
alle einzahlen die diesen Krieg
unterstützen wollen wenn das die
Mehrheit ist so wie Sie behaupten dann
müssen sie doch ganz entspannt sein sind
sie aber nicht weil sie wissen dass das
nicht geht weil sie die Mehrheit nicht
hinter ihnen haben
[Applaus]
die Mehrheit der Menschen ist gegen
diesen Krieg
die Mehrheit der Menschen wünscht sich
Frieden
und
wir alle die für den Frieden eintreten
müssen und uns hier auch noch als
Agenten moskaust beschimpfen lassen
vom wirken sie von dem Amerikanern
gesteuert bezahlt und überwacht werden
liebe Freunde das ist das was Sie hier
die ganze Zeit machen und
dagegen wenden wir uns von der AFD
offensichtlich jetzt auch viele von den
Linken und dafür sind wir den Daten
danke schön
[Applaus]
die Kollegin Dr Marie agnesstrack
Zimmermann hat jetzt das Wort für die
FDP-Fraktion
boah
Paartherapie zwischen rechts und links
da gibt es vielleicht eine extra
Aufwandsentschädigung für sie beide
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen frau Präsidentin
der Auftritt auf der Bühne am Ende der
Pro russischen Friedensdemo das
nachhaltigste was geblieben ist und was
in Erinnerung bleibt ist der Auftritt
der Protagonisten auf der Bühne Sarah
Wagenknecht
extraktionsvorsitzende der Linken ihr
Gatte Oskar Lafontaine unter anderem
Ex-Mitglied der Linken Alice Schwarzer
Ex Ikone der Frauenbewegung bei der das
Thema Vergewaltigung von ukrainischen
Frauen die Welt wartet vergebens darauf
auf deren berechtigten Aufschrei und
generalfahrt militärischer ex-berater
der Kanzlerin alle vier tänzelnd auf der
Bühne Händchen haltend zu John Lennons
give peace a chance meine Damen und
Herren was für ein zynischer auftritt
und das ganze das Ganze garniert mit
bekannten Rechtsextremisten und
Holocaust Leugnern und ihre
Fraktionsvorsitzende
sie ist heute auch nicht da das ist
erstaunlich der Schwund ist
offensichtlich meine Damen und Herren
heute forderte Linksfraktion
diplomatische Gespräche mit Russland und
was human klingt ist in Moskau aber ein
Arrangement mit Massenmördern voll daran
und Vergewaltiger eine Diplomatie die
ins Leere läuft Wladimir Putin jeden Tag
betonen dass er die Ukraine auslöschen
will dass er eben nicht bereit ist die
völkerrechtswidrige Gesetzen Gebiete zu
verlassen
meine Damen und Herren diejenigen die
das narrativputins Verbreiten Russland
sei vom Westen bedroht worden und hätte
sich mit dem Angriff auf die Ukraine
doch nur erwehren müssen und diejenigen
die von der Ukraine Kompromisse erwarten
das sind die die bereit sind die Ukraine
zu opfern und wer der Ukraine Waffen und
militärisches Material verwehrt der
spricht der Ukraine schlicht das Recht
auf Selbstverteidigung ab und warum tun
sie das weil sie es nicht interessiert
dass 1.300 Kilometer von hier ein Volk
hingerichtet wird weil sie in Ruhe
gelassen werden wollen weil sie wollen
dass sich die Ukraine fügt sie verraten
damit das Völkerrecht das nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg sicherstellen wollte
dass nie wieder ein Land nie wieder ein
Land ein anderes überfällt und grenzen
überschiebt sie nehmen dem Kauf dass die
ukrainische Kultur die Sprache die
Identität ausgelöscht wird und noch
schlimmer sie ignorieren die brutale
Realität die russische Streitkräfte
gehen Vertrauen voller Härte vor und ich
werde Ihnen jetzt mal ein Beispiel
bringen in irpin legten sie nach einem
Massaker den Hingerichteten Müttern ihre
weinenden Kinder auf den Bauch und als
ukrainische Soldaten diesen Kindern
helfen wollten sterben auch sie weil
russische Soldaten zwischen den Müttern
und ihren Kindern Sprengfallen
angebracht haben dieses unfassbare
Grauen geschieht genauso lange bis Putin
entscheidet dass es aufhören muss und
deswegen sitzt dort der richtige
Adressat für alle friedensappelle
manifeste Demonstrationen dort sitzt der
Täter in Moskau und dieser Täter hört
nicht auf die Sprache dieser Form von
Diplomatie und das geträllere von
friedensliedern er versteht eben nur die
Sprache der Stärke und Gespräche können
auch nur aus der Stärke herausgeführt
werden und das alleine entscheidet die
Ukraine und ganz sicher nicht Herr Gisi
und deshalb
speziell wichtig die weltgemeinschaften
wer will was Herr fahle will was und
also er möchte nämlich an eine
Zwischenfrage stellen möchten Sie die
Zulassung
und deshalb ist es wir wollen nicht
übertreiben deshalb ist es so
existenziell wichtig dass ich die
Weltgemeinschaft hinter die Ukraine
stellt und sie wirtschaftlich humanitär
aber eben auch mit Waffen unterstützt
damit dieser Terror endlich gestoppt
wird und die territoriale Integrität der
Ukraine wieder vollständig hergestellt
wird jedes abtreten von Gebiet wäre ein
Erfolg Russlands meine Damen und Herren
das ist das Problem das ist das Problem
was wir haben und das ist die wahre
Bedrohung für den Frieden in Deutschland
in Europa ja und in der ganzen Welt
meine Damen und Herren
Thomas Mann hat
1941 aus dem Exil heraus in einer
Radioansprache an das Deutsche Reich
sich gewandt als ich die
Nationalsozialisten darüber beschwert
haben der Kriegseintritt der USA und die
Wehrhaftigkeit der Engländer würden den
Krieg verlängern seit 82 82 Jahre später
trifft es immer noch den Punkt und
erklärt wie verbrecherische Despoten
sind Zitat sie verlangen Frieden sie die
vom Blute des eigenen Volkes und anderer
Volker triefen sie Wagen ist diese Worte
in den Mund zu nehmen damit meinen sie
Unterwerfung die Legalisierung ihrer
Verbrechen die Hinnahme des menschlich
unerträglichen aber das ist nicht
möglich mit einem Hitler gibt es keinen
Frieden weil er des Friedens von Grund
auf unfähig und weil dieses Wort in
seinem Munde nur eine schmutzige
krankhafte Lüge ist nach 82 Jahren
ticken verbrecherische Despoten immer
noch so
Zimmermann war das für die FDP die
Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses hier diese
Aussprache jubeingarten erwarten wir
jetzt für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren die Ukraine steht in der
schwersten Krise ihrer kurzen Existenz
als unabhängiger Staat zum dritten Mal
muss dieses leitgeprüfte Volk um sein
Überleben kämpfen gegen Stalin gegen
Hitler und jetzt gegen Putin
die Ukraine hat gerade den schwersten
Winter ihre Geschichte überlebt aber sie
zahlt einen ungeheuren Preis dafür bei
den Kämpfen um bachmut bei den
Zehntausenden Toten bei den russischen
Terrorangriffen auf Infrastruktur und
Wohngebiete in diesem Überlebenskampf
hat das ukrainische Volk ein Recht
darauf dass wir uns auch im Deutschen
Bundestag mit seinem Schicksal und
ermöglichen Beendigung der Kämpfe
beschäftigen aber das muss angemessen in
voller Solidarität und mit aller
denkbaren Unterstützung für die Ukraine
für den ukrainischen Überlebenskampf
erfolgen
der heute debattierte Antrag der Linken
erfüllt diese Ansprüche nicht er ist
vielmehr ein Dokument der Kaltherzigkeit
der arroganten Überheblichkeit und der
ideologischen Verblendung in der ihnen
verbirgt sich eine tragische
Gleichgültigkeit gegenüber dem Schicksal
der Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer der
vermeintliche Aufruf zum Frieden ist
nichts anderes als ein Aufruf an die
Ukraine zur Kapitulation zur
Unterwerfung unter den russischen
Aggressor
liebe Kollegen und Kollegen die
Voraussetzungen für das Überleben der
Ukraine ist die militärische Hilfe der
freien Nationen nicht als Selbstzweck
nicht zur kriegsverlängerung sondern um
der Ukraine überhaupt die Möglichkeit zu
geben weiter zu existieren wer diesen
Zusammenhang leugnet spielt das Spiel
Putins und er oder sie tut das bewusst
und unter den kaufname der militärischen
und politischen Vernichtung der Ukraine
damit reiht sich der Antrag ein in
unzählige Aufrufe und Demonstrationen
der letzten Wochen es ist beschämend wie
sich bei diesem Thema die
rechtsradikalien in der AFD und die
Rechtsradikalen bei den Linken verbünden
und in gemeinsamen aufrufen äußern
Forderungen nach Waffenstillstand und
Frieden ohne zu sagen wie sie erreicht
werden sollen sind billig und
oberflächlich das ist nicht unser Weg
wir haben uns als Regierungskoalition an
die Parteien die sie tragen in den
letzten Jahren nicht leicht gemacht auf
dem Weg die Ukraine zu unterstützen ohne
Kriegspartei zu werden und ohne einen
europäischen oder gar weltweiten
Konflikt auszulösen aber wir sind dieser
Linie Unterführung des Bundeskanzlers
erfolgreich nachgekommen haben Waffen in
die Ukraine für annähernd drei
Milliarden Euro geliefert und zwar die
Waffen die die Ukraine jeweils dringend
brauchte Panzer ehemals sowjetischer
Bauart bis heute das Rückgrat der
ukrainischen Panzerwaffe modernste
Artillerie und die besten
luftabwehrwaffen der Welt die die
massive Bedrohung durch russische
jagdbombe und Drohnen eindämmen dazu
große Mengen an Munition Logistik
Panzerabwehr und infantriebwaffen jetzt
kommen mehrere leopard-bataione im
europäischen Verbund dazu wir werden
diese Linie weiterführen die Ukraine vor
einer militärischen Niederlage bewahren
und alles dafür tun dass Russland die
auslosigkeit
seines Tuns einsieht und an den
Verhandlungstisch kommt wir tun alles
was dazu notwendig ist und wir tun es so
lange es notwendig ist
meine Damen und Herren Waffenstillstand
und Friedensschluss bleiben
selbstverständlich Ziele der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion auch wenn das im
Moment weit entfernt scheint aber mit
einer freien Ukraine und nicht zu den
Bedingungen Russlands und dann müssen
auch dort die Verantwortung für diesen
russischen Angriffskrieg und die dort
begangenen Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit benannt werden müssen
sich die Verantwortlichen vor einem
tribunalverantwortlichen verantworten
allen voran Wladimir Putin
auf diesem Weg lassen wir die Ukraine
nicht allein und es ist beschämend dass
ich die Linke diesem Weg der Solidarität
der Freiheit und der Gerechtigkeit nicht
anschließt
sie berufen sich bei den Linken auf die
Freiheitlichen Traditionen der deutschen
Arbeiterbewegung wir alle in diesem Haus
wissen dass über diesem Anspruch ohnehin
schon der Schatten der sed-dekoratur
liegt aus dem sie hervorgegangen sind
und jetzt geben sie diese Traditionen
schon wieder auf und geben der Kälte der
militärischen Macht den voll zu den
Vorzug ein erneutes historisches
Versagen ich kann nur an sie appellieren
ändern Sie diesen Weg trennen Sie sich
von denen die mit dem Friedenswillen der
Menschen Schindler oder treiben und
nehmen Sie diesen unzähligen Antrag
zurück er ist das Themas nicht würdig
vielen Dank
für die SPD in Richtung der
Linksfraktion
und jetzt hat die cdu/csu-fraktion in
Personen von Jürgen hat noch mal die
Möglichkeit auf diesen Antrag zu
reagieren erste Fassung dieses heute
hier vorliegenden Antrags gelesen habe
habe ich mir vorwundert die Augen
gerieben da stand runter Antragsteller
Ali Bartsch und ich habe die Namen
cupala Weidel vermisst weil das wäre ein
guter erster gemeinsamer Antrag von
links und rechts außen in diesem
Bundestag gewesen in der Tradition des
demonstrationsaufrufs vom vergangenen
Samstag
wir haben
die
linke Fraktion in einer Situation in der
sie den Drohnen ununtergang vor Augen
sieht und sie fischt im drüben und hat
mit dem Neo faschistischen Beifang den
sie dabei einräumt kein Problem das ist
die Fraktion die alle anderen
demokratischen Fraktionen des Hauses
stets mahnt klare Kante zu zeigen
gegenüber Rechtsaußen die das genau
jetzt verletzt und kein Problem damit
hat dass Neofaschisten ihre Politik auch
öffentlich unterstützen
möchte ich möchte zu den den Inhalten
kommen im Zentrum des Antrags steht der
sofortige Waffenstillstand
ein sofortiger Waffenstillstand würde
bedeuten dass russische Truppen
dauerhaft nämlich mindestens bis zum
Ende des Waffenstillstands vermutlich
darüber hinaus auf fremden nämlich
ukrainischen Boden stehen und das
Russland aus der Größe des Landes
seine Truppen in der Ukraine
stabilisieren und stärken könnte
der Waffenstillstand würde in erster
Linie dem russischen Angriffskrieg
dienen und deswegen ist es auch
ungewöhnlich verwunderlich dass viele in
Moskau diese Überlegungen genauso teilen
und dass das auch Teil dieses
chinesischen Vorschlags gewesen ist
Diplomatie hat in diesem Konflikt eine
große Chance gehabt die Entscheidung
Diplomatie statt Waffen haben wir 2014
getroffen ich erinnere mich an intensive
Diskussionen am Rande der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz in Washington auch
im Auswärtigen Amt mit Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus dem Kongress bei der
parteienrepublikaner wie Demokraten die
gesagt haben wir müssen die Ukraine
aufrüsten und den Preis für Protein in
die Höhe zu treiben wir Deutsche auch
wir in der cdu/csu haben gesagt wir
wollen keine militärische Eskalation
sondern wir wollen eine diplomatische
Lösung normandieformat Bundeskanzlerin
Angela Merkel Präsident macron gemeinsam
mit dem russischen und dem ukrainischen
Präsidenten diese acht Jahre hat
Russland genutzt um sich vorzubereiten
auf diesen Angriff gegen die Ukraine
wir sollten jetzt nicht den Fehler
machen wieder zu sagen Diplomatie vor
Waffenlieferungen sondern beides muss
möglich sein und ich sage umgekehrt ich
glaube je stärker die Ukraine ist desto
näher kommen wir an den Punkt an dem man
im Kreml einsieht dass die Fortführung
des Kampfes ein größeres Risiko für
Putin und den kandidar stellt als das
Eintreten in tatsächliche ernsthafte
Verhandlungen und ich bin davon
überzeugt wenn dieser Punkt erreicht ist
wird man auch in Kiew und bei allen
unterstützenden Nationen zum Ergebnis
kommen dass das der richtige Zeitpunkt
ist leider sind wir an diesem Zeitpunkt
noch nicht es fehlt der Ukraine leider
an Kraft jetzt kraftvoll diesem diesem
Angriff zu widerstehen in deinem im
Frühjahr ich fürchte dass wir in den
letzten drei Monaten eher eine Stärkung
der russischen Truppen erlebt haben weil
wir zu zögerlich waren mit Waffen die
Frauen
und wir haben in der Europäischen Union
das steht am 20 März auf der
Tagesordnung des auswärtigen Rates wenn
dies richtig verstanden habe den
Initiative von Estland einige Milliarden
zur Verfügung zu stellen um Munition
bereitzustellen für die Ukraine und ich
habe in diesem Zusammenhang die
Bundesregierung gefragt eigentlich geht
es ja nicht um Geld sondern es geht um
die Frage wo sind die wo ist die
Munition wo sind konkret die
panzerhaubitzengranaten die die Ukraine
jetzt dringend braucht ich habe die
Frage gestellt kann die deutsche
Bundesregierung ausschließen dass es in
Deutschland ungenutzte Kapazitäten zur
Herstellung solcher Granaten gibt obwohl
wir doch alle wissen und alle unsere
Partner sagen wir brauchen die und ich
habe bisher darauf keine Antwort
erhalten und ich erwarte dass die
Bundesregierung sicherstellt dass alle
Kapazitäten in Deutschland bei der
Rüstungsindustrie und in der Bundeswehr
genutzt werden und der Ukraine die
notwendige Munition zur Verfügung zu
stellen damit wir eben an den Punkt
kommen wo die Diplomatie tatsächlich
wieder eine Chance haben
möchte die letzten Minute meiner Rede
darauf verwenden vielleicht noch mal
mich der Frage zu widmen wie die Leute
Bevölkerung das deutsche Volk zu diesem
Kriegs ganz gegen die Ukraine steht
erstens glaube ich das ist nur ganz ganz
wenige gibt einige wenige von denen
waren am Samstag Vorteil hier in Berlin
die den Sieg Russland über die Ukraine
wollen
ich glaube aber dass es in Deutschland
eine doch große Zahl von Menschen gibt
die der Meinung ist wenn wir Putin nur
das geben was er will kommt der Friede
zurück nach Europa und wir haben Ruhe
sie billigen nicht diesen Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine aber sie
glauben wenn die Ukraine nachgeben würde
und wir die Ukraine darin bestärken wäre
der Konflikt zu Ende
ich fürchte dass dies eine
Fehleinschätzung ist die Antwort die wir
geben müssen ist viel bitterer nämlich
dass wir sagen in dem Augenblick wo
Russland Erfolg hat bei der Eroberung
der Ukraine geht der große
Konflikt in Europa erst los und früher
oder später werden wir erleben das
molder Georgien Baltikum
am Ende sogar die NATO von Putin
herausgefordert wird wenn er sich durch
Erfolge ermutigt fühlt in diese Richtung
zu gehen das ist leider eine bitterere
Wahrheit als das Versprechen gibt doch
Putin was er will und dann gibt es Ruhe
aber es ist wie ich fürchte die Wahrheit
und deswegen müssen wir die Ukraine nach
Kräften unterstützen dass sie diesen
Kampf gewinnen kann und ich hoffe dass
wir in den nächsten Wochen auch mehr
Dynamik und mehr Schwung enthalten
insbesondere seitens der Bundesregierung
Jürgen hart war das für die
Unionsfraktion der außenpolitische
Sprecher er hat die Kapazitäten der
Rüstungsindustrie angesprochen heute
morgen in seiner Regierungserklärung hat
der Bundeskanzler der Rüstungsindustrie
Hilfen zugesagt damit sie eine laufende
Produktion von wichtigen Waffen Geräten
und Munitionen aufbauen können
die Linksfraktion hat heute einen sehr
knappen und kurzen Antrag zum russischen
Angriffskrieg vorgelegt und dabei sage
und schreibe zwei Forderungen vorgelegt
sie fordern zum einen die humanitäre
Unterstützung der geflüchteten aus dem
Kriegsgebieten so weit so
selbstverständlich und sie fordern einen
Waffenstillstand und friedensverhandlung
was sie aber nicht sagen ist wieder Weg
dorthin aussehen soll und wie man den
Kriegsverbrecher Putin eigentlich dazu
bringen möchte die Waffen schweigen zu
lassen ohne dass sich die Ukraine selbst
aufgeben muss wie kommt man zu einem
tragfähigen Frieden bei dem Putin und
auch seine Nachfolger
alle Wahl davon Abstand nehmen die
Ukraine gewaltsam vernichten zu wollen
dazu sagen sie überhaupt gar nichts und
die Leisten seit einem Jahr eben keinen
Beitrag dazu eine ernsthafte
demokratische und diplomatische Lösung
vorzulegen werden sich die ganze Welt
den Kopf darüber zerbricht
diese Sprachlosigkeit wird leider
begleitet von einer gefährlichen
Realitätsverweigerung es ist Putin der
mit der Methode Gewalt seine
imperialistischen Interessen
durchzusetzen versucht ganz egal wie
viele Leute er dafür opfern muss und sie
ignorieren eben noch immer dass der
eigentliche Kriegstreiber in Moskau
sitzt und das ist das eigentliche
Problem denn sonst würden sie ja
verstehen dass sie ihren Appell
Diplomatie statt Panzer an niemanden
sonst richten sollten als an Vladimir
Putin aber diese Realität die passt halt
nicht ins Weltbild weil der Schurke eben
hier nicht in den USA sitzt sondern in
Moskau ihre Realitätsverweigerung die
hat gefährliche Auswirkungen sie führt
dazu dass die Menschen noch mehr Angst
haben
Angst musikkapital schlagen sondern auch
die extreme Rechte da drüben und es
führt eben dazu dass noch mehr Menschen
offene Ohren entwickeln für eine
brandgefährliche Täter Opfer Umkehr von
der Putin profitiert
mit Relativierungen von
putinsraditionismus und
menschenverachtender Verbrechen durch
die Talkshows und das entzückt natürlich
nicht nur den kramel sondern auch seine
rechtsextrem Verbündeten im Rest von
Europa und darum ist es eben auch kein
Zufall dass viele rechtsradikale am
vergangenen Wochenende Seite an Seite
mit Mitgliedern der Linkspartei und
Putin Freunden durch Berlin marschiert
sind
noch einmal kurz zur mitschreiben für
Sie was der Rest der demokratischen
Fraktion seit einem Jahr tut mit der
Unterstützung der Ukraine humanitär
finanziell und militärisch verfolgen wir
gemeinsam mit den internationalen
Partnern eben die Strategie um Putin an
den Verhandlungstisch zu zwingen wir
helfen der Ukraine sich gegen die
Aggression Putins zu wehren und so soll
Putin eben ein machtpolitisches
Interesse entwickeln zu verhandeln statt
zu schießen und so wollen wir die
Friedensordnung in Europa wieder
herstellen und wegen dieses
militärischen teils in der Unterstützung
werden sie jetzt der Bundesregierung vor
kriegslöstern zu sein und das ohne eine
konkrete alternative vorzulegen wie man
denn sonst zu Verhandlungen kommen soll
und das zeigt eben dass sie sich gerne
leicht machen aber
das ihrem verantwortungslos in dieser
Position unsere Situation die Wahrheit
ist doch ohne die militärische
Unterstützung der Ukraine wäre die
Ukraine schon längst von der Landkarte
gestrichen und die Lehren aus diesen
Krieg werden gewesen erstens für die
Demokratisierung wirst du als
postwertzischer Staat blutig bezahlen
und die EU lässt sich im Stich zweitens
hol die Atomwaffen wenn du deine
Integrität schützen willst und wenn du
schon welche hast dann gibst sie niemals
ab und drittens als ergressor kannst du
sogar mitten in Europa gewaltsam Grenzen
verschieben und es passiert ja
eigentlich im Kern gar nichts zu was für
einem Frieden würde das führen auch dazu
kein Wort in ihrem Antrag
stattdessen spielen sie weiterhin die
militärische Unterstützung und die
Diplomatie gegeneinander aus die Wiese
muss aber heißen Diplomatie und
militärische Hilfe für die Ukraine liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen so eigentlich
bräuchte es genau jetzt eine linke
Partei die sich kritisch mit dem Post
sowjetischen Imperialismus
auseinandersetzt die Demokratie
Feindlichkeit und Revisionismus klar
zurückweist
als die aufrichtige Wege für einen
tragfähigen Frieden beschreibt und sie
sind diese Partei leider nicht das ist
der traurig denn für Antifaschismus und
Frieden zu sein das heißt Widerstand
gegen Putin zu unterstützen
Slava Ukraine
für die AFD das Wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Liebe
Landsleute
kein Krieg der Geschichte hätte so
leicht verhindert werden können wie der
in der Ukraine
so schnell nach dem Zusammenbruch der
Sowjetunion Zusagen getätigt wurden dass
sich die NATO nicht nach Osten ausdehnen
dürfen so schnell wurden diese auch
gebrochen
Russlands Schuld am Krieg ist nicht
bestreitbar aber es muss dabei beachtet
werden dass seine berechtigten
Sicherheitsinteressen missachtet wurden
ein Jahr ist es nur her dass der Krieg
im Osten Europas begann was sie seither
geschehen
hunderttausende tote
unendliches Leid und gravierende
finanzielle Folgen für Millionen
Deutsche die deutsche Regierung aber
agiert wie ein Schlafwandler getrieben
von der skalationsdruck und
Kriegstreibern die unser Land in den
Abgrund führen
statt die Lage endlich nüchtern zu
analysieren und unsere national
Interessen zu vertreten lassen Sie die
ampelkriegstreiber von anderen am
nasenried durch die magnese führen die
Lieferung deutschen Kampfpanzern die
Ukraine weil weitere
tiefpunktpolitischen Unvermögens was
wird diese Bundesregierung wie wird die
Krieg weiter eskalieren
Kampfjets oder sogar eigene deutsche
Besatzungen
sie schüren das vorher die skalation
indem sie einen zerstörten Panzer vor
der russischen Botschaft aufstellen
über 50.000 Teilnehmer an der
Friedensdemo am Wochenende haben die
Nase voll von ihren Provokationen
in einer Krisensituation wie dieser
sollte die Stärkung unserer
Wirtschaftskraft und die Sicherung
unserer Energie und ressourcenversorgung
eine hohe Priorität haben
stattdessen beteiligen wir uns an einem
selbst zerstörerischen Sanktionsregime
das unsere Wirtschaft mehr schadet als
der Russlands
man kann und muss mit der russischen
Seite verhandeln das ist möglich sein
kann haben wir in der Frühphase des
Krieges sehen können
beide Seiten führten damals
Verhandlungen und standen kurz vor einer
Einigung Russland hätte sich nach diesen
Plänen zurückgezogen die Ukraine wäre
neutrales Gebiet geworden leider wurde
ein Abschluss von den Profiteuren des
Krieges aus den USA und Großbritannien
blockiert
ich schließe mit einem Zitat von Helmut
Schmidt unter dem ist diesen Krieg
möglicherweise nicht gegeben hätte
lieber 100 Stunden umsonst verhandeln
als eine Minute schießen
meine Damen und Herren von der
Bundesregierung stoppen Sie die
todbringenden Waffenlieferungen und
setzen Sie sich für einen
Waffenstillstand und Gespräche ein
vielen Dank
von der AFD hat gerade noch mal die
Demonstration zu der Sahra Wagenknecht
und alles schwarzer unter anderem ja am
Samstag in Berlin aufgerufen haben
angesprochen und die Angaben über die
Teilnehmerzahl die geht tatsächlich sehr
weit auseinander der Veranstalter sprach
von 50.000
Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmern und die
Polizei von 13000 Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen den Kollegen
Schmidt von den von der AFD da empfehle
ich mal die
Sichtung des Budapester Memorandums wo
eindeutig drin steht das Russland sich
als Garantie macht für die nationale
Integrität der Ukraine in ihren Grenzen
inklusive krimen einzusetzen hat und
eigentlich müsste Russland gerade gegen
sich selber kämpfen wenn es sich an
seine Verträge halten würde die es mit
der Ukraine unter anderem aber auch mit
dem besten geschlossen hat und wenn hier
irgendjemand Sicherheits
Sicherheiten gefährdet dann ist das
Russland ich kann mich nicht daran
erinnern dass es irgendjemanden gab aus
der gesamten nato-familie der jemals die
Integrität Russlands in Frage gestellt
hatten es macht mich wirklich zornig
dass sie immer wieder versuchen mit
ihren narrativen über afd-tv die
Bevölkerung über irgendeinen Unsinn der
wirklich nicht stimmt zu infizieren und
da müssen wir alle gegen kämpfen
der Antrag der Linken ist deshalb auch
heute für mich im besten Fall naiv im
schlechtesten Fall ein Trojanisches
Pferd für die Interessen des russischen
Präsidenten ich sage es deshalb deutlich
jeder von uns in diesem Hohen Hause
möchte lieber Diplomatie statt Panzer
aber die harte Wahrheit ist doch dass
der Krieg nur durch Diplomatie und
Panzer beendet werden kann aus
russischer Sicht ist eine militärisch
schwache Ukraine nämlich kein
gleichwertiger Verhandlungspartner
sondern sie ist ein leichtes Opfer für
den russischen Imperialismus und dass
die Ukraine
sich so tapfer verteidigt hat haben in
Russland diese ganzen Strategen die das
ganze vom Zaun gebrochen haben nie für
möglich gehalten da brauchen Sie gar
nicht verschämt in Ihren Rechner zu
schauen sie sind der größte Freiheit
hier die ganze Zeit gewesen Herr Kollege
es ist einfach mal Fakt das Russland die
Ukraine überfallen hat obwohl sämtliche
Präsidenten Kanzler Regierungschefs die
gesamten Regierungschef der westlichen
Welt versucht haben genau dieses zu
verhindern und sie machen sich mit
Leuten Gemeinden die der Meinung sind
das ist in Ordnung ist wenn in einem
Krieg Frauen vergewaltigt werden sie
machen sich das ist ihre eigene Partei
Freundin die das
außen vertreten hat und ich habe mich
selten so geschämt für den Auftritt von
ihr bei hart aber fair wir haben selten
Zeit sowas anzuschauen der Faktencheck
ist mir da relativ egal wann ich nämlich
zufälligerweise auch sehr sehr viele
Fakten in meinem Hirn habe und es war
schlichten ergreifend peinlich für ihre
gesamte Partei was Sarah Wagenknecht
sich dort geleistet hat
die SPD ist dankbar ohne Ende des Oskar
Lafontaine in irgendwann den Rücken
gekehrt hat und dass er auch in der
schwuppler Ecke bald andere Menschen
sich beschäftigen kann der hat sie
selber im Saarland im Stich gelassen
nicht darf sie daran erinnern viel Spaß
mit diesen Freunden die sie da haben und
die da drüben sind laut hufeisentheorie
heute aber ganz ganz besonders bei ihnen
angedockt und ich finde das fürchterlich
peinlich das ausgerechnet die
Linkspartei und die AFD hier im Hohen
Haus von uns verlangen dass wir für Sie
eine Paartherapie machen wie meine
Kollegin stark Zimmermann vorhin schon
angemerkt hat das ist nicht unsere
Aufgabe ja aber versuchen Sie sich
wirklich und das kann ich Ihnen nur
raten von den Rechten in diesem Haus
abzugrenzen weil ansonsten wird sie
wirklich niemand mehr davor retten
können dass sie in der politischen
Bedeutungslosigkeit Deutschlands
gelangen werden und fragen Sie doch mal
ganz offen gesagt was starten wie das
aus dem Baltikum wie Finland oder Polen
von ihrem Antrag halten die Antwort
können Sie gerne am Moskau weiterleiten
ich gehe davon aus dass ihr Draht dort
immer noch am besten ist und wenn ich
daran erinnern darf Vladimir Putin hat
kurz nach dem Ausbruch des ukrainekriegs
im Fernsehen in Russland gesagt dass er
die Machtverhältnisse von 1990
wiederherstellen möchte und Wladimir
Putin weiß was er gesagt hat er hat
damit auch Ostdeutschland gemeint und
wer der Meinung ist dass die DDR
wiedererstehen soll das können
eigentlich in diesem Haus nur sie wollen
weil sie dann offensichtlich zu ihrer
alten Machtfülle zurückkehren wollen
hier werden uns mit aller Macht
dagegenstellen die Freiheit Europas und
der Bundesrepublik zu verteidigen das
ist Aufgabe dieser Bundesregierung und
der sie tragenden koalitionsfraktion
[Applaus]
von den Liberalen hier mit Tipps in
Richtung der Linken die dort wenn ich
die Reaktionen richtig gedeutet habe
nicht so richtig gut ankam nicht
überraschend
nächster jetzt für die Sozialdemokratie
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir debattieren
im Deutschen Bundestag heute über einen
Antrag der Fraktion DIE LINKE diese
möchte ich mit Ihnen einmal genauer
durchgehen nicht Wort für Wort keine
Sorge aber doch einige auffällige
Passagen
DIE LINKE fordert ein Ende des Krieges
eine Aussage die wir im Grundsatz
mittragen nach 371 Tagen des brutalen
russischen Angriffskrieges gegen die
Ukraine wünschen sich alle
demokratischen Partner einen Frieden in
der Ukraine in Europa weiter im Text
heißt es sinngemäß mit Frieden
beziehungsweise über Frieden zusammen
mit europäischen und nicht europäischen
Staaten zum Beispiel Brasilien zu
verhandeln auch hier im Grundsatz in
Ordnung wir müssen das breite Spektrum
diplomatischer Möglichkeiten weiter
ausreizen zum Beispiel mit China oder
Indien in bilateralen gesprächsformaten
oder im Rahmen von multilater treffen
wie geht 20 war schon passiert macht
unsere Außenministerin unser
Bundeskanzler unser
Bundesverteidigungsminister erlauben Sie
mir eine weitere Stelle aus dem Antrag
wiederzugeben und da möchte ich fair
sein
sie sagen die humanitäre Hilfe für die
Ukraine muss verstärkt werden und dann
bitte ich auch fernes von ihrer Seite
uns gegenüber und auch von Ihnen Herr
Gregor Gysi denn mein Kollege Jürgen
Jürgen Trittin hat es auf den Punkt
gebracht es ist einer unserer
Schwerpunkte außen Sicherheitspolitik
auch in Entwicklung zum Arbeitspolitik
die Ukraine humanitär und auch im
Bereich der katast Katastrophenhilfe zu
unterstützen aktuell seit Kriegsbeginn
mit 12,5 Milliarden Euro und wenn sie
sagen dass wir nicht bereit sind dann
ist das die Unwahrheit und ist die Lüge
und muss auch so zu Protokoll gegeben
werden
so jetzt kommen wir aber mal zu den
Dingen die nicht drin stehen und die
nicht thematisiert werden ob bewusst
oder unbewusst beides bezeichne ich aber
als fahrlässig beginnen wir gleich beim
Titel ihres Antrags der Titel Diplomatie
statt Panzer impliziert zwei
fundamentale falsche Grundannahmen wenn
wir erstens die diplomatischen
Bemühungen hochfahren und zweitens die
Ukraine aufhören militärisch zu
unterstützen dann wäre aus der Logik der
Linksparteien mit einmal der Krieg
gestoppt
das heißt der Krieg wäre zu Ende wenn
wir aufhören würden militärisch zu
unterstützen und ausschließlich
Diplomatie am Tag liegen meiner Meinung
nach meine Damen und Herren ist das ein
Trugschluss und lassen Sie mich ganz
ganz deutlich sagen es wäre der
Todesstoß für eine demokratische freie
und souveräne Ukraine
Diplomatie gab es schon vor dem
russischen vor der russischen Invasion
vor dem
24.22 als die russische Invasion
gestartet hat und in der Zeit wurde
nicht einmal darüber diskutiert Kampf
und Schützenpanzer in nahbarer Zeit zu
liefern und trotzdem haben alle
diplomatischen versuche nicht geholfen
weil Russland nicht bereit ist von
seinen Kriegsziel abzuweichen das kriegt
sie Putins ist ganz klar die Ukraine ist
kein Staat für Sie es hat kein
Existenzrecht und die ukrainische Nation
gibt es nicht deshalb bombardiert
Russland Putin seit über einem Jahr die
Ukraine und unschuldige Menschen
verlieren ihr Leben Frauen werden
vergewaltigt Kinder werden in führt
Soldaten auf beiden Seiten verlieren ihr
Leben und ich möchte an dieser Stelle
nicht aufhören diesen Denkfehler der
Linkspartei jetzt weiter aufzuschließen
sondern lassen Sie uns meinen Szenarien
denken vor allem weil die Leute draußen
noch zugucken mir ist es wichtig nicht
vor allem sie zu überzeugen sondern die
Menschen da draußen die vielleicht noch
nicht hundertprozentig verstehen was wir
gerade tun und das ist auch in Ordnung
weil es nicht selbstverständlich ist in
einer Zeit zu leben aufzuwachsen in
einem Krieg und Waffen liefern zu müssen
Szenario würde Putin aufhören mit dem
Krieg wenn wir keine Waffen mehr liefern
würde es einen echten Waffenstillstand
geben wenn wir aufhören Waffen zu
liefern und die russischen Soldaten
würden sich zurückziehen würde die Angst
viele andere osteuropäischen Länder
Finnlands oder Schweden schwinden und
sie die Garantie bekommen frei vom
autoritären destabilisieren Russen
Einfluss zu sein und ich sage Ihnen ganz
klar die Antworten noch alle drei dieser
Punkte lautet ganz klar nein lassen Sie
mich deutlich sagen Putin würde
weitermachen mit Diplomatie und ohne
Waffen er würde nicht zurückstrecken er
würde weiter versuchen die Ukraine
gewaltsam auseinander zu pflücken und es
ist immer wichtig das zu betonen
Friedensverhandlungen auf jeden Fall auf
Augenhöhe jederzeit lieber gestern als
morgen aber jede Waffenpause russische
Waffenpause würde Putin nutzen um sich
vorzubereiten
aufzurüsten aufzurüsten und gewaltsam
bei einem Zeitpunkt X weiterzumachen die
Ukraine von der Landkarte wegzufinden
alles andere ist doch Humbug Liebe
Linksfraktion alles andere zumbuk
deshalb müssen wir die Ukraine
diplomatisch finanziell humanitär aber
auch militärisch unterstützen und zum
Schluss wenn sie wirklich glaubwürdig
solidarisch an der Seite der Ukraine
stehen wollen eine nachhaltigen echten
Frieden wollen dann distanzieren sie
sich geschlossen von Sahra Wagenknecht
schmeißen sie aus der Fraktion raus und
danach aus der Partei erst dann sind
ihre Worte glaubwürdig und die
Solidarität mit der Ukraine ebenfalls
vielen Dank
Herr Alisa metovic für die SPD-Fraktion
diesen Antrag den die Linke hier
eingebracht hat nach einem sofortigen
Stopp an den Waffenlieferung und nach
friedensverhandlung an die
Bundesregierung der hat sich und das ja
nicht überraschend auch immer mehr zu
einer Wagenknecht Debatte hier
entwickelt die Linke hat alle aber
allerdings kein Rede recht mehr in
dieser Debatte kann also jetzt nicht
mehr direkt reagieren für die Union
nimm ganze Landstriche vernichtet wurden
ein Jahr in dem wir alle gerungen haben
um die notwendige Unterstützung für die
mutigen Ukrainerinnen Ukrainer die auch
unsere Freiheit und unsere Sicherheit
verteidigen Putin hat nicht nur die
Ukraine angegriffen er will die
Europäische friedens- und
sicherheitsordnung zerstören diese
europäische Friedensordnung ist
ausformuliert meine Damen und Herren in
Verträge gegossen und da schreiben sie
von der linke in ihrem Antrag von einer
dauerhaften Lösung die die
Sicherheitsinteressen sämtlicher Akteure
berücksichtigen müssen und schon allein
damit wir klar dass sie nur
russenpropaganda verbreiten einem
diktatfrieden das Wort reden und dazu
ist eigentlich in dieser Debatte nun
schon alles gesagt
meine Damen und Herren den
Jahrestag des Überfalls konnte ich mit
Vorsitzenden und Stellvertretern
auswärtiger Ausschüsse aus 13
europäischen Ländern in Kiew verbringen
ein Zeichen der Solidarität in der
Hauptstadt eines freien und
demokratischen Landes die vom Krieg
gezeichnet ist 10.000 Menschen haben
durch sinnlose Zerstörung ihre Wohnung
verloren ich konnte in diese freie Stadt
fahren weil tapfere Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer vor einem Jahr nicht aufgegeben
haben
weil sie diese Stadt verteidigt haben
und dafür müssten sie auch
schrecklichste Gräueltaten ertragen wie
zum Beispiel Butcher und andere Orte
gezeigt haben und damit wird auch eines
klar in den besetzten Gebieten herrscht
kein Frieden auch nicht nach einem
Waffenstillstand den sie fordern eine
besetzten Gebieten sind Ukrainerinnen
und Ukrainer Menschen zweiter Klasse die
vergewaltigt verschleppt gefoltert
ermordet werden für Kriegsverbrecher
Putin zählt das rechte stärkeren und
nicht Vereinbarungen und Verträge das
hat er nun immer und immer wieder
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Jahrestag in Kiew war für mich ein
Tag der Demut und des Respekts vor der
Leistung die ukrainische Soldaten bisher
Tag für Tag vollbracht haben
aber er war auch ein Tag an dem deutlich
wurde dass es auf jede noch so kleine
Unterstützung ankommt das ist auch
Geschwindigkeit ankommt dass jeder Tag
zählt bei der Lieferung von Gerät und
Munition und das ist auf
Durchhaltefähigkeit ankommt die wir
sicherstellen müssen und dass wir dazu
unsere Trägheit überwinden müssen
vor knapp zehn Monaten schon wurde hier
entschieden dass wir einen Teil unserer
Haubitzen liefern den ukrainen Ukrainern
zur Verfügung stellen zehn Monate und
seitdem ist wieder die Bestellung für
die erschafft für die Ersatzbeschaffung
ausgelöst
seitdem ist wieder eine Bestellung von
Verschleißteilen und Munition erfolgt
zehn Monate meine Damen und Herren in
denen nicht ein bisschen vorausgedacht
wurde in denen in dieser Regierung
offenbar nicht klar wurde auf was es
ankommt ist das die Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit von der der Kanzler
heute sprach Estland ergreift jetzt die
Initiative bei der munitionsbeschaffung
weil wir es verschlafen haben
und dabei kommt noch eine wichtige
Aufgabe hinzu nämlich einmal über die
nächsten Monate hinauszudenken
vielleicht müssen wir nicht
14haubitzen nachbestellen sondern
vielmehr weil in Zukunft Sicherheit für
die Ukraine Ukraine und für ganz Europa
sehr stark durch die Wehrhaftigkeit und
die abschreckungsfähigkeit der
ukrainischen Armee sichergestellt werden
wird und weitere Realitäten sind klar
die Ukraine ist ein europäisches Land
Neutralität und die Militarisierung
hatten wir schon die Ukraine wird in
eine westliche verteidigungsarchitektur
eingebunden sein dazu braucht es jetzt
endlich kräftigere Schritte unserer
Bundesregierung und dazu braucht es
keine ständige Wiederholung von Russen
Propaganda wie wir sie hier von links
und rechts ständig erleben wir müssen
dauerhaft klarmachen dass die
größenwahnsinnigen Träume Putins keine
Aussicht auf Erfolg haben
wir müssen jeden Tag klarmachen dass wir
an der Seite der Ukraine stehen mit
allem was nötig ist bis die Ukraine
komplett befreit ist bis Europa mit in
eine friedliche Zukunft blicken kann
herzlichen Dank
Thomas Erndte der stellvertretende
Vorsitzender des Auswärtigen Ausschusses
hier im Bundestag und einreden haben wir
noch zu diesem debattenpunkt der kommt
aus den Rhein der Sozialdemokraten
Fabian Funke
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren ich glaube ich weiß
warum sie von den Linken diesen Antrag
gestellt haben er ist die Reaktion auf
das Groteske Schauspiel dass ich am
vergangenen Samstag vor dem
Brandenburger Tor abgespielt hat er ist
ein verzweifelter Versuch das wieder
einzufangen was ich leider nicht mehr
einzufangen lässt und es zeigt wie tief
sie gespalten sind wir haben gesehen am
Wochenende und dann möchte ich kurz auf
die Demo eingehen wie Menschen mit
ukrainischen Symbolen angepöbelt und
beleidigt wurden wie sich auch
Querdenker und rechtsradikale dahinter
versammelt haben und wie von der Bühne
ein eigenartiges zerbild des russischen
Krieges gezeichnet wurde und was haben
wir in den letzten Monaten nicht alles
gehört die Amerikaner haben Schuld am
Überfall Russland auf die Ukraine
Russland möchte eigentlich nur
Sicherheit und die NATO ist sowieso an
einem Schuld das ist bedenklich er
Unsinn
und es ist das gute Recht der
TeilnehmerInnen eine solche
Demonstration durchzuführen und für
Frieden zu demonstrieren ist
grundsätzlich sympathisch es ist aber
genauso das Recht aller anderen zu sagen
was ihr sagt ist schädlich und das ist
ein keine Zensur und das ist auch nicht
autoritär das ist der Kern unserer
Demokratie und Sie müssen sich schon die
Frage gefallen lassen worum
Bundestagsabgeordnete und
spitzenfunktionärinnen ihrer Partei
immer wieder ein massives Problem damit
haben sich vom russischen Regime zu
distanzieren Wladimir Putin steht an der
Spitze eines gleichgeschalteten Staates
der seit Februar 2022 den Alltag seiner
Bürgerinnen und Bürger durch
meditalisiert extrem
Russland als die heilige Nacht die ihre
Heimat er hatte von Satan befreien muss
Putins Russland ist eine
menschenverachtende Diktatur und da
sollte es einer Linkspartei sich nicht
schwer fallen davon zu anzieren und mit
den Opfern dieser Aggression zu
solidarisieren das was aus Teilen der
Linkspartei in den letzten Monaten kommt
ist hochgradig
wir alle hier wollen Frieden und das
lieber heute als morgen aber dafür muss
man erstmal in der Lage sein klar zu
benennen wer diesen Frieden gefährdet
und das ist zweifelsohne und einzig und
allein das Regime Putins und auch
deshalb möchte ich am Ende dieser
Debatte noch mal mit ein paar Mythen
aufräumen Mythos Nummer 1 die
Verhandlungsbereitschaft Russlands hat
er diese ja auch thematisiert und quasi
neben dem Antrag gleich den zweiten
Friedensplan der Linken heute
mitgeliefert und da frage ich mich
wirklich wenn man die Debatte der
letzten Monate verfolgt sieht man dass
Putins Russland kein Interesse an
Frieden hat sondern weiterhin das
einzige Ziel darin besteht den
ukrainischen Staat aufzulösen und die
Souveränität der Ukraine zu vernichten
und selbst Chinas Friedensplan von dem
wir ja auch ehrlich gesagt alle wissen
dass er am Ende auch keiner ist selbst
den hat man im Kreml abgelehnt wo sehen
Sie die Verhandlungsbereitschaft
Russlands Mythos Nummer zwei
Waffenlieferungen stoppen sorgt für
Frieden und es ist ja völliga Unsinn das
wurde hier auch schon ein paar mat
standardisiert Russland würde
weitermachen wir würden weiter
Situationen wie in Butcher und irpin
bekommen und ganz ehrlich sie fordern
die ganze Zeit Verhandlungen aber wenn
die Ukraine nicht mehr existiert weil
sie sie sich nicht mehr verteidigen kann
mit wem soll Russland dann überhaupt
noch verhandeln und Mythos Nummer drei
die Bundesregierung tut nichts anderes
als Waffen zu liefern und das ist
ehrlich gesagt einer meiner
lieblingssätze auch so sinngemäß aus
diesem Antrag und da muss ich sagen
haben sie die Regierungsarbeit der
letzten 12 Monate aber wahnsinnig
schlecht verfolgt wir sind einer der
größten Geberländer der Ukraine mit
finanziellen Mitteln mit humanitäre
Hilfe wir haben wirklich eine große Zahl
von Krieg geflüchteter Menschen aus der
Ukraine aufgenommen und ja wir liefern
auch Waffen aber das deutsche Engagement
in der Ukraine darauf
zurückzuziehen ist einfach unwahr
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Linksfraktion ich würde Sie bitten
sprechen Sie lieber mal mit den Leuten
die gemeinsam mit rechts außen am
Wochenende demonstrieren gehen über
diese Mythen Stadt das Plenum mit diesem
halbgaren zwei Punkte Friedensplan zu
beschäftigen ich glaube dann werden uns
allen mehr geholfen vielen Dank
ja und Fabian Funke hat hier für die SPD
das noch mal aus seiner Sicht
zusammengefasst und einige Punkte
angesprochen die immer wieder hinter
Debatte vorkam die Linke die hatte ihre
ganze Redezeit sie hat auch in diesen
Debatten nicht so viel weil sie die
kleinste Fraktion ist also ihre ganze
Redezeit ihrem außenpolitischen Sprecher
Gregor Gysi überlassen konnte also im
weiteren Verlauf der Debatte dann nicht
mehr eingreifen der Antrag der Linken
Teile Überraschung der wird hier im
Plenum abgelehnt ja der Bundestag hat
jetzt einige andere Abstimmung noch
vorzunehmen das ganze ohne Aussprache in
ungefähr 10 Minuten geht es dann aber
weiter hier mit einer aktuellen Stunde
da wird es um die Bahnstreiks im
öffentlichen Dienst gehen dann melden
uns wieder von hier in der Zwischenzeit
informiert sie aber über weitere
aktuelle Ereignisse meine Kollegin Ines
Arland in Bonn überweisen gibt es
weitere überweisungsvorschläge das ist
nicht der Fall dann ist so geschlossen
und wir verfahren wie vorgeschlagen ich
rufe auf die Tagesordnungspunkte 26 a
bis P es handelt sich um die
Beschlussfassung zu Vorlagen zu den
keine Aussprache vorgesehen ist
Beschlussempfehlung des Rechtsausschuss
zu dem Antrag der Fraktion der AFD mit
dem Titel Meinungsfreiheit schützen
keine Zensur von telegram die Ausschuss
empfiehlt in seiner Beschlussempfehlung
auf Drucksache 44 71 den Antrag der
Fraktion der AFD auf Drucksache 10 29
abzulegen wer stimmt für die
Beschlussempfehlung
das sind die Fraktion linken der SPD
sich die Grünen FDP und cdu/csu wer
stimmt dagegen das ist die afd-fraktion
bis sich jemand enthalten das ist nicht
der Fall damit ist die
Beschlussempfehlung angenommen
die Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses
für innere sind Heimat zu dem Antrag der
Fraktion der AFD mit dem Titel
Digitalisierung der öffentlichen
Verwaltung beschleunigen Anforderungen
an ein online-zugangsgesetz 20
berücksichtigen der Ausschuss empfiehlt
in seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
Drucksache 56 05 den Antrag der Fraktion
der AFD auf Drucksache 2587 abzulehnen
wer stimmt für die Beschlussempfehlung
die Linke weiß noch nicht
dann warten wir einen kleinen Moment
damit wir Bescheid wissen
ihr seid dagegen okay also dann ist aber
gegen die Beschlussempfehlung oder für
die Beschlussempfehlung
also noch mal wer ist für die
Beschlussempfehlung
wer ist dagegen
wer enthält sich damit ist bei
Gegenständen der AFD und kein Enthaltung
die Beschlussempfehlung mit den Stimmen
der übrigen Fraktion des Hauses
angenommen wir kommen zu 26c die
Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses für
Gesundheit zu dem Antrag der Fraktion
der AFD mit dem Titel Einführung Aufbau
und Betrieb eines nationalen
mortalitätsregisters für
Forschungszwecke der Ausschuss empfiehlt
in seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
drucksach 51/93 den Antrag der Fraktion
der AFD auf Drucksache 45 66 abzulegen
wer stimmt für die Beschlussempfehlung
wer stimmt dagegen wer enthält sich
damit ist die beschussempfehlung
angenommen die AFD hat dagegen gestimmt
niemand hat sich enthalten alle anderen
waren dafür
Tagesordnungspunkt 26d
Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschuss für
Gesundheit zu dem Antrag der Fraktion
der AFD mit dem Titel Verordnung zur
Sicherstellung der Versorgung der
Bevölkerung mit Produkten des
medizinischen Bedarfs bei der durch das
Coronavirus darf Kopf 2 verursachten
Epidemie sofort außer Kraft setzen der
Ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache 44 35
den Antrag der AFD auf Drucksache 32 71
abzulegen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
wer stimmt dagegen wer enthält sich
damit ist die Beschlussempfehlung
angenommen die AFD hat dagegen gestimmt
niemand hat sich enthalten alle anderen
Fraktionen haben dafür gestimmt es ist
egal wie viele Leute von den Fraktionen
vertreten die Fraktion vertreten
Tagesordnungspunkt 26e bis P wir kommen
zu den Beschlussempfehlungen des
Petitionsausschusses sammelübersicht 271
auf Drucksache 55 71 es handelt sich
hierbei um 73 Petitionen wer stimmt
dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
[Musik]
Enthaltungen damit ist die
sammelübersicht einstimmig angenommen
wir kommen zusammen Übersicht 272 auf
Drucksache 55 72 hier geht es um 71
Petitionen wer stimmt dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
Enthaltungen damit ist die
sammelübersicht einstimmig angenommen
sammelübersicht 273 auf Drucksache 55 73
hier geht es um 63 Petitionen wer stimmt
dafür
dagegen
Zeitungen einstimmig angenommen
sammelübersichtshof 74 auf Drucksache 55
74 das sind 82 Petitionen wer stimmt
dafür
bestimmt dagegen
Enthaltungen damit es die
sammelübersicht angenommen bei
Gegenstimmen der Fraktion DIE LINKE alle
anderen haben dafür gestimmt
sammelübersicht 275 auf Drucksache 55 75
das sind 19 Petitionen wer stimmt dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
Enthaltungen die sammelübersicht ist
angenommen dagegen hat die afd-fraktion
gestimmt alle anderen dafür
sammelübersicht zu 76 auf Drucksache 55
67 das sind acht Petitionen wer stimmt
dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
Enthaltungen die sammelübersicht ist
einstimmig angenommen sammelübersicht
277 auf Drucksache 55 77 hier geht es um
drei Petitionen wer stimmt dafür
bestimmt dagegen
Enthaltungen
vielen Dank die Fraktion DIE LINKE hat
dagegen gestimmt alle anderen dafür
damit sie sammelübersicht angenommen
sammelübersicht 278 auf Drucksache 55 78
das sind zwei Petitionen wer stimmt
dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich vielen Dank die sammelt
über sich das angenommen die Fraktion
der cdu/cs
79 auf Drucksache 55 79 das ist eine
Petition wer stimmt dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
Enthaltungen
dagegen haben gestimmt die Fraktion der
cdu/csu und die Linke alle anderen dafür
damit ist die sammelübersicht angenommen
sammelübersicht zu 80 auf Drucksache
55,80 wer stimmt dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
enthält sich vielen Dank dafür haben
bestimmte Koalitionsfraktionen und die
Linke cdu/csu und AFD haben dagegen
gestimmt die Petition ist die
sammelübersicht ist angenommen
sammelübersicht 2 81 auf Drucksache
55/81 das sind 9 Petition wer stimmt
dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
Enthaltungen vielen Dank die
sammelübersicht ist angenommen bei
Zustimmung durch die koalitionsfraktion
und die Linke die Fraktion der CDU CSU
und der AFD haben dagegen gestimmt
sammelübersicht 22 82 auf Drucksache 55
8200 164 petitionen sind das wer stimmt
dafür
sind die koalitionsfraktion bestimmt
dagegen
enthält sich vielen Dank da die
koalitionsfraktion haben dafür gestimmt
die anderen Fraktionen dagegen niemand
hat sich enthalten die sammelt über sich
das angenommen jetzt rufe ich auf den
Zusatzpunkt aktuelle Stunde die Fraktion
DIE LINKE hat eine Aktuelle Stunde
verlangt zu dem Thema
zusammen geht mehr für einen attraktiven
und verlässlichen öffentlichen Dienst
die Kollegin Janine Wissler ist die
erste Rednerin für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
liebe Beschäftigte im öffentlichen
Dienst wie viel verdient ein Busfahrer
in Leipzig
Einstiegsgehalt 13 Euro 84 pro Stunde
brutto wohlgemerkt das erzählt mir
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Leipziger
Verkehrsbetriebe als ich bei ihrer
streitkundgebung war und in Vollzeit ist
das ein Grundgehalt von etwa 2.300
brutto im Monat für einen fordernden Job
mit so viel Verantwortung im
Schichtdienst mit Arbeit an Sonne und
dann Feiertagen das sind Menschen die
den Laden am Laufen halten und sie
müssen jeden Euro umdrehen und nicht
selten ein Zweitjob annehmen meine Damen
und Herren der aktuellen Tarife
Auseinandersetzungen geht es um 2,5
Millionen Beschäftigte im öffentlichen
Dienst vom Hund und Kommunen Menschen
die unseren Müll entsorgen vielen Dank
und die Aktuelle Stunde hat gerade
angefangen beantragt von der Linken es
geht um die Tarifverhandlungen im
öffentlichen Dienst es spricht die
parteivor Janine
was sie sich wünschen die streiken eine
Leipzig sagt mir gute Arbeitsbedingungen
höhere Löhne und vor allem Wertschätzung
Wertschätzung für ihre Arbeit und die
drückt sich eben nicht in Sonntagsreden
aus damit warmen Worten kann man
bekanntlich keine Rechnungen bezahlen
wir unterstützen die Forderungen der
Gewerkschaften nach 10,5% mehr Lohn
mindestens 500 Euro sowie 200 Ausweg die
bundesinnenministerin Feser bietet fünf
Prozent mehr Lohn an für die nächsten 27
Monate und nur drei Prozent in diesem
Jahr und das nicht mal ab sofort sondern
ab dem 1 oktober bei einer Inflation von
fast 9 Prozent und das nennt
bundesinnenministerin faesar ein faires
Angebot und Ausdruck von Respekt das ist
kein Angebot das ist eine Frechheit das
bedeutet eine Lohnsenkung das weiß
profeser auch ganz genau mit Respekt hat
das überhaupt nicht zu tun die erinnern
wir uns die systemrelevanten die
corona-heldinnen und Helden die kann man
noch nicht unterhalb des
Inflationsausgleich abspeisen so dass
sie am Ende noch weniger Geld in der
Tasche haben als vorher und die
Einmalzahlungen die helfen nicht
langfristig und die bringen auch für die
Rente gar nichts meine Damen und Herren
wenn man mit Kolleginnen und Kollegen
spricht dann berichten Sie vom
Personalmangel und von der Überlastung
in den Kitas in der sozialen Arbeit in
den Krankenhäusern in der öffentlichen
Verwaltung das ist der viel gepriesene
schlanke Stadt nämlich die Folge von
Privatisierung von Personal und
Bürokratieabbau Maßnahmen die er
angeblich alles viel effizienter machen
sollten und heute zeigt sich was es
bedeutet wenn man den öffentlichen
Dienst kaputt spart nämlich lange
Wartezeiten bei den Bürgerämtern
Bauanträge die ewig dauern und
geschlossene Einrichtungen die
personaldecken vielen Kitas ist so dünn
dass wenige Krankheitsfälle dazu führen
können dass die tageweise geschlossen
werden muss und die leitragenden sind
Kinder und Eltern die Beschäftigten in
den Krankenhäuser sind seit Jahren
völlig überlastet und deshalb sagen die
Streitenden von Verdi zurecht nicht
unser Streik gefährdet die Patienten der
zumal der Normalzustand im
Krankenhäusern der gefährdet die
Patientinnen und Patienten
und da ist es doch kein Wunder dass
immer mehr Beschäftigte gehen der
corona-bonus kam bei vielen gar nicht an
die versprochenen Verbesserung bei der
Personalbemessung die stehen unter
Lindner Vorbehalt und jetzt noch eine
faktische Lohnsenkung sieht so gute
Gesundheitsversorgung aus das ist doch
wirklich unwürdig meine Damen und Herren
die Beschäftigten streiken für uns alle
sie streiten für ihre Patientinnen und
Patienten sie streiten für die Fahrgäste
die Kita-Kinder für die Daseinsvorsorge
und das gilt auch für die Streitenden
bei der Deutschen Post bei der Bahn und
an den Flughafen die Post hat im letzten
Jahr ein Rekordgewinn von 8,4 Milliarden
Euro eingefahren
ein Rekordgewinn die beschädigen die
Beschäftigten erarbeitet haben und die
müssen streiten für eine angemessene
Lohnerhöhung und deswegen stehen wir auf
der Seite der Beschäftigten bei der Post
die zustellbereiche werden immer größer
15 Prozent mehr Lohn ist eine absolut
berechtigte Forderung bei diesen hohen
Gewinnen
und jede
Frau
Angebote machen aber noch nicht darüber
diskutieren dass Streikrecht
einzuschränken meine Damen und Herren es
gibt in diesem Land Geld wie Heu aber es
ist nicht ungerecht verteilt und werden
Bund und Kommunen trotz steigender
Steuereinnahmen nicht genug Geld haben
ihre Leute vernünftig zu bezahlen ja da
muss man halt endlich mal ran an die
Spitzenverdiener und vermögenden diesem
Land und man würde sich wünschen dass
sie Erzieherinnen und Pflegekräfte
ähnlich hörbare Lautsprecher in der
Ampel hätten wie wäre es um die Rüstung
geht Frau Präsident ich komme zum
Schluss die streiken im öffentlichen
Dienst bei der Post an dem Flughafen sie
haben unsere volle Solidarität in
Frankreich streiken Millionen gegen die
Renten gegen die Erhöhung des
Renteneintrittsalter in Großbritannien
gibt es große streiquellen verschiedene
Länder verschiedene Branchen eine
Bewegung dafür dass die Beschäftigten
angemessenen gesellschaftlichen Reichtum
beteiligt worden letzter Satz
zusammengeht mehr Tourismus
in diesem Sinne alles gute Dinge
Gewerkschaften und den Beschäftigten für
den streiten
Januar laufen die Tarifverhandlungen für
die rund 2,5 Millionen Beschäftigten im
öffentlichen Dienst von Bund und
Kommunen das ganze doch relativ zäh man
ist noch nicht zueinander gekommen
deswegen gibt es seit Wochen ja auch
Bahnstreiks betroffen unter anderem
Nahverkehr die Kitas die Müllabfuhr die
Straßenreinigung und wer die hat
angekündigt in den kommenden Tagen diese
waren Streiks noch auszuweiten
Höhe von 2 Milliarden Euro erdrückt
sie haben kein Geld um in Ihre Zukunft
zu investieren sie haben kein Geld um
sich den Eigenanteil der Förderprogramme
zu leisten und sie haben nicht die
Finanzmittel für ausreichend Personal
dass sie vielen möglichen vorderanträge
schreiben können
selbstverständlich ist ein
Tarifabschluss nach Maßgabe der
Abschlüsse der Metall- und
Chemieindustrie wünschenswert weil auch
die Beschäftigten im öffentlichen Dienst
von der hohen Inflation betroffen sind
weil wir heute in den öffentlichen
Dienst investieren müssen um morgen ein
handlungsfähigen Staat zu haben der
öffentliche Dienst ist zwingend
erforderlich um gesellschaftliches
Zusammenleben in Deutschland zu
organisieren wir brauchen die
Beschäftigten in den städtischen
Betrieben wir brauchen die städtischen
Kindergärten Kitas und Schulen wir
brauchen den öffentlichen Dienst im
Gesundheitssektor in der polizeilichen
Gefahrenabwehr im zivil und
Katastrophenschutz wir brauchen das
Personal bei der Energieversorgung der
Abfallwirtschaft und der allgemeinen
Verwaltung
der öffentliche Dienst umfasst auch die
sozialen Sicherungssysteme sie würden
das Rückgrat haben vereinbar
Vielfalt Gleichstellung und flexible
Arbeitsbedingungen schaffen damit
familienberuf weit besser miteinander
vereinbart werden können
den Personalaustausch und die Rotation
zwischen den verschiedenen Behörden
zwischen Bund und Länder sowie zwischen
Verwaltung und Privatwirtschaft
vereinfachen
die Einstellungsvoraussetzungen Richtung
praktischer berufsbilden Berufserfahrung
flexibilisieren
und derzeit laufen halt die
Verhandlungen im tarifbeschäftigen des
Bundes und der Kommunen
angesichts der hohen Inflation brauchen
wir eine Entlastung der Beschäftigung
und Beamten im öffentlichen Dienst wir
brauchen eine Perspektive wie wir den
öffentlichen Dienst insgesamt für die
Zukunft stärken wollen
[Applaus]
und dabei geht es einerseits um
wettbewerbsfähige Gehälter
andererseits geht es darum insbesondere
die Kommunen die Möglichkeit zu geben
für ihren Nachwuchs zu sorgen
nur wenn Sie heute ausreichend ausbilden
können werden sie in Zukunft ausreichend
qualifiziertes Personal haben
in meiner Heimat den Bergischen Land
aber auch in vielen anderen Regionen
Deutschlands können die Kommunen das
momentan nicht leisten der hohe
Schuldenstand verhindert Investitionen
in die Zukunft
wenn wir also darüber reden den
öffentlichen Dienst in all seinen
Bereichen zu stärken attraktiver zu
gestalten dann müssen wir auch über die
Finanzen reden und das heißt wir
brauchen noch in diesem Jahr den
altschulenform
ohne den altschonenform werden die
Kommunen in den letzten ihren letzten
Handlungsspielraum verlieren das gemeine
sehen das Gemeinwesen wird in den
Kommunen auch in Zukunft nur mit einem
starken öffentlichen Dienst
funktionieren und dafür brauchen wir
sofort den altschonendbau und entfernter
Schloss Dankern
[Applaus]
nicht nur Mitglied im Innenausschuss des
Bundestages sondern ist auch
Ehrenvorsitzende der deutschen
feuerwehrgewerkschaft
nächste Rednerin ist hier Petra
Nicolaisen für die Unionsfraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen bei den aktuellen
Tarifverhandlungen geht es um mehr als
2,4 Millionen Tarifbeschäftigte bei den
kommunalen Arbeitgebern und um rund
134.000 Tarifbeschäftigte des Bundes und
für uns als Union ist es natürlich eine
Selbstverständlichkeit dass die
Ergebnisse die der Tarifabschluss dann
erzielt natürlich Zeit und
wirkungsgleich auch die Beamtinnen
Beamten die Richterinnen und Richter und
die Soldatinnen und Soldaten übertragen
werden müssen ich bin mir sicher es
zweifelt auch niemand daran dass eine
Lohnanpassung bei der Jahresinflation im
Moment von fast acht Prozent und hohen
Energiekosten angemessen ist das gehört
zu unserem Verständnis von Gerechtigkeit
und sozialer Marktwirtschaft es geht
nicht nur um Entlastungsmaßnahmen der
Bundesregierung sondern es braucht einen
richtigen und fairen sozialen Ausgleich
aber die Menschen im öffentlichen Dienst
übernehmen nämlich höchst
verantwortungsvolle Aufgaben an der
Schnittstelle zwischen Staat
Gesellschaft Wirtschaft und Verwaltung
ob als Tarifbeschäftigte oder Beamte
beim Wirtschaftsministerium als
Pflegekräfte in kommunalen
Krankenhäusern oder Mitarbeiter bei den
kommunalen Stadtwerken die gute Arbeit
von motivierten Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern trägt dazu bei dass
Deutschland funktioniert hohe
Lebensqualität hat und ein attraktiver
Wirtschaftsstandort bleibt für mich ist
es ganz klar die Arbeitsleistungen der
Beschäftigten müssen gewürdigt werden
damit sie motiviert bleiben und die
Herausforderungen wie zum Beispiel bei
der Digitalisierung auch engagiert
angehen können eine Anpassung der Löhne
insbesondere auch mit Blick auf die
unteren Besoldungsgruppen ist also
angebracht ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
die Ministerin hier heute sitzt deswegen
sage ich jetzt noch mal Frau Ministerin
oder Herr Staatssekretär sie haben am
Verhandlungstisch als Tarifpartner
gesessen und sie sind zuständig für
Bundesbeamte und Tarifbeschäftigte des
Bundes mehr sonst könnte besser um die
Bedeutung des öffentlichen Dienstes
wissen als sie und dennoch
und dennoch haben sie in der vergangenen
Woche ein gemeinsames Angebot
unterbreitet bei dem die Vorstellung
noch meilenweit auseinander liegen mein
Eindruck ihre Bemühungen sind
unzureichend die Gewerkschaften sind
enttäuscht und sie bringen sich selbst
und die kommunalen Arbeitgeber in eine
schlechte Verhandlungsposition
Herr Staatssekretär sie hätten es besser
wissen müssen oder Frau Ministerin ich
hätte mir mehr Verhandlungsgeschick von
ihnen erhofft
die Beschäftigten haben ein gutes und
faires Verhandlungsergebnis verdient und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch wenn
sich die Fraktion DIE LINKE es manchmal
wünschen würde aber es ist nicht der
Deutsche Bundestag der über die
Tarifergebnisse entscheidet sondern es
sind die Tarifpartner die dies unter
sich verhandeln
und das ist auch gut so schließlich
haben wir eine in Artikel 9 des
Grundgesetzes garantierte Tarifautonomie
diese tarifautomie stellt sicher dass es
zu einer fairen aus zu einem fairen
Ausgleich kommt einem Gleichgewicht der
Interessen das ist richtig und wichtig
Ausgleich bedeutet dass auch die
finanzielle Situation auf der
Arbeitgeberseite berücksichtigt wird und
und Kommunen stehen vor schwierigen
Herausforderungen es muss viel Geld in
die Hand genommen werden um die neuen
Aufgaben zu bewältigen und Aufgaben wie
zum Beispiel Energiekrise Klimawandel
Digitalisierung Wohnungsbau
Gesundheitsversorgung Migration
Integration und und ich könnte
fortfahren ein finanzierbarer Vorschlag
ist in der derzeitigen Situation
zugegeben kein einfacher
Abwägungsprozess
aber die Beschäftigten haben ein
Interesse an einer
langfristig so sie lieben
Finanzsituation die Verlässlichkeit und
Planungssicherheit schafft
diese Planungssicherheit braucht der
öffentliche Dienst unter anderem beim
Fachkräftemangel der bis 2030 zunehmen
wird 1,5 Millionen Menschen werden aus
Altersgründen aus dem öffentlichen
Dienst ausschalten ohne ein attraktives
Arbeitsplatzangebot wird der öffentliche
Dienst nicht funktionieren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen deshalb
geht von der Tarif von den
Tarifverhandlungen eine Signalwirkung
aus es ist eine Chance den öffentlichen
Dienst in einer schwierigen Zeit
sichtbar und spürbar zu stärken
einigungserfolg wird allerdings
maßgeblich vom Verhandlungsgeschick und
der Kompromissfähigkeit der
Bundesministerin abhängen glaubt man den
Schilderungen der Gewerkschaften haben
wir davon bisher noch wenig gesehen
um es angelehnt an den aktuellen zu
sagen da geht auf jeden Fall noch mehr
denn auch eine Lösung kommt nicht von
allein herzlichen Dank
Gerte Müller
sich die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben hier
schon öfter über Tarifverhandlungen
geredet und jedes Mal habe ich darauf
hingewiesen dass Tarifverhandlungen
eigentlich kein Thema für den Bundestag
sind sondern tarifhandlungen sind Sache
der Tarifpartner und doch ist diese
Debatte heute gut denn nach den Streits
von Verdi gab es gleich wieder Stimmen
aus der Union
mittelstands- und Wirtschaftsunion
Kollegin Connemann die wieder ganz tief
in die Mottenkiste gegriffen haben unter
Streikrecht einschränken wollen und das
geht gar nicht das ist in keiner Weise
akzeptabel
in unserem in unserem Grundgesetz in
Artikel 9 steht aus gutem Grund und sehr
eindeutig dass sich alle Menschen in
Gewerkschaften organisieren und sich für
gute Arbeitsbedingungen einsetzen können
das Streikrecht ist genau dort im
Grundgesetz verankert auch wenn es nicht
wortwörtlich dort erwähnt wird es ist
ein wichtiges Instrument damit die
Gewerkschaften auf Augenhöhe
Tarifverhandlung führen können oder wie
ist das Bundesarbeitsgericht einmal
formuliert hat Tarifverhandlungen ohne
Streikrecht wären nichts anderes als
kollektives betteln das gilt auch für
die Beschäftigten im öffentlichen Dienst
und das sollten Sie die Union auch
endlich mal akzeptieren
und außerdem und außerdem gibt es beim
Arbeitskampf auch ausreichend
gerichtliche Kontrollinstanzen die
unverhältnismäßige Streits beenden bzw
unterbinden können abgesehen davon ist
Deutschland immer noch ein
vergleichsweise streikarmes Land und
daran ändern auch die Streiks im
öffentlichen Dienst bei post- oder
Flughäfen gar nichts für die Hysterie
und den wiederholten reflexartigen Ruf
nach Einschränkungen beim Streikrecht
gibt es also überhaupt keinen Grund
hören Sie also endlich damit auf
aber jetzt zu den Tarifverhandlungen ich
hoffe es kommt zu einem wirklich guten
Tarifabschluss denn die Beschäftigten im
öffentlichen Dienst sind wichtig in der
Pflege Familienhilfe Kitas kommunale
Kitas Krankenhaus Bauhof Müllabfuhr
Verwaltung sie alle halten das
gesellschaftliche Leben am laufen auch
während einer Pandemie und deshalb haben
die Beschäftigten Wertschätzung und
Anerkennung verdient und das bedeutet
Sie müssen angemessen fair und gerecht
entlohnt werden und das gilt ganz
besonders natürlich in Zeiten von
Inflation und hohen Energiepreisen ich
werde mich jetzt hier nicht für eine
irgendwelche Prozentzahl stark machen
aber ich hoffe dass sich die
Tarifpartner auf einen relevanten
Mindestbetrag einigen denn im
öffentlichen Dienst gibt es schon viele
Menschen die nicht wirklich
üppig verdienen und gerade sie müssen
von diesen Tarifverhandlungen
profitieren
bei den Tarifverhandlungen geht es um
Wertschätzung habe ich schon gesagt aber
es geht auch grundsätzlich darum dass
der öffentliche Dienst als Arbeitgeber
attraktiv ist das ist dann eine Antwort
auf den Fachkräftemangel und auch den
demografischen Wandel und deshalb bin
ich auch sicher dass die Tarifpartner am
Ende eine gute Lösung einen guten
Abschluss verhandeln werden und zum
Schluss komme ich jetzt doch noch mal
zum Thema Streik und zwar im doppelten
Sinne morgen am dritten märz gibt es
einen Aktionstag gemeinsam von Verdi und
Fridays for future sie kombinieren den
globalen klimastreik mit Warnstreiks im
öffentlichen Personal Personennahverkehr
gemeinsam kritisieren sie die
Arbeitsbedingungen in ÖPNV dabei geht es
um niedrige Löhne um Arbeitszeit und
Stress und vor allem um den eklatanten
Personalmangel der sich in Zukunft auch
noch weiter verschärfen wird aber das
Personal heute schon stark belastet und
genau hier muss ich unbedingt was
verändern
und gleichzeitig fordern Sie mit einer
gemeinsamen Erklärung dass die Emission
im Verkehrssektor endlich gesenkt werden
das Gelder für neue Autobahnen in
emissionsärmere Mobilität umgeleitet
wird sie fordern gemeinsam eine echte
mobilitätswende als Antwort auf den
Klimawandel verbunden mit Investitionen
in die Beschäftigten also Investitionen
in gute Arbeit und genau so muss es sein
Klimaschutz geht immer nur ökologisch
und sozial und deshalb sind wir von
diesem Aktionstag wirklich begeistert
und ich hoffe dass sich viele daran
morgen beteiligen werden vielen Dank
[Applaus]
soweit Beate Müller
und in nächster Redner ist und kein gott
schaut der finanzpolitische Sprecher der
afd-fraktion
[Musik]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren gestanden sie
mir vorab eine persönliche Bemerkung die
aber auch mit dem Debatten Gegenstand zu
tun hat gestern ist völlig überraschend
mein geliebter Mann mit dem ich 20 Jahre
zusammen und vier Jahre verpassen bin
gestorben
und ich habe mir gedacht was hätte er
heute zu dieser Debatte gesagt als
finanzinspektor als jemand der eben in
diesem öffentlichen Dienst arbeitet er
hätte gesagt wir und beim Finanzamt ob
Erbschaftssteuer Einkommensteuer
oder auch anderen Abteilungen die Kohle
rein und hier wird sie mit offenen
Händen rausgeschmissen er hätte gesagt
stellt euch doch den Problemen und
Interessen und Bedürfnisse von 82
Millionen Menschen hier im Lande und
holt nicht noch zwei oder drei Millionen
Probleme mit dazu damit alle am Ende des
Tages noch mehr Probleme haben wir geben
Geld aus und denken nicht an die
Probleme unserer eigenen Menschen
warum sage ich das weil er seit zehn
Jahren an Depressionen litt und wir
haben sehr viel getan zusammen und das
war verdammt schwer in der so reichen
Hansestadt Hamburg und diese Probleme
sind ihnen die schon länger hier sitzen
alle bekannt um geeignete Therapieform
ungeeignete Unterbringung zu finden
und dieses Problem anzugehen
man kann aber sagen selbst wenn man Geld
hat und wir können uns glaube ich über
Geld ja alle nicht beklagen
es ist schwer diese Menschen zu helfen
und das hat dann nichts mit gender Gaga
bin ich linksdrehend rechtsdrehend
welcher Konfession gehöre ich an zu tun
sondern das sind die Bedürfnisse der
Menschen die hier in diesem Lande leben
und die gehen sie seit Jahren nicht an
er hat er gesagt mit recht mit seiner
schwäbischen Schnauze ihr labert halt so
viel aber gebacken kriegt er nett und
das ist der Punkt hier gibt das Geld in
die falschen Kanäle wir wissen dass alle
mit der öffentlichen Verwaltung
beispiele gefällig die Hamburger Polizei
hat bis vor kurzem noch mit Windows 8
und 90 gearbeitet das ist sehr attraktiv
die Kollegin der linke macht hier eine
große Rede wer hat denn hier in Berlin
in diesem fails steht so lange mit
regiert und ist für diese Missstände in
der Verwaltung sie können nicht mal
Wahlen geschweige denn anderes
verantwortlich das sind die das sind sie
das sind Krokodil meine Damen und Herren
und natürlich steht meine Partei und ich
dafür das Arbeitnehmer ob nun in der
freien Wirtschaft oder im öffentlichen
Dienst
bei hoher anhaltender Inflation mehr
Lohn erhalten das ist absolut
nachvollziehbar aber mit dem eben
dargestellten kann man das eine eben
nicht mit dem anderen isoliert sehen und
wir und ich waren es schon seit längerem
und viele expertenstimmen nach langer
Zeit mal mit ein vor der sogenannten
lohnpreisspirale und die wird jetzt vor
der Tür stehen das heißt wir haben
sinkende reale weil die Inflation eben
schon wieder mit 8,7% vor der Tür steht
und die Gefahr liegt darin ich erinnere
mich an Herrn Klunker das wird der SPD
vielleicht weh tun und die 70er Jahre
ich erinnere an die Geschichte der
sogenannten Skala mobile aus Italien die
vierteljährlich automatisch das wäre
wahrscheinlich nach ihrem guster Gusto
die steigenden Preise angepasst hat das
führte 1980 in Italien zu einer
Inflation von
22%. meine Damen und Herren an dieser
Stelle muss klar gesagt sein dass die
Inflation ja überhaupt Kern dieser
Forderung ist und sie ist nicht vom
Himmel gefallen bereits im Jahr 2021
haben in Deutschland eine Inflation von
3,1% beobachten können also hören Sie
auf mit dem Märchen das wäre der Ukraine
Krieg oder andere Dinge ist erstmal ein
Loch in diesem Damm der Inflation dann
sparen sich die Inflation den Weg oder
mit dem Ex Bundesbank Präsidenten die
ist wie Zahnpasta ist sie erstmal aus
der Tube bekommen Sie die schwer zurück
Frau lagart hat hier die Maßnahmen viel
zu spät eingeleitet anders als die Fett
und sie kann ja auch nicht anders weil
sie haben alle zugeschaut und hier
kommen wir wieder zum Thema Deutschland
finanziert Gott und die Welt und
natürlich auch in der Transferunion
mittlerweile Europa sie haben zugeschaut
dass die EZB handlungsunfähig ist weil
sie wie ich es immer sage und so würde
es auch mein Mann sagen die Party und
deutsche Vita Staaten des Südens
finanzieren und dabei sind wir seit
Gründung meiner Partei daraufhin
es geht demnach am Ende gar nicht darum
dass dem Beschäftigten im öffentlichen
Dienst wäre Löhne und vor allen Dingen
gute Arbeitsbedingungen geliefert werden
schauen Sie sich manche Bürogebäude
manche Verwaltung mal an da fällt wie in
den Schulen der Prozess von der Decke
die wollen sie dahin mit der Wirtschaft
stehen sondern es muss am Ende des Tages
das große Ganze im Auge Wahrheiten
werden und da hätte mein Mario auch
wieder gesagt ihr steht wieder eure
Dogmen und ihre Ideologie über die
Realität der Bürger und ihre Probleme
und das ist das Kernproblem in diesem
Land mit den Parteien die länger hier
sitzen insoweit wünsche ich mir dass er
den Realität sind alle zusammen zurück
bekommen ich wünsche auch den
Angestellten und öffentlichen Dienst
[Applaus]
Dankeschön leb wohl Mario
Kai Gottschalk war das hier für die
afd-fraktion die afd-fraktion trauert
auch um sein die afd-politikerin Corinna
miazzka die gerade erst im Alter von nur
39 Jahren an Brustkrebs verstorben ist
unser Beileid für den Verlust
auszusprechen
und Katrin Göring-Eckardt hat ja auch
noch mal das Beileid im Namen des Hauses
ausgesprochen für den Verlust von Kai
Gottschalk
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
von den aktuellen Tarifverhandlungen im
öffentlichen Dienst sind ungefähr 2,5
Millionen Beschäftigte direkt oder
indirekt betroffen und so wenig der
Deutsche Bundestag oder die
Bundesregierung selbst über das Ergebnis
der Verhandlungen bestimmen kann so sehr
sind diese Verhandlungen doch Anlass den
Beschäftigten im öffentlichen Dienst an
dieser Stelle dank Respekt und
Anerkennung auszusprechen
und ich möchte das gerne tun mit Blick
vor allen Dingen auf zwei Gruppen und
mit Blick auf zwei Themen die gerade von
besonderer Relevanz sind das ist zum
einen das Thema der Migration wir haben
eine Situation in der im vergangenen
Jahr ungefähr eine Million Menschen aus
der Ukraine nach Deutschland gekommen
sind die müssen versorgt werden die
werden untergebracht die werden betreut
von Beschäftigten unterschiedlicher
staatlicher Ebenen wir haben aber auch
andere Menschen die nach Deutschland
gekommen sind aus Syrien aus dem Irak
aus Afghanistan Asylanträge gestellt
haben und insgesamt ergibt sich daraus
eine hohe Belastung für den öffentlichen
Dienst das gilt für die Bundespolizei
das gilt für die
Ämter vor Ort und all diesen Menschen
die sich um die Menschen die zu uns
kommen kümmern gilt ein besonderes Danke
schön
die zweite Gruppe die ich gerne
ansprechen möchte ist die Gruppe der
Soldatin und Soldaten es ist schon
angesprochen worden es ist guter Brauch
dass das Ergebnis dieser
Tarifverhandlungen dann auch zügig
übertragen wird auf weitere Bereiche des
öffentlichen Dienstes und hier müssen
wir auch denken an die Soldaten und
Soldaten und die Soldatinnen und
Soldaten die für uns im Auslandseinsatz
sind beispielsweise in Litauen die sich
derzeit in Deutschland kümmern um die
Ausbildung ukrainischer Soldaten die
leisten einen besonderen Beitrag und es
ist gut und richtig dass die Bundeswehr
auch wieder mehr ins Zentrum der
gesellschaftlichen Debatte rückt es ist
richtig das Zeitenwende nicht ein bloßes
Lippenbekenntnis ist sondern dass das
auch bedeutet dass wir uns mit den
Menschen die bei der Bundeswehr dienen
hier konkret auseinandersetzen und dass
wir sie auch besser entlohnen
es ist aber völlig klar und das ist hier
schon angeklungen das Respekt
Anerkennung und danke schön nicht alles
sein kann das warme Worte nicht alles
sein können sondern das ist am Ende auch
um eine bessere finanzielle Entlohnung
der Menschen gehen muss und es ist
nachvollziehbar dass bei diesen
finanziellen Belastung das bei dieser
hohen Inflation gerade im vergangenen
Jahr die Gewerkschaften entsprechende
Forderungen gestellt haben und ich kann
das sehr gut nachvollziehen gerade mit
Blick auf die unteren Besoldungsgruppen
hier muss es auch eine deutliche
Anhebung geben die Menschen müssen
spüren dass der Staat sie als Dienste in
dieser besonderen Situation nicht
alleine lässt und gleichzeitig
und gleichzeitig will ich an dieser
Stelle ein bisschen Verständnis dafür
zum Ausdruck bringen dass die
bundesinnenministerin und das
Bundesinnenministerium jetzt im ersten
Schritt nicht sofort sich die Forderung
der Gewerkschaften zu Eigenmacht denn
wir müssen auch mal daran denken wo das
Geld eigentlich herkommt mit dem die
Menschen im öffentlichen Dienst bezahlt
werden jeder Euro der im öffentlichen
Dienst ausgegeben wird der muss zunächst
in der Privatwirtschaft verdient werden
und deswegen ist es auch richtig dass
die Bundesregierung darauf achtet dass
das Geld nicht ohne jede Begründung und
ohne meiden Ruhe darüber nachzudenken ob
man auch an die Strukturen dran muss
ausgegeben wird und deswegen ist es
richtig hier aufzupassen jeder Euro muss
erst verdient werden und deswegen haben
wir vertrauen auch in das
behandlungsgeschickt der
bundesinnenministerin meine Damen und
Herren
ich glaube dass wir insgesamt wenn wir
über dieses Thema sprechen auch über den
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Rückhalt für
den öffentlichen Dienst sprechen müssen
und wenn wir sehen wie Polizeibeamten
Polizeibeamte bei Demonstrationen
angemacht werden wie schon Leute die
einfach nur im Bürgeramt sitzen von
beispielsweise reichsbürgern wirklich
ganz schrecklich behandelt werden dann
finde ich das unerträglich und deswegen
sind diese Auseinandersetzungen sind
diese Debatten hier auch ein Grund klar
zu machen der gesellschaftliche Rückhalt
für den öffentlichen Dienst er muss in
Deutschland besser werden
auch wir als Gesetzgeber können was
machen wir können uns das nicht nur
angucken was bei den Tarifverhandlungen
geschieht sondern wir haben als
Gesetzgeber auch eine eigene
Verantwortung und die hat ja das
Bundesinnenministerium gerade vorgelegt
einen Entwurf für ein Gesetz zur
Sicherstellung einer Amts angemessenen
bundesbesoldung und bundesversorgung wir
werden da im Einzelnen drüber sprechen
ich finde es nur wichtig dass wir mit
diesem Gesetz nicht bloß die
Rechtsprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts nachvollziehen
sondern dass wir dieses Gesetz auch
nutzen um ein paar strukturelle Reformen
im öffentlichen Dienst auf die Reihe zu
kriegen ich nenne stellvertretend aus
dem Koalitionsvertrag die Anerkennung
gleichwertiger beruflicher
Qualifikationen für höhere Karrierewege
im öffentlichen Dienst ich nenne
zweitens Einstellungsvoraussetzungen für
praktische Erfahrung zu öffnen und ich
nenne als drittes Beispiel die
IT-Fachkräfte den wir übrigens auch mal
ermöglichen müssen wieder aus dem
öffentlichen Dienst rauszukommen es ist
ja nicht unbedingt eine
lebensumscheidung als it-fachkraft sein
ganzes Leben beim Start zu arbeiten
sondern wird es vielleicht auch nur ein
paar Jahre machen in diese Richtung
sollten wir denken dann bin ich
optimistisch dass wir hier bald auch
wieder über diese Tarifverhandlung
sprechen nämlich das Ergebnis für die
Beamten und weitere Gruppen übernehmen
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
der Kollege Pascal Meister hat das Wort
für die Linke
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren ob bei der Müllabfuhr
den Wasserwerken der Krankenpflege den
Rettungsdiensten den Kitas oder in
vielen anderen Bereichen des
öffentlichen Dienstes die dort
Beschäftigten leisten ein
unverzichtbaren Dienst für die
Allgemeinheit und dafür haben sie unser
aller Dank mehr als verdient allein 2,5
Millionen von ihnen sind beim Bund in
den kommunalen Arbeitgebern beschäftigt
sie alle kämpfen aktuell um eine bessere
Bezahlung und bessere Arbeit und
Ausbildungsbedingungen und ich finde
dafür haben sie die größtmögliche
Unterstützung verdient
ich freue mich auch dass ein Vertretern
der Streikenden Pflegekräfte aus Berlin
hier heute auf der Tribüne unsere
Debatte beiwohnt und sicherlich auch das
was von den einzelnen Rednern Rednern
hier gesagt wurde zurückträgt ist doch
schon jetzt
unübersehbar dass der Personalmangel in
vielen Bereichen des öffentlichen
Dienstes drastische Konsequenzen hat ob
lange Wartezeiten bei den Bürgerämtern
Kita Schließung wegen Personalmangel
oder die Überlastung der Beschäftigten
in den Krankenhäusern und es droht noch
schlimmer zu werden bis zum Jahr 2030
wird allein beim Bund jeder dritte und
jede dritte beschäftigt den Rente gehen
hier muss endlich vorausschauender
gehandelt werden meine Damen und
denn qualifizierte und motivierte
Beschäftigte fallen nicht einfach vom
Himmel deshalb muss nach erfolgreicher
Ausbildung zum Beispiel automatisch
unbefristetes Arbeitsverhältnis
folgendes kann doch nicht sein dass man
die erst mal in der Befristung schickt
wenn man sie halten will meine Damen und
Herren
auch auf die Bezahlung öffentlichen
Dienst muss in vielen Bereichen deutlich
attraktiver werden doch aktuell leben
die dort Beschäftigten genau das
Gegenteil steigende Mieten hohe Preise
für Energie und Lebensmittel die hohe
Kosten sind insbesondere für diejenigen
den unteren Entgeltgruppen kaum noch zu
bewältigen und was ist alles anschaut
dann habe ich wirklich null Verständnis
dafür dass Innenministerin Fräser als
Verhandlungsführer in der öffentlichen
Arbeitgeber diese Sorgen der
Beschäftigten nach meinem Einschätzung
nicht wirklich ernst nimmt
eine Erhöhung von mickrigen 5% in zwei
Schritten für 27 Monate und das bei
einer Inflation von rund 14% alleine im
letzten und diesem Jahr laut den letzten
Prognosen das kann doch nicht ernst sein
da können da können auch einmal
Zahlungen nicht drüber hinweg täuschen
denn Einmalzahlungen das sagt das Wort
die kann man nur einmal auch ausgeben
die Preise aber werden dauerhaft hoch
bleiben und dass sich die
Arbeitgeberseite kategorisch weigert die
unteren Beschäftigten Gruppen besonders
zu lassen die besonders nötig haben und
stattdessen insbesondere die oberen
Entgeltgruppen überproportional dann
auch mit einer Lohnerhöhung dann
versorgen wir das macht keinen Sinn das
Spalte die Belegschaft und das ist nicht
gut
gefasst den bodenausschlägt allerdings
die Förderung Lohnkürzung ja Sie haben
richtig gehört Lohnkürzung in
Krankenhäusern und Pflegeeinrichtungen
mit dem neuen Tarifabschluss zu
ermöglichen erinnert sich in der
Bundesregierung noch irgendwer daran wie
wir hier alle für die Helden der
corona-krise wie wild geklatscht haben
und den höchster Respekt gezeugt wurde
und dann sowas
da muss das muss man den Ohren der
Beschäftigten der Pflegekräfte wie
blanker hohen klingen meine Damen und
ja viele Kliniken und
Pflegeeinrichtungen sind in einer
schwierigen wirtschaftlichen Situation
doch dies kann doch nicht auf dem Rücken
der Beschäftigten ausgetragen werden
hier ist die Bundesregierung gefordert
und zwar anders hier ist Gesundheit mit
seiner Lauterbach gefordert endlich für
eine bedarfsdeckende Finanzierung zu
sorgen damit auch keine Krankenhäuser in
Probleme Gerät
ich sage Ihnen bei solche Angeboten der
Arbeitgeberseite braucht man sich auch
nicht wundern wenn die
Streikbereitschaft steigt und schon
offen über ein unbefristeten Streik
gesprochen wird und ich finde schon
viele wenn jetzt die ersten Tritt
Mitfahrer aus der CDU aber auch der
Hauptgeschäftsführer der
Bundesvereinigung der
Arbeitgeberverbände sofort noch eine
Einschränkung wenn die Beschäftigen
ihren berechtigten Forderungen
nachträglich verleiden müssen ich hoffe
wir sehen uns in diesem Hause einig dass
solche Forderungen unmissverständlich
zurückgewiesen werden müssen wer die
Hand an das Streikrecht legt der legt
die Hand an die Hand unserer sozialen
demokratischen Grundordnung und deshalb
Hände weg
wer tatsächlich verhindern kann dass es
jetzt zu flächendeckenden unbefristeten
Streiks kommt das ist die
Innenministerin das ist Frau Feser als
Verhandlungsführerin und es sind die
kommunalen Arbeitgeber nehmen Sie diese
Verantwortung endlich wahr die hohen
Inflationsraten lassen immer weniger vom
Geld zum Leben übrig als Fraktion DIE
LINKE im Bundestag unterstützen wir
daher die Forderung der Beschäftigten
und ihre Gewerkschaften im öffentlichen
Dienst nach einem Lohnplus mindestens
500 € 10,5 % ist die Forderung wir
halten das für absolut gerechtfertigt
wenn eines ist klar ein attraktiver und
verlässlicher öffentlicher Dienst ist
besser für alle und kann der gelernt
real und Verlust jetzt im öffentlichen
Dienst gestoppt werden dann wird das
auch andere Branchen ausstrahlen wenn
auch dort die dringend notwendigen
Lohnerhöhung leichter durchzusetzen sein
und das ist dringend notwendig vielen
Dank
Meiser war das hier für die
Linksfraktion er ist ja Sprecher für
Gewerkschaftspolitik und DIE LINKE
unterstützt in ihrem Antrag ganz klar
wie eben auch gesagt die Forderungen der
Protestierenden der Streitenden Patong
nun Dunja Kreiser für die SPD-Fraktion
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
eine Aktuelle Stunde überschrieben mit
dem Aufruf von Verdi zusammen geht mehr
wer die für die Tarifverhandlungen
gemeinsam für gdpgw
IG BAU sowie
dbb-beamtenbund und tarifunion zur
Tarifrunde öffentlicher Dienst an 200
Orten finden morgen Streikaktionen statt
verdi hat aufgerufen zum
öpnv-warnstreik Nahverkehr auch in
Niedersachsen wo ich lebe gleichzeitig
findet in zahlreichen Städten ein
klimastreik von Fridays for future für
die Verkehrswende statt sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren
nun sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Linken liebe Frau Wissler
ich muss Ihnen sagen ich habe Zweifel an
der Sinnhaftigkeit dieser aktuellen
Stunde sie Kapern hier einfach mal diese
Streiks Herr Kollege Meiser hat noch
letztes Jahr Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
angezählt sich nicht in
Tarifverhandlungen
von daher denke ich sie sind mit dieser
nein mit dieser aktuellen Stunde einfach
fehl am Platz und damit Sie mich nicht
falsch verstehen und nicht gleich
schimpfen ich bin stolz es
ver.di-Mitglied und das schon seit
Jahrzehnten als ehemalige
abwassermeisterin und
Personalratsvorsitzende in einem
kommunalen Eigenbetrieb weiß ich was
geleistet wird in unserem öffentlichen
Dienst viele unterwegs in meinem
Wahlkreis in Wolfenbüttel in Salzgitter
in Seesen und auch in meinem
betreuungswahlkreis in Helmstedt oder
Wolfsburg weiß ich was geleistet wird
von meinen Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
von den Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern in der Kita in evessen der
Gemeinde eigenen Einrichtungen wo ich
noch Bürgermeisterin bin auch als
innenpolitikerin weiß ich was geleistet
wird im öffentlichen Dienst Liebe VW
Isler wir stehen durchaus auch an der
Seite der Beschäftigten im öffentlichen
Dienst aber eins weiß ich auch verehrte
Damen und Herren
Verkehrs es herrscht Tarifautonomie in
Deutschland meine Damen und Herren ich
traue werde durchaus zu die Belange der
2,5 Millionen Beschäftigten im
öffentlichen Dienst in Bund und Kommunen
laut durchsetzungsstark und mit hohem
Maße Kompetenz zu vertreten da scheinen
sie liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
den Linken Zweifel zu haben doch warum
habe ich Zweifel an der Sinnhaftigkeit
diese Aktuellen Stunde es geht ihnen
frei bei dem es steht Ihnen natürlich
frei bei dem Warnstreiks vorbeizuschauen
mit auf die Straße zu gehen Seite an
Seite das machen wir als
Sozialdemokraten natürlich schon seit
jeher aber die Verhandlungen in den
Bundestag verlagern zu werden das ist
ein schwieriges Unterfangen und einer
ist Instrumentalisierung mit der sie aus
meiner Sicht die Verhandlung erst stören
als wirklich was für die Beschäftigen zu
erreichen wie sie es vorgeben damit ist
niemanden im öffentlichen Dienst
geholfen und ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht ganz sicher ob Fridays for
Futures sie ist so vereinnehmen lassen
wollen die haben sie ja auch gleich mit
einbezogen
ich jedenfalls vertraue eine Tarifrunde
bei der es eine gute Einigung geben wird
auch wenn das erste Angebot als
unzureichend angesehen wird denn
natürlich ist klar die öffentliche Hand
sollte ein guter ein attraktiver
Arbeitgeber sein dazu gehören natürlich
auch attraktive Löhne dazu gehören
gehört eine gute Personalausstattung
dazu gehört eine Ausstattung eine gute
Ausstattung generell die Angestellten im
öffentlichen Dienst
brauchen Entlastung der wird nur allzu
oft am Limit und darüber hinaus
gearbeitet es wird vor allem brauchen
wir dringend diese personelle
Unterstützung die Aufstockung der
stellen und im Bund und Kommunen die
Bund der Bund und die Kommunen buhlen um
die Fachkräfte die wir dringend brauchen
um unser Land voranzubringen und
Transformationen Energiewende Umdenken
im Bau und ja auch die Verkehrswende
voranzubringen und zwar zügig jetzt am
besten gestern und wir brauchen vor
allem gut bezahlte und motivierte
Fachkräfte in unseren Kitas und
Ganztagsschulen am 7 märz ist übel Pay
Day wir setzen uns für eine
ambitionierte Gleichstellungspolitik ein
dazu gehört auch eine Gesichter der eine
gesicherte Ganztagsschule Betreuung ein
Kitas und Schulen denn noch ist es so
dass besonders Frauen beruflich
zurückstecken oft in Teilzeit arbeiten
Ganztagsbetreuung ist darum für die
Gleichstellung im Berufsleben immens
wichtig dafür braucht es natürlich auch
die speziellen Mittel sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren sie wissen auch um die
knappenkassen in unseren Kommunen die
Kommunen leisten viel doch auch sie
treffen die Inflation und die schwierige
Situation der Wirtschaft Kollege Kuhle
hat es gerade schon gesagt wo das Geld
herkommt vielerorts wird über höhere
Gebühren und Grund und Gewerbesteuer
nachgedacht das fällt auf die
BürgerInnen und Bürgerinnen direkt
zurück das scheint für sie vielleicht
keine Rolle zu spielen lassen Sie doch
bitte Gewerkschaften ihre Arbeit machen
es gibt viel zu tun in unserem Parlament
in diesem Land vielleicht schafft es
schaffen sie es ja auch eigene
Forderungen zu entwickeln dann müssen
Sie nicht auf die von Verdi
zurückgreifen in diesem Sinne gutes
Gelingen und gute Verhandlung bei der
dritten Runde vom 27 bis zum 29 märz in
Potsdam vielen Dank allen Beschäftigten
öffentlichen Dienst Glückauf
Dunja Kreiser ruft dazu aus mit den
Protestierenden und Demonstranten ins
Gespräch zu kommen das dürfte morgen an
vielen Orten möglich sein die
Gewerkschaft will ja den öffentlichen
Nahverkehr in sechs Bundesländern und
einigen Städten für 24 Stunden morgen
nahezu flächendeckend lahmlegen
es ist ja immerhin gut und richtig dass
wir uns einig sind dass wir
einen starken funktionierenden
öffentlichen Dienst brauchen ich will
das auch noch mal für die cdu/csu
Bundestagsfraktion sagen wir sind
überzeugt die mehr als 5 Millionen
Beschäftigten im öffentlichen Dienst die
sind für das Funktionieren unseres
Gemeinwesens unverzichtbar wir haben
dort viele kluge engagierte kompetente
Beamte und Tarife Beschäftigte und für
uns ist klar sie verdienen Wertschätzung
und auch eine gute Vergütung da besteht
im Grundsatz kein Essen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
aber es ist auch so und das ist in
dieser Debatte schon angeklungen die
Tarifverhandlungen die sind natürlich
vor allem Sache der Tarifparteien und es
ist auch unsere richtige Überzeugung
dass auch die Tarifverhandlungen über
den öffentlichen Dienst jetzt nicht
irgendwie permanent nur durch
Begleitmusik parallelverhandlungen im
Deutschen Bundestag begleitet werden
müssen ich will sagen in der Situation
ist es ja nicht unverschämt jetzt 10,5
Prozent mehr zu fordern das ist eine
legitime Forderung es ist aber genauso
legitim dass die Kommunen zum Beispiel
auch sagen ja wir müssen das am Ende
auch irgendwo bezahlen und deswegen ist
es richtig dass am Ende ein Kompromiss
steht und ich finde diesen Ausgleich
müssen die Tarifparteien auch treffen
und das ist nicht unsere Sache hier im
Parlament einseitig vor Festlegung zu
treffen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich will in diesem Zusammenhang aber
auch sagen weil das hier jetzt
gelegentlich zum Anlass genommen wurde
um die UN unzu kritisieren und die
Beschlusslage und die Verlautbarung die
etwa das Präsidium unserer
mittelstandsunion verlautbart hat die
Forderung die auch die Bundesvereinigung
der Arbeitgeberverbände aufgeworfen hat
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich finde
es ist ein richtiger Ansatz zu sagen wir
brauchen gesetzliche klare Regelungen
für das Streikrecht und es ist
unzulässig wenn Sie diesen Vorschlag mit
einer Einschränkung des Streikrechts
gleichsetzen es geht um klare und
nachvollziehbare Regelung und das ist
ein legitimer und richtiger Vorschlag
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
klar Artikel 9 des Grundgesetzes gewährt
eine umfassende streikfreiheit das
Problem ist aber schon aus juristischer
Sicht dass wir die Großteile des
Arbeitskampfrechts heute dann nur sehen
durch richterrechtliche Auslegungen dass
wir sehen dass es an klaren gesetzlichen
Vorgaben fehlt das ist aus meiner Sicht
ein objektives Problem und das Gitter
Connemann und der Hauptgeschäftsführer
der Bundesvereinigung der
Arbeitgebervereinigung Herr Kampeter das
kritisiert haben das finde ich nur
nachvollziehbar und richtig liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aber ich will
Ihnen vor allem sagen was mich dann doch
wundert an dieser aktuellen Stunde ist
das ausgerechnet die Linkspartei sich
dann jetzt dieser Tage aufschwingt zum
großen Verteidiger des öffentlichen
Dienstes das ist ja klar
nachvollziehbar sie wollen irgendwie die
Grund DNA der sozialen Gerechtigkeit
dann heute aufrecht erhalten das wäre ja
auch schön und gut das Problem ist nur
wenn man sich in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland umschaut und wenn man sich
die Situation des öffentlichen Dienstes
anschaut dann sieht man dem geht es dort
besonders schlecht wo die Linkspartei
regiert liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das ist doch die Realität sie können
sich hier hinstellen und für tolle
Tarifabschlüsse werden die Realität kann
man hier in Berlin sich anschauen ihre
Arbeitsergebnisse marode Schulen
Integration gescheitert Schle
Bedingungen für die Lehrkräfte
Personalmangel in der Justiz das sind
die Ergebnisse von rot-roter und linker
Politik und da brauchen Sie sich hier
nicht als Verteidiger des öffentlichen
Dienstes aufspielen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und ich will Ihnen schon
auch sagen und das knüpft an an die
Debatte die wir auch heute morgen hatten
Friedrich Merz hat vollkommen zu Recht
auch den Hinweis gemacht auf ihre
fehlende Abgrenzung zu dem Agieren von
Kollegin Sarah Wagenknecht es ist so
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn Sie
schon eine Aktuelle Stunde beantragen
jetzt in dieser Woche wenn es dann um
Versammlung um Streits umsonst was geht
unter der Überschrift finde ich ja
besonders putzig zusammengeht mehr
hätten sie sich vielleicht mal damit
auseinandersetzen müssen das zusammen
geht mehr für Sarah Wagenknecht einfach
heißt die Abgrenzung zu Neonazis und
holocaustleugnen aufzugeben denn das ist
das eigentliche Problem liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und ich erwarte
von Ihnen dass Sie als Linkspartei vor
allem dieses Thema auch aufarbeiten und
man muss sich schon fragen wo ist Frau
Wagenknecht eigentlich das ist ihr
Hauptthema die Parteivorsitzende der
Linkspartei redet Frau Wagenknecht ist
hauptberufliche Kreml Kommentatoren in
Talkshows die ist nicht mehr hier die
letzten neuen Abstimmungen hat sie
verpasst Ihre aktuelle Stunde auch Sie
sollten bevor sie hier sich für den
öffentlichen Dienst aufspielen lieber in
ihren eigenen aufräumen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
soweit Philipp Amthor und damit kommen
wir zu Leon Eckert er sitzt unter
anderem für die Grünen im Ausschuss für
Inneres und Heimat sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger ob
im Krankenhaus in den Verkehrsbetrieben
oder im Rettungsdienst die Beschäftigten
des öffentlichen Diensten halten dieses
Land am laufen und dafür gebührt ihnen
unser Anerkennung und unser Respekt
die Bezahlung dabei ist eine wichtige
Stellschraube wenn die Bezahlung nicht
attraktiv genug ist laufen wir Gefahr
für diese wichtigen Aufgaben
mittelfristig kein Personal mehr zu
finden und zentrale Leistungen unseres
Staates nicht mehr bringen zu können und
dabei ist die Tatsache seine Arbeit
seine Leidenschaft in die Dienst der
Gemeinschaft zu stellen ja eine große
Motivation die kennen auch die meisten
die hier sitzen gemeinschaftlich für die
Gemeinschaft zu arbeiten
doch die Motivation trägt nur so lange
wie auch eine faire Bezahlung dafür
sorgt dass ein gutes Leben möglich ist
durch die Inflation verschärft sich aber
für viele Menschen in Deutschland
aktuell die Situation deswegen kämpfen
Beschäftigte zu Recht in den aktuellen
Tarifverhandlungen
die Tarifautonomie ist in diesem Land
ein hohes Gut und ich bin der festen
Überzeugung dass eine gute Einigung
zwischen Bund Kommunen und dem
Beschäftigten in Aussicht steht und das
auch gelingen wird
deswegen möchte ich das Thema
Fachkräftemangel diskutieren weil das
schwingt ja mit wenn es auch um
Bezahlung geht wir haben in vielen
Kommunen die paradoxe Situation das
erstmal in so Räten viel geschimpft wird
über langsame Verwaltungen über nicht
funktionierende Prozesse und
gleichzeitig gefordert wird das
ordentlich eingespart wird im
personalkörper und das ist natürlich
dann nicht verwunderlich wenn man
jammert dass wir niemanden finden für
Kindergärten für die Gemeindeverwaltung
und wer mit dem Bürgermeisterinnen und
Bürgermeisterin vor Ort spricht der weiß
wie zaches ist z.B ein Gemeinde ITER zu
finden das ist dann manchmal nur die
schlechte Gemeindehomepage die daraus
kommt aber in manchen Fällen hängt ja
auch die Feuerwehralarmierung drin die
da nicht so klappt wie sie eigentlich
klappen sollte und dann wird schon etwas
brenzlig wenn wir eben nicht im
öffentlichen Dienst diese Stellen
besetzen können
diese Fachkräftemangel wird eine bessere
Bezahlung sicher nicht vollständig
beheben können aber es ist eine wichtige
Stellschraube und wir glauben ich glaube
dass wir noch viele andere Ideen aber
aktivieren müssen um unseren
öffentlichen Dienst attraktivieren zu
können also Herr cooler hat schon gesagt
was alles möglich ist und ich möchte
noch mal auf den Rettungsdienst eingehen
weil diese Gruppe mir ganz am Herzen
liegt wenn man mit jungen
notfallsanitäterinnen und Sanitätern
spricht dann erzählen die einem aus der
Abschlussklasse sind die meisten schon
wieder aus dem Rettungsdienst raus weil
der Job einfach sehr hart ist sehr lange
Schichten man hat Bereitschaft und in
vielen Städten ist die Bereitschaftszeit
aber Dauereinsatz weil einfach so viele
Einsätze nacheinander reinkommen gerade
in dieser Berufsgruppe ist dringend
Handlungsbedarf erforderlich
und diese diese
Handlungsbedarf äußert sich glaube ich
in erster Linie darin dass wir einfach
von der Arbeitszeit runterkommen müssen
es muss auskömmlich sein im
Rettungsdienst zu arbeiten aber mit
weniger Arbeitsbelastung und
gleichzeitig müssen wir aber motivieren
Teilzeitmodelle Jobsharing finden die
Bereitschaftszeiten reduzieren dass wir
das schaffen und was besonders
verwerflich ist dass dann private
Anbieter von Rettungsdienst noch außer
Tarifbindung rausgehen und sozusagen auf
den Kosten dieses harten Jobs dann
Gewinn zu machen und ich glaube da sind
wir uns einig dass wir den beim
Rettungsdienst da genau angreifen müssen
und diese Arbeitszeitverkürzung ich
glaube die ist nicht nur im
Rettungsdienst
überlegenswert sondern im gesamten
öffentlichen Dienst es gibt ja jetzt
einige ganz spannende Modelle wo vier
Tage Woche ausprobiert wird wo die
gleiche Effizienz herrscht bei gleichem
Lohn aber nur vier Tagen und ich glaube
wenn wir in der Zukunft den öffentlichen
Dienst trotz Motivation für die
Gemeinschaft zu arbeiten attraktiv
halten wollen dann muss man glaube ich
auch offen über Innovationen in der
Arbeitszeit nachdenken und dass die vier
Tage Woche ein gutes Beispiel um die in
Verwaltung in Rathäusern in
Kindertagesstätten ausprobieren um auch
Zukunft viele motivierte Menschen für
den öffentlichen Dienst zu finden
heute morgen sind viele Leute unterwegs
die streiten ich wünsche Ihnen viel
Erfolg ihre Anliegen voranzubringen bei
mir in meiner Feuerwehr habe ich mal ein
bisschen rum gefragt wer ist alles
unterwegs ist sind doch mehr als man
denkt ehrenamtlich und den Beruf für die
Gemeinschaft unterwegs und für Sie alle
gilt toi toi toi und viel Erfolg
die Wünsche von erlernen Eckert waren
das für die Grünen in diese Aktuellen
Stunde haben wir noch drei Rednerinnen
und redener jetzt hat Volker Räder für
die FDP-Fraktion das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren
das wissen die meisten Leute ich war
auch mal zehn Jahre im öffentlichen
Dienst und deswegen habe ich tatsächlich
volles Verständnis für die Aktivitäten
gerade aber ich bin ja auch Unternehmer
und
mit eigener Verantwortung für über 40
Mitarbeiter schaue ich mit einem
besonderen Blick auf die aktuelle
Debatte weil mein Eindruck ist halt dass
es doch nur um Geld geht nur um Geld und
also 10,5% und 500 €, aber wir wollten
ja eigentlich darüber reden wie mache
ich denn den öffentlichen Dienst
attraktiver wie mache ich ihn
interessanter wie mache ich ihn so dass
die Leute auch gerne in den öffentlichen
Dienst gehen und deswegen lade ich sie
mal zu einem Perspektivwechsel ein was
ist denn aus Arbeitgebersicht
ganz ganz wichtig für ein gutes
Arbeitsverhältnis wie muss man mit den
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern
umgehen was muss man ihn bieten gerade
wo es derzeit so schwer ist überhaupt
welche zu finden und es geht dann halt
eben auch ums Geld aber eben nicht nur
es geht tatsächlich um das was wir so
ein paar mal erwähnt haben Wertschätzung
aber auch im Selbstverwirklichung
schlanke Hierarchien Ausstattung und
optimierte Prozesse und ich bin ja auch
so in digitalo also reden wir jetzt
gleich ein bisschen über Prozesse
bezüglich des öffentlich natürlich
inzwischen eher von draußen drauf und
nicht mehr als Insider aber mein
Eindruck ist bezüglich der Praxis der
Wertschätzung der Hierarchien da ist
noch Luft nach oben und
ich habe und das ist nicht gelogen ich
habe hier im Bundestag erlebt dass wenn
man in einige bundestagsbüros kommt und
den Rechner anmacht das ist 10 Minuten
dauert bis man den benutzen kann
und das sehe ich auch genau das ist
normal danke und das sehe ich nicht nur
bundestagsbüros das sehe ich auch in der
öffentlichen Verwaltung und deshalb
brauchen wir einen wirklich
attraktiveren und zuverlässigeren
öffentlichen Dienst mit einer moderneren
Ausstattung
genauso wichtig ist die Digitalisierung
der Prozesse in der Verwaltung da müssen
wir wegkommen von der rein digitalen
Abbildung der analogen Prozesse wir
kennen das alle da wird ein Formular
einfach als PDF abgelegt dann ist das
digital nein es ist nicht so also es
muss wieder Spaß machen Büro und Rechner
arbeitet im öffentlich muss wieder Spaß
machen ich habe hier so ein schönes
Passwort performante easy to use
Digitalisierung also schnell und einfach
okay das klingt besser gut also damit
wir den Leuten wieder besseres Gefühl
bei der Arbeit geben damit sie auch in
kürzeren Zeiten höhere Qualität
produzieren können und das gute Gefühl
haben am Ende des Tages etwas wirklich
weggeschafft und das geht halt auch mit
Digitalisierung so damit haben wir
langfristig zufrieden der Beschäftigte
wir haben auch dann langfristig den
Personalmangel teilweise kompensiert
weil Digitalisierung hilft uns dabei mit
weniger Personal auszukommen
das erzeugt natürlich auch Skepsis bei
dem Beschäftigten ähm sie haben Bedenken
nicht mitzukommen deswegen müssen wir
also nicht dass sie verweigern deswegen
müssen wir sie von Anfang an Einbinden
in die Prozesse
wirklich wichtig danke
also die Digitalisierung ermöglicht den
Mitarbeiter an der Verwaltung ihre
Aufgaben besser zu erledigen durch die
Automatisierung von Routineaufgaben und
dem konsequenten Wegfall von diesen
ganzen Medienbrüchen übrigens sich
einfach und langweilige arbeiten die
Daten werden eben nicht mehr händisch
abgetippt ja das erlaubt den
Mitarbeitern sich gezielter auf
komplexere Aufgaben zu konzentrieren die
haben wir ja auch in der öffentliche
Verwaltung und ich habe noch mal eben
ich habe ja den Personalmangel erwähnt
der Fachkräftemangel ist aber nicht nur
im öffentlichen Dienst ein Problem für
die Aufgaben Erledigung erfüllt auch
Perspektive zu Bearbeitungszeiten und
damit zu wirtschaftlichen Schaden das
ist aber auch ein echtes Problem für den
öffentlichen Dienst der geht jetzt schon
gerne in den öffentlichen Dienst wenn er
weiß dass er die Arbeit von zwei Leuten
machen muss obwohl er nur für eine
bezahlt wird
von der FDP aber na ja
so die hohe Arbeitsbelastung für die
übrigens auch dazu das Beschäftigte im
öffentlichen Dienst sich immer häufiger
krank melden der Durchschnitt bei
Krankmeldungen hier in Berlin lag schon
vor der corona-pandemie beim Rekordhoch
von 38,7 Kalendertagen das sind das sind
mehr als fünfeinhalb Wochen im Jahr also
mehr als man Urlaub normalerweise hat
deshalb bei der Diskussion immer die
Attraktivität des öffentlichen Dienstes
erhöhen nicht nur über Geld reden
Digitalisierung ist wichtig
Arbeit kann viel Freude machen und es
sind stiften wenn man sieht das Umfeld
entsprechend attraktiv gestaltet und
zwar so dass genügend Freiräume für
kreative und Herausforderung Teil der
Arbeit bleiben dann arbeiten die
Menschen wieder sehr sehr gerne weil er
Selbstwertgefühl steigt sie sich
wertgeschätzt fühlen und dadurch
zufriedener und seltener krank werden
Arbeit kann so Freude machen und da
müssen wir gerade im öffentlichen Dienst
wieder hinkommen ich danke
[Applaus]
für die CDU CSU-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren
Müllabfuhr öffentlicher Nahverkehr Kitas
Kliniken Verwaltung nein es geht nicht
viel ohne den öffentlichen Dienst und
allein wenn nur einige Bereiche
zeitweise sei es aufgrund von Streik
oder auch nur von der Krankheitsfälle
ausfallen dann steht schnell der Alltag
Kopf ja in allen Lebensbereichen ist der
präsent in allen Lebensabschnitten ist
ja ein Begleiter von klein auf haben wir
mit ihm dem Staat zu tun von der Geburt
in der Klinik wenn es eine öffentliche
vor Ort ist Kita Kindergarten Schule
Standesamt und so weiter ja aber dieser
Staate ist nicht nur eine Institution er
wird repräsentiert von Gesichtern und
zwar genauer gesagt von fünf Millionen
Gesicht dann die Hälfte öffentlicher
Dienst die andere Hälfte Beamte die
natürlich diesen Tarifabschluss in der
Regel übernehmen so dass wir insgesamt
von 5 Millionen Betroffenen
reden das sind 5 Millionen Menschen die
tagtäglich die Arbeit tun wichtige
Arbeit für uns alle zentrale
unverzichtbare Aufgaben die jeder
braucht
Kommunen Länder und Bund die
Beschäftigten des öffentlichen Dienst
aus diesem Bereichen es ist daher
wichtig sie zu erhalten Sie nicht zu
verlieren und sie auch insbesondere wenn
jetzt die Babyboomer in Rente gehen neue
zu gewinnen wir haben es ist von den
vorrätern schon angesprochen worden auch
im öffentlichen Dienst inzwischen mit
einem eklatanten Fachkräfte bzw
Arbeitskräftemangel zu tun das heißt
alle haben ein Interesse daran wenn Sie
wollen dass der Laden läuft dass ihr
Müll abgeholt wird dass sie ihre Kinder
in die Kita geben können oder in die
Schule das sind ÖPNV Angebot realistisch
erreichbar sie haben alle ein Interesse
daran dass diese Menschen ihren Job
machen und bleiben und im Moment haben
sie viele viele Möglichkeit auch den Job
zu wechseln fakt ist die Inflation ist
immens 89
aber im Wesentlich in dem Bereich und
dann ist natürlich nachvollziehbar dass
die GEW erkschaften erstmal noch ein
bisschen mehr fordern es ist auch
logisch das kann nicht sein dass gerade
diese Jobs die so wichtig für uns alle
sind die sind die dann im Falle einer
Inflation ganz massiv an Kaufkraft
real,-
natürlich sehen muss der Arbeitgeber
wird diese so schnell nicht erfüllen
können
jetzt haben wir die Situation ich bin
selbst Mitglieder eines
kommunalparlaments ich sehe wie das ja
was den Haushalt verabschiedet wie
natürlich die Kostensteigerungen das
auch verschieben wir mal auf Projekte
verzichten muss nur eins ist nur so
wenn wir keine Alternative haben wenn
wir die Leute brauchen wenn wir eine
starke Konkurrenz der Arbeitgeber haben
bleibt es dem Staat wenn er will dass
seine fundamentalen Aufgaben erledigt
werden gar nichts anderes übrig als auch
für eine angemessene Besoldung zu sorgen
und deshalb drücke ich ganz ehrlich all
den Gewerkschaften all den Demonstranten
die Daumen sie werden natürlich nicht
einen vollen Inflationsausgleich kriegen
die Lohn Preisspirale lässt grüßen aber
ich drück die Daumen dass es so gut wie
möglich ausgeht auch wenn ich weiß dass
das für die Haushalte bitter wird und
deshalb habe ich auch überhaupt nicht
verstanden dass der erste Vorschlag so
schlecht war von der Frau Weser weil es
natürlich völlig klar ist damit kann
sich keine Gewerkschaft zufrieden geben
damit kann sich kein beschäftigen das
öffentliche Dienste zufriedengeben wir
haben Streik völlig zurecht ich hoffe
dass der nächste Vorschlag besser ist
dass wir vielleicht schneller beenden
können weil ich möchte nicht dass wir
Monaten lang ständig Streiks haben die
zulassen ist nicht nur die Ungewissheit
für die Beschäftigten des öffentlichen
Dienst sondern
alle anderen Menschen die ihr Kind nicht
in die Kita geben kann den keinen wirst
benutzen können Chaos auf den Straßen
deshalb verstehe ich die Kooperation
dann teilweise auch nicht die hier dann
auch noch anvisiert wird noch mehr Chaos
auf den Straßen nein die normalen Leute
müssen ihren Job machen und deshalb
brauchen wir nun ein ordentliches
Angebot das ging so nicht
[Applaus]
es ist aber so wenn man vor hat Leute zu
gewinnen reicht allein die Beschäftigung
nicht das ist schon angesprochen neben
der höheren Entlohnung ist es wichtig
bessere Einstiegsgehälter flexible
Arbeitszeiten Einführung von
Lebensarbeitszeit konnten Homeoffice die
Flexibilität gerade bei Frauen natürlich
gerade in der öffentliche in Dienst ist
vor für Frauen interessant und was ist
für die häufig am wichtigsten inzwischen
auch bei vielen Männern aber erst recht
bei Frauen die Vereinbarkeit die
Flexibilität da müssen wir flexibler
werden das muss man anbieten ich brauche
Ihnen nicht sagen
IT-Sicherheit wir haben Zusammenhang mit
dem Ukraine Krieg Anschläge auf unsere
kritische Infrastruktur wie wollen wir
denn diese guten Leute her holen zu oft
stellen Sie sich die Frage lohnt es sich
zum Start zu gehen oder Nein in die
private Wirtschaft zu Ort ist zu oft ist
die Antwort lohnt sich zum Staat zu
gehen nein wir haben keine Wahl wenn wir
nicht wollen dass unser Land nicht nur
übertragenen Sinne still steht weil es
am geeigneten Personal fehlt sei es im
ÖPNV in Kitas Schulen Techniken
IT-Bereich oder der Müllabfuhr dann muss
der Staat in Bewegung bleiben sich
weiterentwickeln und zwar nicht allein
um seiner selbst willen sondern um unser
aller Willen
Silke launert war das aus der
Unionsfraktion und damit kommen wir zum
letzten Redner in dieser aktuellen
Stunde die letzten fünf Minuten in der
Aussprache hatten und Ulli krötsch für
die SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen kurz
grundsätzlich gesagt und wie immer beide
Forderungen nach einem attraktiven und
zukunftssicheren öffentlichen Dienst
haben sie das Sozialdemokratie natürlich
an ihrer Seite denn seit 1863 setzen wir
uns ein für eine Besserstellung der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer und
optimale Arbeitsbedingungen
[Applaus]
wie wir wissen drückt sich Respekt auch
ein Stück weit immer auf dem Lohnzettel
aus und deshalb sage ich ganz
grundsätzlich die Forderungen nach
höheren Löhnen auch im öffentlichen
Dienst sind natürlich berechtigt denn
der öffentliche Dienst ist das Rückgrat
eines starken und handlungsfähigen
Stadtfest wir
und damit meine ich wir wollen keine
Beschäftigten im öffentlichen Dienste
hunderte Überstunden vor sich
herschieben wir wollen keine
unterbesetzten Behörden in Bund Ländern
und Kommunen in denen die beschäftigt
nicht mehr hinterherkommen mit ihrer
Arbeit und deshalb gefrustet sind oder
am Ende sogar einen Burnout erleiden
unzureichende Bezahlung und ein
schlechtes Klima fehlende Wertschätzung
das ist der Nährboden für radikales
Gedankengut liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und das wiederum kann schneller
zu einer echten Gefahr für die
freiheitliche demokratische Grundordnung
werden als es uns allen lieb ist auch
das lehrt uns die deutsche Geschichte
deshalb
deshalb und auch wenn es vielleicht
nicht
unmittelbar mit den Tarifverhandlungen
zu tun hat deshalb ist es gut dass wir
die Hochschule der Polizei mit einer
polizeistudie beauftragt haben die bis
2024 dem Berufsalltag und die Motivation
von Polizei Beschäftigten in allen
Verwendungen analysieren soll damit wir
Verbesserungen auch in diesem Bereichen
in Angriffen nehmen können auch die
ruhige holzfähigkeit der Polizei Zulage
und das sei ganz ausdrücklich gesagt ist
beschlossene Sache und muss endlich
umgesetzt werden
[Applaus]
vor wenigen Tagen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hat die Bundesregierung die
Änderung des bundesdisziplinargesetzes
beschlossen um Extremisten aus dem
Staatsdienst schneller zu entfernen für
mich und ich glaube für viele von ihnen
ist das ein Meilenstein in der
Bekämpfung extremistischen Gedankengutes
in den Behörden in Deutschland das
gehört für uns zu einer wehrhaften
Demokratie und einem starken
öffentlichen Dienst dazu dass man die
schwarzen Schafe aussortiert
Verfassungsfeinde die eine mangelnde
verfassungsfrei an den Tag legen können
unserem Staat nicht dienen
und deshalb müssen wir eine Situation im
öffentlichen Dienst schaffen in dem
beförderungs- und
Qualifizierungsmöglichkeiten überall
vorhanden sind auf allen Ebenen wir
müssen ein Klima schaffen in dem Frauen
nirgends benachteiligt werden wir müssen
auch ein klimaschaffen in dem
Mitarbeitenden sich trauen Radikale und
extremistische Äußerungen vom
Vorgesetzten anzuzeigen ohne Nachteile
für sich selbst befürchten zu müssen wir
müssen ein klimaschaffen in dem
Beschäftigte nicht diskriminiert werden
wo Hautfarbe Herkunft und der Vorname
keine Rolle spielen dafür brauchen wir
mehr Diversität im Staatsdienst und auch
dafür steht diese fortschrittskoalition
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
einiges haben wir auch in unserem
Koalitionsvertrag schon aufgeschrieben
sie wissen dass zum Beispiel die
Umsetzung einer diversitätsorientierten
einstellungsoffensive bei der
Bundespolizei aber natürlich müssen wir
noch besser werden man muss ja kein
Mathematiker sein um zu sehen dass in
den nächsten zehn Jahren eine
Mammutaufgabe auf uns wartet wenn die
Babyboomer in der Rente gehen 1,5
Millionen Beschäftigte werden das bis
2030 sein und auch in unserer
Sicherheitsarchitektur tobt eine Bitte
der Kampf um qualifizierte Fachkräfte
nicht nur dort aber eben auch dort wir
müssen besser werden nicht nur bei der
Bezahlung sondern auch bei der
Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf bei
der Work-Life-Balance wir müssen uns auf
die Bedürfnisse und die
Lebenswirklichkeit junger Menschen
einstellen weil eben nicht alle wollen
in Vollzeit arbeiten viele wollen im
Homeoffice arbeiten sie kennen das alle
wir brauchen zum Beispiel auch
angemessene Diensträume das klingt für
manche vielleicht ban Fall ist aber
vielerlei vielerorts ein Problem wir
brauchen auch in Zukunft motivierte und
gut bezahlte Beschäftigte im
öffentlichen Dienst die allesamtfest auf
dem pro auf dem Boden des Grundgesetzes
stehen und sich mit unserem Staat
identifizieren dann liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen sind wir ein resilienter
Staat sich diesen Herausforderungen
nicht zu stellen wäre ökonomisch nicht
nur ökonomisch unklug sondern hoch
riskant für unser Land vielen Dank
Uli Grötsch war das hat also hier die
aktuelle Stunde zu den
öffentlichen Dienst Streiks und zu den
Tarifverhandlungen beendet eventuell
wenn sie in Hessen Nordrhein-Westfalen
Baden-Württemberg Sachsen Niedersachsen
oder Rheinland-Pfalz leben werden sie
dort morgen noch besonders betroffen
sein da sind besonders die Warnstreiks
angekündigt bei der nächsten Debatte
könnte es sein dass wir nicht alles
verstehen denn es geht um die
europäische sprachenkarte und den Schutz
von Minderheiten Sprache initiativ
initiiert wurde das vom parlamentskreis
Plattdeutsch hier im Deutschen Bundestag
und die Abgeordneten sind nämlich
aufgerufen ihre Rede in ihrer
Minderheiten Sprache zu halten wenn sie
denn eine solche haben und der erste
Redner ist Johann Saathoff der auch
schon hier Berühmtheit erlangt hat als
er einmal auf Platt eine Rede gehalten
hat er ist eigentlich parlamentarischer
im Bundesministerium des Innern hat sich
aber jetzt auch schon zu seiner Fraktion
gesetzt das heißt er spricht hier als
SPD Abgeordneter aus Ostfriesland
ja moin hochgeachtete Präsidentin live
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Musikgarten und platt probenkönen und
neidwood over platt sondern oklad und da
das Lubmin Sicht ein halbe Söhne
privilegte
europäischen sprachenkarte danken für
Dach für 4 Jahre nicht Obdach genau
happy kialmals daran und hat man kann
sagen eigentlich um illegale wie hieß
platt Brot damals und Pep ein Antrag der
Hinsicht immer noch bedürnswert was von
Rechte sie den Parlament und angenommen
wurde
als Landessprache Blog noch der einzige
Sprache wenig so soll
wenn ich
wenn wir Plattform dann brauchen wir das
weil wie viel und 20 Jubiläum der
europäischen Kater fand regional und
Minderheiten Sprachen Herren des
Europarats die
Pro Logo für Dänisch obersorbisch
niedersorbisch und nicht weit dass wir
Tribüne und glühen
Lausitz Meyer Waldstein herzlich
Willkommen bei uns und SATA friedlich
und Roman ist
und wenn ich in wiederhänden in den
Coach dürfen
so zu sagen in Gedanken mit und ich will
an dich verstehen
FDP-Fraktion frau Präsidentin es ist mir
eine große Freude
Werte Kolleg ich hasse nicht verstorben
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
wenn sie in Holland haben aber bei höher
gehen wir nochmal zusammen durch
Protokoll hat und dann kriegen sie
anschließen
was ja nun was ja nun werde gerade von
parlamentskreis Plattdeutsch zu
zerbrochen und da an dieser Stelle
besten Dank an Güde Jensen wie weit
haben der Idee hat Mensch lad uns doch
ein parlamentskreis machen und hat uns
zusammenkommen wo wir platt und andere
Sprachen ob fördern können und wie sind
die Meinung im Parlament Kreisstadt
platt und Heil Leben hört also von
kindertagesstätter an ovidschgau wie
Gerichten heilwichtig wenn man platt
kann und dann in plötzlich in
Fremdsprache ist ob brathusen in Kultur
in plaichheim des heiligenes wichtig um
ihn sich und ob Arbeit und wo es uns
Arbeit hier in Deutsche Bundestag
deswegen brauchen wir hier für
Dachauplatz
und
und uns ist auch wichtig dass wir den
Lügen animieren das ist übrigens Willen
die sagen Haut doch platt auf Party dann
hat denn gibt kein Verkehr Platz
hier ist kein reakt und verkehrt hat 100
Arten von platt den Manu verstanden kann
und deswegen denkt dran pro Platz wenn
jeder hat einige machen können und Dave
von einige Maden Köln und
mir ist auch wichtig nochmal zu sagen
dass Hochdeutsch letzten Endes Ultra ist
sondern das hat Frauen mal Lüge eben
hätte den skaul7s Morgen das wenn man
der Hochdruck hörte ist dass man dann
doch die kann eigentlich nur platt
gucken und hat man da der Nadeln hat das
ist Neid erlaubt und dann will sie Neid
das sind Gesellschaft und ich will an
man kann auch lernen ins Gaul in
Universitäten vollzugshaube wenn man das
will und wenn du neigt sich um
platterien die kann letzten Endes Rücken
App runterladen für Dach aus face
gelandet
und da kann man platt leeren wenn sie
langweilig Wort kann man das machen und
ich will an diese Stelle noch mal sagen
begriffen und verstanden sind zwei
unterschiedliche Dinge oder wie in
Commander gemeinderatem verstanden
sind nämlich ein Teil von Heimat und der
Begriff Heimat kann man auch verkehrt
verstanden und das ist uns
parlamentarische Aufgabe dafür zu sorgen
das bestimmt
[Musik]
und Begriff von Heimat ist das wie
zusammen und entwickeln das wie zusammen
was Willen das wie friedlich miteinander
leben Willen das wie Vorankommen
zusammen minheimer des Ostfriesland aber
nicht so Niedersachsen nicht so
Deutschland nicht so ok Europa und wir
lassen uns wie lautet Heimat oft
grenzwurt dass die Mehrwert sind das
ahnen sondern wie wilden Heimatbegriff
zusammenkommen und uns Gesellschaft
gestalten
abschließend abschließend frau
Präsidentin von harten bedanken wie all
die Leute sind für plattdeutsche Sprache
und für die minderheitspracheninsätzen
wie uns in Ostfriesland ist das total
Beispiel aber all die durch die Leisten
für die plattdeutsche Sprache und für
die anderen Minderheiten sprach die sind
für die Tribüne Kompliment dann ja
Arbeit und besten Dank an stenografische
Dienst ich kann neidisch sprechen
aber nächste Rede von mir so Hochdeutsch
gesprochen
Johann Saathoff war das hat sich hier
auch noch mal beim stenografischen
Dienst bedankt die doch jetzt sehr
konzentriert arbeiten müssen und man
sieht das auch daran normalerweise
sitzen hier nur zwei Vertreter dieses
Dienstes das jetzt sich hier vier
nebeneinander gesetzt haben um das
aufzuschreiben dürfte auch daran liegen
dass es eben nicht so einfach ist wohl
auch nicht bei der nächsten reden Astrid
Damerow kommt nämlich aus Nordfriesland
und spricht jetzt für die Unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin Liebe Vertreterinnen
und Vertreter der Minderheiten auf der
Tribüne vor allem die Nordfriesen bitte
ich darum jetzt sehr stark zu sein weil
ich werde die ersten eineinhalb Minuten
in friesisch sprechen
lief lief Völkers ich freue mich dort
wie die Linke bundesteil aber ist Männer
halt das Bracke Plattdeutsch sorbisch
dort ein romanese
das ist ein ganz besonderer Tag
aber dort der Heeres Brocke hier in die
Kirche bundesheerei Aufmerksamkeit Frau
das ist in gütlich Kiki
aber das xd-link man ja aus der Rede
efra Schüler dort als mir besonders
wichtig
kieke wie wahre
Ortens noch vorne zu down
wie Brücke Möhren
besonders meine Tante Beispiel
Kultur und ihr grünschule er will sie
bei der hungereschule
Willi Lavendel
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das war eine Mundart des nordfriesischen
dass die friesische Sprache ist ein
lebendiges und kulturstiftendes ein
identitätsstiftendes Kulturgut in
Nordfriesland die friesische Sprache ist
aber auch im Saterland in der
niederländischen Provinz Friesland
lebendig friesisch wird allerdings nur
noch von wenigen tausend Menschen
gesprochen ist also durchaus bedroht es
ist mir ein Anliegen darüber hinaus für
eine bundesweite Stärkung der
Wissensvermittlung über unsere vier
nationalen Minderheiten und Volksgruppen
über das niederdoll und über das
Niederdeutsche in all unseren Schulen in
Deutschland zu werden als Deutsche
Bundestag liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
tragen wir eine große Verantwortung für
alle unsere regional und
Minderheitensprachen gerade in Zeiten
des Ukraine Krieges und andere Konflikte
weltweit möchte ich auch daran erinnern
dass der Schutz und die Förderung
nationaler Volksgruppen und Minderheiten
auch aktive Friedenspolitik sein kann in
diesem Sinne
lassen Sie
in diesem Sinne lassen Sie uns weiterhin
gute Minderheitenpolitik für unser
ganzes Land machen von harten kohletunk
Astrid Damerow war das hat hier
nordfriesisch gesprochen eine auch der
Minderheiten Sprachen die als ernsthaft
bedroht gelten so wie SATA friesisch und
südländisch
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin moin liebe Kollegen und
Böse als Brühen X6 zu erstmal hartlichen
Glückwunsch Glückwunsch zu der eu-kater
für die regional und Minderheit des
Bürger
der hat im Klaren Obdach regional und
minderheitens blocken in der
Europäischen Union Schall wie plagon und
wiedervermitteln und er ihn flog den man
Sickte
nun auch wat24
geburtstag
der Kater verpflichte alte Vertragsdaten
minderheitensbirken tüchtigte
bringen sie schallen nicht nur wie ein
paar lütehosnackt werden sondern durch
dicke Shows in der Administration und in
den Medien und
und
wer in Radiosender in Nordirland können
ob irischer
lesen egal was Studentin Irland studiert
dort kommt wie unterstudierenden an der
Uni für ein Semester auch ihre Lehrern
in
in der Schulen in Irland ist das lernt
von irisch Pflicht für Aal Schüler und
schülersche in Medien Schiller anist
Road und in der Administration sind Hale
ob irisch in einige Gegenden in den
mittelste Westen von Irland wo ist das
in verglückt damit Mitteln
für Plattdeutsch was lernte Lütten in
die Schul ob Gladys wie hebt hier von
Tag der utten
regionalstorte im Norden und Nordwesten
von der Bundesrepublik lange tiefe
Stock ich muss sagen lang nicht als
Gothams irische
Heimat lehrt zu verstauen und ich wollte
das Bild aus platt und damit bin ich
schon der einzige von 108 ein grüner
abordnete der an diesem Tag hier ob
platzen wollt
[Applaus]
fehle hier kennt das ohrensorgtheater in
Hamburg wo sie Theater auch platt altit
kicken könnt das Ohnsorg kennt am
meisten ock wenn sich nett und
Norddeutschland sind zumindest von Namen
in der Grundschule in Hamburg lehrte
Lüdden in Elke ingeneration das Lied in
der externen jung mit tüdelband und
ich have maulen Hamburger fährmeister
sehen
hat das war's dennoch Maze
das war's
kommt in Hamburg zum
der NDR ist im Norden Florida wenn wir
uns anklickendorf
in Norddeutschland
und so und alt wie wegken könnt in
hörsteler Platz wir waren
Internetauftritt vom Norddeutschen
Rundfunk können Sie jemals Videos und
Podcasts und bleibt downloaden ehrlich
echt ich finde das ist nicht noch
[Musik]
dafür mit vivaton aus
hinkriegen hier nur endlich in
woodsblock ob platoufern ein Stück platt
in Alltag ist der aber okteuxberg die
wir hier just führen der hat zuerst ain
Thema disploke Sylt wenn hier mal in
euratsblock wäre platt zur Innenpolitik
oder zur soziale Themen oder
Klimapolitik denn hätten wir in Kurden
Anstoß für die platttütest Burg in
Alltag in Deutschland geben
erste Parlaments kriegen
Beton Umfallen damit wir dorthin kriegen
Don damit klar
hier in Parlament volksmold platzed
noch viel zu tun Mann wie könnte den
Geburtstag von der eu-karte auch Vieren
danke
und
die Rede mit Gesangseinlage von
Linda Heitmann war das Plattdeutsch ist
sonst was vollkommen verschwunden laut
Goethe-Institut sprechen jetzt nur noch
drei Prozent hier in der deutschen
Bevölkerung eventuell könnten wir eine
weitere rede jetzt aber auf Platz hören
Götz Frömming ist zwar für Berlin im
Bundestag ist aber in Eutin geboren
ja auch wenn die Karnevalsstimmung
gerade auf ihrem Höhepunkt ist ich habe
dem stenografischen Dienste zugesagt
mich das Themas ernsthaft und in einem
inklusiven Hochdeutsch zu nähern meine
Damen und Herren die Sprache und ich
zitiere mit der Erlaubnis der
Präsidentin die Sprache ist gleichsam
die Seele einer ethnischen Kultur mit
diesen Worten würde ich der Hartmut
koschik der frühere Beauftragte der
Bundesregierung CSU für Aussiedler
Fragen und nationale Minderheiten die
Bedeutung der Sprache für eine ethnische
Minderheit
wir erlauben uns zu ergänzen dass dies
nicht nur für ethnische Minderheit meine
Damen und Herren sondern natürlich auch
für die ethnische Mehrheit gilt
es ist gut und richtig dass wir heute an
die Kater zum Schutz der Minderheiten
Sprachen erinnern und es ist gut und
richtig dass Deutschland sie
unterzeichnet und auch ratifiziert hat
wie mehr in Vorbereitungen auf diese
Rede eine ältere Dame mitteilte schlug
man noch vor wenigen Jahren im Elsass
kleinen Kindern in der Schule auf die
Finger wenn Sie während des Unterrichts
Auto automatisch in ihr deutsches Idiom
rutschten diese Zeit ist zum Glück zu
Ende meine Damen und Herren doch muss
man an dieser Stelle bemerken dass
Frankreich interessanterweise zwar die
Karte unterschrieben hat aber bis heute
nicht in Kraft gesetzt und ratifiziert
hat hier sollte vielleicht die
Bundesregierung mal ihren Einfluss
geltend machen das auch Frankreich diese
schöne Kater unterschreibt wenn die
Bundesregierung denn in Frankreich noch
einen gewissen Einfluss hat meine Damen
und Herren
es ist schon gesagt worden wir haben
vier anerkannte nationale Minderheiten
in Deutschland der Saathoff übrigens
gehört das Niederdeutsche nicht zu den
sprachlichen Minderheiten des wissen sie
es genießt einen gewissen Schutzstatus
das ist auch in Ordnung und natürlich
gegen dieser Schutzstatus auch nicht
verloren wenn man das deutsche als
Landessprache in unsere Verfassung
aufnehmen würde wir finden das immer
noch richtig und würden hier gerne dem
Vorbild anderer Länder folgen meine
Damen und Herren
wir sollten heute aber nicht nur über
die sprachlichen Minderheiten hier in
Deutschland sprechen sondern auch und
das wird sie nicht wundern dass wir
diese Rolle übernehmen auch einmal einen
Blick werfen auf das deutsche als
Minderheiten Sprache im Ausland die Zahl
der deutschen Muttersprachler in nicht
deutschsprachigen Ländern wird allein
für Europa einschließlich Russland auf
über 3 Millionen geschätzt während
frühere Bundesregierung diesen deutschen
Minderheiten noch ein hohes Maß an
Aufmerksamkeit entgegenbrachten zeigt
das aktuelle Beispiel Polen wie sehr sie
als Bundesregierung diese Aufgabe
inzwischen vernachlässigen die Polen
meine Damen und Herren fühlen sich
inzwischen als Nachbarn zweiter Klasse
insbesondere im Vergleich zu Frankreich
diese Konflikte haben inzwischen dazu
geführt dass wir die deutsche Minderheit
in Polen der deutschsprachige
muttersprachige Unterricht von drei
Wochen Stunden auf einige kürzt wurde
das ist in grün natürlich egal was sich
hier um deutsche handelt uns ist das
nicht egal meine Damen und Herren
deshalb
abends polnischen Parlamentariergruppe
dass hier Mittel der Bundesregierung zum
Einsatz kommen das ist inzwischen auch
gelungen und wir hoffen dass wir auf
diesem Weg weitergehen und die
Bundesregierung in ihren Anstrengungen
nicht nachlässt
werfen wir abschließend noch einen Blick
auf das deutsche in unserem Land meine
Damen und Herren die Sprache ist der Kit
einer jeden gesellschaftssprache hält
Gesellschaft zusammen und leider
bröckelt dieser Kit auch in unserem Land
immer mehr es gibt inzwischen
Schulklassen in Deutschland in denen es
der Lehrer die einzige Person die
Deutschen auch als Mutter Sprache
spricht der aktuelle Ländermonitor zeigt
es in vielen Familien bis zu 30 Prozent
in westdeutschen Großstädten Deutsch
nicht mehr gesprochen wird zu Hause
meine Damen und Herren diese Entwicklung
geht immer weiter und wenn wir daran
nicht etwas verbessern und das als
Auftrag auch für die Bildungspolitik
verstehen wird bald Deutsch zur
Minderheitensprache in unserem eigenen
Land werden wir wollen das nicht meine
Damen und Herren die Alternative für
Deutschland setzt sich dieser
Entwicklung entgegen vielen Dank
war das für die afd-fraktion und jede
Jensen von der FDP-Fraktion wurde auch
schon hier angesprochen weil sie eine
der Initiatorinnen ist dieser Debatte
sie kommt aus Nordfriesland
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin David Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Herr Dr Frömming ähm ihr
Problem ist ja nicht derenografische
Dienst sondern dass sie die Sprache
nicht können
[Applaus]
jetzt schnacken sonst ähnlich mit mir in
Irland eine ombuds wie schnacken nicht
war Politik so fail aber ich muss sagen
mehr Mocken und ähnlich setzt man nicht
sehen wir sitzen nicht wie duzen und das
natürlich nicht wo Präsidentin das mache
ich aber hier auch gerne machen ich
freue mich ganz ganz doll das Lied hören
können vielen Dank an alle die dort zu
betränken
können nicht nur um mal so ein Betten
Stimmung in diese Parlamente bringen das
ist manchmal wichtiger Johann sondern
weil das eben wichtige Thema ist
deswegen
2008 Teilen hem Johann Sartor von igtom
ob in Ukraine Reise gemeinsam mit
Wolfgang selten in den Restaurant und
haben irgendwann zufällig feststellt das
wie beide plattdeutsche schnacken können
ich muss sagen hört wie die ich kann
diese wunderbare ostfräsen platt nicht
schnacken Nordfriesland aber wir haben
uns bei in Wort die wie kriegen eine
Parlament für morgen könnt und dann
haben Felix polart und ich zusammen in
äh Gespräch in digitale Gespräch mit äh
Sekretariat und die junge lüte
Fällen dann danke da sind und wir haben
darüber was nackt was kann diese
Bundestag eigentlich dauernd diese ganze
Thema Aufmerksamkeit und dann gehen
immer wieder die Debatte doch die
parlamentskreis Herd und Bus und Born
und vor Ort wo wohnen können wir nicht
einfach in parlamentskreis Plattdeutsch
und das Handy mockt und ich bin froh
dass wir gemacht haben und ich bin froh
dass hier in parlamentskreis
Minderheiten kennen die Stefan und
Denise Gründen kennen und
dort arbeiten wie Gott für sorgen und
ich muss überlegt von der ombuds Tisch
und Minen Irland verteilt zumindest noch
gausing wie das englische
Hochdeutsch erst lernen
Vater ist ähnlich Plattdeutsch und dann
geht das
war Schnack mal nicht mit Kinder
schnacken wohl nicht Plattdeutsch weil
das ist für mich noch Herrn in den Kreis
studiengift und ihrem kennen sie alle
tollen ganz anders sind nämlich je mehr
sprocken je mehr inflüsse Kinder kriegen
je mehr in unterschiedliche Perspektiven
Situation
deshalb
und deshalb wir uns natürlich eine
Westküste und in eckernförderungs in
Ostküste in pladdysche
Vorlesewettbewerbs die eine schulwunden
und dann in den Kreis aber ja aber dann
Kinder Problem in den kreisherwick
verloren und er kriegt der Jury perfekt
die Jury woran hätte denn das Lingen und
dann hätten sie sich man hört da du das
nicht schnacken da ist und das erste
oder Minen Konsequenz wäre ich bin
Termin und heftig wie schnacken jetzt
Plattdeutsch und das ist eigentlich
Sport weil ihr kennt Hochdeutsch kennen
dich offensichtlich mit mein Oma heftig
Markt und sie steht da schnacken den
Vater und ich versorgen und ähm deswegen
kann ich leider nicht abschrieben
deswegen dort hier hochdeutsche Begriffe
und ich versuche das jetzt irgendwie so
getante aber seltensten
wenn man nicht gerade Minderheiten
dieser kriteraria hat oder nicht
sekretariat schnaken- ist ein sprock von
der Altach von der Süd wenn wenn eine
Westküste wie nie Spaziergang
Gedanken darüber
machen natürlich schnacken die hütier er
war regionale Minderheiten gesprochen
und darüber wie kalt wie das gesprochen
schützen aber wie Mörder Upton Altach
waren dort und deswegen ist die Debatte
so wichtig das galt nicht um
Fischbrötchen und und Möwengeschrei und
voll chlore da die Möhren an den Punkt
kommen das hat alltäglich war das
kindersenkt Papa ich möchte auch
Plattdeutsch mit dir sprechen oder wo
kann ich das lernen wie man dort
hinkommen dass tonies ihrem
ähm genau
Ukraine und vietnamesisch und Polnisch
diese Rektum in Deutschland die schützen
und bewahren und fort entwickeln das ist
der Ort die wir auf der Welt blicken und
das Allerletzte was ich denken muss
Präsidentin weil Mutter und Schluss
kommen obwohl ähnlicher immer schnell
und gabelpunkt kommen
wie uns in der parlamentskreis
Plattdeutsch sind noch Plätze frei und
wie freut uns sehr der nächste
parlamentskreis mit ihrem
tresant-tumorken man muss nicht wladic
schnacken dürfte man kann einfach für
wie kommen mit uns einen Kaffee trinken
vielen Dank dafür Morgen und ich freue
mich ob der wiederere Debatte
zum Schluss hier noch eine Einladung von
Güdingen doch in den noch recht neu
gegründeten parlamentskreis Plattdeutsch
dazu zu kommen und damit kommen wir zur
nächsten Rednerin Petra Pau Berliner
Abgeordnete für die Linksfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen werte Gäste in
dieser Debatte geht es um die eu-karte
der regional und Minderheiten
sie wurde vor 25 Jahren vereinbart aber
nicht dass Jubiläum sollte Anlass für
diese Aussprache sein
vielmehr ist es nach einem
Vierteljahrhundert seither geboten der
Frage nachzugehen wie steht's eigentlich
mit der Umsetzung der Karte
die Linke versteht die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland auch als eine
multikulturelle Demokratie die nicht
deutsch national horniert ist
deshalb begrüßen wir auch diese eu-karte
sie betrifft die regional- und
Minderheitensprachen dänisch in drei
Varianten zudem obersorbisch
niedersorbisch nordfriesisch
sata-friesisch und romanisch
sie alle sind als Teil unserer Kultur zu
fördern dem hat die Linke immer
zugestimmt und zugleich frage ich warum
gehört eigentlich noch immer nicht dazu
hinzu kommt der Begriff Regionalsprachen
verleitet dazu die damit verbundenen
Kulturen auch nur regional zu vermitteln
und nicht bundesweit das beklagt
übrigens auch der minderheitenrat die
Lausitzer sorgen die Deutschen sind hier
und Romme die dänische Minderheit und
die friesische Volksgruppe in einem
aktuellen Schreiben an die
Kultusministerkonferenz
wir die Linke teilen das Ansehen dieses
Schreibens auch Sachsen sollten etwas
über Friesen wissen und Hamburger über
sorgen und so weiter kurz um die Kultur
der Minderheiten sollte bundesweit
vermittelt werden und übrigens die
Förderung der Kultur und der Sprachen
muss ich zum Schluss auch im Haushalt
niederschlagen in der aus- und
Weiterbildung von Erzieherinnen und
Lehrern und auch darüber hinaus auch das
gehört mit dazu
nun wurde er im Vorfeld der Debatte
empfohlen all jene die eine
Minderheitensprache beherrschen mögen
ihren Beitrag in dieser erhalten das
wäre bemerkenswert und wir haben es hier
heute ja auch schon gehört ich muss sie
enttäuschen ich kann weder friesenisch
noch platt bleibt die Frage ob wir nicht
noch mehr auch sprachliche Minderheiten
in der Bundesrepublik haben die
Beachtung verdienen ich als Ostdeutsche
muss noch immer broiler oder Datsche und
manchmal auch POS übersetzen ich denke
alle die eine Polytechnische Oberschule
besucht haben wissen wovon ich spreche
aber so ist das mit der Kultur und der
Bildung ich denke wir sollten dafür
sorgen dass das nicht nur in unserem
Selbstverständnis und seine gemeinsamen
Reichtum ausmacht und wir sollten es
gemeinsam befördern
Petra Pau war das auf Sie folgenden
Natalie public sie ist die Beauftragte
der Bundesregierung für Aussiedler
Frauen und nationaler Minderheiten und
Mitglied der SPD-Fraktion frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen verehrte Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer ich spreche zwar Hochdeutsch
doch die Kultur und Sprache von
architektonen Minderheiten und Regionen
sichtbarer zu machen sie zu schützen und
zu fördern das liegt mehr als
Beauftragte der Bundesregierung für
aussiedlerfragen und nationale
Minderheiten sehr am Herzen
deswegen freue ich mich sehr dass wir
heute dieses Thema hier im Plenum
diskutieren
als Muttersprache vieler Menschen in
Deutschland sind die regional und
Minderheiten Sprachen für die
Angehörigen der Minderheit aber auch für
unsere gesamte Gesellschaft prägend
sprach es zu dem wichtig um Kultur
Brauchtum und Traditionen weiterzugeben
denn das geht am besten in der Sprache
mit der diese Bräuche und Tradition und
trennbar verknüpft sind zusammen mit dem
Rahmen über Einkommen zum Schutz
nationaler Minderheiten ist die
sprachenkarte die zentrale Vereinbarung
in Europa um nationale Minderheiten und
ihre spezifischen Sprachen sowie
Regionalsprachen zu bewahren und zu
fördern bei meinen verschiedenen
Besuchen in den Siedlungsgebieten der
einzelnen Sprachgruppen und den
persönlichen Austausch mit den Menschen
vor Ort hat mich deren oft
ehrenamtliches Engagement für den Erhalt
und die Pflege der Sprache in Mensch
beeindruckt gerne möchte ich Ihnen hier
ein paar Eindrücke aus dem Alltag
schildern
dazu gehören zum Beispiel
Altenpflegeeinrichtungen in denen das
Niederdeutsche fest im Alltag verankert
wurde das Angebot reicht von gemeinsamen
Singen Vorlesen auf Plattdeutsch bis hin
zu Berücksichtigung der Sprache bei der
biografiearbeitung der Betreuung von
pflegebedürftigen denn für sie ist
plattdeutsch die Sprache ihrer Kindheit
in der sie ihre Gedanken und Gefühle am
besten ausdrücken können
auch im Kunst und Kulturbereich sind
unsere regional und Minderheiten
Sprachenfest verankert zum Beispiel
durch die große Szene der
niederdeutschen Bühnen oder durch das
sorbisch-national ansemble das nicht nur
im Bautzen sondern überregional ein
mitreißendes Angebot für alle
Generationen bereithält
im
gedichtbandissa wurden klassische
deutsche Gedichte ins Romanes übersetzt
der Gedanke dahinter ist dass das
Bewusstsein für die Bedeutung der
Sprache und Kultur zu stärken und das
mit Erfolg die dembalissa zeigt
anschaulich wie lebendig und vielfältig
das Romanes ist
nordphysisch und SATA friesisch sind auf
den zweisprachigen Ortseingang schildern
in Nordfriesland und im Saterland
öffentlich präsent auch in der Lausitz
bemerkt man auch dank der zweisprachigen
Schildern an den Straßen den Ort sein
Gängen und den Radwegen dass dort sorgen
und wenden mit ihren Sprachen
obersorbisch und niedersorge
traditionell beheimatet sind der
Austausch zwischen Mehrheit und
Minderheiten Sprachen der Austausch
zwischen den dazugehörigen Kulturen die
nebeneinander eigenständig existieren
ist für den Zusammenhalt unserer
Gesellschaft essentiell
ganz besonders wichtige Orte der
Begegnung und deshalb täglichen
Austausch sind zum Beispiel die
dänischen Schulen und Kindergärten in
Schleswig-Holstein dort lernen schon die
Kleinsten das friedliche Zusammenleben
von
mehrheits-land habe ich erleben dürfen
wie Kinder mit den unterschiedlichsten
Hintergründen und Herkünften voller
Motivation gemeinsam friesisch lernen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese
Beispiele zeigen eindrucksvoll
Minderheiten sprachen sie lebendig sie
sind Ausdruck von Vielfalt für die
sprechenden sind die Teil ihrer
kulturellen Identität für uns alle sind
sie einzigartiger Bestandteil des
kulturellen Lebens in Deutschland und in
Europa sie zu erhalten und zu fördern
das gilt es jetzt vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
Natalie public war das für die
SPD-Fraktion nächster Redner ist
Christoph die Fries von der
Unionsfraktion er ist auch Vorsitzender
der Gruppe der Vertriebenen Aussiedler
und deutschen Minderheiten der Union
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen xnak leider kein Plan Deutsch
in wichtig Thema mitbracht aber das
mache ich jetzt mal ein Hochdeutsch und
ich möchte einsteigen mit dem
Koalitionsvertrag dort heißt es die
nationalen Minderheiten sind
selbstverständlicher Teil unserer
vielfältigen Gesellschaft das gleiche
gilt für das kulturelle Erbe der
Vertriebenen AussiedlerInnen und
Aussiedler und der SpätaussiedlerInnen
und spät Aussiedler diesen beiden setzen
im Koalitionsvertrag ist im Grunde
nichts hinzuzufügen wir unterstützen Sie
vollumfänglich und wie wir wissen hat
sich die FDP gerade für den zweiten Satz
stark gemacht und deswegen möchte ich an
dieser Stelle auch mal ausdrücklich Dank
sagen dafür dass sie das mit aufgenommen
haben aber was sind
wir haben viel gesprochen aber was sind
die konkreten vorhabende Regierung bei
der Förderung der vier
Minderheitensprachen man weiß es nicht
im Koalitionsvertrag findet sich dazu
jedenfalls kein Wort und was ganz
bemerkenswert ist das habe ich in der
Vorbereitung gesehen dass die aktuelle
Publikationen des
Bundesinnenministeriums zu den
nationalen Minderheiten in Deutschland
den Stand November 2020 trägt also gut
zweieinhalb Jahre ist es her im Vorwort
steht noch immer Bundesinnenminister
Horst Seehofer den ich an dieser Stelle
herzlich grüßen möchte dafür also
also man merkt dieser Enthusiasmus den
wir heute in der Debatte haben der kann
ruhig auch noch Eingang finden in der
Regierungsarbeit aber was diese Debatte
ja zeigt ist dass für jede Minderheit
die jeweils eigene Sprache Identität
stiftend ist und die europäische Karte
von 1992 bildet dafür gemeinsam mit dem
Rahmenabkommen zum schutznationaler
Minderheiten die wichtigste Grundlage
zum Schutz auch durch Tuner Mehrheiten
und Minderheiten und ihrer Sprachen in
Europa aber wie sieht die Wirklichkeit
aus in Europa es ist ausgerechnet der
Sachverständigenausschuss der eu-kater
gewesen der jetzt eine der ersten
Institutionen auf die massiven
Einschränkungen des muttersprachlichen
Deutschunterrichts in Polen aufmerksam
gemacht hat und viele wissen es
vielleicht durch Verordnung seit ersten
September letzten Jahres ist der
muttersprachliche Deutschunterricht von
drei auf eine Wochenstunde gekürzt
worden eine einzige Wochenstunde die
gelehrt wird
und 50.000 Kinder der deutschen
Minderheit in Polen sind davon betroffen
von diesen Einschränkungen und ist die
einzige Minderheit die in dieser Form
betroffen ist liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus unserer Sicht ist das eine
eindeutige Diskriminierung und auch ein
eklatanter Verstoß in der gegen die
eu-kater und deswegen muss das an dieser
Stelle heute auch einmal angesprochen
werden
ich will dabei aber auch herzlichen Dank
sagen an die 14 nationalen Minderheiten
in Polen darunter auch die jüdischen und
die ukrainischen Vertreter die sich
solidarisch erklärt haben mit der
deutschen Minderheit und das kritisiert
haben denn sie haben einzufort
verstanden im Kern geht es um den
Fortbestand der Minderheit in Polen
diese Einschnitte bedrohen die
kulturelle Identität der deutschen
Minderheit und glücklicherweise teilt
diese Bewertung auch die Bundesregierung
ich freue mich deshalb sehr dass die
Bundesregierung ein Teil dieser
Kürzungen versucht hat zu kompensieren
mit 5 Millionen der Kollege Dietmann
niethan von der SPD hat sich auch hier
sehr großartig engagiert aber zeichnet
sich leider jetzt schon ab dass diese
Mittel nicht reichen werden und das auch
ihre Verwendung noch mal überprüft
werden muss hinsichtlich der flexiblen
ähm Gestaltung dasselbe gilt übrigens
auch für die verstärkte Förderung des
polnisch Unterrichts wiederum in
Deutschland durch die Bundesregierung
über kokoproll in Sachsen auch hier
glaube ich müssen wir noch mal dran
politisches aber eins ganz entscheidend
das will ich am Ende sagen nämlich dass
die polnische Regierung ihren Beschluss
zur Einschränkung des muttersprachlichen
Deutschunterrichts revidiert das ist
unsere Forderung der cdu/csu-fraktion
und die möchte ich heute deswegen auch
vortragen und wer auf deutscher Seite
wer auf deutscher Seite den Kampf gegen
Diskriminierung zum erklärten Ziel
seiner Innen- und Außenpolitik macht der
muss sich eben auch daran messen lassen
wie ernsthaft man sich auf Minister
Ebene für die Rechte von Kindern der
deutschen Minderheit im Ausland einsetzt
vielen Dank
Christoph
geht das verstehe ich doch alles ganz
gut jetzt kommt Stefan Seidler vom
südschweigischen wählerverband und er
hat schon angekündigt Teile seiner Rede
auf Dänisch zu halten
Präsidentin moin liebe Kollege Fjord
manderheide
da sahen alte
Schleswig-Holstein
das war nordfriesisch liebe abordnete
lebe junge klatschnass
in diese Zeit in richtig Signal in
Theken in Theken eine lügbar guten Tag
geht ihn mit sein regionale gegenort und
Identität hier in Deutschland hartlich
willkommen und huste ist
den deutsche Geschichte hat uns lehrt
das Hegemonie und Nationalismus in
panishedkram ist und das Minderheiten
Politik Friedenspolitik bedient
regionale Spuren und männerhäten kamt
und bliebt bloß nicht einfach so das
Mythen die Mythen
klare bot an der Kultusminister
und friesisch unterrichten könnt
im Sommer wäre uns Bundestagspräsidentin
Flensburg sie wurden mir die junge
lutschnacken den Friesen und sind jung
und Oma doch verteilt uns in die junge
Frau der Zähne schon mit ihr mehr
süstern Plattdeutsch nackt dass er den
Lehrer dass sie damit abhauen
wenn sie groß ist was fühlen dumm
Tobi könnte wieso Helden dass die
bundeszentral für politische Bildung
mehr über regionale Sprachen und
Minderheiten oklorid wir können open
Lücken aber bannig wichtig täglich
hätten wenn in beten
Informationsmaterial über uns Arbeit ins
Boost in boomstark lotsenlückenstück ob
plaidsch frisch Romanes sorbisch und all
der anderen regionalen Brocken zu finden
sind
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen auf
Hochdeutsch als Minderheitenvertreter
hier im Bundestag freut es mich
besonders dass das Namensrecht und das
gerichtsverfassungsgerichtsverfassungsgesetz
jetzt minderheitskonform angepasst
werden
zum Schluss auf dänisch
wie
minderarbeit
vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit und
vielen Dank an die Stimmung
Stefan Seidler war das er hatte schon im
Vorfeld gesagt dass er am meisten
Respekt vor dem friesischen Part habe
davor hatte er ein bisschen Muffensausen
weil das nicht seine Muttersprache
gewesen sein er wollte extra ein
bisschen lernen für die Rede das hat
sich wohl gelohnt Simona küssen und für
die SPD-Fraktion
i präsidenta
verschonne nenne
satzka Rest yoshiba die sorbische
Sprache lebt
ich selbst spreche nicht niedersorisch
aber sie sollten uns heute einmal gehört
haben
die Stärkung der Minderheiten Sprachen
bedeutet für die letzten Sprecherinnen
und Sprecher immer auch ein Gewinn an
Selbstvertrauen Zugehörigkeit und
Identität für die Mehrheitsgesellschaft
bedeutet sie mehr kulturellen Reichtum
denn kulturelle und sprachliche Vielfalt
kam nicht erst durch Zuwanderung nach
Deutschland heute sprechen etwa
67.000 Menschen sorbisch mit Hilfe der
Sprachen Kater ist das sorbische in den
Fokus gerückt
Brandenburg hat den zweiten landesplan
zur Stärkung der niedersorbische Sprache
und ein mehrsprachigkeitskonzept gerade
erarbeitet
sorbisch soll nicht nur gerettet sondern
wiederbelebt werden es soll
Kommunikationsmittel in allen
Lebensbereichen sein im Beirat der
Stiftung für das sorbische Volk kümmern
wir uns um die Förderung digitaler
Übersetzungsprogramme wir wollen dass
öffentliche Online-Angebote auch in den
Minderheiten Sprachen verfügbar sind und
die digitale Spracherkennung muss auch
sorbisch verstehen und transkribieren
können das ist doch eine Frage der
Inklusion und es gibt noch so viel mehr
zu tun denken Sie einmal an die
Krankenkassen und die Beschriftung von
Führerscheinen die Post muss Briefe
befördern die entsorisch beschriftet
sind die Förderung der Belange von
Minderheiten sollte als gemeinnützig
anerkannt werden
unsere Ortsschilder sind bereits
zweisprachig nur die Autobahnschilder in
Verantwortung des Bundes die sind es
noch nicht mit dem Programm sorja können
auch Erwachsene sorgeschlagen aber uns
fehlen die Sprachlehrer es müsste noch
viel mehr Weiterbildungen geben dazu
hatte ich heute übrigens erst ein
Gespräch mit der domovina dem Bund der
Sorben und Wenden die Sprachausbildung
und die Erforschung von Mehrsprachigkeit
sollten wir weiterhin durch unsere
universitäre Sprachinstitute begleiten
lassen und noch ein Wunsch möge der
Strukturwandel in der Lausitz auch zu
einer Stärkung der sorbischen Sprache
und Kultur führen
dabei sollte klar sein dass Fördermittel
auch für kleine Träger unbürokratisch
und schnell zugänglich sein müssen
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam daran arbeiten
herzlichen Dank
Simone Kurs sie hat es erwähnt sie sitzt
unter anderem auch im Beirat
parlamentarischen Arbeit der Stiftung
für das sehr schön voll letzter reden da
nun in dieser Debatte ist Andreas
Mattfeld für die Union
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen und für allen Label toki cash
für eine ganz charmante Idee da wir von
Dorge Düsseldorf Debatte to minskiden
die das noch so beten kann ob inne
Minderheiten sprock holen darf übrigens
habe ich sogar vor sich obig das mit
Düsen gender Jim Oct hier von der grünen
aufeinander aber ich kann schon sagen
funktioniert hat einfach nicht und das
ist so
und ich dachte ich hätte mich durch die
Freiheit hat unsere fachpolitik hast die
fachpolitik ist von dort innere und von
den Kultur der Chemie als plattdeutschen
hussler hier von Dorge das Rede Recht in
rühmtheit aber so beten bin ich ja als
Fußfälle ok dafür verantwortlich dafür
mit 66 Millionen den Minderheiten in
unseren Land und vor allem ihre Brocken
hier fördern dort und so lütchenwinkel
ja an die Ampel ich Löw wie mögt doch
mehr Mocken die hat dann eben gehört und
wie durfte nicht kürzen und Gott ihnen
fallen deshalb
[Applaus]
gehört leider fell to selten Liebe
Johann sartorf Uhse plattdeutsche sporki
im Bundestag obwohl in Deutschland noch
er bisselben Millionen Lühe Plattdeutsch
nackt und davon hat sogar 2 Millionen
ganz bannig goal Kenntnisse von
Düsseldorf Rock und gerne in der ich
mich um es daran dass ich mit meinem
Freund Wolfgang Börnsen die sich um das
Plattdeutsche bannig für den Markt hat
hier in unserem Plenum schnacken können
ja die ein oder andere die kennt den
Wolfgang noch dafür ein anständigen Kerl
das wie für Dorge mit Gründen Parlament
Kreis von das plattdeutschen
Abgeordneten nur dummen zum Beten zum
Beten unser heimatsport hier in Berlin
plate und danke liebe Güte da du dafür
aus organisiert hast
Abgeordneter erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage aus ihrer eigenen Fraktion
viel vielen Dank Kollege Manfred dass
jede Frau Lord wie helft ja just von der
rechten Ort dazu dagegen sind natürlich
ihre modesprache gehört und man hat ja
segin forchers hat von das
Sprache und hocket
schneller im Kopf sind dass sie
intelligenter sind
und motorsprache das kann ziehen
polnisch das kann Team türkisch
aramäisch Ohr platt
ich bin utten Münsterland im Münsterland
wird plattkühlt nicht mehr so viel als
früher und Nordrhein-Westfalen ist in
von acht Bundesländern wo Plattdeutsch
kühlt wird Essig einen kleinen dotswas
hebe jeden Tag platt hört es sieht Kraut
was Herwig ehemalige weg platthaut und
nun kann ich e-Moll in Monat platt hören
Leibe Kollege was können wir denn tun
das Urte Kinder und die Jungen
oh Herr Kollege jetzt können Sie denken
sie hört aber das ist das wichtige sie
hört ja dass wir in Deutschland allen
anders
beste Frau Präsidentin wäre wenn wir
jede wecke hier eine plattdeutsche eine
plattdeutsche Debatte hat denn dann
wurde ich jetzt mal sagen der
plattdeutsche das sorgt für godeharmonie
wie mag das doch alte hoben der Planet
das führt aus dem Betten und eh nicht
Mutten senken Plattdeutsch als Anspruch
im Bundestag das ist doch was schönes
wenn sie weg wie aus wie aus in
Niedersachsen
emotional mit osteur kalt
dann hört sich doch schön an ne wenn ich
sage aber leck mich am ab Punkt ist das
was anderes ne deshalb glaube ich mehr
Plattdeutsch hier in usem Bundestag das
kann Hülben das kann höben für die
Werbung für unsere sprock und wie
schüttert mehr morgen danke dir
denn ich denke das ist eben für die
wichtig dass wir irgendeiner guten als
politisches dokumentierter das
plattdeutschen usen Bundestag eben nicht
vergessen wart das galt natürlich auch
für die anderen Sprachen und für die
Dialekt und wenn ich über die Dialekte
Schnake Edelhäuser an ich kann mit dazu
muss nicht für kniepen und ich muss mir
eine bayrischen Kollegen davon anthrop
hinwiesen das Sehen mit der bayerischer
Mann bloßen die Dialekt hat wie aber mit
unserer
[Musik]
in getragene anerkannte Frau das ist ein
ganz was anderes
aber wie Herbert Erben hört die Frau ist
ja wirklich was könnt wie morgen damit
die Minderheiten sporken eben mit und
straft sicher wie könnt Geld in den
Haushalt entstellen und für dich war da
zur ok noch mehr die Haushaltsberatung
die Stadt hier vorurteur aber ich bin
ganz ehrlich Geld ist wichtig Geld
unterstützt aber Geld regt alle nicht
wichtig ist dass unsere Schulen
oktaukünftig die Kinder in Kontakt mit
der plattdeutsche bringt und ich
erinnere an die plattdeutschen
Wettbewerbe für die Kinder das ist für
viele junge lügt der erste Kontakt mit
unserer heimatspruch und die Kraft ganz
peinlich danke sehr für all day der
Viktor engagiert und der das Ganze
organisiert das allerwichtigste frau
Präsidentin damit möchte ich aber dann
auch fast Abhören dann allerwichtigste
ist aber und nun kommt in ganz ganz
großen Appell an all die taugliches
Buden an den Fernsehapparate das
wichtigste ist wenn sie noch zum Beten
ganz
Betten dann dort das mit John die Kinder
dort hat mit Johnny Enkelkinder der
blutwinn Ines Spork in Uwe Familien
schnappt war dann hätte Sport in reelle
Chance für eure Leben und bemüttert so
frau Präsidentin ähnlich wie begüte
meine Kinder erholt hat mich für die
sind von dort gedreht und wenn ich und
wenn die kritisiert mit panisch da liegt
nicht platt mit dem sprockenhepp warum
ich da nicht downt ihn nicht gar nicht
aber
Enkelkinder hessenschal dann schlag ich
platt mir die Enkelkinder in diesem
Sinne hatlichen Dank
und ich sag von dieser Stelle herzlichen
Dank für diesen sprachlichen Reichtum
den wir hier haben aber nicht in jeder
Sitzungswoche
[Gelächter]
nicht so jetzt geht's ich schließ
e die also das war dann doch eine Absage
trotzdem war das hier eine mehr als
ungewöhnliche Debatte zu der Sprachen
Kater der europäischen Karte der
regional- und Minderheiten Sprachen die
hier am ersten im März den 25 jahresstag
verzeichnen konnte nun geht es um ein
ganz anderes Thema und zwar hat die
Unionsfraktion einen Antrag eingereicht
in denen es um die Rahmenbedingungen für
den Datenschutz und die künstliche
Intelligenz im Gesundheitswesen geht
Hintergrund ist einer der Bericht einer
Expertenkommission Forschung und
Innovation die am 15 Februar ja Jahres
gut 28 23 an den Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz übergeben hat indem sie sehr
deutlich davor warnt dass Deutschland
aufpassen muss nicht hinterher zu hinken
wenn es um die Standortvorteile
Deutschlands geht der Fall biontech hat
ja schon viele
erschrecken lassen das Unternehmen hat
sich dazu entschieden im britischen
Cambridge auch noch ein in ein
Forschungs- und Entwicklungszentrum zu
investieren für die Unionsfraktion
spricht nun Thomas ihr tombeck Bildungs-
und forschungspolitische Sprecher seiner
Fraktion
im Jahr 2021 waren insgesamt fast 1,5
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland in
Behandlung wegen Krebs im Krankenhaus
und im letzten Jahr sind 500.000 weitere
Patientinnen und Patienten hinzugekommen
in diesem Jahr werden es genauso viele
sein eine schreckliche Krankheit die
viele aus unserer Mitte betrifft und
heute diskutieren wir über das Thema
gesundheitstechnologie Biotechnologie
und gerade hier geht es um mRNA mRNA ist
eine Technologie die vielen bekannt
geworden ist durch die Impfstoffe bei
Corona aber mRNA ist ursprünglich vor
allem darüber gedacht worden als
Krebstherapie und zwar dadurch
das waren Menschen nicht mehr bestrahlt
oder mit anderen harten Therapien
versieht sondern dass der eigene Körper
versteht was ist Tumor und was ist
gesund und man durch eine
mrna-therapie gezielt den eigenen Körper
dazu bringt den Krebs zu bekämpfen eine
tolle Sache mit einer großen Perspektive
viele Menschen die unheilbar heute
erkrankt sind zu therapieren und wir
haben mit biontech und curvec zwei
Unternehmen aus Deutschland die hier in
der Weltliga spielen und gerade bei
biontech-
gründungsprogramme wie go baio die wir
hier aufgebaut haben aber es ist
insbesondere auch ein sehr großes
privates Investment von Privatinvestoren
der Familie strünmann oder von Dietmar
Hopp in diesen beiden Fällen und letzten
Endes war auch Corona ein großer Treiber
hier das alles ist nicht unbedingt so
eins zu eins reproduzierbar und deshalb
ist unser Standort hier auch im Feuer
man muss es einfach mal so sagen denn
bayerntech und das ist auch der Grund
für die heutige Debatte hat angekündigt
genau für diese Krebsforschung eine
strategische Partnerschaft mit der
britischen Regierung einzugehen und
insgesamt bei 10.000 Patientinnen und
Patienten in Großbritannien am Ende die
Forschung genau dort zu betreiben und
eben nicht hier und das ist Grund für
uns dass wir sagen es braucht eine
Analyse von starken und Schwächen
unseres Standorts um herauszufinden sind
wir hier wirklich konkurrenzfähig und
was ist
nichts zu tun und da hören wir von der
Komplexität der Zulassungsverfahren als
allererstes die ja einen Punkt sind aber
es geht auch um das Thema der
Forschungsdaten die zu nutzen in
Deutschland und Europa hinreichend
schwierig ist gerade für die Nutzung von
künstlicher Intelligenz die ganz zentral
ist um hier in der Medizin neue Dinge zu
entwickeln und es geht auch um weitere
regulatorik wir haben ja schon oft genug
auch von der Bundesministerin gehört was
das Thema gehen editing betrifft wir
müssen aus der Verbotsdebatte raus und
deshalb reicht es aber nicht in
Interviews schöne Worte zu sagen sondern
es muss jetzt was passieren und hier
haben wir Defizite meine Damen und
Herren wir haben hier heute eine ganze
Reihe von Punkten aufgeschrieben an die
wir hier heran müssen das beginnt mit
dem Gesundheitsdaten nutzungsgesetzes
das ist bisher von der Regierung
angekündigt worden ist noch nicht da das
registergesetz ebenfalls es geht um den
europäischen gesundheitsdatenraum der
erst 2025 kommen soll wir müssen das
Verfahren hier beschleunigen wir müssen
gucken wie wir mit nationalen wegen hier
auch schon dem vorangehen
und wir müssen das Thema Datenschutz
angehen wir haben 17 datenschutzer und
nirgendwo ist es so kompliziert und
uneinheitlich wie in Deutschland am Ende
mit Forschungsdaten zu arbeiten hier
herrscht Handlungsbedarf
ein Punkt der uns immer noch wichtig ist
ist das Thema der Finanzierung zwei
Milliarden Euro aus dem
Zukunftsfonds sind noch da wir wollen
eine Milliarde für Biotech machen zumal
der neue deepack fand explizit keine
medizinische biotechnutzung vorsichtig
hier ist eine riesige Lücke und das
haben wir alles schon beantragt im
letzten Jahr wir machen heute die
Debatte erneut wir hatten einen
Wirtschaftsausschuss dazu eine gute
Anhörung gestern die bestätigt hat dass
wir große Handlungsbedarf ist und
deshalb Frau Bundesministerin tun Sie
was hier ist Handlungsbedarf wir müssen
Gas geben
Rupert Stüwe erhält das Wort für die
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wer in der
Gesundheit die Digitalisierung
vorantreibt setzt sich für etwas Gutes
ein das können wir schon mal ganz am
Anfang festhalten und deswegen habe ich
mich auch erstmal gefreut über den
Antrag dann ist es ein bisschen
Sammelsurium geworden und
unterschiedlichen Sachen aber
grundsätzlich geht es um das Gute für
die Patientinnen und Patienten weil
Digitalisierung führt ja tatsächlich
dazu dass wir mehr Daten haben um
bessere Therapien und Medikamente
entwickeln zu können für Forscherinnen
und Forscher die auf der einen Seite auf
große Datenmengen zurückgreifen müssen
auf demografische Studien aber auch
die sich um das Thema seltene
Krankheiten ganz anders kümmern können
wenn Sie Zugriff auf eine breite
Datenmenge haben für das
Gesundheitspersonal was effizienter
arbeiten kann natürlich auch für die
Unternehmen die auf Grundlage von Daten
Medikamente und Produkte besser
entwickeln können all das ist richtig in
dem arbeiten wir
gesundheitsdatennutzungsgesetz
forschungsdatengesetz European heads
data space all das wird gerade in der
Koalition entwickelt und auch ein
Parlament diskutiert und ich finde es
auch richtig dass das der Ort ist wo wir
im Parlament noch mal gucken was sind
eigentlich unsere Maßstäbe beim Thema
Datennutzung in der Forschung aber vor
allen Dingen auch in der
Gesundheitsforschung für mich ist es
Daten müssen erstmal verfügbar sein
bevor wir über alles andere reden haben
wir immer noch in verfügbarkeits Thema
und da haben wir ja auch da gucke ich
aber jetzt haben auch in der
Vergangenheit investiert da drin
medizinformatik Initiative 200 Millionen
2023 bis 2026 Netzwerk
Universitätsmedizin nach der Corona 20
23 23 24 80 Millionen nationale
Forschungsdaten Infrastruktur im
Gesundheitsbereich 15 Millionen bis 2025
das heißt an dem Thema Verfügbarkeit
Daten arbeiten wir hart oder die Zahlen
sehen sie auch es gibt Nachholbedarf
hier in Deutschland auf Ebene der
Kliniken aber auch auf Ebene der
Forschung das zweite Thema ist das Thema
Zugänglichkeit beim Thema
Digitalisierung auch da müssen wir rein
da müssen wir natürlich dafür sorgen
dass wir einheitliche Regelungen und
eine einheitliche Anwendung der Regelung
auf in Deutschland haben und dafür das
über die Bundesländer Grenzen
hinweglegen es geht aber auch darum das
Thema Wiederverwertbarkeit von Daten
noch mal in den Blick zu nehmen das
heißt es geht darum das Thema Daten
Alkoholismus in den Mittelpunkt zu
stellen öffentliche Daten aus dem
Gesundheitsbereich die Unternehmen für
Forschung zur Verfügung gestellt werden
die dürfen danach nicht privatisiert
werden sondern die müssen in
öffentlicher Hand bleiben auch darüber
müssen wir reden und wir müssen auch
darüber reden bei dem was wir hier
Euphorie reinbringen dass das Thema
Sicherheiten wichtiges Thema ist beim
Thema Daten da geht's um das Thema
Infrastruktur da geht's aber auch darum
dass wenn ich meine Daten für
Forschungszwecke bereitstelle und spende
dass ich mir sicher sein kann dass damit
was anständiges passiert und das wäre
auch ich da sicher sein kann dass ich
die Kontrolle nicht darüber verliere
und da müssen wir zum Beispiel über das
Thema gehendaten und gehensequenzen
reden weil da geht es nicht nur um meine
eigenen persönlichen Daten sondern jetzt
auch darum wie das eigentlich mit den
Daten ist die meiner Familie und meine
Angehörigen die ich damit mit Spende da
müssen wir darüber reden welche
treuhänderregelungen ist zum Beispiel
gibt für Daten auch das ein wichtiges
Thema dem sich die Bundesregierung auf
dem Weg gemacht hat wer in der
Gesundheit die Digitalisierung
vorantreibt tut auf jeden Fall was Gutes
manchmal mehr oder weniger strukturiert
mir ist wichtig dass am Ende was gutes
dabei rauskommt deswegen glaube ich dass
die gesetzesprozesse die vor uns stehen
die richtigen sind und deswegen glaube
ich dass diese Koalition die richtige
ist am Ende was gutes für das
Gesundheitswesen durch Digitalisierung
zu erreichen vielen Dank
soweit Europa Stühle zu diesem Antrag
der
Unionsfraktion für die afd-fraktion
spricht nun Nicole höchst auch sie sitzt
im Ausschuss für Bildung Forschung und
Technik Folgenabschätzung
wir debattieren den
wissenschaftspopulistischen Antrag der
cdu/csu-antrag Gesundheit
Forschungsstandort Deutschland stärken
bessere Rahmenbedingungen für
Datennutzung und künstliche Intelligenz
schaffen ja guten Morgen der
Wissenschaftsrat hat bereits 2018
Fehlentwicklungen im Bereich der
klinischen Forschung und grundlegende
Strukturprobleme angezeigt heißt sie
haben den bestehenden Rückstand
maßgeblich mit verschuldet meine Damen
und Herren
ihr Antrag soll nun ungenutztes
Potenzial entfesseln weniger Drama ging
ja wohl nicht dabei ist der Grundgedanke
ja richtig sie schreiben ich zitiere
sinngemäß dass nur dort eine Chance auf
eine dauerhafte Spitzenposition im
internationalen Wettbewerb besteht wo
Forschung und Innovation stets im
Aufwind sind Zustimmung einige ihrer
Forderungen sind nachvollziehbar der
Nutzen für den wissenschaftsforschungs-
und Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
erkennbar leider klären Sie folgende
Datenschutz Belange in keinster Weise
wie bleibt der Bürger souverän seiner
Daten wo sollen die Daten gelagert
werden mit welchen Systemanbietern
arbeiten wir zusammen sie fordern Punkt
8 den Aufbau einer zentralen Stelle für
den Zugang zu Gesundheitsdaten für die
sekundärnutzung mit einem Rechtsanspruch
auf den Zugang zu solchen Daten in
anonymisierter und gegen gegebenenfalls
pseud anonymisierter Form das sehe ich
besonders kritisch und ich sage Ihnen
auch mit einem Beispiel warum ich habe
ein chinesisches Mobiltelefon mit
amerikanischen Betriebssystemen verwende
Suchmaschinen soziale Netzwerke
Messenger-Dienste und bin in der AFD
somit bin ich bereits jetzt nie alleine
habe die Chinesen Amerikaner Russen den
Verfassungsschutz und wer weiß wen noch
alles immer mit dabei die Datenkraken
sammeln allzeit fleißig und genau das
ist das Problem wenn wir über
Datennutzung sprechen der Mensch wird im
Zuge der viel gepriesenen großen
Transformation immer mehr zum wandelnden
Daten
verwandelnden Datenmenge einem
zellbasierten Algorithmus der aber kann
gehackt kontrolliert verändert zensiert
und zu allen möglichen Zwecken verkauft
und letztlich gelöscht werden
wissen ist Macht wer die Hoheit über die
Daten der Menschheit hat ist nicht nur
unendlich reich er hat auch die totale
Kontrolle meine Damen und Herren machen
wir uns über unseren Handlungsspielraum
hier keine Illusionen im Machtgefüge der
Welt wo beispielsweise die WHO
größtenteils von der Bild- und Melinda
gate-stiftung finanziert wird und in dem
Geldströme und Einflussnahmen weltweit
sehr deutlich und transparent aufzeigen
wer eigentlich die Geschicke dieser Welt
lenkt und das ist immer schwieriger
nicht misstrauisch zu sein meine Damen
und Herren
prinzipiell müssen aber Datenschutz und
Datennutzung kein Widerspruch sein viele
Bürger Deutschlands stehen im Ansinnen
Gesundheitsdaten zu sammeln aber eher
kritisch gegenüber deshalb müssen wir
Volksvertreter den Gesichtspunkten
Vertrauen und Transparenz große
Aufmerksamkeit widmen die in ihrem
Antrag fehlen mit der afd-fraktion ist
digitaler Fortschritt zu machen aber
nicht gegen den Willen und zum Schaden
der Bürger der Bürger darf nicht durch
die Digitalisierung zum allseits und
allzeit beherrschbaren homo Algorithmus
werden sondern muss der Souverän im
Staat seinem eigenen Leben und in seiner
tata-space bleiben
lassen wir uns nicht zu Handlangern von
weltumspannende Netzwerken der Reichen
und Mächtigen der Wirtschaft und der
Pharmaindustrie machen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Nicole höchst für die afd-fraktion war
das wir kommen nun zu Laura Kraft für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren die
Digitalisierung im Gesundheitssystem ist
eines der zentralen Vorhaben und
bedeutet ein enorme Verbesserung für die
Gesundheitsvorsorge in Deutschland
Forscherinnen und Forscher leisten einen
bedeutsamen Beitrag für eine bessere
Zukunft sie brauchen aber auch die
richtigen Rahmenbedingungen und dazu
gehört vor allem auch das
Gesundheitsdaten besser nutzbar werden
in ihrem Antrag kritisiert die Union
aber ein Zustand wen wundert den sie
selber mit herbeigeführt haben sie
kritisieren in ihrem Antrag die
Rahmenbedingungen für Datennutzung und
KI das ist aber ganz schön mutig für
eine Fraktion die gerade mal vor zehn
Jahren für sich das Internet als Neuland
entdeckt hat wir erinnern uns und so
ja aber so haben unsere Gesundheitsämter
dann leider auch die Pandemie bekämpfen
müssen mit Fax Papier und mit Stift und
die überbürokratisierung im Bereich der
medizinischen Innovation das ist auch
eine Hinterlassenschaft mitunter von
ihrer Regierung aber ich finde es
grundsätzlich ja auch ganz nett dass sie
ja in ihrem Antrag unseren
ampelkoalitionsvertrag scheinbar so
loben und davon überzeugt sind denn sie
alle Forderungen die sie ja stellen die
sind da im Prinzip schon in der
geplanten vorhabung mit drin und an der
Umsetzung wird ja derzeit auch schon
gearbeitet und wir werden neue und
bessere Situation in der
Gesundheitsforschung mit Zukunft
schaffen
[Applaus]
Gesundheitswirtschaft einberufen und
außerdem haben wir auch bereits im
letzten Jahr ein Strategieprozess in die
Wege geleitet der den Rahmen für das
registergesetz und das
gesundheitsdatennutzungsgesetz schon in
Kürze bestimmen wird und mit der
elektronischen Patientenakte für alle
werden die erstmals vollständig und
flächendeckend
gesundheitsdatenstrukturiert
dokumentieren können und werden
gleichzeitig die Patientin und Patienten
Zugriff auf Ihre Daten erhalten dabei
können die Patientinnen und Patienten
selbst bestimmen welche Daten für sie
für gemeinwohlorientierte
Forschungszwecke zur Verfügung stellen
und das alles in einer absolut
datenschutzorientierten Umgebung
und dabei werden dann forschende auch
durch einheitliche Regeln der
Datenschutzbehörden unterstützt und
können Forschungsprojekte in Zukunft
einfach besser beantragen
[Applaus]
weiterhin bringt sich die ampelregierung
auf europäischer Ebene aktiv in den
Prozess zum European Health data space
ein um ein Datenaustausch auch
länderübergreifend zu ermöglichen und
Deutschland so international
anschlussfähig zu machen und die
Bundesregierung ist also ja dem Antrag
schon längst einem Schritt voraus und
die digitale Transformation in der
Gesundheitsforschung die bringt
gewaltige Chancen mit sich das haben sie
schon erläutert das ist auch richtig und
es entstehen so ja auch neue
Perspektiven zum wissenschaftlichen
Erkenntnis gewonnen über die Entstehung
von Krankheiten aber auch Wirksamkeit
von Therapien und durch digital
Innovation wird unser Gesundheitssystem
dann auch zukunftstauglich
weil der demokratische Wandel einen
Anstieg der Betroffenen von
altersbedingten Krankheiten mit sich
bringen wird ist die Dinge digitale
Transformation eben unerlässlich denn so
können wir dann die zukünftigen Hürden
besser bewältigen und das vor allen
Dingen auch in Krisenzeiten wie wichtig
das ist haben wir auch während der
Pandemie gesehen die Rahmenbedingungen
verbessern die auch indem wir
Datenerhebung Datenspeicherung
standardisieren und den Weg für eine
patientenzentrierte individuelle
Behandlung bereiten und damit alle die
für sich genau richtige
Gesundheitsversorgung erhalten können
durch eine bessere
gesundheitsdateninfrastruktur werden die
Prozesse möglichst vereinfacht während
gleichzeitig der Datenschutz gestärkt
wird und die dann Infrastruktur muss
dabei so beschaffen sein dass die
möglichst gut nutzbar für die Forschung
wird aber die Bedürfnisse der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dürfen nicht
vernachlässigt werden und darum ist es
so wichtig dass alle Beteiligten in den
Prozess und in die Entwicklung mit
eingebunden werden
durch dann nutzbar gemachten
Gesundheitsdaten wird es möglich sein
bislang noch zu wenig erforschte
Krankheiten auch seltenerkrankungen
besser zu entwickeln
Therapiemöglichkeiten zu entwickeln
voranzutreiben
und da wir aktuell den Endometriose
wellness-monat haben denke ich auch hier
verstärkt an die Betroffenen von dieser
besonders schmerzhaften Erkrankungen die
schätzungsweise zehn bis 15 Prozent der
Frauen im gebärfähigen Alter betrifft
und ihn soll jetzt endlich besser
geholfen werden gerade die Gesundheit
von Frauen ist durch eine viel geringere
Datenlage als bei Männern bisher
gefährdet durch die erleichterte
Bereitstellung von Gesundheitsdaten für
die Forschung wird sich dann auch
endlich der Gender data GAP schließen
können
insgesamt müssen aber die Möglichkeiten
von Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler in der
Gesundheitsforschung verbessert werden
und das gelingt uns durch optimierte
Rahmenbedingungen gerade bei klinischen
Studien da können wir dafür sorgen dass
Forschung und Entwicklung von
Therapeutika in Deutschland stattfinden
und dann auch die Produktion hier vor
Ort stattfinden wird und auch hier ist
wieder sinnvoll wird und dadurch werden
wir auch unabhängiger und wir verkürzen
Lieferketten wir bleiben an der Spitze
der Forschung und das ist doch das was
wir wollen ja wir wollen den
Forschungsstandort hier in Deutschland
leben
und wir sehen mit dem Vorhaben die Ampel
geht voran die Ampel kommt weg vom Fax
und geht hin in Richtung KI und das ist
das was wir brauchen vielen Dank
für die Fraktion DIE LINKE hält dr Petra
Sitte das Wort und Petra Sitte
Sprecherin für Bildung Forschung und
Technik Folgen Abschätzung ihrer
Fraktionen wenn man den Antrag der Union
liest sehr schön dann könnte man fast
vergessen das sieht die Themen
Gesundheit und Forschung in den letzten
Jahren verantwortet haben
na klar sind Gesundheitsdaten bzw die
Nutzung von Gesundheitsdaten für die
wissenschaftliche Forschung extrem
wichtig es gibt hier große Potenziale
und wir brauchen um diese tatsächlich zu
heben wirklich eine gesetzliche Regelung
anders geht es nicht derzeit
derzeit ist die rechtliche Lage nämlich
völlig undurchschaubar dabei gibt es
durchaus viele viele Menschen die
gewillt sind ihre Daten zur
medizinischen Forschung zur Verfügung zu
stellen um zu helfen aber wenn Sie das
tun wollen dann bekommen sie einen
konvolut von 20 bis 30 Seiten vorgelegt
und das ist für die Leute doch eher
beängstigend als ermutigend und da das
dann am Ende eh niemand liest würde ich
auch nicht machen verliert Datenschutz
an Akzeptanz und die informierte ein
Entscheidung also die informierte
Entscheidung wird dadurch unterlaufen
natürlich sind persönliche
Gesundheitsdaten hochsensibel da muss
ich hier niemand irgendwie
gegenseitig überzeugen Voraussetzung für
eine Freigabe sind Vertrauen und hohe
Standards für Datensicherheit und da
hatten Souveränität daraus folgt wie ist
der Antrag schreibt eine ich zitiere
abgestufte freiwillige und widerrufbare
Datenfreigabe in enger abstimm mit den
Datenschutzbehörden Datenschutz
Aufsichtsbehörden wichtig Vorschläge
dieser Art das muss ich der Union sagen
liegen seit Jahren vor beispielsweise
der Ethikrat hat dazu gearbeitet die
ankeit-kommission künstliche Intelligenz
hat dazu Vorschläge gemacht es wundert
mich aber ausgerechnet dass in einem
unionsantrag in den einzelnen Punkten
wieder zu finden zur Erinnerung noch
einmal es war ihr Gesundheitsminister
Gesundheitsminister Spahn der mit dem
digitale Versorgungsgesetz die
Abrechnungsdaten der Krankenkassen für
alle möglichen Zwecke freigegeben hat
und zwar unter völliger Missachtung der
Betroffenen Rechte und mit begrenzten
sitzen ja ja das können sie ja alles
nachher besser ausruhen und mit
begrenzten Nutzung für die Wissenschaft
das wollen sie lieber nicht bereden
interessant ist auch dass ihnen der
europäische gesundheitsdatenraum nicht
schnell genug kommen kann mich hat es
stutzig gemacht die Bundesregierung soll
am besten noch mit der Umsetzung
beginnen bevor die endgültigen Regelung
bekannt sind wie immer das auch
letztlich funktionieren soll ich frage
mich ob Ihnen die deutliche Kritik am
derzeitigen Entwurf aus Datenschutz
Sicht bekannt ist denn dort fehlen
nämlich genau diese Betroffenen Rechte
die sie hier auf einmal so hochhalten
und schließlich sollten wir nicht
vergessen dass für die wissenschaftliche
Forschung Fragen der Standardisierung
und der Datenqualität nicht weniger
entscheidend sind als die das Daten
Zugangs abschließend es ist daher
wichtig dass wir vorhaben wie die
nationale Forschungsdaten Infrastruktur
und hier insbesondere NFD NF die vorhers
also für den Gesundheitsbereich auf
Dauer einrichten und Liebe
Ampelkoalition auch ausreichend
finanzieren
danke
Petra Sitte war das auch Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz hat ja viele konkrete
Gesetzesvorhaben angekündigt ist dabei
aber nicht sehr viel konkreter geworden
eventuell kann uns Maximilian Funke
Kaiser erhellen von der FDP-Fraktion
spricht er nun
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren der Union es ist ja
schon sehr bezeichnet dass die in ihrem
Antrag das argumentative Grundgerüst auf
eine Ausarbeitung des Wissenschaftsrates
aus dem Jahre 2018 aufbauen sie sprechen
davon grundlegenden Strukturproblemen
die eine Herausforderung für den
deutschen
Forschungsstandort darstellen und das
ist insofern bezeichnend weil ich finde
dass es sehr sehr mutig dass sie auf
Basis dieser Argumentation ihren Antrag
aufbauen denn und das wurde gerade eben
auch schon angesprochen es ist nach
meinem Kenntnis so nach meiner
Zeitrechnung dass sie 2018 in
Regierungsverantwortung waren und es ist
auch nicht so als wäre die Erkenntnis im
Jahre 2018 erst im Jahre 2018 entstanden
da liegen noch ein paar Jahre davor und
es ist auch nicht so dass Sie in diesem
Bereich nicht auch wesentliche
Ministerien besetzt haben sie haben die
Bundeskanzlerin gestellt sie haben den
Gesundheitsminister gestellt und ja sie
haben auch die
Forschungsministerin gestellt die
grundlegenden Strukturprobleme die haben
sie offensichtlich damals schon nicht
ernst genommen genauso wenig wie sie das
in ihrem Antrag tun liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und ich kann Ihnen
versichern die fortschrittskoalition und
die FDP mit auch Ministerin Bettina
stark Watzinger die gehen die vom
wissensstraat angefangen hatte über
Bürokratisierung den Ausbau des
wissenschafts-gesetz im Gesundheitswesen
und vieles weitere uns ist die Forschung
und Innovationspolitik nämlich nicht
egal das zu behaupten ist bei ihrer
Regierungsbilanz im
forschungs-satz zu den letzten Regierung
des Forschungen Inno vation für die
Ampelkoalition extrem wichtig
und bevor ich zu ihren Antrag komme kurz
zu ihrem Aufhänger biontech das ist mir
nämlich sehr sehr wichtig denn die
meisten hier im Hohen Haus die wissen
dass wir sehr sehr viele kluge Köpfe in
diesem Land haben und wiederum auch
viele wenn auch nicht alle wissen dass
wir noch mehr kluge Köpfe in diesem Land
brauchen und deswegen finde ich es gut
dass sie ihren Antrag mit bei uns direkt
als Aufhänger aufgebaut haben oder den
so aufgebaut haben nehmen wir uns ein
Beispiel an biontech und auch die
Entwicklung des Impfstoffes nehmen wir
uns ein Beispiel an den Gründern es dem
theoretische und Uga Schein machen wir
mehr migrations Erfolg Stories
migrationsgeschichten zur volksstories
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und ich
kann Ihnen sagen
von diesem Erfolgsgeschichten wird es in
Zukunft auch mehr geben denn uns ist
bewusst dass wir Zuwanderung in den
Arbeitsmarkt hier in Deutschland
brauchen ein entsprechender
Gesetzentwurf ist auch in diesem Fall
bereits in der Pipeline die erleichtern
den Zugang von qualifizierten
Arbeitskräften in den deutschen
Arbeitsmarkt denn die Beseitigung von
Arbeitskräfte Engpässen und das muss in
dieser Frage eben auch berücksichtigt
werden ist vor allem auch für den IT-
und Gesundheitsbereich und für die IT-
und Gesundheitsbranche entscheidend und
damit auch für den Erhalt des
Wohlstandes hier in Deutschland was dann
aber und das finde ich sehr sehr
bezeichnet und so schließt sich der
Kreis doch sehr bezeichnet ist zu
Zuwanderung von Arbeitskräften findet
sich in ihrem Antrag rein gar nichts das
überrascht aber ehrlicherweise auch
nicht verkürzt ihr Vorsitzender die
Debatte doch mit Planken ich zitiere
kleine Paschas Populismus also hören Sie
doch bitte auf hier den Leuten Sand in
die Augen zu streuen und Migration
erfolgreich mit ihren Anträgen Zweck zu
entfremden wenn sie solche
Erfolgsstories doch eigentlich gar nicht
wollen
kommen wir zu den konkreten Forderungen
des Antrags überweisen auf den European
Health data space sie erkennen richtig
dass der ihds-vorgaben zu
Interoperabilität setzt ihr erkennen
ebenfalls richtig dass hier auch der
Aufbau eines
europaübergreifenden
gesundheitsdatenraums dringend notwendig
ist die Irren jedoch in der Annahme dass
es mit der Umsetzung dieser Zielvorhaben
lange dauern wird denn unsere
dateninitiativen und ich bin darauf
schon eingegangen und auch das
Gesundheitsdaten nutzungsgesetz die
kommen noch in diesem Jahr während wir
auf die Umsetzung des
Kommissionsvorschlags der das ehds von
ihrer Parteifreundinnen Ursula von
alleine und da schießen sie sich
ehrlicherweise selber ins Knie noch bis
2025 warten das der Grund warum wir
heute auch über fehlende
Interoperabilität reden und über
Datenstandards das hat im Grunde auch
damit zu tun dass wir die
Digitalisierung der letzten Jahre falsch
verstanden haben und dabei ist ganz
einfach wenn wir miteinander reden
brauchen wir einheitliche Daten Sprachen
einheitliche Sprache sprechen wir keine
einheitliche Sprache dann ist das ein
Problem das ist eines der ganz großen
Probleme warum wir 15 Jahre lang in der
Digitalisierung im Grunde zurückliegen
auch im Gesundheitswesen und das packen
wir jetzt an und wir müssen eben nicht
mehr warten bis der ihds kommen sondern
wir liefern da jetzt auch schon die
Conclusio ist also sämtliche ihres Punkt
Anträge ihres Antrages sind von uns
bereits erledigt weitere wichtige Punkte
fehlen ihr Antrag ist somit obsolet und
was sie wenn sie heute fordern dass wir
unsere Vorhaben schnelle umsetzen wollen
die sie erst gar nicht erst angezeigt
haben das ist das mehr als glaubwürdig
haben Sie noch etwas Geduld wir hatten
es 16 Jahre lang mit ihnen herzlichen
Dank
Maximilian Funkel Kaiser hat hier den
Antrag für erledigt erklärt dagegen wird
sich wahrscheinlich die nur Sorge
aussprechen erste gesundheitspolitische
Sprecher der Union
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass wir ein bisschen stärker
auch bei der Thematik über Chancen
sprechen würden und was ich jetzt gerade
wieder hier gehört habe ist im Grunde
nur irgendwelche einseitigen
Schuldzuweisungen da ist überhaupt nicht
auf Chancen im Bereich Digitalisierung
Chancen im Bereich künstliche
Intelligenz und insbesondere auf die
Frage wie können wir es schaffen Daten
besser zu nutzen weil ja Daten Leben
retten im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes wie
können wir das hinbekommen da ist
überhaupt nichts gekommen von ihrer
Seite liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
will noch mal dem Herrn Kollegen Funke
Kaiser ein bisschen auf die Sprünge
helfen da ja offensichtlich noch nicht
so lange hier dabei ist und immer so tut
als sei in den letzten 16 Jahren all das
was schief gegangen ist an der Union
fest zu machen ich darf nur daran
erinnern bei der Frage
forschungsdatennutzung haben wir in der
letzten Legislatur drei
digitalisierungsgesetze gemacht der
damalige Bundesgesundheitsminister Jens
Spahn ist immer dafür geschalten worden
dass er zu viele Gesetze zu schnell und
vor allen Dingen im Bereich
Digitalisierung viel viel zu viel wollte
und jetzt stellen Sie sich hierher und
sagen dass ein nichts passiert also das
ist überhaupt nicht ehrlich liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und dann will
ich Ihnen auch noch mal ganz konkret
sagen weil sich ja hier auch die
Kollegen der SPD so aufspielen als als
hätten sie in der Vergangenheit
überhaupt keinerlei Verantwortung
getragen das Thema
forschungsdatenzentrum haben wir in drei
digitalisierungsgesetzen im DVG
beispielsweise in
patientendatenschutzgesetz haben wir
jedes Mal gesagt beim
forschungsdatenzentrum also dort wo
Daten versorgungsdaten die jeden Tag
milliardenfach anfallen zusammengeführt
werden da muss natürlich auch Industrie
da müssen private Unternehmen überhaupt
mal den Antrag stellen dürfen diese
Daten nutzen zu dürfen um wissen sie was
passiert ist ihr Kollege Karl Lauterbach
ihre Kollegin Bars die haben in den
entscheidenden Besprechung jedes mal
gesagt das wollen wir nicht wir wollen
keine Industrie wir wollen keine
privaten Unternehmen weil die ja böse
sind das ist nämlich das was soweit auch
dazu gehört liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und wenn wir darüber sprechen
zeigen wie bekommen wir das besser hin
dann ist dieser Antrag ja sie haben es
Studio glaube ich genannten Sammelsurium
hier ist kein Sammelsurium das ist im
Grunde in der Auflistung dessen was wir
alle gemeinsam viel schneller auf den
Weg bekommen müssen und es ist auch ein
Alarmsignal wenn biontech wenn Bayer
wenn BASF wenn die alle sagen hier
verlagern Innovationen Produktion ins
Ausland also raus aus Europa raus aus
Deutschland
hat danach gesagt ja es ist nur so ein
bisschen Kooperation aber es hat doch
ein Grund warum Tech ins Vereinigte
Königreich gehen will weil dort einfach
die Nutzung von Daten viel viel besser
geregelt ist und wenn ich mir überlege
was der zuständige Minister ja Karl
Lauterbach unser
Bundesgesundheitsminister getan hat was
hat er gemacht hat das angekündigt hat
richtig er hat getwittert und wissen Sie
was hat er hat geschrieben
Forschungsbedingungen in Deutschland
schlecht Problem
Voraussetzung der Datennutzung schlecht
aber die Konsequenz daraus war nicht
etwa dass er jetzt in anderthalb Jahren
dieses
gesundheitsdatennutzungsgesetz auf den
Weg gebracht hätte nein er hat es eben
nicht getan und dann darf ich sie noch
erinnern sie haben ja ein ganz tollen
Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten
die Bundesregierung aufgefordert das ist
kein Witz vor Präsidentin ihre Zeit das
ist auch kein Facebook eine Sekunde noch
den Facebook-Auftritt der
Bundesregierung vom Netz zu nehmen weil
datenschutzrechtlich Bedenken bestehen
also ein Auftritt muss ich Millionen von
Menschen informieren und Digitalisierung
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Daten
nutzen wollen und das ist unsere ihre
datenpolitik ihre datennutzungspolitik
das macht neue Therapieansätze unmöglich
das macht neue Arzneimittel unmöglich
und da sollten wir gemeinsam dran
arbeiten anstatt uns hier gegenseitig
die Schuld zu schieben vielen Dank
nächste Rednerin ist für die
SPD-Fraktion
danke schön sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Besucherinnen und
Besucher schön dass Sie da sind bei
einer so wichtigen Debatte immer wenn es
einen Durchbruch in der
Gesundheitsforschung gibt zum Beispiel
in der Krebsforschung dann denke ich an
die die ihren Bruder ihren Freund ihre
Frau ihre Mami an den Krebs verloren
haben und wie oft werden sich diese
Menschen gedacht haben wäre er wäre sie
doch nur ein paar Jahre später erkrankt
oder aber sie denken wäre die Forschung
doch nur ein paar Jahre schneller
gewesen
so ist es auch meiner besten Freundin
Sabrina ergangen als sie in einer
Zeitschrift gelesen hat dass es nun
gelungen sei aus körpereigenen Gewebe
eine Herzklappe zu konstruieren sogar
eine klitzekleine wie sie Lolo gebraucht
hätte für Lolo wie ihr kleiner Sohn
Lorenz genannt wird kam das zu spät er
hat unglaublich gekämpft er war
wahnsinnig tapfer aber wenn ihm keine
biologische und keine künstliche
Herzklappe gepasst hat wurde er nur 15
Monate alt
die mechanische Klappe die man ihm
eingesetzt hat hat immer wieder
Blutgerinnsel erzeugt ich wusste hat
Sabrina gesagt ich wusste es hängt vom
Fortschritt der Forschung ab wie lange
und wie qualitativ wertvoll das Leben
von meinem Kind sein kann und dafür
hätte sie alles gegeben der
verantwortungsvolle Umgang mit
persönlichen mit sensiblen Daten ist
Sabrina die seit vielen Jahren bei der
SAP in Mannheim arbeitet sehr wichtig
bevor Lorenz in ihre kleine vierköpfige
Familie kam war sie vorsichtig und
skeptisch was das veräußern Ihrer Daten
angeht und gestern sagte sie mir es war
mir komplett egal wo die ganzen Daten
liegen ich hätte für Lolo alle Daten
sofort gegeben
damit ist Sabrina sicherlich kein
Einzelfall unsere Aufgabe als Politik
ist es klang heute öfter einen genau
weil es so ist dass diese verzweifelten
Angehörigen darauf vertrauen können dass
Ihre Daten in guten Händen sind wenn
diese verbunden mit großer Hoffnung
preisgegeben werden
aber es geht heute ja gar nicht nur um
die Angehörigen und es geht auch nicht
nur um die Daten von erkranken wieso
braucht medizinische Forschung überhaupt
so persönliche individuelle Daten kann
man das nicht alles auch im Reagenzglas
erforschen leider nein denn zentrale
Fragen in der Gesundheitsforschung sind
zum Beispiel warum wird der eine krank
und der andere nicht und welche Faktoren
spielen dabei eine Rolle ist es Umwelt
das soziale Umfeld oder vielleicht auch
Arbeitsbedingungen und dafür werden
Daten von gesunden oder besser von der
Durchschnittsbevölkerung erhoben
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage des
Kollegen Sorge
nein nein vielen Dank ist die Rede
bewegt mich gerade so sehr dass ich
leider nicht leider nicht ihre
Zwischenfrage annehmen werde ich hoffe
Sie verstehen das also noch mal zurück
dafür werden dann Daten von gesunden
oder der Durchschnittsbevölkerung
erhoben im besten Fall über Jahre hinweg
und dann wird geschaut wer erkrankt und
wer nicht
sind die erhobenen Datenmengen dann
irgendwann groß genug dann lassen sich
auch Rückschlüsse auf konkrete Risiken
ziehen wie wir das ja auch bei den
Gefahren
des Rauchens oder es Bewegungsmangels
schon erlebt haben und deshalb sollte
die Forschung einen privilegierten
Zugang auch zu Gesundheitsdaten haben
wie sie sagen und was manchmal wie ein
Widerspruch klingt persönliche viel
Daten für die Forschung und Datenschutz
ist in Wahrheit gar nicht gar keiner um
es mit den Worten von Ulrich Kälber den
Datenschutzbeauftragten des Bundes zu
sagen der Datenschutz steht der
medizinischen Forschung nicht entgegen
im Gegenteil Datenschutz und
medizinische Forschung stellen beide das
Wohl des Patienten in den Mittelpunkt
ihrer Tätigkeit es gibt daher ein
gemeinsames Interesse das dazu führen
sollte im Gespräch miteinander zu sein
und zu bleiben genau das tun wir heute
hier genau
[Applaus]
Antrag richtig nicht alles was Sie im
Antrag schreiben finde ich sehr seriös
wenn man bedenkt dass sie und das wurde
heute schon gesagt 16 Jahre das
Gesundheitsministerium hatten aber das
finde ich jetzt auch gleichzeitig
irrelevant denn es wird ja jetzt was
getan ich weiß dass gerade Karl
Lauterbach dieses Thema sehr wichtig ist
und er gerade aktiv am Gesundheitsdaten
nutzungsgesetz arbeitet sabrina hat mir
übrigens gesagt sie denkt oft an die
Kinder die noch in der Kinderklinik
kämpfen
sie hat ihren kleinen Sohn obduzieren
lassen für die Forschung so kann Lolo
vielleicht noch die Leben anderer Kinder
retten danke
Maja Waldstein war das hat hier auch
noch mal erläutert warum sie keine
Zwischenfrage aus der Union zulässt nun
gibt es eine Kurzintervention von Tino
Sorge in Waldstein ich wollte ihnen
eigentlich danken für Ihre Ausführungen
die ich teilweise aufgrund meiner kurzen
Redezeit nicht machen konnte und deshalb
wollte ich eigentlich nur noch mal
darauf hinweisen dass das was sie ja
Ansprachen an dem konkreten persönlichen
Fall auch festgemacht haben der mich
übrigens sehr bewegt
also das ist ja darum geht
datenfreigaben jetzt vermutlich und
weil sie haben Kälber angesprochen haben
also ich habe mit ihm ja auch viele
Gespräche geführt es geht ja dann darum
im Rahmen von elektronischen
Patientenakten auch
im Daten zur Verfügung zu stellen gerade
für solche Fälle
die ich aus dem Privatbereich auch kenne
und deshalb wollte ich sie eigentlich
nur bitten darauf hinzuwirken auch in
ihrer Fraktion dass wir das was uns
Wissenschaftler sagen beispielsweise am
Deutschen Krebsforschungszentrum dass
sie Daten haben für neue Krebstherapien
für immun onkologische Therapieansätze
also wo Daten in
versorgungs-daten die man aber momentan
nicht zusammenführen darf dass wir
gerade bei der Frage
forschungsdatenzentrum ja wirklich
innerhalb der der Koalition bei den
Fachpolitikern teilweise überhaupt kein
Dissens haben weil wie gesagt haben wir
müssen diese Daten zur Verfügung stellen
weil Daten Leben retten und den Bürger
die Möglichkeit geben diese Daten
überhaupt erstmal zur Verfügung stellen
zu können also nicht dass die
Wissenschaftler sagen wir würden ja
gerne aber wir können nicht wir dürfen
nicht und deshalb wäre es ja ebenso
wichtig im Rahmen des
forschungsdatenzentrums diese Freigabe
die Möglichkeit das private Unternehmen
einen Antrag stellen können diese Daten
für Forschungszwecke nutzen zu dürfen
dass wir das hinbekommen und das wäre im
Grunde meine Bitte dass sie das in ihre
Ampelkoalition auf den Weg bringen im
Rahmen des Gesundheitsdaten
nutzungsgesetz ist dass wir da was
hinbekommen dass wir den Menschen helfen
können da haben sie uns an ihrer Seite
und ich glaube das wird dann was Gutes
[Applaus]
ich stimme Ihnen zu und ich habe das
vielleicht in meiner Rede nicht ganz
deutlich gemacht ich finde ich bin Ihnen
dankbar dass sie mit diesem Antrag die
Debatte ins Haus gebracht haben und auch
natürlich dann im Ausschuss auch
ich finde wir haben da vielleicht in den
letzten Jahren nein ganz sicher in den
letzten Jahren einfach auch viel
verschlafen und deshalb
danke dass wir die Debatte jetzt hier
führen aber es darf eben auch nicht nur
bei der Debatte bleiben ich sage ihnen
dass habe das in der Rede ja versucht
deutlich zu machen vielleicht ich bitte
um Vergebung wenn ich da nicht deutlich
genug geworden bin das ich bin gerade im
Gesundheitsministerium einfach auch sehr
viel Aktivität in diesem Thema sehr sie
werden mit der persönlichen Biografie
von Karl Lauterbach verstehen dass er da
auch ein großes Interesse daran hat er
endlich auch voranzukommen und genau das
werden wir als Koalition gerne mit Ihrer
Unterstützung auch vorantreiben das hat
danke noch mal dass sie das hier in die
Debatte gebracht haben
und die nächste Rednerin ist die
Abgeordnete
Kollegen die Union möchte den
Forschungsstandort Deutschland stärken
und bessere Rahmenbedingungen für
Datenschutz und künstliche Intelligenz
schaffen wir haben es mehrfach heute
gehört sie selbst hat festgestellt dass
er Wissenschaftsrat das bereits 2018
anmahnte und bis zum Ende der
Legislaturperiode hat sich damals nichts
geändert die Union hat diesen
Fortschritt in ihrer Legislaturperiode
leider verschlafen anstatt die digitalen
Probleme anzupacken hat sie einen kaum
überschaubares Geflecht an
beratungskoordinierungs- und
umsetzungsprämien erschaffen was zu
Verantwortungslosigkeit und Kompetenz
vergangen gefühlt hat ich habe das mit
vielen Anträgen hier im Bundestag
kritisiert und Verbesserungsvorschläge
gemacht die einzige haben sie alle
abgelehnt wie hieß es damals gute Antrag
falscher parteifrunde aber man kann ja
dazu lernen und der heute Vorliegen der
Antrag ist ein guter Antrag denn die
Ampel macht es im Moment nicht viel
besser und Deutschland hat eine Menge
aufzuholen gerade bei der Nutzung von
Gesundheitsdaten zu Forschungszwecken
aber Preis vermisse ich in ihrem Antrag
Werte Kollegen nämlich den Menschen
mitzunehmen kein Wort davon viele sehen
in der KI unter Datennutzung eher ein
Risiko als einen Fortschritt es fehlt
das Vertrauen und selbst die EU spricht
von Risikoklassen der KI aber nicht von
Chancen und wertigkeitsklassen auf der
einen Seite wird der Datenschutz mit der
dsgvo fast religiös zelebriert und man
sagt den Bürgern Daten sammeln ist böse
und auf den anderen Seite sollen sie
jetzt medizinische Daten freigegeben das
geht nicht ohne den Bürger mitzunehmen
man muss mit den Bürger reden und nicht
über ihn meine Damen und Herren sie
müssen den Menschen das erklären und
ihnen die Angst nehmen und ihnen die
Vorteile aufzeigen und gleichzeitig
sicherstellen dass Ihre Privatsphäre
geschützt wird und auch bleibt wir
brauchen einen öffentlichen Diskurs
damit in der Bevölkerung bestehende
Unsicherheit hinsichtlich der Risiken
überwunden werden kann und dieser
Diskurs muss eben hier starten und dann
muss die Ampel aber bitte die PS auf die
Straße bringen denn das Thema
Digitalisierung vernachlässigt sie
leider genauso wie vorher die groko und
ein letzter Satz sei mir noch gestartet
lieber SPD bitte lassen Sie das mit der
chatkontrolle vielen Dank
Joanna cotar bis vor kurzem noch
afd-abgeordnete mittlerweile
fraktionslos hier in der Debatte zum
Antrag der Unionsfraktion Katrin
Staffler spricht jetzt für die
Unionsfraktion
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Frau
Präsidentin
wissen Sie es ist ja schon ein bisschen
goldig wenn man der Debatte so folgt hat
man irgendwie das Gefühl es ist
sie finden sogar gar nicht so richtig
ein Argument wieso sie jetzt heute oder
dann wenn es zur Abstimmung steht diesen
Antrag ablehnen man sieht ihnen förmlich
die Anstrengung an mit denen Sie sich an
das kleinste Detail Klammern wo man
jetzt dann Abstimmung einen
Ablehnungsgrund findet
kann Ihnen an der Stelle nur sagen wenn
sie dann am Ende nur noch mit dem
Argument kommen das hätten wir ja in den
letzten 16 Jahren selber machen können
dann muss ich ihnen entgegenhalten es
bleibt halt am Ende des Tages trotzdem
richtig und deswegen wird es bei der
Abstimmung dann einfach spannend sein
sie sehen wie sie sich verhalten wenn es
dann nämlich nur die 60 Jahre sind ist
die die Ablehnung nicht das Richtige und
sie haben halt ehrlicherweise einfach
keine guten Argumente und ehrlicherweise
sie müssen sich jetzt hier nur vor uns
rechtfertigen aber was machen Sie denn
mit diesem 16 Jahre Argument wenn sie im
Gespräch sind mit teilweise
schwerstkranken Menschen die dringend
darauf angewiesen sind dass sie sich bei
der Nutzung von den Forschungsdaten
endlich was ändert und was verbessert
zum Beispiel jemand der Ankunft erkrankt
ist von heute auf morgen aus seinem
bekannten Leben gerissen worden ist ohne
Aussicht auf schnell verfügbare
ausreichende Behandlungsmethoden da ist
es doch wichtig und nötig dass wir die
Daten haben dass wir die dann sammeln
und sie auch nutzen wir brauchen
wir brauchen in Deutschland endlich ein
neues Denken was Daten betrifft weg von
den Sorgen und Ängsten der Kollegen hat
Kollege hat es angesprochen und hin zu
den Chancen und Potenzialen der Wille
bei uns ist da bei den Betroffenen ist
er auch da nur ein Beispiel ich habe
kürzlich mit VertreterInnen von einem
Start abgesprochen die haben auf einer
Plattform Patientendaten zu lonkovit
gesammelt die haben mittlerweile über
10.000 Betroffene die freiwillige
detaillierte Daten zur Verfügung
gestellt haben anonymisiert und
datenschutzkonformen der Hoffnung dass
sich daraus dann neue Forschungs- und
Behandlungsansätze ergeben das gleiche
gilt bei den seltenen Erkrankungen da
gibt es kaum Therapiemöglichkeiten die
brauchen die bessere Datennutzung und da
müssen wir helfen bei unserem Antrag
geht es nicht nur um die Datennutzung es
geht auch um das Potenzial des hinter
der Biotechnologie steckt weil
Biotechnologie Datennutzung und
Gesundheit sich in der heutigen Zeit
einfach nicht mehr voneinander trennen
lassen und ich sehe im Saal schon die
roten Warnleuchten angehen wenn man die
Begriffe Biotechnologie und Daten in
Verbindung bringt als wäre das irgendwie
was unanständiges das zu tun aber genau
deswegen sage ich Ihnen ja natürlich
müssen wir über Risiken im Datenschutz
und Datenschutz sprechen und Lösungen
für eine sichere Anwendung finden aber
die Lösungen lassen sich finden das ist
absolut möglich und deswegen sollten wir
endlich anfangen allen voran auch mal
die enormen Chancen in den Mittelpunkt
zu stellen und zu sehen ich hoffe dass
unser Antrag dafür den richtigen Impuls
gegeben hat heute auch bei Ihnen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Ampel
jetzt sind sie am Zug und wir freuen uns
wenn man daran dann mitarbeiten können
danke schön
[Applaus]
letzte der Debatte Entschuldigung ist
für die SPD-Fraktion dr Holger Becker
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zunächst ein
Disclaimer diese Rede wurde nicht mit
Hilfe von Chat geschrieben das muss man
ja bei KI Debatten mittlerweile immer
vorweg erwähnen
zunächst erstmal ich glaube in der
Stoßrichtung stimmen wir hier in diesem
Haus weitestgehend überein und auch der
claim-daten retten Leben auch da glaube
ich stimme weitgehend überein zunächst
erstmal noch bemerken zu Frau kothar der
ACT über den wir hier gerade in im
europäischen Zusammenhang reden hat ja
eben genau ein
risikomanagementansatz und zwar genau
denselben Risikomanagement Ansatz wie
wir ihn bei der den ISO 14971 das ist
nämlich das Risiko Management für
Gesundheit für Medizinprodukte haben
deswegen ist es gerade sinnvoll diese
Technologie genauso anzugehen das sind
bewährte Werkzeuge
ich möchte aber trotzdem liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen von der Union ein
paar Kritikpunkte an ihrem Antrag
formulieren
erstens sie fordern in dem Antrag einen
nationalen Alleingang bei Verzögerungen
auf EU-Ebene zum European Health data
space ehds diese Forderung zeigt mir
dass sie aus Fehlern in der
Vergangenheit relativ wenig zu gelernt
zu haben scheinen denn sie wissen doch
selbst ein nationaler Alleingang führt
immer nur zu unnötig vielen
prozessschleifen Anpassungen und am Ende
zu einer völlig frustrierten Branche
genau deshalb verwundert es mich etwas
dass sie in ihrem Antrag als Best
Practice Beispiel für den nationalen
Alleingang gerade das
it-sicherheitsgesetz und Denise
Richtlinie benennen denn gerade bei
diesem Beispiel haben wir doch alle
schmerzhaft in Erinnerung wie viel
bürokratische Aufwand und unnötiges hin
und her dieses Vorgehen für alle
Beteiligten gebracht hat
am Ende schießen sie mit so einem
Vorgehen genau diejenigen ins Knie diese
mit diesem Antrag eigentlich
unterstützen wollen wie im Dezember 2020
als das damals noch unionsgeführte BMI
den Stakeholdern beim
Gesetzgebungsprozess zum
it-sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 genau 27
Stunden Zeit gegeben hat sich
einzubringen das erscheint mir an der
Stelle sehr problematisch
zweiter Punkt sie schreiben mehrfach in
ihrem Ansatz über die dringende
Verbesserung von gründungsbedingungen
und die Etablierung von weiteren
förderungsinstrumenten für Startups und
wieder wundere ich mich ein wenig denn
lieber Herr zombex sie haben ja vor
sechs Wochen hier in dem Plenum durchaus
ihre Unterstützung für die
start-up-strategie
zur Kenntnis gegeben das kann ich gut
verstehen denn mit der
start-up-strategie tun wir ja genau das
was sie an vielen Stellen dieses Antrags
fordern
dritter Punkt sie sie werfen uns zu dem
Zeitpunkt in dem wir die
Zukunftsstrategie Forschungen Innovation
vorstellen Stillstand vor das
widerspricht sich meines Erachtens auch
ein wenig liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das Timing lässt sich so ein bisschen
schmunzeln zurück vor allen Dingen mit
dem Blick darauf dass wir eben gerade
Gesetzesvorhaben wie das
Gesundheitsdaten nutzungsgesetz oder
Forschungs-
in Arbeit sind Gas geben lieber Herr
zombrecht das tun wir gerade und das
wissen sie und ich bin mir sicher dass
wir das auch erfolgreich umsetzen werden
vielen Dank
damit schließe ich die Aussprache in der
fraktionelle die Überweisung der Vorlage
abdrucksache 58 05 an die in der
Tagesordnung aufgeführten Ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen gibt es ihrerseits weitere
überweisungsvorschläge das ist nicht der
Fall dann verfahren wir wie
vorgeschlagen
ich rufe nun auf den Tag die
Tagesordnungspunkte 11a und elf zehn die
erste Beratung des von der
Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurf zur Förderung eines
inklusiven Arbeitsmarktes
so und in diesem Gesetzentwurf geht es
nämlich darum dass die Bundesregierung
ist leichter machen möchte dass Menschen
mit Behinderungen auch eben auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt Arbeiten Arbeitsminister
Hubertus Heil hat deswegen hier einen
Gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt Arbeitgeber die mindestens 60
Arbeitsplätze haben müssen eigentlich
auch
Arbeitsplätze anbieten für Menschen mit
Behinderung wenn sie das nicht tun dann
müssen sie eine Strafe dafür zahlen und
diese Strafe die sollen nun erhöht
werden auf 720 € monatlich momentan ist
das die Hälfte die sie dafür nur zahlen
müssen
deswegen sollen nun ab Anfang 20 24
diese höhere Abgabe eingeführt werden
und die Arbeitgeber müssen dann ab
früher 20 25 zum ersten Mal das Zahlen
der Arbeitsminister wird nur noch
weiteres dazu erläutern
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir leben
aktuell eine Zeit in der wir
tagtäglich als Staat als Volkswirtschaft
als Gesellschaft gefragt sind
Krisenmanagement zu leisten
und Tatsache ist gemessen eine
Befürchtung des letzten Jahres was die
wirtschaftliche und soziale Entwicklung
dieses Landes betrifft haben in
Deutschland deutlich gemacht dass wir
das können die wir zum Beispiel trotz
der Wirtschaftskrise den Arbeitsmarkt
stabil gehalten haben
aber Deutschland meine Damen und Herren
das kann nicht nur Krisenmanagement
sondern Deutschland kann auch
Fortschritt
und wir müssen deutlich machen bei aller
Kraft die Krisenmanagement kostet wir
müssen gleichzeitig wirtschaftlichen
ökologischen aber eben auch sozialen
Fortschritte machen
zum sozialen Fortschritt gehört dass wir
die Chancen von Menschen mit Behinderung
auf dem Arbeitsmarkt weiter verbessern
weil ihre Kompetenz brauchen Stichwort
fachkräfteversicherung aber vor allen
Dingen deshalb war auch Menschen mit
Behinderung ein Recht auf Teilhabe in
dieser Gesellschaft haben und für
Teilhaber auf in dieser Gesellschaft ist
der Arbeitsmarkt zentral
ich war im vergangenen Jahr
bei der Firma ThyssenKrupp in Duisburg
an der deutschen Traditionsunternehmen
[Musik]
dieses Unternehmen hat in Duisburg einen
betriebseigenen inklusionsbereich für
MitarbeiterInnen Mitarbeiter mit
Einschränkungen das sind alles
Fachkräfte ihre ursprüngliche Tätigkeit
im Unternehmen nicht mehr ausfüllen
können beispielsweise weil sie ein
Unfall hatten oder eine schwere
Erkrankung ich habe dort einen jungen
Mann kennengelernt noch keine 30 Jahre
angelernter Stahlwerke dieser Mann hatte
einen schweren Unfall und sitzt seitdem
im Rollstuhl
schweres persönliches Schicksal aber er
kann seine Arbeitskraft weiter ins
Unternehmen einbringen und ist nun in
der Metallverarbeitung tätig denn das
Unternehmen weiß
was es an ihm hat und meine Damen und
Herren ich finde dieses Beispiel macht
Mut aber wenn wir ganz offen und ehrlich
miteinander reden es ist zu wenig an
guten Beispielen in diesem Bereich
denn
die bittere und statistisch erwiesene
Realität in diesem Land ist dass wir
überarbeitet und Fachkräftemangel reden
und gleichzeitig die Menschen mit
Behinderung die arbeitslos sind im
Schnitt höher qualifiziert sind als
andere arbeitslose Menschen aber
schwieriger haben Arbeit zu finden
es ist ökonomischer Unfug die Potenziale
nicht zu erkennen aber es ist auch
sozial ungerecht meine Damen und Herren
deshalb müssen wir gemeinsam dafür
sorgen wenn ich sage wir Wirtschaft und
Staat gemeinsam dass wir mehr Menschen
mit Behinderung in regulärer Arbeit
bringen
man kann auch sagen nur ein inklusive
Arbeitsmarkt ist ein starker
Arbeitsmarkt das muss ich in Deutschland
wünschen
und Frau Präsident meine Damen und
Herren genau dazu leistet auch der
vorliegende Gesetzentwurf einen Beitrag
ja wir führen mit ihm eine vierte
Staffel bei der Ausgleichsabgabe ein es
geht um die sogenannten Null
beschäftigte das sind Unternehmen die
eigentlich schon seit Jahren rechtlich
verpflichtet sind Menschen mit schweren
Behinderung einzustellen ist aber nicht
tun und leider sind es nicht wenig wir
reden über
45.000 Firmen in Deutschland
deswegen ist es richtig dass sie in
Zukunft mehr Ausgleichsabgabe zahlen und
ich will Ihnen auch sagen die Zeit der
Ausreden muss vorbei sein ich weiß
natürlich auch
viele Unternehmen in Deutschland
Beschäftigten schwerbehinderte Menschen
sie sind vorbildlich sie gehen mit guten
Beispiel voran und nicht jedes
Unternehmen hat die Ressourcen eines
global players die ThyssenKrupp
deswegen haben wir für kleine und
mittlere Unternehmen übrigens auch
Sonderregelungen vorgesehen zudem
unterstützen wir Arbeitgeber durch
einheitliche Ansprechstellen es gibt das
muss ich rum sprechen über die
inklusionsämter über einheitliche
Ansprechstellen alle Möglichkeiten auch
Unterstützung zu bekommen um inklusive
Arbeitsplätze einzusetzen wir haben
gerade eine Debatte gehabt über
technischen Fortschritt über
Digitalisierung Gesundheitswesen über KI
es gibt tolle alle möglichen technischen
Fähigkeiten Menschen mit Einschränkungen
zu beschäftigen es gibt Förderung
und das macht ein deutlich meine Damen
und Herren die Zeit sich aus der
Verantwortung zu stehlen mit dem Hinweis
es ist zu teuer oder zu kompliziert
Menschen mit Behinderung einzustellen
muss vorbei sein und meine Damen und
Herren
dieses Gesetz setzt eine Reihe von
Verbesserung zusätzlich um die Mitte der
Ausgleichsabgabe werden in Zukunft
zielgerichtete eingesetzt und zwar
vorrangig auf dem ersten Arbeitsmarkt
wir beschleunigen die bewilligungs- und
Verfahren der integrationämter und wir
machen auch das Budget für Arbeit
attraktiver all das zeigt wir handeln
und wir können nicht nur
Krisenmanagement sondern auch
Fortschritt und in der Inklusion von
Menschen am Arbeitsmarkt steckt ein
doppelter Fortschritt ein
wirtschaftlicher ohne Zweifel im Zeichen
des Arbeits- und Fachkräftemangels aber
eben auch in sozialer meine Damen und
Herren ich hoffe auf gute Beratung in
diesem Bundestag und niemand hält ein
Parlament davon ab ein sehr gutes
Gesetzentwurf noch besser zu machen
deshalb freue ich mich drauf und Wünsche
wir werden uns gut daran beteiligen aber
am Ende zählt wir erreichen mit diesem
Gesetz etwas was jahrelang nicht möglich
war ich bitte Sie um Unterstützung
herzlichen Dank
Bundesminister für Arbeit und Soziales
Heil hat hier für sein Gesetzentwurf
geworben Wilfried irlers antwortet nun
für die Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren erst
kürzlich berichtete der Tagesspiegel von
einer jungen Frau die wegen einer
fortschreitenden Erkrankung des
Nervensystems auf einen Elektrorollstuhl
angewiesen ist gerade will sie in einer
Ausbildung starten für den Bereich
Redakteurin Moderation im
print-fernsehen Radio dadurch Kreuz
Corona ihre Pläne doch die junge Frau
gibt nicht auf und seit einem Jahr
arbeitet sie nun bei einem
beratungsverein und unterstützt dort
Menschen mit Behinderung demnächst
vielleicht sogar mit einem eigenen
Podcast mit behaarungsvermögen und
Flexibilität hat diese junge Frau es
geschafft aber anderen Betroffenen
gelingt dieser Weg nicht immer daher ist
es gut und wichtig wenn wir auch heute
wieder über die gelingensfaktoren eines
inklusiven Arbeitsmarkt diskutieren weil
Menschen mit Behinderung wertvoll für
unseren Arbeitsmarkt sind
vor knapp einem Jahr haben wir das
bereits mit und auf Grundlage unseres
Antrags Potenzial nutzen und inklusive
Arbeitsmarkt Stärken getan heute beraten
wir nun die erste Initiative der
Bundesregierung ja leider erst 15 Monate
nach Antritt der Ampelkoalition die
erste Initiative im Bereich Behinderten
und teilhabepolitik überhaupt in der
Problemanalyse dürften wir uns einig
sein doch welche Wege die richtigen sind
die Probleme zu lösen das steht auf
einem anderen Blatt einige Wege die die
Ampel hier vorschlägt begrüßen wir
ausdrücklich dazu zählt die
beabsichtigte Einführung der
genehmigungsfunktion von sechs Wochen
für anspruchsleistungen der
Integrationsämter wobei auch wir wie der
Bundesrat die geforderte gesetzliche
Klarstellung begrüßen das Zeiten der
sachverhalts-
die Aufhebung der Deckelung des Budgets
für Arbeit haben wir in unserem Antrag
bereits gefordert unterstützen auch
diese in unserem Antrag haben wir
allerdings noch weitere Vorschläge
unterbreitet wie zum Beispiel die
Einbeziehung in die
Arbeitslosenversicherung und das weitere
Bewerben des unterstützungsinstruments
hier liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
lieber Herr Minister
fordert euch die Ampel auf nachzulegen
damit diese gute Idee des
bundesteilhabegesetzes aus der
vorherigen Legislaturperiode 2016 zu
einem wirklichen Erfolgsmodell wird
positiv sehen wir auch die geplanten
aufgabenverschärfungen für die
inklusionsbetriebene als Unternehmen des
ersten Arbeitsmarktes und auch die
Neuausrichtung des Sachverständigen
beiratsversorgungsmedizin die Einführung
der vierten Stufe der Ausgleichsabgabe
sehen wir allerdings nach wie vor
kritisch laut den aktuellsten Daten der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit waren im Jahr
2020 knapp 300.000 freie
pflichtarbeitsplätze unbesetzt aber nur
170.000 Arbeitslose schwerbehinderte
Menschen standen zur Verfügung die junge
Führerschein hat nicht die Anzahl der
freien Stellen sondern die
offensichtliche Vermittlung ist das
Offensichtliche Problem hier an dieser
Stelle und da müssen wir viel viel
besser werden
und wenn man dann noch berücksichtigt
dass die allermeisten 0er-betriebe die
mit der vierten Stufe der
Ausgleichsabgabe erreicht werden sollen
Betriebe sind mit 20 bis 60 Mitarbeitern
so muss man feststellen dass diesen
einfach der personalkörper fehlt um
diese umfangreichen Anträge und die
Organisation von Arbeitsplätzen auch
umsetzen zu können deswegen haben wir in
der letzten Legislaturperiode gemeinsam
in der großen Koalition noch die
einheitlichen Ansprechstellen eingeführt
statt deren Wirkung erst einmal
abzuwarten verschärfen Sie nun die
Sanktionen wenn Sie unserer Forderung
nach einer Strategie und einem eines
Zeitplans der Evaluation nicht
nachkommen zu beachten Sie doch bitte
die Forderung der
Behindertenbeauftragten aus Bund und
Ländern diese fordern in ihrer
ehrfurchte Erklärung vom 4 November
letzten Jahres eine Evaluation der
einheitlichen Ansprechstellen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich bin
davon überzeugt die beabsichtigter
antriebswirkungen für mehr inklusive
Beschäftigung auf dem ersten
Arbeitsmarkt lässt sich mit der vierten
Stufe der Ausgleichsabgabe nicht
erzielen der Schlüssel liegt in einer
flächendeckenden Beratungsstruktur für
Unternehmen und auch die Vermittlung
positiver Beispiele die Beschäftigung
von Menschen mit Behinderungen durch
andere Unternehmen denn letztlich geht
es um Vertrauen in Stärken Potenziale
und Mut der Beschäftigten übrigens die
junge Frau aus dem Tagesspiegel hat
ihren Wunsch noch nicht aus dem Auge
verloren irgendwann einmal die
Tagesschau zu moderieren ich bin
gespannt auf die weiteren Beratungen
gemeinsam mit meinen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und der Schüler und den
Schülerinnen und Schülern aus Kaufbeuren
herzlichen
Gründe hat das Wort Corinna
sehr verehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich habe ein
versprechender abgegeben diese Woche
Ihnen folgendes zu berichten und ich
habe überlegt war nicht das tun kann und
das passt heute ganz gut weil es nämlich
zum Thema passt wenn man näher drüber
nachdenkt
ich war auf einer Podiumsdiskussion hier
in Berlin und dort ging es um ein Gesetz
das von vielen betroffenen Menschen
tatsächlich als Bedrohung wahrgenommen
wird von Menschen die mit ihren
intensiven medizinischen Bedarfen zum
Teil jahrzehntelang selbstbestimmt in
der eigenen Häuslichkeit gelebt haben
Diener Arbeit nachgegangen sind von
Kindern und Jugendlichen die Kitas und
Schulen besuchen in Freundeskreis
Pflegen von der Erwachsenen die zum
Beispiel an ALS erkrankt sind und mit
einer limitierten verbleibenden
Lebenszeit zu rechnen haben
sie alle fürchten sich seit einigen
Jahren davor in ein heimziehen zu müssen
weil der Gesetzgeber wir also Vorgaben
für ihre Versorgung gemacht haben die
schlicht und ergreifend auch nach
Meinung aller Fachleute mit den wir
geredet haben nicht zu erfüllen sind
ganz abgesehen davon dass es Wahnsinn
ist kontrolliert die mäßig in das
Privatleben von Menschen einzugreifen
scheitert die Umsetzung dieses Land der
Dinge in Sachen Berlin gestern hatte
sich ja die SPD mit ihren beiden
Landesvorsitzenden für die Aufnahme von
Koalitionsverhandlungen mit der CDU
ausgesprochen und wie gesagt wir warten
jetzt auf die Pressekonferenz der CDU
und das hier ist der Stand der Dinge bis
jetzt
im Partei nahen Ernst lemmer-institut
könnte die Union es heute offiziell
machen ja zu Koalitionsverhandlungen mit
der SPD gestern schon hatte die noch
Regierende Bürgermeisterin und
SPD-Chefin Franziska Giffey klar gemacht
kein weiter so mit den bisherigen
Partnern Grüne und Linke bei vielen
Themen gebe es größere Schnittmengen mit
der Union das Thema der
funktionierendenstadt das Thema der
Sicherheit und Ordnung das Thema des
bezahlbaren Wohnens und eben auch das
verkehrsthema und das sind wichtige
Punkte gewesen wo wir einfach gesagt
haben wo sind für uns die Dinge wo wir
erkennen können es gibt einen Neubeginn
mehr Personal für die innere Sicherheit
das war Wahl bestimmt seit den Qualen in
der Silvesternacht bis zu 20.000 neue
Wohnungen pro Jahr verloren
mit dem
vorliegenden Gesetzentwurf setzen wir
Teile des Koalitionsvertrages
diesbezüglich um wir führen eine vierte
Staffel der Ausgleichsabgabe ab das ist
mehrfach jetzt schon gesagt worden für
die Betriebe die sich weigern ehrlich
gesagt Schwerbehinderter einzustellen
und da kann ich wirklich nicht
nachvollziehen warum sich die CDU seit
Jahren sperrt vielleicht kommen wir
darüber noch mal ins Gespräch und finden
Einigkeit wir sorgen dafür dass die
Mittel aus der Ausgleichsabgabe endlich
für die Beschäftigung behinderter
Menschen auf dem allgemeinen
Arbeitsmarkt verwendet wird und nicht
länger in Werkstätten und Wohnheime
fließen wir schaffen den Deckel beim
Budget für Arbeit ab so dass die
Lohnkostenzuschüsse in angemessener Höhe
gezahlt werden können und wenn Menschen
Ihre vollständigen Unterlagen
eingebracht haben dann gelten sie nach
sechs Wochen als genehmigt bei den
integrationsämtern die sogenannte
genehmigungsdiktionen und wir wir hoffen
uns dass dadurch Bürokratie abgebaut
wird und tatsächlich ein Zugang deutlich
erleichtert wird wir befinden uns heute
in der ersten Lesung und hoffen dass wir
in den parlamentarischen Verhandlungen
zu weiteren Verbesserungen kommen werden
die Fraktionen die Linke hat einen
Antrag vorgelegt in dem aus unserer
Sicht tatsächlich richtige Punkte
enthalten sind ich nenne mal
beispielhaft die Streichung der
bußgeldvorschrift für nullbeschäftiger
da sind auch wir der Meinung dass die
nicht gestrichen werden dürfen in ein
freikaufen dürfen wir nicht erlauben die
Betriebe sind weiterhin verpflichtet
Schwerbehinderte gemäß der Quote zu
beschäftigen wir teilen auch die
Auffassungen dass die Ausgleichsabgabe
nicht mehr als Betriebsausgabe
steuerlich abgesetzt werden sollte denn
warum sollte die Allgemeinheit dafür
aufkommen das betriebene Verantwortung
zu übernehmen haben und aus unserer
Sicht braucht es einen
Versicherungsschutz bei Arbeitslosigkeit
für Beschäftigte im Budget wir haben in
der Pandemie gesehen dass das notwendig
ist und auch darüber hinaus gibt es
Dinge zu klären für die wir uns in den
nächsten Wochen intensiv Zeit nehmen und
das jetzt auch schon tun aber wie man es
dreht und wendet kann man sagen dass wir
mit diesem Gesetz natürlich noch keinen
inklusiven Arbeitsmarkt abgeschlossen
haben werden dass wir den eingeführt
haben werden sondern natürlich müssen
wir daran weiterarbeiten das Ende der
Fahnenstange ist nicht erreicht das
betriebliche Eingliederungsmanagement
zum Beispiel ist ein total wichtiges
Instrument wir brauchen einheitliche
Standards wir dürfen Menschen die aus
gesundheitlichen Gründen gerade nicht
arbeiten können nicht zurücklassen
sondern wir müssen ihnen die Möglichkeit
geben einzusteigen genauso brauchen wir
Zugänge zum Arbeitsmarkt für diejenigen
für diejenigen den es bisher von
vornherein keiner zugetraut hat
Jugendliche mit einer sogenannten ge
offenbar einträchtigen zum Beispiel also
auch über die mit hohem
Unterstützungsbedarf müssen wir reden
auch auf diese Menschen können und
wollen wir nicht verzichten wir müssen
endlich dafür sorgen dass bestehende
Instrumente viel selbstverständlicher
zur Anwendung kommen dorthin schauen wo
Dinge funktionieren anstatt ständig
darüber zu reden und zu lamentieren
warum Inklusion nicht funktioniert es
gibt viele da draußen die sich längst
auf den Weg gemacht haben auch auf
Seiten der Arbeitgeber und dringend war
darauf warten dass wir die Politik sie
endlich konsequent unterstützen niemand
will mehr reden hören über Barrieren in
den Köpfen was man da draußen sehen
möchte ist dass der Gesetzgeber
Barrieren einreist herzlichen Dank
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort
Rene Springer
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Gäste vor allem
diejenigen mit Behinderung
die debattieren hier ein Gesetzentwurf
der Bundesregierung in dem es darum geht
die Potenziale von Menschen mit
Behinderung besser als bisher für den
Arbeitsmarkt zu nutzen ist eine wichtige
Forderung eine notwendige Forderung eine
Forderung die wir als afd-fraktion
unterstützen
wir haben in Deutschland knapp fünf
Millionen Menschen mit Behinderung immer
erwerbsfähigen Alter aber lediglich 57%
davon sind beschäftigt wir haben ja ein
Potenzial von über 2 Millionen möglichen
Arbeitskräften dem gegenüber stehen 1,8
Millionen unbesetzte Stellen in unserem
Land
man braucht also nicht in neoliberaler
Manier in Afrika oder Asien nach
lohnkräften zu fischen wenn man
hierzulande ein solches ungenutztes
Potenzial hat und das ist unsere
Überzeugung als afd-fraktion dass es
wichtig ist diese Potenziale zu nutzen
und Herr Minister Heil sie haben recht
es ist Unfug diese Potenziale nicht zu
erkennen aber wir sagen auch es ist
größerer unfug-ausländische Potenziale
gegen inländische Potenziale am
Arbeitsmarkt gegeneinander auszuspielen
beim Lesen des Regierungsentwurfs sind
uns positive Dinge aufgefallen die wir
als AFD voll und ganz unterstützen zum
Beispiel der höhere Lohnkostenzuschuss
die teilhabeorientierte Neuausrichtung
des sachverständigenbeirats oder auch
der Anspruch auf digitale
Pflegeanwendung für Pflegebedürftige und
pflegende Angehörige doch wie so oft bei
den Regierungsvorhaben hier gibt es
einen Haken wie immer steckt zwischen
den sinnvollen Ideen und einer
sozialklingenden Sprache gut eingebettet
ein Schlupfloch Sie beabsichtigen
nämlich das Bußgeld für Unternehmen
abzuschaffen die sich weigern Menschen
mit Behinderungen einzustellen dieses
Bußgeld kann momentan bis zu 10.000 Euro
betragen
das an sich ist ja grundsätzlich nicht
verkehrt aber da muss man einen anderen
Mechanismus anbieten um die Einbindung
von Menschen mit Behinderung am
Arbeitsmarkt auch zu forcieren sie
wollen lediglich eine neue Stufe bei der
Ausgleichszahlung einführen die sich
maximal auf lächerliche 720 € monatlich
beschränkt also 720 Euro
Ausgleichszahlung statt bis zu 10.000 €
Bußgeld damit würden sie den Unternehmen
nicht bloß eine Hintertür für die
weitere Diskriminierung öffnen sondern
gleich ein ganzes Tor man merkt die FDP
ist Teil dieser Regierung
dieses perfide Spiel machen wir als
Alternative für Deutschland nicht mit
wir wollen die Ausgleichszahlungen
deutlich anheben es muss weh tun wenn
ein Unternehmen sich der sozialen und
gesetzlichen Verpflichtung entzieht und
keine Menschen mit Behinderung
einstellen will mehr noch und das ist
eben die andere Seite die wir betrachten
es muss sich auch lohnen für Unternehmen
die den Verpflichtungen nachkommen die
unsere Mitbürger mit Behinderung
beschäftigen und deshalb fordern wir als
afd-fraktion und wir haben das auch in
der letzten Legislaturperiode schon
getan ein Bonuszahlungen für diejenigen
Unternehmen die ihre
pflichtarbeitsplätze mit Menschen mit
Behinderung voll besetzen
allerdings kennen 41 Prozent der
Unternehmen nicht mal die jetzigen
staatlichen angebotenen Förderungen und
auch das muss ich schleunigst ändern
hier brauchen wir einen neuen Ansatz in
der Beratungspraxis
alles in allem hoffen wir dass sie die
Vorschläge der afd-fraktion aufgreifen
anderenfalls kaschiert ihre inklusions-
und Solidarität Rhetorik nur eine
perfide neoliberale Politik die sich mit
sozialer Sprache schmückt aber mit
echter Solidarität überhaupt nichts
gemeint hat ich danke Ihnen für die
Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
und für die FDP-Fraktion hat das Wort
Jens Beek
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Frau
Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
dass ich hier noch mal stehe lieber
Hubertus Heil und sage top Gesetz aus
diesem Haus habe ich vier Jahre lang
nicht vermutet jetzt sind wir dabei und
genauso ist es genauso ist es dieser
Entwurf
zu einem ersten Punkt zur Verbesserung
des inklusiven Arbeitsmarktes ist
bereits ein großer Wurf und zwar ein
großer Wurf an den Stellschrauben die
klassischerweise
Durchlässigkeit im Arbeitsmarkt schaffen
das beginnt bei der Ausgleichsabgabe
die hat noch gar nicht jeder hier im
Haus verstanden habe ich gerade gehört
wir schaffen eine vierte Stufe der
Ausgleichsabgabe für die 0er-betriebe
720 € im Monat Herr Kollege Springer pro
Pflichtarbeitsplatz das sind knapp
10.000 Euro im Jahr
ja wer hat das verglichen und so getan
als würde man die 10.000 aus dem
Bußgeldern gegen die 720 einmalig
anrechnen müssen und wenn sie sich die
Zahlen der Vergangenheit mal ansehen
dann stellen sie fest dass es so
zwischen 80 und 140 Bußgeldverfahren
Bundeswehr
bundesweit im Jahr gegeben hat in den
letzten Jahren wo ich die Zahlen
gefunden habe sind daraus Bußgelder
rechtskräftig festgesetzt worden in Höhe
von 21.000 Euro
wir haben in Deutschland pro Jahr
bundesweit wir haben in Deutschland
derzeit etwa
44.300 Betriebe die keinen einzigen
Menschen mit Schwerbehinderung
beschäftigen obwohl sie verpflichtet
sind die Zahlen künftig monatlich 720
Euro
unterstellte man dass die alle nicht
durch Abgaben an die Werkstätten oder
andere Dinge ihre Zahlen lassen senken
stehen hier also 450 Millionen Euro
20.000 Euro gegenüber und das zeigt was
wir hier machen wir machen einen
massiven Anreiz zu mehr Beschäftigung
von Menschen mit Behinderung in dem
Arbeitsmarkt und zwar im ersten
Arbeitsmarkt und das ist genau der
richtige Weg ja Kollege
und dass das möglich ist hängt auch
miteinander zusammen wir gehen nämlich
weg von diesen oft ideologisch
befrachteten Instrumenten wie
Bußgeldvorschriften die faktisch nichts
gebracht haben in den letzten Jahren
wenn wir von 20.000 Euro Bußgeldern die
verhängt wurden reden oft verbunden
damit dass danach der entsprechende
Arbeitgeber gar nicht mehr mit der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit spricht und vor
dem Hintergrund einer Zahl am
Arbeitsmarkt die die bußgeldvorschrift
rechtlich an sich bereit schwierig
machen lässt denn wir haben derzeit etwa
290.000 unbesetzte pflichtarbeitsplätze
in Deutschland aber nur 170.000
arbeitslose Menschen mit
Schwerbehinderung selbst die
Unterbeschäftigung die die Bundesagentur
ausweist liegt deutlich unterhalb der
pflichtarbeitsplätze und das heißt
selbst wenn alle Unternehmen alle
Menschen einstellen würden die derzeit
schwerbehindert arbeitslos und Arbeit
suchen sind wären nicht alle
pflichtarbeitsplätze besetzt und das
Bußgeld zu bewähren erscheint sehr wenig
sinnvoll deswegen machen wir genau das
Richtige wir gehen ein ideologiefreien
Weg der tatsächlich Anreize dafür setzt
dass Menschen in den Arbeitsmarkt
integriert werden und wir machen das
konsequent nicht nur bei dem Bußgeld und
der Ausgleichsabgabe sondern wir gehen
ausdrücklich weiter wir sagen dass wenn
andere Instrumente wie das Budget für
Arbeit genutzt werden sollen und dazu
werden wir der öffentlichen Anhörung
Sachverständige gehören die da sehr viel
zu beitragen können dann sind die häufig
hoch qualifiziert der Minister das
ausgeführt
derzeit ist aber über die Kupplung an
den 18 SGB 4 erreicht dass man im Grunde
nur ein Zuschuss bekommt auf der Höhe
des Mindestlohns was wir jetzt machen
ist sagen wir anerkennen die hohe
Qualifikation die Menschen mit Teilhabe
betreffen Arbeitsmarkt häufig haben und
genau da setzen wir auch mit unserer
Förderung an indem wir diese Kopplung an
den echt 18 SGB 4 loslösen auch das ein
ganz wichtiger Schritt die
hochqualifizierten Menschen in den
Arbeitsmarkt zu bringen
und wir lösen ein weiteres Problem mit
diesem Gesetzentwurf denn mit der
Ausgleichsabgabe nehmen wir ganz
erheblich Mittel ein die dazu dienen
sollen zu helfen
überanträge bei den integrationämtern
Arbeitsplätze so einzurichten dass wenn
Arbeitgeber und Arbeitnehmer sich einig
geworden sind ein Arbeitsplatz zu
besetzen die technischen und sonstigen
Voraussetzungen geschaffen werden können
schnell und unbürokratisch damit das
auch möglich wird das scheitert heute
häufig daran dass die Anträge an das
Integrationsamt gestellt werden aber die
Bearbeitungszeiten sehr sehr lang sind
weil das einerseits eine extrem
komplizierte Rechtsmaterie ist die auch
unterschiedlich in den Bundesländern und
von den zuständigen Gerichten beschieden
wird und weil zweitens eine gewisse
Überlastung da ist und wir sagen jetzt
dass geht nicht mehr zu Lasten der
Arbeitgeber und der Arbeitnehmer die
sich einig geworden sind sondern wenn
nach sechs Wochen keine Entscheidung
getroffen ist dann gilt die
Genehmigungsfiktion und alles andere
kann man hinterher Regeln auch das ein
ganz wichtiger Beitrag auf die aktuelle
Situation einzugehen und diese zu
verbessern deswegen natürlich kann man
das Gesetz immer noch verbessern
interessant dass der Minister uns dazu
auffordert ich finde das schon ziemlich
gut und lass uns auf diesem Weg
gemeinsam weitergehen das ist ein
richtiger Weg vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und will Fraktion DIE LINKE hat das Wort
Sören Pellmann
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen inklusive Arbeitsmarkt ein
Thema
Minister Heil was wir ja schon seit
vielen Jahren diskutieren und ich habe
bei ihren Ausführungen sehr genau
zugehört und insbesondere Potenziale von
Menschen mit Beeinträchtigung zu heben
das ist jetzt nicht so ganz neu in ihrer
Äußerung aber und das muss ich lobend
anerkennen sie legen mit dem heutigen
Gesetzentwurf etwas vor was ein erster
Schritt ist und die Hausaufgaben die
Hausaufgaben die sie uns aufgegeben
haben habe ich wohl verstanden willst du
zwei sehr konkreten Dingen kommen
Kollegin riffer hat es auch schon
angesprochen zum einen ist es ja so dass
das Bußgeld abgeschafft wird das halten
wir für falsch und zweitens und das ist
etwas das Arbeitgeber die
Ausgleichsabgabe steuerlich geltend
machen können sich also Freunde der
Steuerlast freikaufen können das ist ein
Moment wo ich sage wenn man konsequent
sieht und wirklich
ArbeitgeberInnen und Arbeitgeber
verpflichten will dass sie Menschen mit
einer Schwerbehinderung einstellen muss
diese Regelung aus dem Gesetzentwurf
raus aber das steht auf dem
hausaufgabenzettel sehr häufig hören wir
heute noch nach wie vor die Barrieren in
den Köpfen Menschen mit Behinderung sind
nicht so leistungsfähig sie sind
häufiger krank
sie können uns nicht nutzen und wir
werden sie auch nicht wieder los so viel
zur Meinung von Arbeitgebern ich arbeite
seit gut zweieinhalb Jahren mit einem
jungen Mann zusammen
Thomas ist seit fünf Jahren in einer
Werkstatt für Menschen mit Behinderung
weil es ein guter mittlerweile guter
Freund und bekannter ist Thomas kämpft
seit fünf Jahren auf dem Weg zu einem
inklusiven Arbeitsmarkt aus der
Werkstatt herauszukommen und auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt Fuß zu fassen das was wir
an den letzten fünf Jahren gemeinsam
erlebt haben an Barrieren die ihm in den
Weg gelegt werden wie es ihm erschwert
wird aus der Werkstatt herauszukommen
auf der einen Seite die Arbeitsagentur
die im Stein in den Weg legt auf der
anderen Seite die Werkstatt die sagt
einen so guten Beschäftigten deren
Leistungsträger meiner Werkstatt ist den
kann ich doch nicht ziehen lassen auch
das ist Aufgabe eines inklusiven
Arbeitsmarktes Potenziale zu heben und
einem jungen Mann wie Thomas die Chance
zu geben auf einem inklusiven
Arbeitsmarkt ein Job zu bekommen und
dann auch auszuführen wir haben
insbesondere in der jetzigen Diskussion
wenn es um den inklusiven Arbeitsmarkt
geht eine Forderung die wir begrüßen die
wir auch in der letzten Wahlperiode
schon begrüßt hatten die Einführung
einer vierten Stufe nicht einer vierten
Staffel wie hier kurzzeitig angeführt
worden ist an der vierten Stufe der
Ausgleichsabgabe die Ausgleichsabgabe
auch das hat ja schon hier und den
Rednern eine Rolle gespielt ist etwas wo
man Arbeitgeber verpflichten will mehr
dazu zu kommen Menschen mit
Behinderungen anzustellen wir haben uns
gewünscht und ist auch eine Forderung wo
wir mit dem Gewerkschaften
übereinstimmen das auch die Stufen 1 2
und 3 deutlich angehoben werden da es
noch nach
besserungsbedarf notwendig
abschließend frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sollten
insbesondere den weiteren Beratungen die
Kritik die auch vom
Behindertenbeauftragten und der
Behindertenbeauftragten der Länder kommt
was Nachbesserung insbesondere die
steuerliche Anrechenbarkeit betrifft
ernst nehmen aufnehmen und dann aus dem
schon guten Gesetz ein sehr gutes Gesetz
machen vielen Dank
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
der Kollege takismus
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren an erster
Stelle möchte ich gerne einen
riesengroßen Dank an den Minister
aussprechen für den sehr sehr gelungenen
Referentenentwurf den Gesetzesentwurf
angesichtspandemiekrieg und Inflation
halten wir an dem Koalitionsvertrag
festhalten wir auch an den an den Zielen
für mehr Inklusion in der Gesellschaft
fest und freue mich deshalb dass wir
heute in der ersten Beratung und
Zusammentreffen im Kern erleben wir eins
dass es weiterhin darum geht weitere
Barrieren abzuschaffen im Januar waren
165.000 Schwerbehinderte immer noch
arbeitslos gewesen mal so im Vergleich
was auch schon hier angedeutet worden
ist
45.000 pflichtarbeitsplätze waren da
nicht besetzt da darf man sich fragen
warum geschieht das nicht
an den Qualifikationen kann es ja nicht
gelegen haben die Kollegen vorher haben
es gesagt der Minister hat es noch mal
deutlich gesagt 55 Prozent davon haben
ein Berufs- oder Hochschulabschluss das
muss man sich vergegenwärtigen im
vergleich einfach nicht Schwerbehinderte
Arbeitslose hatten dabei lediglich 45
Prozent ein Berufs- und
Hochschulabschluss das zeigt dass
Menschen mit Behinderung höchst
qualifiziert sind es müsste unser
Interesse sein diese Menschen so schnell
wie möglich in den Arbeitsmarkt zu
integrieren auch im Hinblick darauf dass
uns die Fachkräfte nun mal fehlen
deshalb meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren Werte Zeit für die vierte Stufe
der Ausgleichsabgabe weiterhin belassen
wir es nur nicht dabei der Kollege Jens
Beeck hat's noch mal mit der
Genehmigungsfiktion deutlich erklärt wir
werden dadurch gewährleisten dass wenn
ein Antrag für die berufliche Assistenz
eingereicht worden ist dass diese auch
innerhalb von sechs Wochen zu genehmigen
ist sonst ist der so wie er eingereicht
worden ist genehmigt das haben wir im
Übrigen auch schon 2016 gemacht beim
bthg in den übrigen Regelungen der
Eingliederungshilfe funktioniert da zwar
noch nicht ganz so aber das werden wir
auch noch versuchen zu klären meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren und die
Deckung beim Budget für Arbeit maximal
mit 75% beim Lohnkostenzuschuss wurde ja
auch bereits angesprochen was vielleicht
in dem Zusammenhang auch noch relevant
ist und das freut mich sehr dass endlich
die Mittel der Ausgleichsabgabe nicht
mehr für einrichtungszwecke in der
Eingliederungshilfe verwendet werden
können
ich möchte hier noch mal darauf
hinweisen das habe ich ja schon ein paar
mal gesagt dass insbesondere in
Baden-Württemberg nicht mehr die Mittel
dafür eingesetzt werden können Wohnheime
zu bauen und Werkstätten zu bauen
sondern direkt für die Mittel in der für
die Verwendung auf dem ersten
Arbeitsmarkt verwendet werden können
abschließend noch es ist sehr sehr
wichtig dass auch die Neuausrichtung der
Sachverständigen Beirats für die
versorgungsmedizinische Begutachtung
ganzheitlich betrachtet wird wir werden
die Sozialraumorientierung mit
hineinfügen so dass nicht nur
medizinische Diagnosen im Vordergrund
sind und noch ein kleiner Ausblick ich
freue mich auch das gemeinsam mit dem
Ministerium und mit den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus bei den Grünen und mit der
FDP dennoch dieses Jahr ein größeren
Aufschlag machen werden das ist ein
Gesetz zur zum inklusiv zur inklusiven
Arbeitswelt wir werden die Werkstätten
uns genau anschauen und im übrigen
werden auch noch mal an den
Umsetzungsstand des
bundesteilhabegesetzes dran gehen
insgesamt eine sehr gute
Legislaturperiode für Menschen mit
Behinderung das machen wir zusammen
vielen Dank
Fraktion hat das Wort dr Stefan Nake
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor genau einem
Jahr im März 22 haben wir genau an
diesem Ort unseren unionsantrag zur
inklusiven Arbeitswelt beraten damals
haben die Rednerinnen und Redner der
Ampel unter Verweis auf ihren
Koalitionsvertrag vollmundige
Versprechen gemacht und einen
umfassendes Gesetz für einen inklusiven
Arbeitsmarkt angekündigt wenn ich mir
ansehe was wir hier heute beraten bin
ich ein bisschen enttäuscht
erwartet hatte ich einen großen Wurf
sehen tue ich nur einen Artikel gesetzt
mit relativ viel kleinen
ich könnte jetzt klagen und sagen warum
haben sie nichts getan so wie sie das in
vor einem Jahr in der Debatte uns
gegenüber gemacht haben das will ich
aber nicht denn wenn auch das Gesetz der
technisch daherkommt es geht hier und
heute um sehr viele Menschen mit ihrem
jeweils individuellen Schicksal das oft
nicht einfach ist und für genau diese
Menschen müssen wir gemeinsam passfähige
Lösungen finden nah beieinander sind wir
beim Thema Genehmigungsfiktion für
anspruchsleistung des Integrationsamtes
nahe beieinander sind wir auch beim
Thema aufgabenschärfung der
inklusionsbetriebe wir begrüßen die
Regelungen zur Finanzierung der
Bundesvertretung der Frauenbeauftragten
in den Werkstätten und wir begrüßen die
Neuausrichtung des Sachverständigen
Beirates versorgungsmedizin hin zu mehr
Partizipation das ist schon mal viel
Konsens finden Sie nicht aber jetzt
kommt doch ein aber und das haben sie
sich schon gedacht ein paar Themen
müssen wir noch mal genauer hinschauen
beziehe ich ein was uns die
Sozialverbände VdK Caritas und die
deutsche Rheuma-Liga in ihren
Stellungnahmen mitgegeben haben Punkt
eins die Ausgleichsabgabe wird aufgrund
der fehlenden Beschäftigung
schwerbehinderter Menschen im ersten
Arbeitsmarkt erhoben sie sollen nur für
besondere Leistungen zur Förderung
schwerbehinderter Menschen im
allgemeinen Arbeitsleben verwendet
werden wir können noch mitgehen dass
Jugendliche und junge Erwachsene aus dem
Fond gefördert werden wenn Sie trotz
fehlender Schwerbehinderung dennoch
Leistungen zu Teilhabe am Arbeitsleben
erhalten nicht mitgehen können wir doch
bei dem Plan dass zukünftig Werkstätten
überhaupt keine Mittelmeer aus dem
Ausgleich finden sollen und das sieht
auch die Caritas so diese Mittel fehlen
zum Beispiel um Menschen mit schwerst
und Mehrfachbehinderung beim Übergang in
den ersten Arbeitsmarkt zu fördern sie
sind auf eine individuelle Förderung
angewiesen diese ist dann nicht mehr
möglich das kann niemand wollen
wir als Union wollen das nicht
Punkt 2 unter dem Stichwort Budget für
Arbeit wie zum Beispiel die Caritas die
Schwierigkeit dass die budgetnehmer zwar
Kranken Renten und pflegeversichert sind
aber aufgrund ihrer Rückkehroption in
die Werkstätten keine
Arbeitslosenversicherung haben dieses
Rückkehrrecht sieht auf den ersten Blick
gut aus es führt aber dazu dass Menschen
mit Behinderung die auf dem ersten
Arbeitsmarkt gut integriert waren in
jedem Fall in ein extra System
zurückfallen vielleicht sollten wir es
Ihnen ermöglichen durch eine
Arbeitslosenversicherung im ersten
Arbeitsmarkt zu bleiben und diese
Möglichkeiten wie zum Beispiel
Kurzarbeitergeld wahrnehmen zu können
Punkt 3
warum halten sie sich nicht an ihren
eigenen Koalitionsvertrag und lassen die
vor einem Jahr eingerichteten
einheitlichen Ansprechstellen für
Arbeitgeber bei diesen Gesetzentwurf
außen vor sie hätten erste Erfahrung
diese Ansprechstellen sammeln und
auswerten können sie hätten weitere
Maßnahmen zur Feinjustierung dieses
Angebots für Arbeitgeber vornehmen
können diese Chance hat die Ampel leider
versäumt das beklagt auch die deutsche
Rheuma-Liga
und den vierten letzten Punkt mache ich
als Berichterstatter der Unionsfraktion
für Rente und Rehabilitation die Ampel
hat in Koalitionsvertrag angekündigt das
betriebliche
Eingliederungsmanagement stärken zu
wollen wo wäre ein besserer Ort um
konkret zu werden als bei diesem Gesetz
ich kann mich den Sozialverband VdK nur
anschließend der schreibt Zitat dass
durch eine frühzeitige Intervention der
weit überwiegende Teil chronisch kranker
oder behinderter Menschen wieder
eingegliedert werden könnte
Arbeitslosigkeit und vorzeitiger
Rentenbezug kosten ein vielfaches mehr
als eine sinnvolle Prävention und
Rehabilitation das finde ich absolut
richtig und es sind aktuell viel zu
wenig Menschen die einen
eingliederungsangebot erhalten da muss
die Ampel noch mal ran also
im Sinne aller Menschen mit Behinderung
erwarte ich dass aus diesen eher noch
kleinen kleinen gesetzt doch noch ein
großer Wurf wird also macht was lieber
[Applaus]
für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
Angelika Klöckner
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen man könnte diesen
Gesetzesentwurf von heute so umschreiben
versprochen und gehalten wir beraten
heute in erster Lesung den inklusiven
Arbeitsmarkt und ich danke Hubertus Heil
unserem Arbeitsminister und seinem
Hauses sehr dafür dass es auch wahr
gemacht wurde was wir versprochen haben
was haben wir versprochen wir machen den
Arbeitsmarkt inklusive und damit wollen
wir mehr Menschen mit Behinderung Zugang
zum Arbeitsmarkt ermöglichen und es
wurde mehrfach ausgeführt es ist auch
dringend erforderlich denn Menschen mit
Behinderungen sind doppelt so häufig von
Arbeitslosigkeit betroffen wie Menschen
ohne Behinderung und das wird der
Kolleginnen das wollen wir ändern
für uns heißt es zweierlei Menschen mit
Behinderungen die gleichen Chancen geben
wie Menschen ohne Behinderung und
zweitens natürlich auch die Potenziale
nutzen die auf dem Arbeitsmarkt noch
ungenutzt sind in Zeiten des
Fachkräftemangels ist es einfach
erforderlich und dringend geboten dass
wir an dieser Stellschraube anpacken
Kern geht es dabei auch das wurde
mehrfach ausgeführt um die vierte Stufe
der Ausgleichsabgabe das bedeutet für
alle Betriebe die keinen einzigen
Menschen mit Behinderung beschäftigen
obwohl sie es aufgrund ihrer Größe
müssten dass sie als Ausgleich für das
nicht tun mehr Geld zahlen müssen bisher
war es ja häufig so dass Unternehmen
lieber eine kleine Abgabe als Ausgleich
gezahlt haben anstelle des Lohns und das
muss geändert werden wir reden über auch
das wurde schon mehrfach betont
45.000 Unternehmen die sich an diese
Pflicht nicht halten die SPD-Fraktion
und das will ich auch mal in Richtung
der Union sagen hätte das gerne früher
gemacht mit der Ausgleichsabgabe aber
sie haben auf der Bremse gestanden und
übrigens auch beim BAM wir könnten beim
Ben schon viel weiter sein wenn sie es
nicht verhindert hätten sehr
verwunderlich dass Sie sich jetzt
darüber beschweren die Ausgleichsabgabe
ist ein sehr wichtiges Instrument denn
wir als Arbeitgeber Schwerbehinderte
beschäftigt der hat tatsächlich einen
Wettbewerbsnachteil weil er Lohnkosten
zahlt und die Ausgleichsabgabe wie sehr
niedriger war und diesen ungerechte
diesen ungerechtfertigen
Wettbewerbsvorteil den werden wir jetzt
abschaffen und das ist gut so liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Ausgleichsabgabe ist aber keineswegs
als Sanktion zu sehen wir sehen das als
Anreiz denn es ist doch viel besser
einen Lohn zu zahlen für eine
Arbeitsleistung für die ich auch als
diese Arbeitsleistung als Gegenleistung
erhalte als einfach die diese
Ausgleichsabgabe ohne jeglichen
Gegenwert mit den Mitteln der
Ausgleichsabgabe über unterstützen wir
jene Betriebe die Menschen mit
Behinderung beschäftigen und das ist gut
so kurz um dieses Gesetz ist ein
weiterer Meilenstein für mehr Inklusion
und deswegen werden wir das beherzt
angehen ich freue mich auf die weiteren
Beratungen und bin gespannt wie wir
weiter voran kommen bin aber sicher wir
kommen vielen Dank
und wir kommen auch voran das war
nämlich das Ende dieses debattenpunktes
ich schließe die Aussprache dazu und
interfraktionell wird die Überweisung
der Vorlage auf den Drucksachen 56 64
und 58 20 an die in der Tagesordnung
aufgeführten Ausschüsse vorgeschlagen
gibt es ihrerseits weitere
überweisungsvorschläge das sehe ich
nicht dann verfahren wir wie
vorgeschlagen und wir kommen zum
nächsten Tagesordnungspunkt dem
Tagesordnungspunkt 12 der Beratung des
Antrags der Fraktion der CDU CSU mit dem
Titel Kollaps der Ziviljustiz Kollaps
der Ziviljustiz verhindern wirksame
Regelungen zur Bewältigung von
Massenverfahren schaffen
für die Aussprache ist eine Dauer von 39
Minuten vorgesehen
ich bitte die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ihre Plätze einzunehmen so dass wir
zügig
auch weiter
fortfahren können
und ich eröffne die Aussprache und ich
erteile das Wort für den Bundesrat dem
Staatsminister aus Hessen Herrn Doktor
Roman posing
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und